spricht also anschließend direkt dagegen
also dann folgt eine rund vierstündige
Diskussion aller im Bundestag
vertretenen Parteien über eben die
Politik der Bundesregierung und den
Haushalt dieses Jahres doch zuerst
treffen nun bei meinem Kollegen Gerd
Joachim von verloren die zwei
stellvertretenden Faktoren
Fraktionsvorsitzenden zum einen von CDU
und auch von der SPD direkt aufeinander
geht bitteschön
ja vielen Dank Tobias Ufer schönen guten
Morgen meine Damen und Herren die
Generaldebatte in diesem Jahr vielleicht
ganz besonders ist nämlich genau
Halbzeit der ampelregierung und deswegen
wird das auch so ein bisschen die
Bewertung der letzten zwei Jahre und
auch die Frage was wird noch kommen und
vor allen Dingen wie wird's finanziert
beim Geld hört ja die Freundschaft
bekanntlich auf der Kanzler hat in
Meseberg noch mal gesagt also die
Gesetzgebung muss ein bisschen ruhiger
werden als in den vergangenen Monaten
war dem kann man sich eigentlich nur
anschließen und wir wollen jetzt reden
mit den beiden stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzen denn Dirk Wiese von
der SPD und die entspannt von der CDU
ähm Wiese wenn man jetzt mal auf das
neueste Politbarometer gucken 19% der
Menschen dort sind nur noch zufrieden
mit der Arbeit der Ampel 80% nicht was
muss die Ampel ändern ich glaube die
letzten Wochen und Monaten waren
sicherlich kein gutes Beispiel dafür und
wir sind da auch sehr selbstkritisch und
sagen das muss anders werden das haben
wir auch auf jeden Fall Klausurtagung
der Bundestagsfraktion jetzt auch noch
mal intensiv diskutiert und unser klarer
Anspruch muss sein wir wollen dieses
Land regieren in herausfordernden Zeiten
in denen wir sind aber kommunikativ
sicherlich muss es anders laufen den
Anspruch haben wir und dem stellen wir
uns auch und den wollen diese Aufgaben
jetzt auch angehen als Ampelkoalition
alle drei ampelparteien haben mächtig
verloren gegenüber der Bundestagswahl
haben negativ Werte gegenüber der
Bundestagswahl die Union hat sich
gesteigert auf 29 Prozent kommt aber
nicht über diese 30 Prozent hinweg die
müsste doch eigentlich jetzt alles
abgreifen an unzufriedenen Fehlern was
da ist aber siehe da sie tut es nicht
warum Herr von verlor bleiben wir doch
erstmal bei der Regierung denn es geht
ja darum was im Land passiert ich
wünsche Olaf Scholz gute Besserung aber
muss sagen das Bild ist ja quasi ein
Sinnbild für den Zustand der Koalition
nach zwei Jahren ständiges raufen
streiten das ist ja nicht normal das
erste Mal dass man sich jetzt vornimmt
es soll besser werden dieser Streit geht
seit zwei Jahren immer wieder wird der
neue Anlauf genommen und das ist jetzt
in dieser Krise fatal die BürgerInnen
der Union nicht zu das besser zu machen
warum sind die Werte da unter 30
naja ich finde erstmal wenn man schaut
woher willkommen wir haben die letzte
Bundestagswahl verloren haben wir ja
schon wieder deutlich an Zuspruch
gewonnen die Kanzlerpartei ist
mittlerweile auf Platz 3 diese Ampel
muss ich ja mal die Frage stellen warum
so viele Menschen Vertrauen verloren
haben warum so viele auch Frust und
Protest wählen wollen weil halt die
falschen Schwerpunkte gesetzt werden
kiffen legalisieren
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das sind nicht
die Themen die die Menschen gerade
beschäftigen die beschäftigt er die
Frage wie sie über die Runden kommen bei
rekordinationen wie wir die Wirtschaft
wieder ankurbeln wie ein Pakt für
Leistung haben dass der der arbeitet
mehr hat als der der nicht arbeitet wie
wir Migration unter Kontrolle bringen da
würde ich mir vom Kanzler heute endlich
mal politische Führung erwarten und
nicht weiter schweigen die deutsche
Wirtschaft schwächelt Wiese und zwar
gewaltig
es wird jetzt diskutiert über die
Subventionierung des
industriestrompreises die
Ministerpräsidenten sind heute in
Brüssel wollen offensichtlich dort ein
gemeinschaftliches Papier vorlegen für
diese subventionierten
industriestrompreis aber da gibt es zwei
die sind dagegen nämlich der
Bundeskanzler und der
Bundesfinanzminister wie geht das denn
aus lassen Sie mich Einsatz zu Jens
Spahn sagen ich glaube ja zweifelsohne
ist dieses Land in einer
herausfordernden Situation und ja auch
die Ampelkoalition hat nicht alles
richtig gemacht was wir allerdings was
wir allerdings nicht machen ist
permanent dieses Land schlecht reden und
ich muss auch sehr deutlich sagen wenn
ich mir die Sommermonate noch mal
anschaue und gerade das sommerinterview
von Friedrich Merz anschaue dann waren
es ja nicht sie SPD Grüne und FDP die
Friedrich Merz kritisiert haben es waren
ja die eigenen Leuten die seine
Führungsschwäche deutlich gemacht
deswegen gucke ich nach vorne die Frage
die jetzt mit mächtig aufkommt ist der
industriestrompreis die FDP-Fraktion ist
dagegen SPD und Grüne wollen das die
Ministerpräsidenten scheinen das auch zu
wollen noch mal Finanzminister und
Kanzler wollen sich überzeugen sie den
Kanzler noch mit und wie wir werden als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion nicht locker
leisten wir brauchen diesen
industriestrompreis für energieintensive
Industrieunternehmen ich merke das
gerade bei mir in Nordrhein-Westfalen im
Sauerland wo wir Betrieb haben die Hände
Ringen die sind Preis diesen Strompreis
das Eingang letztendlich brauchen ich
war ziemlich irritiert das Friedrich
merzin erst abgelehnt hat und dann doch
zurückrudern müsste das zeigt er dass
die Union auch in Wirtschaftsfragen
nicht gut aufgestellt ist wir brauchen
diesen industriestrompreis ich halte
auch das Signal der Ministerpräsidenten
parteiübergreifend für richtig und seien
Sie sicher wir Sauerländer und auch die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion kann bei dem
Thema sehr hartnäckig sein das wollen
wir nochmal klären wie ist die Haltung
der Unionsfraktion dazu wir brauchen
wieder wirtschaftliches Wachstum in
Deutschland wir brauchen Bedingungen wo
Unternehmen auch hier investieren wollen
wetten wir das Wachstum dass die
Eurozone hat nur der Schnitt der
Eurozone also keine Raketenwissenschaft
keine Wunder dann hätten wir 20
Milliarden Euro mehr an Steuern und
Abgaben dann würde der Bundeshaushalt
auch anders aussehen deswegen braucht
sympulse die Stromsteuer die
Energiekosten müssen runter erstmal für
alle die Energiekosten senken auch für
Bäckereien Handwerk Mittelstand das wäre
wichtig dass Angebot ausweiten die drei
Kernkraftwerke müssen wieder ans Netz
der Kanzler sagte die Tage das wäre ein
totes Pferd diese drei Kernkraftwerke da
sag ich na wer hat denn getötet also das
geht wenn man will sie wieder etwas geht
dass sie in der Krise mitten in der
Krise Kernkraftwerke die sicher und
übrigens günstig für zwei Cent die
Kilowattstunde Strom produzieren
abschalten das lässt eben Leute
Vertrauen verlieren in die Politik das
sehen wir in den Umfragen und deswegen
braucht es jetzt vor allem eine Politik
die den Standort Deutschland stärkt und
ja in diesem Zusammenhang kann auch ein
brückenstrompreis Sinn machen
darf wenn ich noch einmal Einsatz zeigen
darf zu Kernkraft das war Jens Spahn der
unter Schwarz-Gelb 2011 den Ausstieg
beschlossen hat für 2023 das ist
umgesetzt worden ich bin manchmal über
die Amnesie der 16 Jahre sehr stark ja
das muss ich aber sagen nach dem
Abschalten der Kernkraftwerk und das
muss man deutlich sagen ist die in
Deutschland das Licht nicht ausgegangen
und die Betriebsgenehmigung sind
erloschen und das geht nicht von heute
morgen also da wird den Bürgern auch von
cdu/csand in die Augen geschossen
da möchte ich jetzt nicht mehr darauf
eingehen das ist richtig es gab aber
eine Veränderung nämlich plötzlich gab
es kein Gas mehr wie auch immer super
und dann hat diese Regierung trotzdem
beschlossen wir schalten die letzten
drei AKWs ich glaube 30 Terawatt aus und
was viel schlimmer für sie ist der
Kanzler hat ja zu Harmonie aufgerufen
der
fDP-Fraktionsvize also ihr Kollege
Christoph Meyer hat gesagt erst haben
sie die AKWs abgeschaltet und jetzt
wollen sie den Strom subventionieren das
ist doch in der Tat völlig schizophren
vor allen Dingen ist es auch gar nicht
sehr sozialdemokratisch finde ich dass
der kleine bäckerbetrieb vor die Hunde
geht und die mittelgroßen großen
pkw-betriebe die genug Strom verbrauchen
die sind subventionierten Preis bekommen
sollen vielleicht zur Einordnung die
Senkung der Stromsteuer was angesprochen
worden ist bringt für die Energie
intensive Industrie gar nichts weil die
keine Stromsteuer letztendlich bezahlen
und wenn das große Energie intensive
Unternehmen in einer Kleinstadt
vielleicht im Ruhrgebiet letztendlich
schließt und zu macht dann werden wir
Arbeitslosigkeit in den Fällen haben und
dann wird letztendlich auch der Bäcker
die Nachteile davon haben von daher muss
man das immer noch mal gesamt einordnen
an dem Punkt aber ich will noch mal
deutlich sagen wir haben als
Ampelkoalition nach dem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffs Putins auf
die Ukraine diese Herausforderung der
Energieversorgung angenommen wir sind
gut durch den letzten im Winter
durchgekommen es gab viele
Hiobsbotschaften auch von der Opposition
dass das nicht klappt wir werden das
auch für den nächsten Winter schaffen
ich will noch mal eins deutlich machen
wir haben gesagt als der Angriffskrieg
begonnen hat wir können nicht von heute
auf morgen aus der Gasversorgung
aussteigen wir haben dafür viel Kritik
erfahren es war Friedrich Merz der
gesagt hat im April im März 2022 man
muss sofort die Gasversorgung einstellen
dass in der Regierung Land Deutschland
wäre wenn Friedrich Merz Verantwortung
gehabt hätte vor die Wand gefahren okay
ich guck wieder nach vorne Senkung des
Strompreises für alle die Stromsteuer
0,05 glaube ich in Europa wenn man dahin
zurück ginge das sind glaube ich zwei
Cent momentan die alle sparen würden das
ist ja jetzt auch nicht das große Geld
Herr Spahn zuerst einmal zur Energie
intensiven Industrie muss man ja sagen
wir diskutieren ja hier den Haushalt
diese Regierung will für die
energieintensiven Unternehmen in
sogenannten Spitzenausgleich abschaffen
zum Jahresende das heißt also die
Standortbedingungen weiter
verschlechtern und das zeigt dir das
ganze Chaos in dieser Ampel der
Finanzminister gingen
Wirtschaftsminister jeden Tag in der
Wirtschaftspolitik der Kanzler gegen die
SPD neuerdings beim Brücken Strompreis
jeden Tag unterschiedliche Signale und
ich weiß gar nicht ob sie ein Gefühl
dafür haben was das mit Unternehmen
macht die müssen Planungssicherheit
haben um zu investieren und durch diesen
Streit durch diese ungeklärten Fragen
investiert gerade niemand in Deutschland
und wenn man Herrn Weser so zuhört ist
ja alles super also Sie haben es ja
gerade gesagt 80 Prozent der Deutschen
haben kein Vertrauen mehr in diese
Bundesregierung und da würde ich
gelegentlich empfehlen vielleicht etwas
weniger auf die Opposition zu schauen
und vielleicht etwas selbstkritischer zu
sein das scheint mit der Lage etwas
angemessen diese ein Problem hat
natürlich die jetzige Ampel dass der
Kanzler vor allen Dingen mit seiner
eigenen Fraktion das erste Mal jetzt
quer liegt er hat gestern noch mal auf
der IAA gesagt wird nicht kommen dieser
subventioniert Industrie vom Preis ist
ein Strom Feuer und die die das wollen
also auch sie müssten ihn mal sagen wie
das finanziert werden soll von den
anderen Stromkunden aus der Steuer oder
neue Schulden das hat er angeboten als
drei Wege was werden sie machen wollen
wir sind dabei jetzt
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion hier zu
überzeugen gemeinsam in dieser
Ampelkoalition auch durchzusetzen weil
noch mal aus unserer Sicht für den
Industrie- und Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland ist das eine Kernforderung
die wichtig ist um diesen
Industriestandort Deutschland auch
wettbewerbsfähig zu halten neben anderen
Gesetzen die wir auf den Weg bringen
werden und lassen Sie mich das sagen
weil der Kollege Spanien jetzt die
Ratschläge aus der Opposition gibt ja
wir sind in nicht einfachen Zeiten ja
wir haben auch als Ampelkoalition nicht
alles richtig gemacht aber es hat auch
noch keiner die Herrschaft des Unrechts
erklärt wie Horst Seehofer gegenüber
Angela Merkel als die CDU noch
Verantwortung hatte Herr Spar noch mal
zur Verantwortung der CDU also wenn sie
sagen auch sie sind letzten Endes für
für Subventionen dort dann muss das Geld
ja auch bei ihnen irgendwo herkommen wo
würden sie es denn her nehmen man muss
die Schwerpunkte richtig setzen die
Ampel macht ja mit diesem Haushalt und
mit ihrer Politik weiter als wäre nichts
gewesen Kindergrundsicherung in der
Rente neue Zusagen auch andere Themen
kiffen legalisieren also sie einigen
sich auf lauter Themen die aktuell
eigentlich gar nicht den
Herausforderungen gerecht werden nur da
wo es darum geht wie kommen wir wieder
zum erwirtschaften wie schaffen wir so
viel Wachstum der Schnitt der Eurozone
dann hätten wir auch mehr
Steuereinnahmen da werden keine
Schwerpunkte gesetzt da entsteht auch am
Ende eben keine Lösung sondern nur
Streit deswegen Stromsteuer runter
Abschreibung für Investitionen Pakt für
Leistung Überstunden steuerfrei Stellen
einfach mal wirklich ein Unterschied
machen durch politische Führung und das
ist es was bei diesem Kanzler fehlt
Führung nicht zu sehen wir wollen
weitere Reden über das was in Meseberg
beschlossen wurde im zweiten Anlauf
wachstumschancengesetz warum reden wir
so viel über die Wirtschaft nur wenn die
Wirtschaft ordentlich läuft kann man
auch soziale Wohltaten verteilen
deswegen lassen Sie uns noch mal bei dem
Gesetz bleiben
wachstumschancengesetz schöne Sache 7
Milliarden im Jahr
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten für die
Unternehmen ist das der Weg den sie
gehen wollen und was sagen Sie dann den
Ländern und Kommunen die schon sagen mit
uns nicht denn wir müssen die Chose
bezahlen das muss gemeinsam besprochen
werden trotzdem ist es ein richtiges
Gesetz in diesen Zeiten dieses klare
Zeichen noch gegenüber der deutschen
Wirtschaft zu geben aber lassen Sie mich
das noch sagen weil Jens Spahn gerade
gesagt hat dass Kinder Grundsicherung
und der Kampf gegen Kinderarmut eine
Lappalie ist wer so einen Kompass hat
Kinder nicht die Chance geben will aus
Armut herauszukommen Kindern eine
Lebensperspektive zu geben da muss ich
schon sagen da hat die cdu/csu dann den
Kompass komplett verloren mit Jens Spahn
wenn das als Lappalie abgetan wird wobei
die Kinder Grundsicherung habe gerade
heute morgen gehört wird im Kabinett
nicht aufgerufen werden es scheint noch
Klärungsbedarf im Finanzministerium zu
geben der nächste Streitpunkt in der
Koalition steht an die Meldungen sind
heute morgen gekommen ich kann Ihnen
aber versichern dass wir sehr zeitnah
das Kabinett erreichen und dann wird
diese Ampelkoalition dieses wichtige
Gesetz für Kinder in unserem Land das
Kindern Chancen gibt dass Jens Spahn als
Lappalie ab tut auch auf den Weg bringen
erstens benutzt vielleicht bleiben wir
einfach mal fair im Umgang miteinander
mit Cannabis und anderes gesagt und
lächerlich gemacht also wer so etwas
macht gegenüber Kinder die in Armut
aufwachsen bei uns im Land der hat
tatsächlich den Kompass verloren nichts
kommt was verloren ihr glaubt halt das
ist Sozi denke ihr glaubt mit mehr Geld
kann man jedes Problem lösen ja wir
haben viel zu viele Kinder in
Deutschland Jungs und Mädels die keine
faire Chance haben im Leben das liegt
aber daran dass sie etwa bei der Sprache
mehr Unterstützung und Förderung
bräuchten wenn du die Sprache nicht
verstehst dass du in der Schule keine
Chance dass sie zum Teil zu Hause
vielleicht nicht das mit auf dem weg
kriegen zu Hause niemand vorlesen kann
was es bräuchte da hilft nicht mehr Geld
da hilft bessere Angebote in den Kitas
in den Schulen da hilft vor allem
verpflichtende Förderung bevor die
Einschulung ist beim Deutsch lernen ihr
glaubt halt immer nur mehr Geld
überweisen löst Probleme das tut es aber
offenkundig nicht und vielleicht müssen
wir in der Sozialpolitik mal wieder ein
bisschen neu denken und die richtigen
Schwerpunkte auch da setzen und dann
übrigens er sehen wir jetzt das haben
wir ja gerade gehört schon wieder wenn
man sich dann mal geeinigt hat ist
trotzdem auch wieder Streit selbst das
bisschen was dann mal geeinigt wird
kommt am Ende auch nicht ins Kabinett
und das ist der Grund und warum 80% der
Deutschen dieser Regierung nicht mehr
Vertrauen und ich sag noch einmal in
sonderlage würde ich etwas
selbstkritischer sein mit dem was ich
sagen Christian Lindner wiederum sagt es
kann keine weiteren Spielräume geben für
weitere sozialtarten wenn wir da was
machen wollen noch in dieser
Legislaturperiode dann sollen ihm die
Fraktionen vorrechnen wo dann gespart
werden kann wir sind ja beim Geld in
dieser Woche also keine weiteren
Sozialreformen sagt der
Bundesfinanzminister der Kanzler war in
der letzten Legislaturperiode in der
gleichen Funktion oft hat man das Gefühl
dass diese beiden Finanzminister sich
sehr gut verstehen auch auf diesem
mathematischen Bereich die Fraktion
wollen was anderes das ist doch der
nächste Konfliktpunkt nein das ist kein
Konfliktpunkt wir werden das intensiv
diskutieren aber wir haben eine Reihe
von gesetzlichen Maßnahmen die wir
machen wollen um gerade letztendlich die
den Arbeitsmarkt letztendlich die guten
Löhne zu stärken wir wollen das Gesetz
für die Tarifbindung auf den Weg bringen
in diesem zweiten Halbjahr wir wollen
das Betriebsverfassungsgesetz Anpassen
an die Realitäten das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Schritt und wir wollen
natürlich auch genau hinschauen dass
diejenigen die täglich unterwegs sind
die in den Unternehmen arbeiten dass die
natürlich auch von Tarifverträgen
profitieren können und auch haben wir
eine ganz klare Position öffentliche
Aufträge die rausgehen soll nur ein
Unternehmen gehen die auch unter einem
Tarifvertrag unterliegen auch das wird
für mehr Gerechtigkeit sorgen ist ein
wichtiger Punkt ich hoffe mal dass die
CDU CSU sich anschließt ich bin mir aber
sicher Sie werden es nicht tun
Mindestlohn steigt jetzt glaube ich auf
12 41 und dennoch Arbeit muss ich wieder
lohnen ist der Slogan in der Tat wenn
man mal schaut der starke Anstieg beim
Bürgergeld der schafft tatsächlich
Probleme was ist da außer Acht gelassen
worden dass wir diejenigen die nicht
arbeiten können wegen Erkrankungen
Behinderung weil gerade eine besondere
Phase im Leben ist angemessen vernünftig
unterstützen es ist nicht der Punkt das
ist richtig ich finde wir müssen noch
mal schauen was ist mit denen die
erwerbsfähig sind wir haben
hunderttausende unter 25-jährige die
aktuell nicht arbeiten aber erwerbsfähig
sind wenn jemand 24/28 Jahre alt ist
gesund ist fit ist finde ich braucht es
Anreize Arbeit auch anzunehmen wir haben
hunderttausendfach zumutbare Arbeit im
Land Gaststätten machen zu weil sie
keine Kellner kein Küchenpersonal mehr
finden und deswegen ist diese starke
Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes für alle das
falsche Signal viele fragen sich warum
stehe ich eigentlich morgens noch auf
und gehe arbeiten und ich wundere mich
etwas dass die Arbeiter die angebliche
Arbeiterpartei der SPD hier das Problem
nicht erkennt Arbeit muss ein
Unterschied machen Wiese Schlusswort
ganz kurz dazu wir lösen das Problem
nicht dadurch dass wir diejenigen die in
einer schwierigen Situation sind
sozusagen noch drauftreten wir wollen
für anständige Löhne kämpfen das ist das
richtige um das Lohnabstandsgebot
einzuhalten nicht sozusagen populistisch
denjenigen das Leben noch schwerer
machen die in einer schwierigen
Situation sind als Opposition hat man es
leichter zu argumentieren die Koalition
muss es dann auch umsetzen Herr Wiese
vielen Dank Herr Spahn dass sie da waren
meine Damen und Herren ich gebe jetzt
rein in den Plenarsaal der Bundeskanzler
ist bereits angekommen er redet
traditionell nach dem Oppositionsführer
am Tag der Generaldebatte das ist der
Tag der Opposition Angriff durch
Friedrich märz wird erwartet und dann
redet auf Platz zwei der Bundeskanzler
das ist übrigens nicht festgeschrieben
meine Damen und Herren da gibt es gar
keine Regel zu ich habe selber schon
erlebt zu Bonner Zeit ich glaube es war
nur einmal das Helmut Kohl sich geärgert
hatte über den Redner vor ihm und er hat
sich dann eine Runde nach hinten
versetzen lassen sehr zum Schreck seiner
Presse Leute denn dann landete er schon
um die Mittagszeit und nicht mehr so
prominent in den Agenturen das wird oder
Scholz nicht machen er wird hier auf
Platz zwei reden also bleiben Sie bei
uns general Debatte im Deutschen
Bundestag jetzt geht's los
und wir setzen nun die
Haushaltsberatungen
fort für die heutige Aussprache haben
wir gestern eine Gesamtzeit für heute
von insgesamt 8 Stunden beschlossene und
wir beginnen nun mit dem
Geschäftsbereich des Bundeskanzlers und
des Bundeskanzleramtes und das Wort hat
als erstes für die Unionsfraktion
Friedrich Merz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir beraten in dieser
Woche den zweiten regulären
Bundeshaushalt nach der sogenannten
Zeitenwende
nach alledem was wir bisher dazu gehört
und gelesen haben wird auch der
Bundeshaushalt für das Jahr 2024 dieser
fundamentalen Herausforderung einer
tatsächlichen Zeitenwende nicht gerecht
in der Bewertung des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine sind
wir uns hier im Haus bis auf ganz links
und da ganz rechts ja weitgehend einig
wir sind es jedenfalls vordergründig
und in der gemeinsam Verurteilung dieses
Angriffskrieges
aber ich habe erhebliche Zweifel ob wir
die ganze Dimension dieses Krieges und
seine weitreichenden Auswirkungen auch
übereinstimmend richtig einschätzen
stellen wir uns einen kurzen Augenblick
vor der Krieg wäre und so hoffen wir es
ja alle morgen zu Ende
ist dann am Tag danach alles wieder so
wie vor dem Krieg könnten wir einfach da
weitermachen wo wir vorher aufgehört
haben das mag mancher hier im Saal so
annehmen aber meine Damen und Herren die
ganze Dimension dieser zeitenwände durch
den Krieg wird erst nach dem Krieg
richtig sichtbar werden wir sind eben
nicht nur Zeitzeugen dieses Krieges wir
sind ob wir das nun wollen oder nicht
auch Zeitzeugen der Zerstörung einer
ganzen Friedens und freiheitsordnung und
je nachdem wie der Krieg ausgeht ob also
die gewaltsame Aneignung eines Fremden
Territoriums durch eine nuklear macht
mehr oder weniger erfolgreich verläuft
wird es weitere Versuche geben
imperialer vermutlich ebenfalls nuklear
bewaffnet der Staaten in ihrer
Nachbarschaft mit militärischer Gewalt
territoriale zugewöhnung zu erzählen
deshalb bleibt auf absehbare und
möglicherweise auf sehr lange Zeit die
Sicherung des Friedens und vor allem die
Sicherung unserer Freiheit die
wichtigste staatliche Aufgabe unseres
Landes in der Europäischen Union und vor
allem in der Natur
vor diesem Hintergrund war es richtig
dass sie ihr Bundeskanzler in ihrer
Regierungserklärung vom 27 Februar des
letzten Jahres versprochen haben ab
sofort zwei Prozent unserer
Wirtschaftsleistung in die Bundeswehr zu
investieren und ein zusätzliches
schuldenfinanziertes Sondervermögen von
100 Milliarden Euro für die Beschaffung
großer langjährig zu finanzierender
Waffensysteme für unsere Streitkräfte zu
errichten wir haben wie Sie wissen diese
Entscheidung aus Überzeugung zugestimmt
Geschäftsgrundlage unserer Zustimmung
war allerdings das so wie sie es hier
versprochen haben der Verteidigungsetat
tatsächlich auf zwei Prozent anwächst
stattdessen sehen wir jetzt einen
weitgehend unveränderten
Verteidigungsetat der immer stärker von
zusätzlichen Personal- und Sachkosten
beansprucht wird und zur reihenformalen
Erfüllung des 2% Ziels bedienen sie sich
für den laufenden Betrieb
zunehmend aus dem Sondervermögen das
schon in wenigen Jahren aufgebraucht
sein wird und spätestens im Jahr 2027
klafft dann eine Lücke von mindestens 30
Milliarden Euro im Verteidigungshaushalt
von der sie heute am Tag keinen Gedanken
und keine Ahnung haben wie sie diese
Lücke denn füllen wollen
ich muss leider sagen
trotz ihrer Regierungserklärung und
trotz des Beifalls den sie dafür im
ganzen Haus bekommen haben bei SPD und
Grünen bleibt das ungeliebte Kind
Bundeswehr schon in kurzer Zeit wieder
weitgehend strukturell unterfinanziert
sehr viel weitreichender übrigens als zu
dem Zeitpunkt zu dem sie vor zwei Jahren
die Bundeswehr übernommen haben
großer Verlierer dieser
Verteidigungspolitik und diese
Haushaltspolitik sind sie Herr historius
der sie angetreten sind mit dem
Versprechen mindestens 10 Milliarden
Euro für den laufenden Betrieb der
Bundeswehr mehr zu bekommen sie bekommen
nichts Verlierer sind aber nicht nur Sie
persönlich
sondern Verlierer sind die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten der Bundeswehr Verlierer
ist das Vertrauen der ganzen
Bundesrepublik Deutschland im Bündnis
der NATO und bei uns europäischen
Partnern
hat der Bundesfinanzminister in seiner
einbringungsrede gestern
interessanterweise genau auf diesen
Sachverhalt und auf weitere große
Risiken der nächsten Jahre hingewiesen
hinter dem Horizont so hat er gesagt
auch wenn er heute morgen nicht anwesend
ist warte ein großer Eisberg auf den wir
zusteuerten und er seinen Kurs nicht
verändern werde also so hat er gesagt
müssten wir unseren Kurs ändern wenn es
nicht zu einer Kollision kommen soll
das war dann die Stelle an ihrer Rede
der Bundesfinanzminister ihre
eisbergrede von der an Sie nur noch den
Beifall ihrer eigenen Fraktion bekommen
haben und in deren weiteren Verlauf
gleich drei Bundesminister der Grünen
Frau Berger
Özdemir demonstrativ die Regierungsbank
verlassen haben
spätestens seit gestern
spätestens seit gestern haben wir also
zwei Oppositionsführer in Deutschland
einen im Parlament und einen in der
Regierung auf gute Zusammenarbeit
Christian Lindner
der Bundesfinanzminister hat in dieser
eisbergrede berechtigter Weise auch
einige Fragen an uns gestellt wie wir
den mit diesen Herausforderungen umgehen
würden lassen Sie mich darauf einige
wenige Antworten geben in der Kürze der
Zeit einige wenige aber schon schon aus
unserer Sicht jedenfalls wichtige die
ganz grundsätzliche Antwort lautet
zunächst die Zeitenwende kann sich nicht
in einer Schulden finanzierten
übergangsfinanzierung der Bundeswehr
erschöpfen das ist nicht die Zeichen
drin
sie hätten in ihrer Koalition
sie hätten in ihrer Koalition im letzten
Jahr den Koalitionsvertrag auf die Seite
legen müssen und die gesamten
Prioritäten vor allem der Aufgaben der
Ausgaben neu ordnen müssen stattdessen
versprechen sie der Bevölkerung es könne
während und nach dem Krieg alles so
weitergehen wie bisher teilweise erhöhen
sie sogar die konstruktiven Ausgaben
noch ohne die Folgen abzuschätzen und
einzuordnen ja das ist genau der Eisberg
den ihn Christian Lindner gestern hier
beschrieben hat und auf dem wir
zusteuern das ist genau der Eisberg
meine Damen und Herren
was müssen daraus beschlussförderung
gezogen werden zunächst unser Land
erstickt in Bürokratie wir würden sofort
alle Gesetze stoppen wir würden sofort
alle Gesetze stoppen die diesen
wahnsinnigen Bürokratie Aufwand immer
noch weiter erhöhen dazu zählen eben das
angekündigte Kinder
Grundsicherungsgesetz dass wir bis heute
nicht haben und das Gebäude
Energiegesetz wir würden es nicht machen
so wie wir
vorschlagen und in diesem in dieser
Woche hier noch durchsetzen wollen
das Gebäude Energiegesetz ist übrigens
ein gutes Stichwort wir würden im
Gebäudesektor wie im Verkehrssektor auf
echte
technologieoffenheit setzen es ist doch
keine Überraschung meine Damen und
Herren dass sie mit ihrer Verbotspolitik
auch im zweiten Jahr in Folge die
Klimaziele verfehlen ihre Klimapolitik
ihre Klimapolitik
wird von den Menschen im Land
mehrheitlich nicht mehr mitgetragen weil
die Menschen ist einfach leid sind nur
noch mit Verboten Regulierungen und
kalkulierbaren Kosten und bürokratischen
Auflagen konfrontiert zu werden wenn man
den Klimaschaden will dann muss man es
genau so machen wie sie es gegenwärtig
machen genau so
wir würden wir würden das sogenannte
Bürgergeld so ausgestalten dass sich
Arbeit mehr lohnt als der Bezug von
staatlichen Transferleistungen
ich verstehe dass sie hier sehr nervös
reagieren aber das ist doch die Wahrheit
die wir im Augenblick sehen die Menschen
gehen nicht zurück in die Beschäftigung
weil sie sich ausrechnen können dass sie
mit staatlichen Transferleistungen am
Ende des Jahres mehr herausbekommen als
wenn sie in einer einfachen
Beschäftigung arbeiten und
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und Steuern
bezahlen müssen
wir würden den älteren Beschäftigten
meine Damen und Herren einen Anreiz
geben eben nicht in die Frühverrentung
zu gehen sondern dem Arbeitsmarkt länger
zur Verfügung zu stehen sie machen davon
genau das Gegenteil
sie reden über Fachkräfte Einwanderung
und lassen es zu dass 260.000 Menschen
vorzeitig in den Altersruhestand gehen
nur damit das hier klar ist weil ich das
hier unter Koalition höre das sind nicht
die Menschen die zu faul sind die
Menschen
könnten im Gegensatz zu manchen von
ihnen wie können rechnen
4 Tage Woche Frühverrentung
Bürgergeld meine Damen und Herren das
Problem sind nicht die Menschen die das
in Anspruch nehmen dies das Problem sind
sie die das ermöglichen und die die
politischen Rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen dass das so ist dass sich
Leistung nicht mehr lohnt
wir würden an den Grenzen zu Polen zur
Tschechischen Republik und auch zur
Schweiz ja nicht neue Schlagbäume
errichten aber wir würden die beständig
weiter ansteigende Zahl der illegalen
Grenzübertritte so kontrollieren wie
dies bereits
so kontrollieren wie dies bereits seit
2015 an der Grenze zu Österreich
stattfindet was ist eigentlich der
Unterschied zum Grenzübertritt in
Tschechien in Österreich in der Schweiz
oder aus Polen was ist eigentlich der
Unterschied
danke dass Sie hier sind heute morgen
Frau Fischer vielleicht erläutern Sie
uns mal in den nächsten Tagen was
eigentlich der Unterschied ist nachdem
sie sich gestern krank gemeldet haben
und in Wiesbaden dpa Interviews gegeben
haben schön dass Sie hier sind und
vielleicht sagen Sie mal etwas zu diesem
Sachverhalt und zu diesem illegalen
grenzüberschritten
ja ich verstehe dass ihm das unangenehm
ist aber sie haben ja einen
Koalitionspartner der bis zum heutigen
Tag beharrlich bestreitet dass es
überhaupt
illegale Migration gibt wenn Sie einen
solchen Koalitionspartner haben dann
kommen sie natürlich nicht zu einer
Lösung dieses Problem das aber
mittlerweile unsere Gesellschaft viel
spaltet und dass uns demnächst rot um
die Ohren zu fliegen wenn sie es nicht
lösen meine Damen und Herren
und dann könnten wir und dann könnten
wir auch einmal über die Aufgaben und
ausgabenverteilung zwischen Bund und
Ländern und Gemeinden miteinander reden
aber erst bitte nachdem Sie dieses
Problem gelöst haben und dafür gesorgt
haben dass Länder und Gemeinden nicht
übergebühr mit diesen Problemen belastet
werden ganz interessant der
Bundesfinanzminister hat ja erstmalig in
diesem Jahr einen Bericht anfertigen
lassen über die Leistungen des Bundes
zur Mitfinanzierung von Länder und
kommunalaufgaben herausgekommen im
August 2023 er kommt aber auf einen
Betrag von 56 Milliarden Euro den der
Bund ausgibt für Aufgaben die eigentlich
länderaufgaben und kommunalaufgaben sind
wir haben in unseren Berechnungen nicht
ganz diesen Betrag erreicht wir liegen
bei ungefähr 40 Milliarden Euro aber
immerhin das ist doch eine Summe aus der
sich heraus das Potenzial ergibt die
eine Neuverteilung der Aufgaben zwischen
Bund und Ländern jetzt vorgenommen
werden müsste meine Damen und Herren und
wenn wir das dann täten wenn sie das
alles machen würden
dann hätten wir auch schnell Spielräume
die zum Beispiel für eine größere
Steuerreform in Deutschland gebraucht
würden wir könnten dann endlich den Soli
abschaffen das würde vor allem den
mittelständischen Unternehmen in
Deutschland schnell und wirksam helfen
aber das wollen sie nicht weil sie
natürlich in ihrer ganzen Klassenkampf
Rhetorik immer nur von den Reichen und
den breiten Schultern sprechen die sie
meinen immer noch mehr belasten zu
müssen das Gegenteil wäre richtig gerade
auch im Interesse der kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen die weitgehend
Personengesellschaften sind in
Deutschland wir könnten dann
so wie die FDP das ja wohl auch will wir
könnten dann für Personengesellschaften
und Kapitalgesellschaften in Deutschland
eine einheitliche Unternehmenssteuer
einführen die vor allem reinvestierte
Gewinne mit maximal 25% belastet das
wären international wettbewerbsfähige
Steuersätze und dann könnten wir sogar
in den in den Einkommensteuertarif in so
gestalten dass sich Leistung wirklich
wieder lohnt aber der
Einkommensteuertarif dann eben nur und
ausschließlich für die privaten
Einkünfte herangezogen wird das wäre mal
ein Steuerkonzept wo sich Leistung lohnt
und wo die Attraktivität des
investitionsstandorts und
arbeitsstandort Deutschland wirklich
schnell und nachhaltig gesteigert werden
könnte
und da jetzt da er jetzt da ist da er
jetzt angekommen ist Herr Lindner im
Sinne einer guten Zusammenarbeit würde
ich sie gerne bitten nicht auf das
hereinzufallen was vom Generalsekretär
SPD in den letzten Tagen dazu
veröffentlicht worden ist das hat mit
unseren steuerpolitischen Vorstellungen
nichts gar nichts zu tun das sind nicht
unsere steuerpolitischen Vorstellung
sie sehen also meine Damen und Herren
wir diskutieren hier nicht nur über die
Details des Bundeshaushalt ist wie wir
widersprechen ihnen in ihrem ganz
grundsätzlichen Staatsverständnis sie
bauen nämlich
trotz zeitenwände den betreuenden
bevormundenden alles regulierenden und
dann auch finanzierenden Staat einen
geradezu paternalistischen Staat immer
weiter aus der möglichst hohe Steuern
einnimmt um sie dann nach Abzug eines
immensen Verwaltungsapparates den sie
natürlich am liebsten aus ihren eigenen
Reihen besetzen mit ihm Menschen Kosten
aus diesem Apparat dann gönnerhaft an
die Bevölkerung nach ihren
parteipolitischen Vorstellungen wieder
einen Teil davon zurückzugeben das ist
der Staat den Sie gerne hätte
und es ich kann es ihnen nicht ersparen
der Bundeskanzler sie werden das nicht
so ganz gerne hören aber sie haben mal
als Generalsekretär der SPD von der
Lufthoheit über den Kinderbetten
gesprochen die die SPD erreichen müssen
sie sind auf diesem Weg ein ganzes Stück
vorangekommen und Kindergrundsicherung
ist genau das was Sie erreichen wollen
Lufthoheit über den Kinderbetten über
den Familien über dieser Gesellschaft
damit Sie sie nach ihren eigenen
Vorstellungen gestalten können das ist
das was sie wollen
wir
ja ich kann ja verstehen dass sie das
alles nicht gerne hören aber meine Damen
und Herren es gibt eben einen wirklich
grundlegenden Unterschied zwischen Ihnen
und uns wir wollen wir wollen ja danke
für den Beifall bestätigt genau das was
ich jetzt sagen möchte wir wollen
nämlich den Menschen den Unternehmen und
vor allem den Ingenieurinnen und
Ingenieuren in unserem Land etwas
zutrauen wir wollen sie zur Leistung und
zur gemeinsamen Gestaltung unseres
Landes wirklich ermutigen und befähigen
sie tun von fast alledem genau das
Gegenteil sie tun genau das Gegenteil
und wenn die Menschen dann am Ende des
Monats auf ihre Lohn- und
Gehaltsabrechnung schauen und Sie sehen
welche Steuern und Abzüge sie dazu
bezahlen haben und gleichzeitig hören
was sie ohne Arbeit in diesem Land auch
bekommen könnten wenn sie dann
anschließend monatelang auf einen
Arzttermin warten und keine Kitaplätze
für die Kinder bekommen ja hat dann
entsteht eben genau diese Stimmung im
Land die wir heute haben Herr
Bundeskanzler beschweren sie sich nicht
über die Stimmung das ist genau die
Stimmung die sie mit ihrer Koalition in
Deutschland herbeiführen und daran
müssen sie grundlegend etwas ändern wenn
sich in diesem Land zum besseren etwas
wenden soll
Friedrich Merz der Oppositionsführer der
fraktions- und Parteichef der CDU und
CSU erhält hier viel beifahrt aus seinen
ryanair hat die Generaldebatte eröffnet
und wie nicht anders zu erwarten mit
seinem Lieblingsthema nämlich der
Unterfinanzierung der Bundeswehr sie
bekommen nix obwohl boris pistorisch hat
ja 10 Milliarden zusätzlich gefordert
die Bundeswehr das ist der einzige Etat
der steigt und der Christian Lindner und
die Bundeswehr bekommt 1,7 Milliarden
Euro mehr das 2 % Ziel allerdings ist
nur zu halten da auch die
finanzierungsprojekte aus dem 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen
angerechnet werden das wird in Zukunft
sehr schwierig werden wenn diese Etat
aufgebraucht ist hat März gesagt die
Eisberge hatte noch mal bemüht die auch
gestern lindern angesprochen hat und
dann hat natürlicher märz das getan was
ein oppositionsgeschäft tut er hat
gesagt der Haushalt
er finanziert viel zu viel soziale
Wohltaten und die Gegenrechnung die
kommt noch jetzt der Bundeskanzler
ich will ganz ausdrücklich sagen es
funktioniert nicht mit den propanzen in
dieser Republik
und der wichtigste Popanz den sie eben
aufgebaut haben
hat etwas zu tun mit der Aufkündigung
eines konsensystem wir hier mit zwei
Drittel Mehrheit sogar etwas mehr
gefasst haben als wir das Sondervermögen
für die Bundeswehr beschlossen haben
sie kündigen den gerade auf und sie
werden dem Ernst der Lage der mit der
zeitenwände die der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine darstellt
überhaupt nicht gerecht mit ihrer nur
rhetorischgemeinden Willen
das ist schlecht das ist schlecht weil
die Aufgabe auf die Zeitenwende zu
reagieren die der russische
Angriffskrieg darstellt und die
Bedrohung die ja für die
sicherheitsaritektur in Europa darstellt
uns ja nicht nur in dieser sondern viele
viele Legislaturperioden beschäftigen
wird und ja wir geben jetzt die 100
Milliarden aus damit die Bundeswehr ab
dem nächsten Jahr zwei Prozent NATO
Quote am Finanzmitteln zur Verfügung hat
und ja schon jetzt
schon heute ist klar das allerspätestens
ab 2028 wird zusätzliche 25 vielleicht
auch fast 30 Milliarden Euro für die
Bundeswehr aus dem Bundeshaushalt direkt
finanzieren müssen und deshalb ist der
Ernst der Lage nicht Rhetorik und
Popanze sondern dass wir in allem was
wir jetzt tun dazu beitragen dass wir in
dem Jahr in der Lage sein werden diese
Haushaltsmittel auch aufzubringen wir
garantieren der Bundeswehr zwei Prozent
NATO Quote auch 28 29 30 in den ganzen
30er Jahren das soll jetzt so sein
und da
und daher März passt es nicht dazu dass
sie in dem was Sie gesagt haben
darauf verweisen dass sie hier in dieser
Woche Steuervorschläge gemacht haben die
alle noch irgendwie versucht werden zu
verstehen weil sie ja gar nicht so genau
sind aber bei denen man jedenfalls
errechnen kann dass die 20 vielleicht 30
Milliarden Euro kosten
einfach so und wie geht das zusammen
wenn wir wissen wir müssen jetzt schon
jedes Jahr diszipliniert sein damit wir
28 29 diese Mittel aufbringen können und
sie machen Vorschläge als gäbe es kein
Morgen das sollten wir nicht mehr tun
und ja ich will auch sagen
wir müssen uns um die Leistungsträger in
dieser Gesellschaft kümmern und auch mit
Ihnen bin ich der Meinung dass dazu
gerne auch Leute gehören die sehr viel
Geld verdienen ich möchte dass es in
diesem Land und erfolgreiche Unternehmen
gibt Start-ups Leute die aus dem was sie
schaffen Millionäre werden eine gute
Sache aber Herr Merz
aber Herr Merz aber Herr Merz
sie haben einen merkwürdigen
Leistungsträger begriff ich glaube der
fängt erst ab 120.000 Euro im Jahr an
und Leute die arbeiten und jeden Tag
berufstätig sind und 40 Stunden 45
Stunden die Woche arbeiten zählen bei
ihnen nichts dazu
deshalb haben sie hier mal so schlank
mit vorgeschlagen dass Leute die viele
Jahrzehnte berufstätig waren nicht mehr
ein paar Jahre früher ohne Abschläge in
Rente gehen können übrigens ja zwei
Jahre vorher als alle anderen das finden
Sie eine Bedrohung für die Zusammenleben
in Deutschland das so fleißige Leute
diese Möglichkeit haben was für ein
Leistungsbegriff ist das bei ihm
und ohnehin
ohnehin im Herz ohne hindermerz finde
ich interessant dass zu den Vorschlägen
die sie am wichtigsten bei den
Sozialreformen finden ist dass wir das
gesetzliche Renteneintrittsalter anheben
sollen das kommt immer wieder als
Obsession bei Ihnen in allen Vorschlägen
vor ich sage das ist nicht gerecht
gegenüber den fleißigen Bürgern und
Bürgern dieses Landes
das musste jetzt sein weil ihr Popanz so
groß war aber trotzdem aber trotzdem
will ich ausdrücklich sagen dass das
eigentlich nicht die Situation für die
ganz klassischen Schlagabtausche in
diesem Bundestag auch bei dieser Debatte
ist wobei das eben frei steht der Krieg
die Energiekrise die Inflation die
Folgen der Klimakrise das alles sorgt
für gewaltige Veränderung Veränderung
die vielen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Sorgen machen die für uns für
Verunsicherung sorgen
was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in einer
solchen Lage von uns erwarten ist doch
kein Schattenboxen hier im Bundestag sie
wollen Orientierung mutige Kompromisse
zur zupackenden Arbeit für unser Land
das ist der Anspruch an uns alle
an die Regierungsparteien die in den
letzten Monaten zu viel gestritten haben
und genauso an die demokratische
Opposition
so setzen wir denen etwas entgegen die
politischen Profit schlagen wollen aus
abstiegsszenarien und Panik machen die
allermeisten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
wissen dass die selbst ernannte
Alternative in Wahrheit ein Abbruch
Kommando ist ein Abbruch Kommando für
unser Land
unser Wohlstand ist doch das Ängste
verknüpft mit der Europäischen Union und
selbst setzt deshalb sind die
Forderungen nach neuen Schlagzeugen
zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten nach einem
Rückbau der Europäischen Union und nach
einem radikalen Abbau des sozialstations
nicht als mutwillige
wohlstandsvernichtung
umso mehr sind wir die demokratischen
Kräfte gefordert an wirklichen Lösungen
zu arbeiten zu viel ist in den
vergangenen Jahren auf die lange Bank
geschoben worden der heute mit der Bahn
oder mit dem Auto von Hamburg nach
München fährt der lebt bei jeder weichen
Störung oder jeder Brückenbaustelle wie
sehr unsere Infrastruktur auf Verschleiß
gefahren wurde statt in die Zukunft zu
investieren haben wir über die PKW-Maut
diskutiert und die jahrelange
Vernachlässigung unser Bundeswehr bis
zur Zeit Wende ist hier schon so auf
debattiert worden dass sich darüber
nicht mehr als das zu Anfang sagen muss
es war eine
Koalition unter CDU-Führung die die
große Sparprogramme bei der Bundeswehr
gemacht haben
vergessen
die Vorgängerregierung haben beschlossen
aus der Kernenergie auszusteigen und aus
der Kohleverstromung wohlgemerkt beides
finde ich richtig nur der aussteigt der
muss so um so dringender einsteigen
Einsteigen in die erneuerbaren Energien
genau das tun wir jetzt übrigens auch
dort wurde der Nacht wohlbedarf am
größten ist im Süden und Westen unseres
Landes
erstmals seit Jahren ist unübersehbar
dass wir in Deutschland auf einen Mangel
an Arbeitskräften zu steuern
das sehen wir das ist etwas das seit
vielen Jahren uns umtreibt und deshalb
ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass wir alles
dafür tun dass wir diesen
Arbeitskräftemangel bekämpfen können und
ich finde es wichtig dass wir damit auch
jetzt gestartet sind mit den Maßnahmen
die wir mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz auf den Weg gebracht
haben aber genauso wie bei dem Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien genauso wie
bei den Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
müssen damit wir es schaffen das
Fachkräfte in unserem Land da sind
genauso ist es überall wichtig dass wir
Tempo machen deshalb nochmal an dieser
Stelle wenn uns zum Beispiel ein großer
Versorger wie er und sagt er hat 600
Verfahren am laufen und nur wenige davon
sind bisher abgewickelt worden für die
verausbau der Verteilnetze dann ist das
etwas dass wir nicht mehr so lassen
können wie es heute ist das ist meine
feste Überzeugung
das geht so nicht weiter
in der Zeit in der wir über die
Verlängerung einer einzigen U-Bahnlinie
oder ein hochhaushaus sprechen und des
planen werden in anderen Ländern ganze
Strecken gebaut die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sind diesen Stillstand leicht und
ich bin es auch
immer wenn ich in den letzten Monaten in
Deutschland unterwegs bin höre ich die
Botschaft sorgt dafür dass wir unser
Land auf Vordermann bringen und dass wir
schneller werden unkomplizierter und
weniger bürokratisch so wie das zum
Beispiel mit dem deutschlandticket der
Fall gewesen ist dass den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr so viel attraktiver gemacht
hat
so wie mit dem Deutschland Tempo indem
wir immer weniger Monate neue
flüssiggast Terminals ans Netz gebracht
haben solche Erfolge haben zwei
Voraussetzungen erstens moderne Gesetze
schnelle Verfahren weniger Bürokratie
und zweitens die Bereitschaft aller
wirklich alle an einem Strang zu ziehen
und natürlich auch in eine Richtung der
Bund die Länder Städte und Gemeinden
Unternehmen und Behörden Verbände und
Gewerkschaften nur gemeinsam werden wir
den Mehltau aus Bürokratismus
Risikoscheu und Verzagtheit abschütteln
der sich über Jahre Jahrzehnte hinweg
über unser Land gelegt hat
dieser Mehltau nimmt unsere Wirtschaft
und er sorgt für Frust bei den Leuten im
Land die einfach wollen dass Deutschland
ordentlich funktioniert dass die Bahn
pünktlich fährt dass unsere
Infrastruktur analog und digital zu den
besten in Europa zählt das einem die
Ämter unter die Arme greifen und keine
Schwierigkeiten machen das erwarten die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nach Jahren des
Stillstands
in meiner Verantwortung als
Bundeskanzler möchte ich Ihnen daher
heute ein Angebot machen mein Vorschlag
richtet sich an die 16 Regierungschefin
und regierungschefette Chef der Länder
an die Landrätinnen und Landräte an die
Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister
überall in unserer Republik und mein
Vorschlag richtet sich ausdrücklich auch
an Sie verehrte Herr märz als
Vorsitzender der größten
Oppositionspartei die im Bundesrat in
den Ländern und Kommunen Verantwortung
trägt wir brauchen eine nationale
Kraftanstrengung lassen sie uns unsere
Kräfte bündeln
beweisen wir den Bürgern und Bürgern
wozu unser Land unser Föderalismus und
unsere Demokratie im standeset viele im
Lande warten gerade zu sehnsüchtig nach
einem solchen Schulterschluss und ich
möchte Ihnen deshalb ein Pakt
vorschlagen sagen wir einen
deutschland-pakt ein Deutschland packt
der unser Land schneller moderner und
sicherer macht Tempo statt Stillstand
handeln statt aussetzen
Kooperation statt Streiterei
das ist das Gebot der Stunde
als Bundeskanzler kann ich natürlich
einen solchen Aufbruch nicht verordnen
für den Bund kann ich aber fest zusagen
wir gehen mit ganzer Kraft voran der
deutschlandpackt setzt dort an wo die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Fortschritte an
dringendsten erwarten bei der
Energieversorgung die sauber sicher und
bezahlbar sein muss beim Bauen neuer
Wohnung und Häuser bei der
Modernisierung und Digitalisierung
unserer Infrastruktur bei der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Unternehmen
bei einer schnellen leistungsfähigen und
digitalen Verwaltung
wir haben den 16 Ländern dazu sehr
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht und das mein
Gespräch mit Ländern und Kommunen weiß
ich sie teilen unser Ziel schneller
moderner und sicherer zu werden das gilt
übrigens für alle regierungschefinnen
und Regierungschefs der Länder egal
welcher Partei sie angehören schneller
das heißt dass wir die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit zum Maßstab für alle
großen erneuerungsprojekte in unserem
Land machen zum Beispiel indem wir noch
die letzten Hürden beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien abräumen das ist
doch der schnellste Weg für nachhaltige
und nachhaltigste Weg für niedrige
Strompreise und als ich
vor einigen Monaten gesagt habe wir
brauchen vier bis fünf neue Windräder
und viele viele Fußballfelder
Photovoltaikanlagen am Tag da habe ich
in viele gefragt wie soll das gehen aber
wir sehen es geht wir haben schon 30
Fußballfelder so einer Anlagen pro Tag
die installiert werden und es gibt sogar
noch viel mehr wenn wir uns anschauen
was zum Beispiel bei den
Windkraftanlagen passiert dort haben wir
im Juni 200 Genehmigung gehabt wenn das
alles in diesem Tempo auch gebaut wird
und wir das halten können sind die vier
bis fünf Windräder pro Tag auch
erreichbar das ist das was wir heute
wissen
und ich bin froh
ich bin froh dass in vielen Ländern
jetzt auch das Tempo zugenommen hat und
Schleswig-Holstein Niedersachsen und
auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist die Zahl
der Genehmigung deutlich gestiegen
teilweise um 60 Prozent und das MUSS
schule machen
etwa wenn wir in den nächsten Jahren die
Netze für Strom und Wasserstoff Aufbauen
der Ausbau der Netze wird Investitionen
von mehr als 100 Milliarden Euro
auslösen und tausende gute Arbeitsplätze
schaffen bis Ende des Jahres stehen die
Pläne für den Aufbau des Wasserstoff
kernnetzes was wir vor allem brauchen
sind natürlich überall Beschäftigte in
den Planungsbehörden in den Bauämtern
die schnell und zügig und unkompliziert
die Genehmigung erteilen vielleicht hat
es früher gereicht dass man für
irgendein Flugplatz und für ein anderes
vorhaben 15 oder 15 Jahre braucht aber
das ist vorbei wir müssen jetzt das
Tempo erreichen dass den
Herausforderungen unseres Landes
entspricht
dann haben wir auch die Möglichkeit dass
wir die große Transformation hinkriegen
die ja immerhin so groß ist wie die
industrielle Modernisierung Deutschlands
am Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts
das schneller heißt natürlich auch dass
wir die Planungsprozesse überall
digitalisieren Schluss mit zwei Meter
Aktenordnern für den Bau eines soldatas
oder eine Mobilfunkantenne schneller
heißt das Gutachten und Umweltdaten die
schon oft da sind nicht noch mal
vorgelegt werden schneller heißt dass
wir EU-Regeln zum Naturschutzrecht eins
zu eins umsetzen damit das auch überall
gleich funktioniert schneller heißt dass
alle 16 Länder bis Ende des Jahres
Bauanträge auch digital annehmen
schneller heißt das nicht noch weitere
Gutachter und sachverständigung für
Genehmigung gebraucht werden wenn ein
Handwerksmeister bestimmter und Gebäude
und Gebäude Teile geplant schneller
heißt das Raumordnungsrecht so zu ändern
dass überall im Land neue
Geothermieanlagen entstehen können
schneller heißt dass wir eine
Anlaufstelle schaffen für
Schwertransporte auf Autobahn damit die
Rotorblätter für Windräder und vieles
andere besser transportiert werden kann
schneller heißt auch manche Genehmigung
kriegt einfach mal zu verzichten damit
Glasfaserleitung für den Nutzern kommen
alles das heißt schneller und darum
geht's wir müssen das Bürokratie
Dickicht lichten
der Deutschland packt dabei ist genau
das Arbeit im Maschinenraum unseres
Staates das Drehen an Hunderten von
Reglern um dafür zu sorgen dass der
Tanker Deutschland auf Touren kommt
damit das gelingt
muss unser Staat natürlich jetzt überall
den Schritt in das Digitalzeitalter
machen Ziel des Deutschlands Praxis ist
eine moderne digitale und bürgernahe
Verwaltung vergangene Woche in Meseberg
haben wir Eckpunkte für ein Bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz beschlossen das
besonders kleine und mittlere Betriebe
von unnötigen Papierkram entlasten
sollen auch gegenüber Brüssel setzen wir
uns für weniger Bürokratie und
schnellere Entscheidung ein zum Beispiel
in Beihilfeverfahren das wollen wir auch
gerne mit Frankreich vorantreiben
seit der Bund und die Länder sich 2017
darauf verständigt haben ihre
wichtigsten Verwaltungsleistung zu
delikalisieren hat der Bund 85% seiner
Leistung umgesetzt
Länder und Kommunen haben bisher ein
Viertel der zugesagten Leistung online
zugänglich gemacht und dabei reden wir
über sehr zentrale Regel fragen wie die
Beantragung von Personalausweisen die
Verlängerung des Führerscheins oder die
Ummeldung nach dem Umzug ich weiß in
mehr als 10.000 großen und kleinen
Städten und vielen Gemeinden mit ganz
unterschiedlicher IT- und
Personalausstattung ist das alles nicht
trivial
aber es ist den Bürgern und Bürgern
schlicht nicht mehr zu erklären dass sie
zwar im Internet einkaufen
geldüberweisen und ihren Urlaub buchen
können aber dass solch grundlegende
Verwaltungsleistungen noch immer nicht
überall in Deutschland online möglich
sind das muss sich ändern
und ganz wichtig dieses Vorhaben
scheitert nicht am Geld in den
zurückliegenden vier Jahren hat der Bund
den Ländern und Kommunen dafür 1,4
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung gestellt
hunderte Millionen können noch abgerufen
werden
auch über andere Großbaustellen werden
wir mit den Ländern im Rahmen des
Deutschlands packt reden wollen was
stauanfällige Straßen marode Brücken
angeht sorgen wir per Gesetz dafür dass
schneller geplant und gebaut wird das
muss jetzt auch passieren
und auch den Investitionsstau bei der
kaputt gesparten Bahn gehen wir an 24
Milliarden Euro an zusätzlichen
Investitionsspielraum erhält die Bahn in
den kommenden vier Jahren das ist das
größte Investitionsprogramm in so kurzer
Zeit ich sag mal seit der Dampflok ein
großer Schub nach vorne
wäre schon selber mal ein Haus gebaut
hat weiß da gibt es jetzt viele
Baustellen aber ich bin sicher die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden dafür
Verständnis haben weil sie sehen jetzt
wird endlich angepackt anstatt unsere
Infrastruktur weiter verfallen zu lassen
eine der zentralen Botschaften des
Deutschlands praktisch ist daher auch
wir denken über den Tag hinaus wir legen
heute den Grundstein für Wohlstand und
die Stabilität in unserem Land in den
nächsten 10 20 und 30 Jahren
und ich sage das gerade auch in Richtung
derjenigen die jetzt immer irgendwie
über die Industrialisierung unseres
Landes sprechen die große
Leistungsfähigkeit unser Industrie habe
ich gestern gerade bei der IAA mobility
der internationalen
automobil-industrialisierung bevorsteht
das weltweit wettbewerbsfähig ist mit
seiner leistungsfähigen Industrie
klar
niemand kann zufrieden sein wenn
Deutschlands Wirtschaft nicht wächst
doch wir werden strukturelle Probleme
nur mit strukturellen Antworten lösen
das beste Wachstumsprogramm ist wenn ein
Betrieb statt drei Jahre künftig
vielleicht nur drei Monate auf eine
Baugenehmigung oder die
Betriebserlaubnis wartet zumal solche
strukturellen Verbesserung auch
günstiger und nachhaltiger sind als
dauer-subvention ich halte auch nichts
ich halte auch nichts von Schulden
finanzierten Strohfeuer namens
Konjunkturprogramm dass die
Inflationsbekämpfung die so wichtig ist
seitens der Europäischen Zentralbank
kommt der Karrieren würde wir sorgen
stattdessen dafür dass unsere
Unternehmen jetzt in die Zukunft
investieren können die Beschlüsse die
wir vergangene Woche in Meseberg
getroffen haben senden eine klare
Botschaft wer jetzt in saubere Energie
und Klimaschutz investiert der spart
dank der investitionsprämie viel Geld
mit der Ausweitung des Verlustvortrags
sorgen wir mit einem Schlag für mehr
Liquidität in Unternehmen rückwirkend ab
dem 1 oktober werden neue großzügige
abschreibungsregeln für alle beweglichen
Wirtschaftsgüter möglich damit auch
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
investieren können und die großen auch
und Betriebe den Geld- und Forschungen
Entwicklung
investieren können künftig mehr von der
Steuer absetzen und natürlich das
wichtige großzügige abschreibungsregeln
werden auch den Bau neuer Häuser und
Wohnungen unterstützen das sorgt für
mehr Investitionen in der Bauwirtschaft
denn wir wollen das Ziel nicht aufgeben
mehr Wohnungen in diesem Land zu bauen
ja die Zinserhöhung haben zu einer
anpassungskrise geführt die steigenden
Baupreise auch die zu hohen
Grundstückspreise übrigens auch aber was
ganz wichtig ist dass wir darüber nicht
aufhören zu verstehen dass jetzt in
großer Zahl bezahlbare Wohnung für
Millionen Menschen in diesem Land gebaut
werden müssen und deshalb werden wir
alles tun damit wir so weit kommen dass
wir tatsächlich jedes Jahr und Jahr für
Jahr 400.000 Wohnungen errichten kann
wir werden das auf einem Baugefühl
besprechen aber ich sage ausdrücklich
vielleicht war da die eine oder andere
Wohnung bei der man sehr viel Geld
zahlen muss um da einziehen zu können zu
viel geplant und zu wenige Wohnungen
geplant weil die sich jemand leisten
kann der auch zu einem Leistungsträger
geht hört weil er 40 Stunden die Woche
arbeite aber nicht so viel verdient
18 Milliarden Euro stecken wir in den
geförderten Wohnungsbau damit das auch
funktioniert
und natürlich dürfen wir nicht vergessen
unser wichtigstes Instrument den Klima
und transformationsfonds allein im
kommenden Jahr sind darin 58 Milliarden
Euro Investitionen möglich in
Wasserstoffwirtschaft in die
Halbleiterindustrie in saubere Energie
klimafreundliche Mobilität digitale
Infrastruktur und die Sanierung von
Gebäuden
rekordinvestitionen aus dem
Bundeshaushalt kommen noch dazu 54
Milliarden für bessere Schienen und
Brücken schnelles Internet oder
Ladesäulen alles das zusammen sind 110
Milliarden Euro mit denen wir in der
Lage sind trotz der Tatsache dass wir
jetzt in den Ausgaben die wir tätigen
müssen vorsichtig umgehen müssen mit
denen wir Investitionen in unserem Land
tätigen können und die Schuldenregel der
Verfassung einhalten
wir sehen übrigens auch erste Erfolge
mehr als 80 Milliarden Euro investieren
internationale Unternehmen in den
Standort Deutschland und zwar in
Zukunftsbranchen die Biotechnologie und
batteriefertigung cleantec
klimaneutralen Stahl und künstliche
Intelligenz und wir sind gerade dabei zu
dem Halbleiter Standort in Europa zu
werden die 30 Milliarden Euro
Investitionen von Intel in Magdeburg ist
die größte ausländische
Einzelinvestition in der Geschichte
Europas hinzukommen hinzu kommen die
neuen Fabriken von Infineon in Sachsen
von Wolf Speed und ZF in Saarland die
Investitionen von Global foundrys in
Dresden und zuletzt der Einstieg von
TSMC in die Chip-Produktion auch in
Dresden übrigens im Verbund mit NXP
Infineon und Bosch denn es ist ja nicht
so dass wir in dieser Frage
technologisch erst alles lernen müssen
jede dieser Investitionen stärkt unsere
technologische Souveränität und jede
dieser Investitionen sorgt dafür dass
Dutzende Zulieferer für gute und sichere
Arbeitsplätze und für auf davon
profitieren und für Aufträge beim
lokalen Handwerk ganze Städte und
Regionen profitieren davon auf Dauer und
deshalb werden wir als Bund diesen
großen Fortschritt der mit der
Wiederansiedlung der Halbleiterindustrie
in Europa und zwar in Deutschland
verbunden ist auch weiter unterstützen
übrigens tun das andere Länder auch um
das mal im Hinblick auf eine etwas
merkwürdige Debatte hierzulande zu sagen
wenn man die Unternehmen fragt was der
größte Unsicherheitsfaktor für Sie ist
dann sind das nicht so sehr die
Energiepreise oder die Frage ob sie noch
mehr Subventionen bekommen können
sondern dann ist das der Mangel an
Arbeitskräften das ist in der Tat die
große Herausforderung für unser Land und
deshalb tun wir erstmal alles dafür dass
diejenigen die hierzulande aufwachsen
auch die besten Bedingungen vorfinden
und dass wir alles dafür tun können dass
sie einen guten Arbeitsplatz und eine
gute Ausbildung bekommen und wir haben
auch damit das geklappt Mittel
bereitgestellt damit die Länder und
Gemeinden Kitas ausbauen können 4
Milliarden Euro wer allerdings behauptet
wir können völlig ohne Arbeitskräfte aus
dem Ausland am auskommen der hat in den
letzten Jahren nicht mehr mit
Handwerksmeister mittelständlerinnen und
krankenhausbetreibern gesprochen
13 Millionen Beschäftigte gehen bis
Mitte kommenden Jahrzehnts in den
Ruhestand deshalb ist es notwendig dass
wir das auch tun und ich appellieren
alle dass das jetzt schon beschlossene
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz jetzt
überall in Deutschland umgesetzt wird
damit wir unbürokratisch die
Möglichkeiten haben und der
Krankenpfleger aus Georgien und die
IT-Spezialisten aus Indien nicht Monate
auf ein Visum oder eine Arbeitserlaubnis
warten müssen
moderne untereinander vernetzte
Ausländerbehörden nutzen übrigens auch
an anderer Stelle wer hier kein
Aufenthaltsrecht hat der muss unser Land
natürlich wieder verlassen in Meseberg
haben wir beschlossen Georgien und
molder aus sicherer Herkunftsländer
einzustufen das ist ein wichtiger
Fortschritt im Kampf gegen die
irreguläre Migration
und ich bin der bundesinnenministerin
sehr dankbar dafür dass sie den Ländern
auch in Sachen Rückführung bei der
Ausweitung der Abschiebehaft und an
vielen anderen Stellen ganz konkrete
Verbesserungsvorschläge gemacht hat
schönen Dank für diese Arbeit
auch das mit Teil des deutschland-paktes
sein und mir ist schon aufgefallen was
passiert
die Bundesregierung hat alles was zu tun
ist auf den Weg gebracht über die
sicheren Herkunftsländer habe ich eben
gesprochen über Verbesserung aller seit
Jahren nicht zustande gekommene Regelung
bei der rechtlichen Organisation der
Abschiebung habe ich auch gesprochen
über die europäische Verständigung über
ein solidaritätsmechanismus damit nicht
alle zu uns kommen sondern dass ein
gemeinsames Verfahren wird habe ich
haben wir hier schon diskutiert wir
haben darüber diskutiert wie die
Digitalisierung der Ausländerbehörden
vorangeht und und und
aber dann wenn das alles passiert dann
suchen sie sich immer noch das nächste
Thema so viel wie hier auf der Agenda
steht haben CDU Innenminister in den
letzten Jahren nicht vorangebracht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach drei
außergewöhnlichen Krisenjahren steht der
Bundeshaushalt 2024 für die Rückkehr zur
Normalität und für einen solide
finanzierten Staat wir investieren ohne
an der falschen Stelle zu kürzen weil
wir wissen
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt ist die
entscheidende Voraussetzung dafür dass
alle mitkommen können auf dem Weg in die
Zukunft unseres Landes durch den
Ausgleich der kalten Progressionen haben
48 Millionen Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler mehr Netto vom Brutto wir
reden hier über den größten steuerlichen
Inflationsausgleich die in eine
Bundesregierung jemals vorgenommen hat
danke für den Applaus aus der CDU
die Tarifpartner machen
millionenfachgebrauch von unserem
Vorschlag den Beschäftigten mit Steuer
und abgabenfreien Einmalzahlung durch
die Inflation zu helfen und das alles
zeigt wirkt Wirkung erstmals seit zwei
Jahren steigt die Kaufkraft in
Deutschland wieder am deutlichsten sind
die Löhne übrigens bei denjenigen
gestiegen die am wenigsten verdienen und
darauf bin ich ganz besonders stolz
das ist auch ein Erfolg des Mindestlohns
und der beschlossenen Reduzierung von
Steuern und Sozialabgaben für
Geringverdiener auch die Renten sind zum
ersten Juli so stark angehoben worden
wie seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr als 30
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung ist
endlich die rentenangleichung zwischen
Ost und West geschafft
und auch die Familien hat diese
Bundesregierung massiv unterstützt
allein das höhere Kindergeld bedeutet
für eine Familie mit zwei Kindern über
700 Euro mehr im Jahr beim
Kinderzuschlag sind es bis zu 500 Euro
das alles fließt ein in die neue
Kindergrundsicherung die im Jahr 25
eingeführt wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger Krieg
Klimawandel Energiekrise Inflation die
Folgen der Pandemie niemand hat sich die
Lage ausgesucht mit der wir es derzeit
zu tun haben aber gerade wenn man
bedenkt wie groß diese Herausforderung
sind wird doch ganz besonders deutlich
was wir hinbekommen wenn wir
zusammenhalten wir haben die Pandemie
überstanden mit weniger Opfern als viele
andere Staaten wir haben entschlossen
auf Russlands Angriffskrieg und seine
dramatischen Folgen reagiert ohne dass
die NATO Kriegspartei geworden ist nach
den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika sind
wir der zweitgrößte Unterstützer der
Ukraine wir haben unser Land immer
weniger Monate aus der Abhängigkeit von
russischer Energie befreit ohne
Versorgungsengpässe ohne Blackouts ohne
Wut Winter ja ohne notwendung und wir
kommen voran bei der Aufgabe unseres
Landes der Aufgabe unser Land so
aufzustellen dass unsere besten Tage
nicht hinter uns liegen sondern vor uns
auch das kriegen wir hin wenn wir
zusammenhalten und genau das erwarten
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger davon uns
dass wir unsere Kraft zusammen nehmen
und gemeinsam anpacken dieses Angebot
mache ich Ihnen heute mit dem
deutschland-
ja meine Damen und Herren das war ein
kämpferischer Bundeskanzler mit einer
sehr interessanten Rede am Schluss hat
das noch mal gesagt er bietet allen
Beteiligten den Deutschland packt an es
muss alles schneller moderner und
sicherer werden über Deutschland liegt
ein Mehltau er hat dann stundenlang
aufgeführt was alles nicht funktioniert
hat an am Ende seiner Rede gesagt was er
alles schon in Gang gesetzt hat ein
bisschen froh kann man sein dass der
Bundeskanzler juristisch und nicht
Historiker denn er hat offensichtlich
vergessen woher auch dieser Mehltau
stammt nicht nur 16 Jahren Angela Merkel
der hat die SPD ja bekanntermaßen 12
Jahre mit regiert die letzten 25 Jahre
davon hat die SPD mit regiert in genau
21 Jahren und das muss an der Stelle
gesagt werden zumal er am Anfang nämlich
für dich März ja ein propans vorgeworfen
habe was die Verteidigungspolitik angeht
sein und Jungs geführte Regierung
gewesen die die Bundeswehr völlig
unterversorgt hätten das ist richtig
aber wenn man noch mal die Reden
zurückschlägt und die Ereignisse von
damals sich anguckt dann war es die
Sozialdemokratie die die Aufrüstung der
Bundeswehr stets verhindert hat der
nächste Redner jetzt Tino krupala von
der AFD der parteivorchef der Herr
Bundeskanzler sie sprachen in ihrer Rede
von der Deutschland Geschwindigkeit von
der Geschwindigkeit seit Erfindung der
Dampflokomotive welche Geschwindigkeit
das ist das Sehen aktuell die Bürger in
ihrer Wahrnehmung ihre Wahrnehmung zur
Situation des Landes geht wirklich an
den Problemen vorbei Herr Merz in ihrer
Rede muss man wirklich sagen sie suchen
jetzt nach dem grünen nach den nächsten
Koalitionspartner soll dann die FDP sein
dieser Schmusekurs eine FDP die in
dieser Bundesregierung Handwerk und
Mittelstand verrät diese FDP wird es
bald nicht mehr geben sie ist
überflüssig und das werden die nächsten
Landtagswahlen ganz deutlich zeigen was
wir heute und auch gestern schon von
Herrn Linder gehört haben ist dass diese
ampelpolitik Schuldenpolitik bedeutet
und die Schulden werden eben nicht hier
in hingetilgt sondern draußen im Land
von den Bürgern und appelpolitik ist
auch immer ein Stück postmodern und eben
beliebig so sind die Berechnung der
Neuverschuldung doch recht kreativ auch
heute haben wir das von Ihnen Herr
gehört Herr
Bundeskanzler der Bundesfinanzminister
verpackte seinen Kunstwerk gestern in
sage und Schreiben 50 Minuten Rede war
er Redezeit der Deutsche Bundestag ist
es nun denn Haushaltsentwurf
verabschieden soll in dem die über 70
Milliarden Euro in den sogenannten
Sondervermögen also neue Schulden
versteckt sind und die zugewiesenen
eu-schulden von 13,2 Milliarden die hat
er ganz beflüssig unter den Tisch fallen
lassen und das zusätzlich zur
offiziellen Neuverschuldung von 16
Milliarden Euro also weit über 100
Milliarden Euro neue Schulden das zu
soliden Finanzen herr Scholz das ist
alles andere als dies
Zitat das Geld fällt doch nicht vom
Himmel ein Zitat von BDI-Präsident
Russwurm der Welt am Sonntag zusagt
vielleicht hat Herr Linda deshalb sogar
plötzlich die Schuldenbremse wieder für
sich und seine Politik entdeckt zu spät
meine Damen und Herren von der FDP 2
Jahre zu spät in dieser destruktiven
andere Regierung hätten sie noch den
meisten wirtschaftlichen Verstand
vielleicht besitzen müssen allerdings
hat das trojanische Pferd in der
Bundesregierung offenbar die Namen Freie
Demokraten in ihm verstecken sich
nämlich die Steigbügelhalter eines
dominanten Staates und sie erlinder
haben es im Bundeskabinett zugelassen
das mitten in der größten Inflation der
letzten Jahre deutsche Firmen ins
Ausland verkauft werden und aus ihrer
Fraktion kamen immer wieder die
kriegsliste an den Töne von Frau
Zimmermann die nun ihr Zug fährt für die
anstehenden Wahlen zum Europäischen
Parlament sein soll viel Spaß dazu
sie sind als Politiker und Partei
mittlerweile nur noch unglaubwürdig und
wirklich absolut überflüssig die FDP ist
im genau das was Sie schon immer war der
ping pong ball den die
Regierungsparteien für Koalitionen
brauchen und Werte Kollegen viele von
ihnen verbringen seit Monaten dann auch
in der Sommerpause Zeit damit den
Bürgern und den Medien zu erklären warum
die Alternative für Deutschland nicht
gut für unser Land sein soll nur
vergessen genau diese Leute auch dass
nicht wir in der Regierung sind dort
sitzen SPD Grüne und FDP und die CDU
findet sich noch immer in der Opposition
nicht ganz so recht mauert an seinen
brandneuerchen rum und auch das fällt
als Opposition komplett mittlerweile die
CDU aus alle diese Parteien
alle diese Parteien meine Damen und
Herren machen seit über 20
Legislaturperioden im Deutschen
Bundestag Politik sie sollen endlich mal
selbst und ihre politischen Leistung
anfangen zu kritisieren und sich
vielleicht einfach mal fragen warum gibt
es eigentlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland sie sollten endlich die Zoll
klappen auch absetzen und nicht alle
Anträge der afd-fraktion ablehnen denn
dann ging es unserem Land wirklich
besser meine Damen und Herren
in der Bevölkerung machen sie sich alle
anscheinend mehr und mehr unglaubwürdig
und das Entdecken offensichtlich immer
mehr Bürger von denen wollen sie zwar
alle wieder gewählt werden pro esken in
Sachsen sechs Prozent die SPD sie
sollten ganz leise sein aber deren
Interessen vertreten wollen sie schon
lange nicht mehr
Zitat die Lage wird toxisch sagt die
Präsidentin des VDA Hildegard Müller
Antworten der Politik jedoch die die
Interessen der Wirtschaft vertreten
sollten zum Beispiel die unsere
Forderung CO2-Abgabe abschaffen
Energiesteuern runter die gibt es nicht
Bürokratieabbau ja dann lassen sie
endlich das liefergesetz kettengesetz
Fallen das braucht hier in diesem Land
niemand es geht mittlerweile auch
niemand mehr davon aus und ich im
Übrigen noch nie dass die Grünen mit
Steuergeld überhaupt umgehen können das
hat schon immer Spaß gemacht bei den
Grünen
es hat schon immer Spaß gemacht bei den
Grünen das Geld anderer Leute Gassi zu
tragen und wir werden von der Politik
des Herrn habe ich tagtäglich darin auch
bestätigt eine solche
wirtschaftsfeindliche Politik hat es in
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch nie
gegeben meine Damen und Herren
diese grüne Wirtschaftspolitik
funktioniert nur in der gleichfarbigen
Blase einer Partei die daran glaubt dass
Klima retten zu können und das hat einen
Preis der für uns alle unbezahlbar wird
meine Damen und Herren allein das
heizungsgesetz GEG kostet unfassbare
2500 Milliarden Euro den Bürgern und das
sind ihre eigenen Zahlen aus der
Bundesregierung dieses Gesetz braucht
kein Mensch und
die Union soll nicht zu tun in Sachsen
plakatiert sie heizungsverbot stoppen
als wenn Sie dieses Gesetz auch nicht
wollte Frau von der Leyen wahrscheinlich
ihre Spitzenkandidatin von der CDU für
die europawahlplan sogar ein noch
schärferes Gesetz auf EU-Ebene diese
Doppelmoral ist sowas von unglaubwürdig
und das erkennen immer mehr Bürger
Zitat die Idee Industrialisierung
beginnt da stellt der
Vorstandsvorsitzende des chemie-konzerns
Matthias sachert fest
das sind sie und ihre Kabinett den es
realisieren wollen
trockeneisieren meine Kollegen und ich
ihn nachhaltig schon seit Monaten Herr
Bundeskanzler und deshalb öffnen sie
wieder wenn sie können bitte beide Augen
und sehen Sie wie die deutsche
Wirtschaft reagiert wie sie abschmiert
und kümmern Sie sich endlich um das
Rückgrat in diesem Land um die deutsche
Wirtschaft
laut dem Energiewende Barometer der dehk
aber erwägen aktuell
43,3% aller Industrieunternehmen mit
über 300 Beschäftigten eine Verlegung
ihrer Kapazitäten ins Ausland 6,7%
planen dies bereits bei 17% laufen diese
Planungen und bei 19,7 % sind die
Realisierungen schon abgeschlossen damit
packen aktuell
36,7% der größten Industriebetriebe ihre
Koffer und das war erst dann für den
Industriestandort das Ende in diesem
Land das ist die Realität der sie sich
komplett verschließen und diese
Bundesregierung hinterlässt eine
traurige Landschaft aus nicht
funktionierenden hoch subventionierten
Windrädern eine unsichere
Energieversorgung ohne Grundlast und
eine unendlich hohe Abgabenlast damit
schaffen sie keine Anreize für
wirtschaftliche Unternehmungen oder gute
Lebensbedingungen für all die Menschen
die tagtäglich zur Wertschöpfung
beitragen welches Geschlecht im
Personalausweis steht das können die
Bürger entscheiden
ob sie aber in Zukunft noch die heiz-
und Stromkosten bezahlen können oder
welche Heizung sie überhaupt einbauen
dürfen das wissen sie nicht werden die
Bundesregierung ihre politischen
Schwerpunkte sind völlig entrückt und
wie die FAZ unlängst Titel der sie sind
absolut regierungsunfähig
[Applaus]
und ich gebe Ihnen mal ein Beispiel aus
der Industrie eine Gießerei in meinen
Wahlkreis hat im Jahr 2016 für eine
Kilowattstunde Strom 11,47 Cent gezahlt
der Krieg in der Ukraine und die damit
erlassenen unsäglichen Sanktionen
führten zu einem Preisanstieg um 98% auf
22,37 Kilowattstunde im Jahr 2022 ab
März diesen Jahres muss dieser Betrieb
die nächste Erhöhung um 98% hinnehmen es
sind dann 44,99 die Kilowattstunde
dieser Betrieb habe ich hat eine super
CO2 Bilanz er produziert einfach nicht
mehr wie auch der Waggon Niesky der
Konkurs angemeldet hat das sind ja bis
180 Arbeitsplätze und nun erwartet
wirklich niemand dass der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister weiß was
darauf folgt ich kann es ihnen sagen
eine Schockstarre aus Kurzarbeit und
Hoffnung darauf dass der Staat seine
Grundaufgaben erfüllt und endlich
Infrastrukturpolitik macht das ist ihre
Aufgabe in diesem Land
mit ihnen und ihre Ampel der
Bundeskanzler hat Deutschland wirklich
fertig sie verspielen auch das sage ich
seit Monaten nicht nur das Vertrauen in
ihre Regierung sondern in die Politik
sie können uns daher dankbar sein dass
wir als einzig wahrnehmbare auch für die
Opposition Fehler hier in diesem Haus
klar benennen und deshalb die Bürger
überhaupt noch an die wahlurmen kommen
und das obwohl sie von ihrem
Bundeskanzler nicht einmal mehr ehrliche
Worte erwarten dürfen sie haben ihre
Klausur in Meseberg angesprochen und
dort sagten sie da der Presse die Preise
sinken
über welche Preise sprachen sie da
eigentlich
die Teuerung spielt bei einer Inflation
von über 6 % wirklich jeder und die
nächsten Preissteigerungen sind bereits
angekündigt im Gastronomie in der
Automobilindustrie und bei den
energieergern hier ein Beispiel kostet
eine klimawandstunde Gas für einen
Privathaushalt in diesem Sommer noch
aktuell 5,318 wird dieser Haushalt ab 1
Oktober diesen Jahres 9,7 Cent die
Kilowattstunde zahlen das ist eine
Preiserhöhung von
81%. aktuell und nebenbei gefragt herr
Scholz wissen sie inzwischen was ein
Liter Benzin oder Diesel kostet
mittlerweile sind wir wieder bei der 2
vor dem Komma ihre Wahrnehmung ist
mittlerweile vollkommen abgekoppelt von
der Lebenswirklichkeit sie leben in
einer Scheinwelt das hat Züge von den
letzten Tagen der Volkskammer in der DDR
aber sie haben immer neue Vorschläge wie
Sie mehr aus der Wirtschaft pressen
wollen um die Wirren klimawendepläne zu
erfüllen seien Sie deshalb auch mal
mutig und informieren Sie die Bürger
doch schon heute das mit der Verdopplung
der Mautgebühren auf deutschen
Autobahnen die ab 2024 kommen soll
wieder neue Preissteigerung zu erwarten
sind und wieder wird die Inflation
dadurch hochgezogen im übrigen ab 3,5
Tonnen das betrifft dann auch
Kleinunternehmer und den Mittelstand die
wieder darunter leiden werden es wird
wirklich Zeit dass die Bürger zu ihrem
Recht kommen und dafür garantiert der
Sozialstaat der auf einen Ausgleich
zwischen Arm und Reich zwischen Alt und
Jung zielt dieser Interessenausgleich
ist bei ihnen aber mittlerweile
vollkommen aus dem Blick geraten wenn
ich arbeiten möchte bekommt
Ersatzleistung nahezu bedingungslos und
die die Arbeiten verlieren Monat für
Monat am netto wie die Rentner
liebe Kollegen noch steigt die
Lebenserwartung in Deutschland damit
auch der Bedarf ein Versorgung
finanziell und medizinisch aber unter
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach wurden
Kliniken geschlossen und das schäbige
daran ist noch dass die impfgeschädigten
in diesem Land allein gelassen werden
steht die im Grundgesetz
garantierte
unantastbare Würde des Menschen bei
ihnen überhaupt noch im Mittelpunkt für
die eigene für die deutsche Bevölkerung
ihre fahrlässige und verfehlte
Migrationspolitik ist ein weiterer
Bereich mit dem diese Bundesregierung
unser Land spaltet mit dem diese
Bundesregierung wirklich auf Amokfahrt
weiter fährt der Strafrecht gewordene
Asylbewerber und Migranten konsequent
ausgewiesen werden müssen wäre wirklich
eine erste kleine Maßnahme aber nichts
passiert merken sie nicht wie sie hier
mittlerweile die Kontrolle darüber
verlieren wer in unser Land kommt
hunderte Migranten täglich an der
Deutsch polnischen Grenze diese
Geisterfahrt muss wirklich beendet
werden merken sie nicht wie die Bürger
ist Leipzig sind wie mit ihren
Steuergeldern umgegangen werden wird
der vorgelegte Entwurf zum
Bundeshaushalt beweist dass umso mehr
eine wirkliche Veränderung für unsere
Bürger die deutsche Wirtschaften ein
zielvereines Deutschland in Europa kann
es nur mit Neuwahlen gehen Herr
Bundeskanzler machen Sie deshalb den Weg
frei die Zeit der Ampel ist abgelaufen
und es geht hier nicht um Parteipolitik
es geht hier sehr wohl um nationale
Kraftanstrengung und die wird es nur mit
der AFD geben es geht um unsere Heimat
in der wir unsere Kinder und Enkelkinder
sehr gern in Sicherheit und Wohlstand
leben möchten daran würden wir als
Alternative für Deutschland in einer
neuen Bundesregierung mit aller Kraft
mit Überzeugung und Glaubwürdigkeit im
Interesse Deutschlands und seiner Bürger
arbeiten vielen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert seit heute
morgen hier in der Generaldebatte der
Bundeskanzler hat allen beteiligt ein
Deutschland packt vorgeschlagen es
müssen schneller moderner und sicherer
in diesem Lande zugehen und Tino krupala
hat jetzt hier noch mal auseinander
genommen dass das Problem vor allem die
Regierung sei hat wörtlich gesagt ähm
sie sind wie die Züge der letzten Tage
der Volkskammer in der DDR und hat dann
den kanzleranschluss aufgefordert am
besten wäre es Neuwahlen abzuhalten das
ist die Alternative für Deutschland und
die Vorsitzende der Bündnis grünen
Fraktion Katharina dröge hat jetzt das
Wort
aussprechen über das was Deutschland ist
sie Herr Merz haben das vor wenigen
Tagen auf dem bayerischen Jahrmarkt
gillamos in einem Bierzelt getan sie
haben gesagt nicht Kreuzberg ist
Deutschland gillamos ist Deutschland
Herr Merz dass sie dieses Bild gewählt
haben das ist kein Zufall das war nicht
im Rausch eines feuchtfröhlichen
bierzeltrednertums solche Bilder wählen
Sie immer wieder solche Bilder werden
sie immer wieder um zu definieren wer
dazu gehört und wer nicht wer richtig in
diesem Land ist und wer falsch wenn sie
von kleinen Jungs im Kindergarten
sprechen deren Eltern muslimisch sind
dann sind das auf einmal nicht mehr
Kinder dann sind das kleine Paschas wenn
sie von ukrainischen geflüchteten
sprechen dann sind das auf einmal sozial
Touristen und wenn sie von Arbeitslosen
sprechen dann sind das auf einmal
Arbeitsverweigerer und auf der anderen
Seite da stehen die Leistungsträger oder
die normalen Menschen wie der Kollege
Hase in der bundestagsdebase gestern
gesagt hat
wenn wir zurückkommen auf das Bild mit
Kreuzberg dann frage ich Sie was an
Berlin Kreuzberg ist nicht deutsch und
was macht die Menschen im bayerischen
Bierzelt Deutscher ist das weil in
Kreuzberg Menschen vieler Nationen leben
und Menschen vieler Biografien und nicht
nur Menschen deren Familien seit
hunderten von Jahren in diesem Land
leben ist das weil in Kreuzberg Menschen
verschiedener Religionen leben und nicht
nur Menschen eine ist das weil in
Kreuzberg Menschen verschiedener
politischer Überzeugungen Leben und
Menschen verschiedener sexuelle
sexueller Identitäten und nicht nur
einer eine CDU die diesen Weg geht die
anfängt zu definieren wer normal ist und
wer nicht wer Deutsch ist und wer nicht
wer dazu gehört und wer nicht die geht
einen gefährlichen Weg wie geht ein
verantwortungslosen Weg gerade in einer
Zeit wie dieser
das wir stattdessen bräuchten wäre eine
Volkspartei die den Anspruch Volkspartei
das heißt für alle eine Partei zu seinen
ernst nimmt was wir bräuchten wäre eine
konservative Partei die den Zusammenhalt
der Menschen in diesem Land nach vorne
stellt und zum Glück haben die Menschen
in diesem Land in zwei Krisen uns
gezeigt von Flensburg bis nach
Niederbayern dass sie diesen
Zusammenhalt schaffen warum sind wir
letztes Jahr besser durch eine Krise
gekommen als wir alle erwartet hätten
das lag daran weil dieses Land
zusammengehalten hat das lag daran bei
Menschen Gas gespart haben weil
Unternehmen Produktionslinien angestellt
haben weil wir gemeinsam daran geglaubt
haben dass wir diese Herausforderung
meistern können und wir haben das
geschafft die Gasspeicher sind besser
gefüllt als erwartet die Wirtschaft ist
besser durch die Krise gekommen als
viele Experten angekommen haben die LMG
Terminals werden schneller gebaut als
sie uns jemals Unkraut hätten die Preise
die sind deutlicher gesunken als wir
alle erwartet hätten das ist eine
gemeinsame Leistung die dieses Land
geschafft hat
und ja es gibt weiterhin große
Herausforderungen auch
wirtschaftspolitische und deswegen frage
ich mich warum gerade der Vorsitzende
der CDU Deutschlands in dieser
Generaldebatte kein einziges Wort zu
Wirtschaftspolitik verloren hat
betrachten sie das nicht mehr als
ihre hierfür Lösungs
voll als Ampel gegen die Aufgaben die
vor uns liegen an mit Tatkraft und mit
Mut zur Zukunft und mit Vertrauen in die
Stärke der Unternehmen in unserem Land
das größte Problem dass die Wirtschaft
hat ist eines über das sie noch nicht
mal sprechen das ist das Thema Arbeits-
und Fachkräftemangel denn wenn der
Bäckerei niemanden mehr finden der die
Brötchen verkauft wenn in der Lausitz
die Ingenieure fehlen und wenn in der
Küste in den Hotels die Arbeitskräfte
ausgehen dann können wir den Laden wir
dicht machen und sie reden noch nicht
mal über dieses Problem während wir als
Koalitionsfraktionen handeln
wir gehen die strukturellen Themen an
mit einem
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz das seinen
Namen verdient hat mit einem modernen
Einwanderungsgesetz und mit der Reform
des Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts wir gehen
alle strukturellen Reformen an ja wir
machen jetzt auch ernst mit dem Thema
Bürokratieabbau denn das ist wichtig das
ist Zentrale in diesem Land das Leben
viel zu viele Unternehmen da muss man
aber auch mal konkret werden und nicht
immer drüber reden sie hatten 16 Jahre
Zeit außer reden haben sie nichts
geschafft
und wir arbeiten an der öffentlichen
Infrastruktur in diesem Land ich möchte
Ihnen eine Geschichte aus dem Sauerland
erzählen von der Talbrücke rammelte bei
Lüdenscheid das ist oder war eine 450
Meter lange Autobahnbrücke der A4 ab 45
wieso marode war dass sie mittlerweile
gesprengt werden musste der ganze
Verkehr der zieht jetzt durch die Dörfer
die Anwohner sind verzweifelt angesichts
des Lärms und der lkw-kara waren die vor
ihrer Haustür durchfahren die Wirtschaft
vor Ort die leidet unter den massiven
Umwegen die die LKWs machen müssen um
irgendwo noch anzukommen wer an dieser
Stelle spart wer die Investitionen in
die Zukunft unserer Infrastruktur von
Nasen vernachlässigt so wie sie das über
viele Jahrzehnte gemacht haben der
gefährdet den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland die Brücke im Sauerland ist
zum Symbol geworden für ihre Tapete
Wirtschaftspolitik
und wenn wir über die Herausforderungen
reden die wirtschaftspolitisch vor uns
stehen dann sollten wir uns auch auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die die
Unterstützung jetzt am meisten brauchen
und das sind die energieutensiven
Unternehmen in diesem Land das sind die
Großen und die Kleinen die stehen im
internationalen Wettbewerb die waren
besonders betroffen von der russischen
Energiekrise die Leiden jetzt unter den
hohen Preisen und ich spreche einfach
eine Einladung aus weil ich weiß dass es
in verschiedenen Fraktionen in diesem
Parlament noch Debatten darüber gibt ob
ein industriestrompreis ob ein
brückenstromkreis die richtige Antwort
ist ich spreche die Einladung aus weil
am Ende müssen wir eine Frage
beantworten Stahl Chemie und Aluminium
die wird es weiterhin geben die werden
irgendwo auf der Welt hergestellt die
Frage ist nur ob die auch in Deutschland
weiterhin hergestellt werden und wir
Grünen und wir sagen ganz klar wir
wollen das weil wir daran glauben das
ist gut bezahlte Facharbeiter Jobs in
diesem Land braucht
Freude daran glauben dass unsere
Industrie gut aufgestellt ist
hochinnovativ und bereit auf dem Schwung
zu einer grünen Zukunft und wenn wir
über Zusammenhalt reden dann müssen wir
auch über Sozialpolitik reden denn die
hohen Preise in diesem Land die Treffen
nicht alle Menschen gleich die treffen
insbesondere diejenigen am härtesten die
am wenigsten haben und deshalb ist es
richtig und deswegen bin ich so froh
dass diese Regierung mit der Anpassung
der Regelsätze an die Inflation jetzt
das macht was angemessen und notwendig
ist wenn Lebensmittel wenn Kleidung wenn
all das was man fürs Leben braucht
teurer wird dann müssen die Regelsätze
angepasst werden dann ist das keine
Bestrafung der hat arbeitenden
Gesellschaft dann ist das einfach nur
die Sicherung des menschenwürdigen
Existenzminimums die uns das Grundgesetz
schon aufgegeben hat
es ist total einfach sich aus der
privilegierten Position eines Mannes der
sein Leben lang sehr sehr gut verdient
hat hinzustellen und auf diejenigen
herabzuschauen den es im Leben nicht so
gut gegangen ist es ist falsch aber es
ist vor allen Dingen auch unehrlich denn
die Anpassung die wir jetzt vornehmen
die geht auf eine Reform zurück der sie
selbst noch vor wenigen Monaten
zugestimmt haben die Reform des
Bürgergeldes ist mit ihren Stimmen und
mit den Stimmen aller unionsgeführten
Regierung in diesem Land verabschiedet
worden und dass sie sich jetzt vor die
Kamera stellen und so tun als ob sie
damit nichts mehr zu tun hätten ich
frage mich wird das Wort der
konservativen Partei in diesem Land
immer nur bis zum Sommer
und das zweite was mir bei Ihnen
auffällt sie entdecken ihr Herz für
diejenigen die hart arbeiten und
trotzdem mit wenig Geld am Ende des
Monats nach Hause kommen immer nur dann
wenn es darum geht gegen diejenigen zu
polemisieren denen es noch schlechter
geht ich frage mich ganz ehrlich was
hilft es der Altenpflegerin die jeden
morgen früh aufsteht und dafür sorgt
dass die Generation ihrer Eltern und
meiner Großeltern eine gute Versorgung
bekommt wenn sie das nicht mehr alleine
schaffen was hilft es der wenn es den
Menschen in der Grundsicherung noch
schlechter geht das einzige was ihr
helfen würde ist dass wir dafür sorgen
dass sie bessere Löhne bekommt und dass
sie unterstützt wird mit den Kosten die
sie in ihrem Alltag hat diese Vorschläge
machen sie aber nicht
sie haben heute gesagt die CDU möchte
die Kinder Grundsicherung stoppen was
für ein Signal gerade für die Frauen in
diesem Land die zum Beispiel das Gehalt
einer Altenpflegerin haben denn die sind
diejenigen die insbesondere von der
Kindergrundsicherung erreicht werden
Menschen die jeden Tag arbeiten gehen
und trotzdem nicht genug verdienen um
die Miete die Winterschuhe und
vielleicht auch mal den Zoobesuch für
die Kinder finanzieren zu können die
nicht mal wussten in der Vergangenheit
dass sie Anspruch auf eine Unterstützung
haben die höher ist als das Kindergeld
das werden wir jetzt damit machen wir
Schluss mit der größten
sozialpolitischen Reform seit vielen
Jahren weil wir endlich einfach machen
dass das Geld bei den Kindern ankommt
und man muss schon sagen wenn sie dann
immer wieder sagen am Ende geht es nicht
um Leistungsverbesserungen sondern es
geht vielleicht um Arbeitsanreize für
diejenigen die im unteren
Einkommensbereich sind der
Altenpflegerin zu sagen macht doch
einfach einen anderen Job oder geh doch
mehr arbeiten das ist zynisch und das
ist so lange wie es uns nicht leisten
diese Altenpflegerin besser zu bezahlen
auch einfach gesellschaftspolitischer
Antwort
sie können mit uns dafür sorgen dass es
den Menschen im unteren
Einkommensbereich besser geht sie hätten
zum Beispiel für die Erhöhung des
Mindestlohnes bestimmen können im
letzten Jahr diese Koalition hat das
gemacht sie haben es nicht gemacht sie
könnten sich für einen Tarif treuegesetz
entscheiden damit endlich Schluss ist
damit dass der Staat bei seiner
öffentlichen Auftragsvergabe auch noch
tariflucht belohnt das wäre eine
Einladung die ich jetzt an sie
ausspreche denn gute tarifverbindung ist
der beste Garant dafür dass die Menschen
ihren Jobs auch gut verdienen und mit
einem Tarif treuegesetz schaffen wir
genau diese Anreize das ist in Zukunft
mehr Tarifverträge in diesem Land gibt
und ganz zum Schluss einfach noch einmal
ein Appell an die Unionsfraktion wir
brauchen Zusammenhalt in diesem Land und
dafür brauchen wir uns alle auch sie wir
brauchen eine konservative Partei die
sagen kann Berlin Kreuzberg ist
Deutschland genauso wie das bayerische
Bierzelt wir brauchen eine konservative
Partei die sagen kann der Christopher
Street Day ist Deutschland genauso wie
die Bayreuther Festspiele und wir
brauchen eine konservative Partei die
sagen kann der Islam gehört zu
Deutschland genauso wie der Evangelische
Kirchentag sie waren da schon mal ich
kann sie nur herzlich einladen kommen
sie wieder zurück
Katharina dröge eine der beiden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Bündnisgrünen
hat sich in ihrer Rede massiv am
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz
abgearbeitet verständlich nach den
Ansagen die Friedrich Merz in den
letzten Tagen immer wieder in Richtung
grüne gegeben hat dass sie keinen
Koalitionspartner sein in dieser
Verfassung nun hat sie ihm den Spiegel
vorgehalten sie hat allerdings auch in
dieser Rede und darauf muss man schon
achten gesagt dass die Grünen weiter für
den industriestrompreis eintreten werden
der Bundeskanzler hat ja 30 Minuten
vorher gerade gesagt dieser
industriestand bei seinem mit ihm nicht
zu machen er hat einen deutschlandpackt
Angeboten an alle Beteiligten
Kooperation statt Streitereien und da
kann man jetzt in Ruhe mal abwarten wie
das in dieser andere Regierung wohl
weitergehen wird nächste Rednerinnen die
noch Fraktionsvorsitzende der Link muss
man ja sagen Amira Mohammed Ali
sehr geehrte
Frau Präsident die Probleme in unserem
Land herrschen klein reden und
gleichzeitig ergotten schlechtes
Regierungshandeln
laut aktuellen Umfragen sind dreiviertel
der Bevölkerung mit der Arbeit der
Bundesregierung unzufrieden und wissen
Sie wie viele laut ARD Deutschland
trennt mit ihrer Arbeit sehr zufrieden
sind
0%. das muss man auch erstmal schaffen
leider ist das kein Wunder alles ist
teurer geworden Lebensmittel Strom Sprit
Heizung Schulsachen Schulausflüge
Urlaubsreisen der Kinobesuch die
Eintrittskarte fürs Schwimmbad die die
vorher schon wenig hatten verzweifeln
und die Angst nicht mehr über die Runden
zu kommen frisst sich immer tiefer in
die Mittelschicht hinein ihre spärlichen
Hilfsmaßnahmen haben nicht dazu geführt
dass die Lage sich entspannt gar nicht
vielleicht können sie wenigstens das mal
einräumen wäre ja ein erster Schritt zur
Besserung
zu Recht sind viele wütend darüber dass
sie auf der einen Seite Milliarden für
Rüstung einfach raushauen und den
Aktionären von Rheinmetall und Co den
reibbach ihres Lebens bescheren auf der
anderen Seite aber überall sonst
knausern und sparen bis es quietscht bis
es knarzt bis es bricht aber das geht so
nicht
2,8 Millionen Kinder in Deutschland sind
in Armut sie haben versprochen das ist
eine Kindergrundsicherung geben wird die
Schluss macht mit der Kinderarmut damit
es eben nicht mehr so ist dass Kinder
ohne Pausenbrot zur Schule gehen oder
durch den Sportverein nicht leisten
können dass kein Kind wegen der
finanziellen Nöte der Eltern mehr
abgehängt wird ihre Familienministerin
Frau Paust hat ausgerechnet das ist 12
Milliarden Euro bräuchte um hier
einigermaßen wirksame Abhilfe zu
schaffen 12 Milliarden Euro das ist
übrigens gerade mal ein Viertel das
militäretals nur mal die Dimension klar
zu machen und was gibt's jetzt
tatsächlich was kommt wirklich
2,4 ich meine man muss kein
Raketenwissenschaftler sein um
festzustellen das ist nur ein Fünftel
der von der Regierung selbst als
notwendig erachteten Summe Frau hat auch
schon zugegeben Frau Pause hat auch
schon zugegeben dass das zu wenig ist
und für Kinder reale Verbesserungen zu
bewirken und sie stellen sich hier
ernsthaft hin und geben sich stolz ob
dieses etikettenschwindet den sie Kinder
sind Sicherungen nennen ihn ist wirklich
gar nichts peinlich wir sollten Sie
verstehen
und Finanzminister Lindner der sagt
sogar dass das die letzte größere
Sozialreformen dieser Wahlperiode sein
wird wow das nennen sie Sozialreform
auch noch größere und jetzt kommt nichts
mehr ich finde das wirklich ein neuer
Tiefpunkt und das wird auch nicht
dadurch besser dass sie Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von SPD und Grünen sich jetzt
alle hinter Christian Lindner verstecken
und in den schwarzen Peter zuschieben
wollen weil er das Geld nicht locker
macht nein das haben sie alle gemeinsam
zu verantworten und nicht so gut nichts
ungewohnt im Gegensatz zu ihnen
behauptet die FDP ja wenigstens nicht
eine soziale Partei zu sein da sind sie
immerhin ehrlich fakt ist ihre Politik
sorgt nicht für Sicherheit im Gegenteil
und deswegen ein kurzes Wort zum
vermursten heizungsgesetz weiterhin
halten sie fest an diesem Quatsch für
das dass der das Klima kaum schützen
würde aber Menschen in unserem Land
verunsichert und Ermer macht auf die
Frage mit wie viel CO2 Einsparungen die
Bundesregierung in eigentlich rechnet
wenn das heizungsgesetz so umgesetzt
wird wie Sie es wünschen antwortet die
Bundesregierung mit 1,4 % bis 2030 wenn
es gut läuft darüber reden wir hier und
dafür regieren sie den Menschen in ihren
Heizungskeller hinein das ist nicht nur
übergriffig das ist absurd
dafür sollen Mieten steigen Kommunen
belastet werden und Hausbesitzer bluten
und wie die Förderung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ganz konkret
aussieht wie man sein Geld konnte
welchen Zeitrahmen man weiß es nicht das
regelt ihr Gesetz nämlich gar nicht klar
ist nur gefördert wird Albert allenfalls
die Kosten für die Wärmepumpe die
Umbauten der Häuser die notwendig sind
aber nicht unmittelbar mit dem Einbau
der Wärmepumpe Zusammenhängen die werden
nicht gefördert da sollen die Leute halt
sehen wie sie klarkommen unglaublich was
sie hier abziehen nur damit Robert
Harbig seine gute situierten Fanbase ein
angeblichen Erfolg für den Klimaschutz
vorweisen kann unfassbar
und derweil
können jeden Tag im ganzen Land Kitas
nicht öffnen wegen Personalmangels ob
Bus und Bahn einen halbwegs zuverlässig
ans Ziel bringen ist weiterhin vor allem
Glückssache wenn Bus und Bahn überhaupt
fahren Kliniken sterben weil sie nicht
rentabel genug sind der Chef der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft Gerald
Gas der erwartet dass in nächster Zeit
ein Drittel der bestehenden
Krankenhäuser schließen muss und er sagt
auch dass die krankenhausreform von der
Lauterbach diese Entwicklung nicht
stoppen sondern noch verschärfen wird
und das sind nur einige Beispiel
viele Menschen machen sich Sorgen um
ihre Zukunft und die Zukunft ihrer
Familien um ihren Arbeitsplatz um Ihr
Zuhause und nein das auszusprechen ist
kein schlecht reden unseres Landes wie
die ampelchor desionäre das gerne
behaupten es ist die Realität
Deutschland ist in einer großen
Wirtschaftskrise einer der größten in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik der
Internationale Währungsfonds IWF rechnet
mit einem Rückgang unserer Wirtschaft um
0,3 Prozent das Ifo-Institut sogar mit
0,4 %. kein anderes Land in der EU hat
vom IWF eine so miese Prognose bekommen
wie Deutschland und was ist die Antwort
der Bundesregierung sparen die
Schuldenbremse soll unbedingt
eingehalten werden koste es was es
wollen eine Volkswirtschaft lässt sich
aber nicht aus der Rezession
heraussparen sie kann nur aus der
Rezession heraus wachsen so ist das
Michael
der Leiter des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung sagte zu ihren
klingen dass jeder Unternehmer wissen
bei großen Herausforderungen wo man neu
Technologien einsetzen neue Produkte
entwickeln will dann muss man erstmal
einen Kredit aufnehmen und sich
verschulden und das Geld auch für den
Staat ihr Festhalten an der
Schuldenbremse ist gegen jede Vernunft
wir dürfen jetzt nicht sparen wir
brauchen große investitions-
und bevor sie das hier reinrufen und
sagen das gäbe ist ja schon der
sogenannte Klima- und
transformationsfonds mit knapp 212
Milliarden Euro möchte ich was zu sagen
man darf man nicht genau hinguckt dann
stellt man fest das reicht nicht das
Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft sagt
dass diese Summe bestenfalls bestenfalls
die Hälfte dessen ist was man bräuchte
und gerade mal die dringendsten
Investitionen zu finanzieren die die
Wirtschaft braucht und zukunftsfähig zu
werden
Michael Hüter Chefin vom IW bezeichnet
die Argument das Staatsschulden immer
schlechte Schulden sein als ökonomisches
Denken der 90er Jahre so viel zum Thema
fortschrittskoalition wie sicher immer
selber gerne nennen ich meine sogar
beiden der ja nur auch nicht auffallen
für Aufbruch und moderne steht sogar der
hat es verstanden die USA haben mit dem
sogenannten den Flächen reduction Act
ein großes Investitionspaket geschnürt
um die Wirtschaft umzubauen und Grüne
Zukunftstechnologien anzusehen deutsche
Unternehmen waren dann in die USA ab
weil sie dort bessere Bedingungen
vorfinden wer ist es hat bereits
stellenstreichen angekündigt und legt
eine ammoniakanlage in Ludwigshafen
steht audi plant E-Autos verstärkt in
den USA herzustellen hier geht es um
relevante Schlüsselindustrien
Deutschland da kann man doch nicht
einfach zu gucken
und es gab schon einmal es gab schon
einmal einen Kanzler der Deutschland mit
seiner Sparpolitik ruiniert hat Heinrich
Brüning Reichskanzler der Weimarer
Republik von 1930 1932 und wohin das
geführt hat und welche politischen
Kräfte dadurch stark geworden sind das
wissen wir
aus Geschichte kann man aber lernen herr
Scholz und auch das können sie tun und
das sollten Sie auch ein weiterer
Unterschied zwischen Deutschland und den
USA wenn Unternehmen dort zu Gute kommt
ist dass die Energie dort bezahlbar ist
und dass das bei uns nicht so ist das
hat Gründe und natürlich war der
russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine der wichtigste Auslöser diese
Entwicklung dass die Preise in
Deutschland aber so hochgegangen sind
und blieben ist das Ergebnis falscher
politischer Entscheidungen dieser
Bundesregierung und jetzt kommen Sie
bitte nicht mit ihrem Stromkreis Deckel
der kam viel zu spät und greift erst bei
viel zu hohen Preisen andere Regierung
waren da klüger Spanien und Frankreich
zum Beispiel
denn bevor ist das für den großen
Teuerung kam hat man harte preisdeckel
für Energie eingeführt und obwohl diese
beiden Länder richtigerweise auch wie
Deutschland den Krieg in der Ukraine
klar verurteilen importieren Sie im
großen Stil das vergleichsweise günstige
Energie Gas aus Russland in diesem Jahr
sogar noch mehr als im Vorjahr wie
gerade vorgestern die Zeitschrift Agrar
heute berichtet hat im Ergebnis fällt
das Bruttoinlandsprodukt dort deutlich
besser aus als bei uns
ich erinnere mich noch an die Worte von
einer beerbock dass die Sanktionen die
russische Wirtschaft ruinieren werden
und ich weiß auch noch was ich andere
die das gesagt haben
wie die mit Schimpf und Schande
überschüttet worden sind wenn man die
Wahrheit ausspricht dass diese
Sanktionen der deutschen Wirtschaft
erheblich schaden werden der russischen
aber nicht Kreml Propaganda und alles
mögliche wurde uns vorgeworfen wir
stellen fest die russische Wirtschaft
wächst um 1,5% in diesem Jahr
offensichtlich hat inzwischen auch Frau
Weber erkannt und einräumen müssen dass
die Sanktionen der russischen Wirtschaft
nicht wirklich geschadet haben
aber folgt auf dieser Erkenntnis jetzt
eine Handlung überdenkt man die falsche
Politik die man gemacht hat ich fürchte
nein stattdessen sagen Sie nun das
Sanktionen nur in Demokratien und
zivilisierten Ländern wirken
[Musik]
das haben wir wieder gewaltige
Sachkompetenz
haben sie damit eigentlich auch
anerkannt dass Koba eine Demokratie ist
ich meine da wirken die
wirtschaftsaktion der USA los erheblich
auf die Wirtschaft aber vielleicht
klären wir das ein andermal ihre
Regierungsarbeit herr Scholz die ist
geprägt durch öffentlichen Streit durch
Unvernunft und durch Unehrlichkeit herr
Scholz wenn Sie wollen dass Deutschland
eine relevante Industrienation bleibt
dann müssen sie ihren Kurs korrigieren
danke
Mohammed Ali die Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linksfraktion hat hier noch einmal
gesagt die Kindergrundsicherung sei ja
in der Ausformulierung wie bisher einen
Etikettenschwindel hat kritisiert dass
es keine größeren Sozialreformen mehr
ergeben soll wenn man den
Bundesfinanzminister ernst nimmt und hat
noch mal gesagt das Festhalten an der
Schuldenbremse sei gegen jede Vernunft
Christian dürr der Fraktionschef der FDP
wird das sicherlich anders bewerten
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kollegen und Kollegen seit eineinhalb
Jahren führt Russland diesen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine Menschen
sterben seit 559 Tagen kämpfen die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer mutig für ihr
Land und eben auch für unsere Freiheit
wir sehen erste auch militärische
Erfolge glücklicherweise
der Durchbruch der russischen
Verteidigungslinie ist einer solcher die
gegen Offensive der Ukraine war an
dieser Stelle erfolgreich auch dank der
militärischen Unterstützung des Westens
und wir aus Deutschland mit unserem
militärischen Material wir helfen
Menschenleben zu retten denken Sie
beispielsweise an das System ihres Tee
und andere das ist das was jetzt zu tun
ist und ich bin dankbar dass die breite
Mehrheit in Deutschland genau hinter
dieser Politik steht das muss man an
einem solchen Tag sagen
ich will Herr Merz aber dennoch direkt
in dem Zusammenhang natürlich auch die
Haushaltspolitik zu sprechen kommen die
sie hier zu Recht eben auch erwähnt
haben
und ich will mit einem Punkt jetzt
aufräumen weil in mehreren Debatten
haben sie das hier eingeführt und es
entspricht schlichtig den Tatsachen wenn
wir in dieser Bundesregierung das 2%
Ziel der NATO sofort nach
Regierungsübernahme und nach Ausbruch
dieser fürchterlichen Krieges im
Kernhaus hätten darstellen können dann
hätte es eine Sondervermögens für die
Bundeswehr gar nicht gebraucht dieses
Sondervermögen was wir
dankenswerterweise mit einer 2/3
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag
beschlossen haben gewährleistet in den
kommenden Jahren das zwei Prozent Ziel
und der Bundeskanzler hat auch über den
Anschluss danach gesprochen das ist die
Einigkeit Herr März alles andere im
Haushaltstitel von den Historie ist
jetzt rumzusuchen macht keinen Sinn war
nicht verabredet ich will an dieser
Stelle einfach mal außer tierisch damit
aufräumen damit alle Klarheit haben an
dieser Stelle liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen alles andere ist nicht richtig
ernährt muss ausgesprochen werden
es ist gleichwohl natürlich nach wie vor
eine herausfordernde Zeit nach vielen
auch krisenbedingten Haushalten
insbesondere während der corona-pandemie
seit 2020 in ihrer
Regierungsverantwortung hat der Bund
einen ganzen Haushalt an zusätzlichen
Schulden gemacht müssen wir aus diesem
Modus herauskommen wir müssen nach vorne
schauen wir müssen zur finanzpolitischen
Normalität zurückkehren und übrigens
deshalb kaum erwähnt bisher es ist eine
gute Entscheidung des Finanzministers
von den vielen Sondervermögen die wir
übrigens von ihnen geerbt haben jetzt
mit diesem Bundeshaushalt ganz konkret
drei Sondervermögen auch mal wieder
abzuschaffen ja das Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr war notwendig zu unserer
Regierungszeit aber wir konzentrieren
uns auf den Kernhaushalt des Bundes und
halten die Schuldenbremse zum zweiten
Mal ein ohne
steuererhöhungsvorschläge der Union
liebe Kollegen auch das ist eine gute
Botschaft
und wir setzen Schwerpunkte mit diesem
Haushalt liebe Kollegen die
Investitionsquote dieser Bundesregierung
im Bundeshaushalt steigt auf 12,2
Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorkrisenniveau
also dem letzten normalen Bundeshaushalt
der großen Koalition wo die
Investitionsquote noch 10,9% betragen
hat das geht in die richtige Richtung
wir setzen sehr klar Prioritäten
beispielsweise beim
wachstumschancengesetz des
Finanzministers ich komme gleich in
Bezug auf die Union noch einmal drauf zu
sprechen und drittens wir entlasten die
Wirtschaft und sorgen für Impulse
insbesondere um den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland zu stärken und verzichten
auf Steuererhöhung liebe Kollegen ich
will auch genau diesen
Wirtschaftsstandort zu sprechen kommen
weil die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
Landes in den letzten Monaten
richtigerweise Thema waren ja und wir
stehen da vor großen Herausforderungen
und deswegen liebe Kollegen Kollegen was
richtig nachdem anderthalb Jahrzehnte
faktisch keine echte Wirtschaftsreform
Politik in Deutschland statt gefunden
hat das muss man einmal aussprechen
glaube ich deswegen war es richtig dass
das Bundeskabinett auf Schloss Meseberg
das wachstumschancengesetz des
Finanzministers beschlossen hat immerhin
mit einem Entlastungsvolumen von
jährlich 7 Milliarden Euro deswegen war
es richtig dass das Bundeskabinett in
die Zukunft schaut und das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz beschlossen
hat wo es um Start-ups geht wo es darum
geht dass mitarbeiterkapitalbeteiligung
auch endlich im Gesetz steht und
deswegen war es richtig dass wir zurzeit
im Deutschen Bundestag über
planungsbeschleunigung sprechen auch das
viele Jahrzehnte besprochen und deswegen
war es richtig dass der
Bundesjustizminister ein großen
Vorschlag für ein großes Bürokratie
Entlastungspaket dieser Bundesregierung
gemacht hat liebe Kollegen Kollegen wir
würden mit diesem Paket auf ein allzeit
Minimum was die Bürokratie Kosten des
Bundes betrifft kommen das sollten wir
tun wir sollten endlich ernst machen und
der Bundeskanzler hat einen packt
angekündigt der Bundestag hat die
Möglichkeit diesen Pakt mit dem bürok
ratie entlassungsgesetz von Marco
Buschmann bereits einzulösen das ist die
richtige Botschaft liebe Kollegen
Kollegen
und
ich will deshalb bei dem Thema bleiben
weil ja richtig in der Sommerpause viele
haben Unternehmen besucht und der
Mittelständler um die Ecke sagt genau
das es sind die Bürokratiekosten
Fachkräftemangel Energiekosten ich komme
darauf später noch aber sind die
Bürokratiekosten die ein Problem da sind
und jetzt müssen wir über Deutschland
hinausschauen
57 Prozent der Bürokratiekosten der
Unternehmen in Deutschland ich saß in
der Deutlichkeit die kommen aus Brüssel
und liebe Kollegen Kollegen der Union da
nehme ich sie in die Pflicht wir werden
in Deutschland alles tun um die deutsche
Wirtschaft bei der Bürokratie zu
entlasten aber ich erwarte ich erwarte
geradezu dass Ursula von der Leyen am
kommenden Mittwoch bei ihrer Rede zur
Lage der Union der Europäischen Union
genau dieses Thema anspricht und in
diesem Pakt in der Bundeskanzler
angekündigt hat wo wir mit Frankreich im
Dialog sein werden genau in diesem Pakt
einsteigt ist wird für die deutsche
Wirtschaft im Herzen Europas nur
funktionieren wenn wir unseren Job
machen das haben wir zugesagt aber ich
erwarte von der kommissionspräsidentin
dass sie auch endlich beim Bürokratie
Abbau ihren Job machen viele Kollegen
diese Erwartungen müssen wir haben in
Deutschland
aber natürlich müssen wir beide
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit darüber
hinausdenken ich sagte es vorhin schon
bei den Stromkosten es gibt höchst
unterschiedliche Konzepte ich denn sagen
wir ein bisschen überrascht in den
letzten Tagen gewesen dass trotz dem
Herr März hier als Parteivorsitzender
der Union gesagt hat dass die Grünen der
Hauptgegner sein jetzt politisch an der
Stelle jedenfalls liebe Kollegen der
Grünen beim Thema industriestrompreis
man inhaltlich als Fraktionsvorsitzender
Friedrich Merzig auf sie zu bewegt gut
dass die FDP dazwischen Sitz will ich an
dieser Stelle sagen aber das nur das nur
nebenbei ähm ich glaube nicht ich glaube
nicht dass eine neue Subvention beim
Preis das richtig ist sondern wir wissen
bei den Abgaben runter deswegen glaube
ich müssen wir über die
stromsteuersenkung sprechen wir könnten
Sie auf das europäische Minimum
reduzieren wir müssen auch über den
Spitzenausgleich sprechen der natürlich
eine Herausforderung ist wenn der
ausläuft insbesondere für eine
energieintensiver in der
energieintensiven Unternehmen in
Deutschland und wir müssen in dem
Zusammenhang Liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
natürlich darüber sprechen wie wir
insgesamt bei der Energiepolitik das was
wir als technologieoffenheit markiert
haben in einigen Gesetzen bereits auch
in Zukunft Fortleben werden wir haben
das heizungsgesetz gesprochen wir haben
Entscheidungen getroffen insbesondere
zum Verbrennungsmotor und vieles mehr
ich habe gehört dass die
bundesaußenministerin im Rahmen der
Botschafterkonferenz auch über
rohstoffpartnerschaften gesprochen hat
und nicht unterstreiche das ausdrücklich
70 Prozent der Primärenergie der
viertgrößten volkswirtschafter der Welt
der Exportnation Deutschland 70 Prozent
importieren wir und ich wage die
Prognose das wird in Zukunft auch so
sein wir sind darauf angewiesen diese
Partnerschaften zu haben beispielsweise
bei synthetischen Kraftstoff und
deswegen ist es richtig dass der
Bundesverkehrsminister auf der IAA ein
Schwerpunkt bei efuelsgesetz hat liebe
Kollegen auch das gewährleistet oder
energiepolitische Sicherheit in der
Zukunft und das ist doch zentral eine
solche Schlüsselindustrie
also es geht um die Erhaltung des
Wohlstands um Schlüsselindustrien wie
beispielsweise die Automobilindustrie
wir wollen in Richtung Klimaneutralität
aber wir wollen eben das insbesondere
durch technologieoffenheit gewährleisten
wir treffen die Entscheidung
beispielsweise zu synthetischen
Kraftstoffen in der Bundesregierung
Kraftstoffe die zu Zeiten der
Unionsregierung verboten waren aber ich
erwarte auch dort ich erwarte auch dort
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
ihre Unterstützung in Bezug auf das was
vor von der Leyen in der Europäischen
Kommission tut wir werden synthetische
Kraftstoff in Reinform an öffentlichen
Tankstellen in Deutschland zulassen wir
werden also dafür sorgen dass das
möglich ist wir werden
rohstoffpartnerschaften abschließen aber
wir können es nicht dulden und wir
wollen es nicht zulassen dass nach wie
vor einigen der Kommission auch die
Kommissionspräsidenten das Ziel hat den
Verbrennungsmotor zu verbieten das wäre
das falsche Signal wir brauchen alle
Technologien insbesondere
Klimaneutralität zu erreichen und der
erwartet sich ihre Unterstützung liebe
Kollegen Kollegen der CDU ist
also
an der Stelle hat auch da will ich
darüber hinausgehen an der Stelle hat
der der Bundesfinanzminister eine ganz
wichtige Ankündigung gemacht er hat
gesagt
Klimaneutralität und
technologieoffenheit das muss ich auch
im Steuerrecht widerspiegeln wir haben
das in der Koalition bereits politisch
beschlossen und wir werden jetzt dazu in
die Gesetzgebung gehen nämlich dass wir
unabhängig davon wo der Kraftstoff
herkommt ausschließlich darauf achten
dass der klimaneutral ist und deswegen
ist es vollkommen richtig die
Elektromobilität die genauso ein Platz
hat wie andere Technologien die
Elektromobilität genauso zu behandeln
wie wir in Zukunft beispielsweise den
Antrieb mit synthetischen Kraftstoffen
steuerlich behandelt werden bei der
Kfz-Steuer und so weiter und sofort das
ist das was wir in Deutschland für
technologieoffenheit tun können
insbesondere auch im Sinne einer
Energiepolitik die diesen Standort
Stärken diese Dinge gehören zusammen
liebe Kollegen
und ich will in dem Punkt
auf etwas zweites zu sprechen natürlich
geht es auch um die Frage wie wir
unseren Wirtschaftsstandort neben den
Rahmenbedingungen neben den steuerlichen
den ordnungspolitischen
Rahmenbedingungen auch Stärken was den
Arbeitsmarkt betrifft es ist vollkommen
richtig dass ein Sozialstaat
selbstverständlich die Schwachen und die
ärmeren die schwieriger gerade am Beginn
ihres Lebens im Blick hat und deswegen
werden wir die Kindergrundsicherung auf
dem Weg bringen mit dem klaren Fokus das
familienpolitische Leistungen einfacher
zugänglich werden richtig ist
gleichzeitig dass die Erwerbstätigkeit
der Eltern die zentrale Herausforderung
ist und Kinderarmut zu bekämpfen und an
dieser Stelle werden wir einiges tun und
ich bin dankbar dass auch der
Bundesarbeitsminister beispielsweise
gesagt hat dass wir natürlich in dem
Zusammenhang gemerkt über das Thema
arbeitsanreiz zu sprechen werden aber
ich will nicht unerwähnt lassen was
diese Regierungskoalition bereits durch
den Deutschen Bundestag gebracht hat
denn es ist ja richtig es muss sich
lohnen Rand zu klotzen es muss
unintelligible beispielsweise für einen
jungen Menschen lohnen eine Ausbildung
anzufangen und richtig ist doch Herr
Merz dass zu ihrer Regierungszeit ein
junger Mensch der aus einer Familie
kommt die Schwert weil sie
beispielsweise im Leistungsbezug von
damals Hartz IV war ein junger Mensch
der eine Ausbildung gestartet hat durfte
von seiner Ausbildungsvergütung gerade
mal 300 Euro erhalten diese
Regierungskoalition hat es zu Recht
entschieden dass es sich endlich lohnt
eine Ausbildung anzufangen dieser junge
Mensch kann jetzt 700 Euro behalten das
ist soziale Gerechtigkeit und Verbindung
mit arbeitseinreizen und deswegen
verstehe ich nicht warum sie dort den
Arbeitsanreize so polymisieren als Union
und ich will einen zweiten Punkt
ansprechen das betrifft die
Bildungschancen junger Menschen es ist
doch vollkommen richtig das gerade junge
Menschen die schwere am Leben haben am
Start ihres Lebens die besten
Ausgangsbedingungen brauchen und
deswegen ist das staatschancenprogramm
der bundesforschungs- und
Bildungsministerin Bettina stark
batzinger so richtig in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist uns einer
Koalition zwischen Union und FDP haben
wir das mit den talentschulen sehr
erfolgreich umgesetzt wir sollten das
bundesweit machen wir sollten bundesweit
mit diesem Staat chancen-programm
endlich durchstarten und da ist meine
herzliche Bitte im Sinne des der
Zusammenarbeit die der Bundeskanzlerin
seiner Rede markiert hat da ist meine
herzliche Bitte dass sie auch auf ihre
Länderkollegen zu gehen ich sag mal in
der Deutlichkeit weil es mich ärgert
dieses Mini der
landeskultusminister und mancher
Ministerpräsidenten das regt mich
langsam auf Bildung ist eine nationale
Anstrengung und wir leisten unseren
Beitrag ich erwarte von den Ländern auch
von den Regierten dass sie nicht
mitmachen dann statt Chancen hören dass
sie mitmachen bei der Digitalisierung
der Schulen dass sie mitmachen dass
Menschen mehr Chancen hat und besser im
Arbeitsmarkt unterwegs sind liebe
Kollegen
und zum Schluss wir müssen natürlich in
die Zukunft denken auch was den Haushalt
betrifft der Bundesfinanzminister hat
gestern zu Recht gesagt dass es an der
Stelle darum geht Eisberge frühzeitig zu
erkennen und richtigerweise zum Schiffen
der Bundestag hat nach wie vor und wird
in Zukunft eine große Herausforderung
bei die demografischen Lasten haben das
ist nicht die Schuld der ältere
Generation sondern es ist auch die
Verantwortung übrigens auch meiner
Partei Regierungsverantwortung in führen
Legislaturperioden zu wenig Vorsorge
getroffen zu haben aber in dem
Zusammenhang fand ich es schon spannend
verehrte Herr märz als ich die Zeitung
aufschlug und in Bezug auf die
gesetzliche aktienrente also das
generationenkapital als Vorschlag des
Finanzministers als sich dort las das
sein hedgefondsmethoden weil meine
Intuition war
hat sich da ein Koalitionspartner
irgendwie kritisch geäußert nein das war
nicht so dann war mir klar es muss von
der Linkspartei kommen hättest von
Methoden wenn es darum geht die
gesetzliche Rentenversicherung endlich
zukunftsfit und Enkel zu machen
Patchwork mit so wissen Sie wer von
Hedgefonds Methoden gesprochen hat wenn
wir über das generationenkapital
sprechen also die zentrale demografische
Herausforderung die Frage ob Menschen in
Zukunft in Würde altern können und die
Beitragslast nicht steigen von hatchimal
Methoden sprach der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der CDU CSU wie weit links sind sie denn
gerückt an dieser Stelle es ist
unglaublich ich kann es nicht fassen ich
kann es nicht fassen
ja die liegt Partei gibt den recht
also liebe Kollegen Kollegen zum
Abschluss meine herzliche Bitte ist dass
wir diese Herausforderung bei der
Bürokratie bei der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unseres Landes auch bei der Bildung
gemeinsam anfassen wir haben erste
Schritte getan bei der Entlastung der
Mitte beispielsweise durch das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz aber eine
Schimäre funktioniert nicht wir halten
die Schulden bringen sie richtigerweise
ein das werden wir auch in den kommenden
Jahren tun aber bitte und auch da meine
herzliche an die cdu/csu hören sie auf
in einem Land das die höchsten Steuern
hat über Steuererhöhungen zu reden liebe
Kollegen Kollegen der Spitzensteuersatz
ich sag das deshalb in der Deutlichkeit
weil sie ja selbst mittlerweile gegen
vermeintlich reichere polymisieren der
Spitzensteuersatz in Deutschland ist bei
der Einkommensteuer in aller Regel die
Unternehmenssteuer für kleine
Unternehmen für Einzelunternehmer und
Personengesellschaften das sind 2,4
Millionen Menschen die für Jobs sorgen
die jeden Morgen ran klotzen die Zahlen
denen den ernsthaft in ihrem Konzept auf
57% faktisch erhöhen zu wollen ist ein
Unding das ist das Gegenteil von
Leistungsgerechtigkeit wir stehen für
leistungsrechtlichkeit in dieser
Regierung ich danke Ihnen
Christian Dürre der Fraktionsvorsitzende
hier mit seiner Rede indem er sehr viele
Punkte angesprochen hat noch mal die
Notwendigkeit das wachstumschancengesetz
das die Zukunft finanzierungsgesetz
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz Bürokratie
Entlastungspaket all dieses sei auf den
Weg gebracht und auch er hat sich sehr
intensiv mit dem Oppositionschef
auseinandergesetzt von der Position
kommt jetzt Alexander Dobrindt
landesgruppenchef von erster
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
der Union
Herr Bundeskanzler nach einer aktuellen
Umfrage des allenbach-instituts glauben
nur noch 10% der Bürger dass die
ampelpolitik dieses Land voranbringen
wird sie regieren an die Probleme der
Menschen vorbei sie Regierenden
Herausforderung dieses Landes vorbei sie
reden an den Sorgen der Bürger vorbei
dieses Land braucht Antworten auf
Inflationsangst auf Energiepreise
obwohlstandsverlust bekommen tut man von
ihnen Cannabis selbstbestimmungsgesetz
und Express Einbürgerung das ist das
Gegenteil von Fortschritt das ist
Abstieg meine Damen und Herren
und dabei haben sie heute gesprochen von
Kaufkraft gewinnen die bei den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern zu
verzeichnen während des Ifo-Institut
bestätigt diese Woche dass es einen
Rückgang der Inflation nur ganz ganz zäh
gibt und wir länger mit dieser Inflation
noch leben müssen und das heißt dass die
Belastungen der mittleren und kleinen
Einkommen durch die Inflation sich
weiter aufbauen wer zu Beginn ihrer
Wahlperiode Herr Bundeskanzler seinen
Wocheneinkauf für 100 € bezahlt hat der
muss heute dafür
130 Euro ausgeben das trifft die
Familien das trifft die mittleren und
kleinen Einkommen das trifft die Rentner
die Inflation ist die Enteignung der
mittleren und kleinen Einkommen ob am
Monatsende der Kühlschrank voll ist oder
leer ist entscheidet sich genau an
dieser Stelle unter verweisen sie darauf
dass es Kaufkraft Gewinne gibt das ist
das Gegenteil von dem was stattfindet
tun sie etwas gegen die Enteignung der
kleinen und bitteren Einkommen und
zeigen Sie den mehrwertsteuermittel
der Bundeskanzler sie haben in ihrer
Rede bevor sie uns einen Pakt angeboten
haben erstmal einen Kompromiss
aufgekündigt sie haben in ihrer Rede der
Zeitenwende davon gesprochen dass diese
100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr
zusätzlich zur Verfügung stehen wir
haben diesen Kompromiss mit ihnen
geschlossen zusätzlich zur Verfügung
stehen heute haben sie uns vorgeworfen
wir würden diesen Kompromiss aufkündigen
ich sage Ihnen Herr Bundeskanzler wir
stehen weiterhin zu diesem Kompromiss es
ist ihre ampelregierung die nicht mehr
zu diesen Kompromiss steht
und möglicherweise haben Sie den Bericht
des Bundesrechnungshof von gestern noch
nicht lösen können vor ihrer Rede der
bestätigt nämlich genau das wörtlich es
läuft dem Zweck des
verfassungsgesetzgebers entgegen dass
sie jetzt versuchen die Verwendung zu
verändern der Bundesrechnungshof hält es
für rechtlich unzulässig dass sie die
Verwendung jetzt verändern sie kündigen
den Kompromiss auf weil sie dieses Geld
eben nicht mehr zusätzlich für die
großen Beschaffungen verwenden wollen
sie wollen es in normalen Haushalt
verbraten und bringen damit die
Bundeswehr und die Ausrüstung
der Bundeskanzler trotzdem war
beachtlich dass sie heute von einer
nationalen Kraftanstrengung gesprochen
haben dass sie von einem Deutschland
packt gesprochen haben dass sie von
Kooperation statt Streitereien
gesprochen haben ich war mir in dem
Moment nicht sicher an wen sich dieser
Satz eigentlich richten sollte
vermutlich an ihre eigene Koalition was
die Streitereien anbelangt der
Dauerstreit scheint ja zum Normalzustand
geworden zu sein aber ich würde sagen
beenden Sie als erstes mal die
Streitereien in ihrem eigenen Laden über
Energiepreise über Kernenergie über
Kindergrundsicherung dann können wir uns
darüber unterhalten wir mit uns
kooperieren kann
nichtsdestotrotz ich glaube dass man in
einer Lage in der sich unser Land
befindet durchaus dieses Angebot von
ihnen ernst nehmen sollte und ich sage
Ihnen auch wir sind durchaus bereit mit
Ihnen auch eine Kooperation oder einen
Pakt auch einzugehen ich halte aber
allerdings auch fest dass dieses Angebot
deutlich zeigt dass die Gemeinsamkeiten
in ihrer Koalition ganz offensichtlich
beendet sie sind und Sie uns ein Angebot
zur Zusammenarbeit machen weil sie ihre
eigenen Ampel für zentrale Fragen keine
Mehrheit mehr sehen der Bundeskanzler
aber wenn ihre Koalition in weiten
Teilen ausfällt ja dann stehen wir
selbstverständlicherweise auch zur
Verfügung um einen deutschlandpack zu
machen dann reden wir aber als
allererstes über eine der zentralsten
Krisen aktuell in Deutschland nämlich
über die flüchtlingskrise dann reden wir
darüber
wie wir gemeinsam diese flüchtlingskrise
bewältigen können und dazu haben wir
einen klaren Fahrplan den können Sie mit
uns sofort in der nächsten Sitzungswoche
in einen deutschland-park zur
Bewältigung dieser Krise hineinschreiben
dann lassen Sie uns darüber reden dass
wir die sicheren Herkunftsstaaten
endlich gemeinsam vereinbar nicht nur
moldaugeorgen sondern die Marke starten
mit dazu
dann lassen Sie uns doch vereinbaren
dass wir Grenzkontrollen jetzt auch bei
Polen bei Tschechien durchführen die in
Österreich mehr als die Hälfte aller
Flüchtlinge aller illegalen einreisen
kommen über die polnische Grenze lassen
Sie uns das vereinbaren ihre
Innenminister blockiert das zurzeit
vereinbaren Sie mit uns dass wir die
Freiwilligen Aufnahmeprogramme ihre
Außenministerin sofort stoppen damit wir
den Druck auf unsere Kommunen damit auch
reduzieren können wir sind sofort dabei
vereinbaren Sie mit uns dass wir mehr
Sachleistungen weniger Geldleistung
machen vereinbaren will uns dass wir
Ausreise Gewahrsam verlängert und
vereinbaren Sie damit mit uns dass es
endlich aufhört das aus ihrer Regierung
heraus die europäischen Beschlüsse zum
außengrenzverfahren
wir können das alles gemeinsam auch
besprechen und diskutieren aber wenn du
den Kollegen auch Taten folgen lassen
und wir erwarten dass auf uns
entsprechend zugegangen wird und genau
für diese Frage der flüchtlingskrise für
eine nächste Sitzung dann die
entsprechenden Vereinbarungen zu treffen
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von der
Beatrix von Storch
lassen Sie diese dummen Zwischenrufen ja
sehr geehrter Dobrind vielen Dank dass
Sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen und ich
muss diese Frage die sich uns immer und
immer wieder stellt bei den ganzen reden
die sie halten insbesondere mit Blick
auf die Flüchtlingspolitik einmal fragen
merken Sie eigentlich irgendetwas ich
meine sie fordern Grenzschutz sie
fordern Abschiebung sie fordern
Sachleistung statt Geldleistung sie
fordern alles das was wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode durchgehend von Ihnen
gefordert haben als sie in der Regierung
waren und es hätte in umsetzen können da
haben sie das alles abgelehnt und das
Gegenteil getan jetzt sitzen sie
machtlos in der Opposition und machen
Wahlkampf Getöse vor Landtagswahlen
immer noch mehr als sonst verstehen Sie
dass die Menschen ihn gar nicht mehr
glauben es vollkommen lächerlich ist
wenn die CDU CSU ankommt und ein hartes
Grenzregime fordert und ein hartes
Vorgehen in illegale Migration Standard
ein konsequenten Grenzschutz von alles
das was sie hätten machen können aber
nie gemacht haben und die ganzen
Probleme die dieses Land jetzt hat sind
in einem Ausmaß deswegen entstanden weil
sie
2015 die Grenzen nicht geschützt haben
ich weiß sie hören das ungern aber es
wäre unglaublich glaubwürdig wenn Sie
sich einmal hinstellen würden und jetzt
wäre vielleicht ein guter Moment sich
hinzustellen und sich vor der Republik
zu entschuldigen für das Versagen ihrer
Regierungszeit insbesondere seit 2014
und dann sozusagen jetzt wollen wir das
Gegenteil von alledem was wir die ganze
Zeit gemacht haben als wir es
entscheiden können
[Applaus]
doch ich habe diese Frage zugelassen
weil ich ihn gerne ein Zitat Vorlesen
möchte von früheren Verfassungsrichter
Udo die Fabio der hat vor kurzem in
einem
bemerkenswerten Interview folgendes
gesagt
die AFD ist nicht konservativ auch nicht
nationalkonservativ wenn man ihre
geistige Nähe zum Kriegsherren Putin
sieht er hat ferner gesagt aber die
radikale Wut bewahrt nicht sondern
zerstört die Verbrüderung mit einem
Russland dass das nationale
Selbstbestimmungsrecht von Völkern bis
achtet kann man kaum anders werden als
einen Verrat an jedem ehrlichen
Patriotismus nennen sie sich nicht mehr
patriorten das ist meine Botschaft an
sie
[Applaus]
Bundesfinanzminister sie haben gestern
in ihrer
Haushaltsrede Bezug genommen auf die 29
sonder Haushalte und haben mich dabei
direkt angesprochen Herr
Bundesfinanzminister und haben gesagt
die wären ja schon aus Zeiten von Theo
Waigel um zumindestens zum Teil zur
Zeiten von Theo Waigel um den Versuch
ihres arguments und den Versuch ihres
arguments zu komplettieren möchte ich
sagen es geht schlichtweg um das Volumen
Herr Bundesfinanzminister und da muss
man doch gar nicht so weit zurückgehen
bis zu theoriegel im Jahr 2019 was ja
ihr Referenz ja ist der war der Anteil
des Haushalts des Bundeshaushalts aus
den sogenannten Sondervermögen 5
Milliarden Euro in ihrem jetzigen
Entwurf ist der Anteil des Haushalt aus
Sondervermögen nahezu 95 Milliarden Euro
und das ist der Unterschied fünf
Milliarden zu 95 Milliarden fast 20
Prozent ihres Haushalts wird aus
Sondervermögen bestätigt und das ist was
anderes als solide Haushaltsführung
was sie gerade tun sie nennen das
konsolidieren ich nenne das Kaschieren
wir stellen fest dass es vom
Bundesrechnungshof jetzt auch einen
neuen Begriff gibt die echte
Nettokreditaufnahme wird eingeführt ganz
offensichtlich weil es auch eine
verschleierte netto Kreditaufnahme gibt
sie reden offiziell von 16,6 Milliarden
die echte nette Kreditaufnahme nach
Rechnungshof sind
85,7 Milliarden das heißt der
Bundesfinanzminister wenn sie fünf Euro
Schulden aufnehmen dann stellen sie eine
einen Euro ganz offiziell da vier Euro
wollen sie dort verheimlichen und dann
haben sie darauf hingewiesen dass sie
auch Sondervermögen auflösen das ist
sehr sehr spannend war ein
Sondervermögen dass sie jetzt auflösen
ist das Sondervermögen digitale
Infrastruktur
digitale Infrastruktur gefüllt aus den
Erlösen der Vergabe der Mobilfunk das
Lizenzen daher kommt das Geld das in
diesem Sondervermögen steckt bisherige
Aufgabe festgeschrieben Breitbandausbau
wo viel Punkte mobilfunknetzausbau
digitalpakt Schule dort lagen 4,2
Milliarden Euro sie nehmen dieses Geld
geben davon 2,7 Milliarden Euro an die
entsprechenden Häuser
Verkehrsministerium und
an das Verkehrsministerium und an das
Familienministerium geben Sie 2,7
Milliarden Euro 1,5 Milliarden Euro von
diesem Sondervermögen stellten sie in
die eigene Tasche das steht für diese
Aufgaben nicht mehr zur Verfügung sie
müsste es zukünftig mit Schulden
finanzieren auch das hat der
Rechnungshof deutlich ausgedrückt das
ist das Gegenteil von Fortschritt das
ist Abstieg wenn Sie jetzt bei
Infrastruktur und digitale Minister
so und der Bundeskanzler sie haben auch
für den fleißigen in diesem Land
gesprochen von den Leistungsträgern ich
bin ihnen da sehr sehr dankbar aber
haben sie die Umfrage auch zur Kenntnis
genommen die heute veröffentlicht ist
dass 52 Prozent der Menschen den
Eindruck haben dass sich Arbeit in
Deutschland nicht mehr lohnt die
Überschrift die Schlagzeile heißt heute
der fleißige ist der dumme und der
Bundeskanzler die Verantwortung dafür
tragen sie mit dem Bürgergeld dass die
Bürger diesen Eindruck haben dass der
fleißige der Dumme ist sie sprechen
davon dass es Trost ist der sich in der
Bevölkerung anstarrt sie sind diejenigen
die die Leute frustrieren mit ihrer
Politik und dafür sorgen dass der
fleißige Dumme ist
und alles
und vielleicht als eindrucksvollen
Beweis dass es eine Reihe von Menschen
gibt die das sind ähnliche Art und Weise
genauso sehen will ich Ihnen mal sagen
wie die Kommunalpolitik und übrigens
auch aus der SPD Kommunalpolitiker
darüber denken der Bürgermeister von
Rottenbuch Markus Bader hat sich
gemeldet in dieser Woche in einem
Interview er sagt dort wörtlich es ist
die Aufgabe der Politik
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen aber nicht
zu bevormunden Recht hat der Mann er
schreibt wörtlich mir scheint es
manchmal das wollen besonders linke
Teile der SPD eine neue Spieler des
Sozialismus ein einführen und dies durch
die ökologische Hintertür vielleicht hat
er recht das können sie beantworten
wörtlich es ist nicht Aufgabe des
Staates eine
Erziehungsanstalt zu sein über diese
Interview des SPD Bürgermeisters lautet
die Überschrift ich kann die Entwicklung
der SPD nicht mehr mittragen dieser Mann
ist ausgetreten aus der SPD Recht hat
der Mann
ein etwas abruptes Ende Alexander
Dobrindt hier er hat am Anfang seiner
Rede gesagt sie regieren an dem Problem
der Menschen vorbei dieses Land braucht
Antworten
beleidigenden
Zwischenrufen sie sind eine Pfeife so
ähnlich war es einen Ordnungsruf
von der AFD mit einem ordnungshof dabei
hatte gestern die Bundestagspräsidentin
noch mal alle ermahnt hier pfleglicher
miteinander umzugehen ist schon am
ersten Tag hier danach wieder
offensichtlich gebrochen worden und
jetzt der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion läuft sie nicht
alles gut
in der Tat ist bleibt die Präsidentin
aber wegen der wegen des Respekts frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu Recht hat der Bundeskanzler
den russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
als seitenwende bezeichnet und nicht
allein die Tat und das Ausmaß sondern
auch die Folgen für die internationale
Ordnung werden sich tief in die Welt
einbrennen und der Krieg in der Ukraine
davon bin ich fest überzeugt und wir
haben öfter hier im Plenum darüber
gesprochen beschleunigt die Neuordnung
der Welt und deswegen ist diese
Feststellung des Bundeskanzlers richtig
und dennoch glaube ich dass es gut ist
den Begriff der Zeiten Wände Weile eben
zu wertvoll zu zentral ist auch mit
anderen Herausforderungen gleichzeitig
zu verbinden und sie gibt es eben in
ganz unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftspolitischen Europa
politischen internationalen Bereich da
ist das Klima die Wirtschaft die
Digitalisierung die Pandemie und ich
sage es auch ganz bewusst weil sich doch
vieles im Leben der Menschen ändert auch
das öffentliche und private miteinander
und deswegen sage ich ja wir leben und
arbeiten in vielen Zeiten wenden meine
Damen und Herren und alleine eine
Herausforderung wer für viele Menschen
schon eine große Herausforderung und sie
erkennen sie als Belastung und deswegen
sage ich auch frei auch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag würde wahrscheinlich
eine zwei drei Zeiten wenden reichen für
eine gesamte Legislaturperiode deswegen
ist das gesamte dem wir uns stellen
müssen natürlich etwas was verunsichert
auch mich persönlich und deswegen
verstehe ich auch wenn die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sich ins Private manchmal
zurückziehen doch sozusagen ihren
Schutzraum identifizieren der Psychologe
Stefan Grünewald hatte am Anfang seiner
großen Studie Anfang letzten Jahres
gesagt das persönliche Zuversicht der
deutschen uns Vertrauen in Politik aber
ich sage auch gleichzeitig in Wirtschaft
und selbst in die Gesellschaft schwindet
und deswegen ist es gut wenn wir auch
etwas bisschen bescheidener vielleicht
manchmal auch in dieser Debatte
formulieren würden deswegen stelle ich
mich meine Damen und Herren dieser
Skepsis zumal und auch das sage ich
offen die Spitzen der Koalition in den
vergangenen Monaten kein gutes Bild
abgegeben haben ja wir müssen besser
werden handwerklich kommunikativ und ich
sage auch sehr deutlich die Antworten
können unterschiedlich sein aber am Ende
gerade auch für diese Koalition steht am
Ende ein gemeinsames Ganzes was auch nur
diese politische Verbindung in dieser
Legislaturperiode erreichen kann
deswegen bin ich auch so stolz
dass wir vor zwei Jahren diese
Verbindung eingegangen sind meine Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen miteinander können wir
erfolgreich sein weil nur in dieser
Konstellation die Herausforderungen
beantwortet werden in keiner anderen
politischen Konstellation schauen Sie
sich im Deutschen Bundestag an wäre es
möglich den Umbau der Arbeit und der
Wirtschaft zu Klimaneutralität ein neuen
Rechtsrahmen der sich speist aus
Liberalität aus einem
Verantwortungsbewusstsein für das Klima
aber gleichzeitig auch der soziale
Rückhalt zu verankern das macht diese
Koalition aus und deswegen sage ich auch
dafür steht meine Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und da hilft keine
hauruck-rede nicht mit dem mit der Faust
auf den Tisch schlagen allein weiter was
genauso weiterhilft ist eine gute
Voraussetzung nämlich eine verlässliche
und auch unaufgeregte parlamentarische
Arbeit und ich sage das sehr
selbstbewusst das Gebäude Energiegesetz
steht für diese verlässliche und
unaufgeregte Arbeit ein Gesetzentwurf
der in mühevoller Kleinarbeit von den
Abgeordneten vom Kopf auf die Füße
gestellt worden ist ich darf das hier so
sagen auch als selbstbewusster
Parlamentarier ich hätte es mir nicht
gewünscht zumindestens diesen
Gesetzentwurf in dieser Form so hier im
Deutschen Bundestag zu sehen aber das
kann man sich nicht aussuchen aber wir
haben es eben geschafft die Grundlagen
zu verändern die kommunale wärmeplanung
wird jetzt damit verkoppelt und beides
itt am
01.01.2024 in Kraft die Zeiträume sind
geändert worden und gleichzeitig eben
auch die Hilfen ganz konzentriert auf
diejenigen orientiert weil nämlich
Klimaschutz meine Damen und Herren und
dafür sind wir in dieser Koalition
angetreten und deswegen hat auch meine
Partei ja gesagt Klimaschutz müssen sich
alle leisten können und genauso ist das
Gebäude Energiegesetz auch konzentriert
deswegen
souveräne und selbstbewusste Parlamente
in Europa in den Ländern aber eben auch
im Bund das sind die Architekten und
gleichzeitig die Handwerker die auch für
diese zeitenwände gut ausgerüstet sind
ja wir dürfen die Herausforderungen das
habe ich gesagt nicht kleinreden und ich
glaube die Bürgerinnen und Bürger spüren
diesen Druck deswegen wissen Sie um die
strukturellen Gründe auch von denen
Deutschland steht natürlich ist die
weltweite Konjunktur ein Problem für ein
so exportorientiertes Land wie
Deutschland aber das ist nicht die
Exportabhängigkeit sondern es steht für
Qualität es steht für den Erfindergeist
auch Deutschland und genau in dieser
Richtung müssen wir denken die Chancen
letztlich erkennen und deswegen sagen
wir ja auch wir wollen den
Arbeitskräftemangel und den
Fachkräftemangel gemeinsam
angehen und gleichzeitig eben auch
wissen dass es neue wirtschaftliche
Zentren in der Welt gibt es bleibt nicht
so wie es gewesen ist wie meine
Generation es vorgefunden hat wir müssen
diesen Weg verändern wir müssen ihn
mitgehen und meine Damen und Herren das
will meine Fraktion und ich bin auch der
festen Überzeugung auch diese Koalition
und deswegen
sage ich auch ja
wenn wir auf die Realitäten ganz genau
schauen und auch ein bisschen
bescheidener formulieren dann akzeptiere
ich auch dass auch uns
Versäumnisse aus der Vergangenheit
vorgeworfen werden aber ich will jetzt
mal einfach sagen dass betrifft dann
auch alle natürlich gebe ich zu dass wir
manchmal nicht die Kraft gehabt haben
für das auch Mehrheiten zu schaffen was
so dringend notwendig gewesen ist und
ich war selbst im Kanzleramt Herr Merz
damals als wir über Klimapolitik
gesprochen haben morgens früh um 5 Uhr
haben wir darum gerungen haben wir darum
gerungen endlich auch bei den Windrädern
bei der erneuerbaren Energie Wege zu
finden und da ist nicht nur in dieser
Koalition blockiert worden wir hatten
auch keine Unterstützung aus dem
Bundesländern gehabt deswegen sage ich
mal alles das was dem einzelnen hier
vorgeworfen wird das betrifft das ganze
und deswegen ist es gut dass diese
Koalition endlich diesen Wandel endlich
diese Wende macht und deswegen sage ich
sehr deutlich selbstbewusste Parlamente
und meine Fraktion werden daran
mitwirken und wir haben etwa sehr
erreicht wir haben etwas erreicht in den
zwei Jahren die Halbzeitbilanz ist gut
wir haben wichtige Etappen gefunden
bleibende Veränderungen soziale Rechte
geschaffen insbesondere für
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und
deren Familien ich nenne das Wohngeld
nicht nur dass es erhöht worden ist
sondern dass es ausgeweitet worden ist
und das Bürgergeld der Kollege Merz
jeder fünfte ist auf das Bürgergeld
deswegen angewiesen weil er zu wenig
Einkommen hat darum geht es in diesem
Land weil zu ringen zu geringen bezahlt
wird und sie an den Bürgergeld
zugestimmt aber die mindestens nicht da
dreht sich etwas um und ich finde das
ist
verantwortungsvoll wenn wir so handeln
und auch das Kindergeld da hat ja
offensichtlich niemand zugehört bis in
die Kreise die sich in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten abgemüht haben das
haben wir mit sieben Milliarden Euro
angepasst
250 Euro jedes Kind ab dem ersten Kind
bekommt dies und dann noch den
Kinderzuschlag das ist etwas um das
Plateau für die Kindergrundsicherung zu
finden und das hat das Parlament gemacht
der Haushaltsgesetzgeber und das war
richtig liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Energiesicherheit Digitalisierung
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte aber eben auch
die Tarifautonomie Stärken es geht jetzt
um Mitbestimmung in den nächsten Monaten
wenn wir hier im Deutschen Bundestag
darüber debattieren was ist mit dem
Betriebsverfassungsgesetz Mitbestimmung
ist eine wichtige
Verbindung in einem Staat der sich
Sozialstaat nennt und das kostet nicht
sondern das gibt etwas das gibt nämlich
Sicherheit den Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern und es gibt Sicherheit den
Unternehmen weil sie wissen alle die
dort in diesem Unternehmen sind arbeiten
Hand in Hand und genau das ist das was
Deutschland als Sozialmodell auch
anbietet und deswegen
Herr Bundeskanzler ich kann für meine
Fraktion sagen dass wir an diesem
deutschlandpackt mitwirken werden und
wenn der dobrin für die gesamte Fraktion
gesprochen hat Kollege Dobrindt dann
nehme ich das gerne auf dass sie daran
mitwirken wollen und wir haben es ja
nicht nur in ihre Richtung als Fraktion
gesagt sondern weil wir auch die
Bundesländer brauchen weil wir doch auch
die Kommunen brauchen darum geht's und
deswegen sage ich ja das Angebot des
Bundeskanzlers für den Deutschland packt
ist richtig und lassen wir es anpackten
ich glaube das ist ein guter Schritt
auch in den kommenden zwei Jahren dieser
Legislaturperiode liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wenn ich gleichzeitig sage
in konjunkturellen Schwächephasen der
Finanzminister und an die ganze
Bundesregierung auch gesagt so muss ich
bekennen dass Sozialdemokraten
Sozialdemokraten die nur 160-jährigen
Geschichte Fest der Auffassung gewesen
sind das antizyklische Wirtschafts- und
Finanzpolitik aber gleichzeitig eben
auch eine faire Lastenteilung von
Einkommen und Vermögen in dieser
Gesellschaft zusammengehören und nicht
akzeptiere dass es unterschiedliche
Meinungen gibt aber ich will ihnen sagen
ich glaube die Beispiele aus der Welt
die Treffen eben zu dass genau die
Staaten die beides verknüpfen
antizyklische Wirtschafts- und
Finanzpolitik auf der einen Seite und
Gerechtigkeit in der Gesellschaft zu
schaffen zurzeit ein Standortvorteil
haben und genau diesen Weg wollen wir
gehen manche überrascht es ja liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das genau die
USA die beiden Regierung das tut wir
reden hier immer über den Inflation
reduction Act aber das darum geht es
überhaupt nicht nur da geht es auch um
soziale Gerechtigkeit einer
demokratischen Regierung in ihrem Land
wenn sie auf Gesundheitspolitik achten
wenn sie auf die ärmeren Menschen achten
und genau diese Verknüpfung glaube ich
ist gut anzubieten deswegen muss ich da
selbstbewusst für uns sagen aber ich
akzeptiere auch andere Meinung aber das
ist doch unsere Stärke in dieser
Regierung dass wir beides miteinander
verknüpfen können und genauso wollen wir
in den nächsten Wochen meine Damen und
Herren auch den Haushalt gestalten und
ich glaube es ist richtig dass wir ein
wachstumschancengesetz auf den Weg
bringen lassen wir Finanzminister
gemeinsam überlegen was die Hinweise ich
nenne es jetzt mal positiv Hinweise von
den Ländern möglicherweise auch noch aus
einem guten ein besseren Gesetzentwurf
machen wenn wir insbesondere über
Innovationsförderung reden die Frage der
Belastung der Kommunen da sollten wir
uns auch noch mal darauf hinbewegen aber
gleichzeitig eine aktive
Wirtschaftspolitik betreiben die den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern und
ihren Familien gut tun deswegen sage ich
sehr deutlich auch für meine Fraktion
das was in der letzten Zeit sich in
Deutschland festgesetzt hat und manchmal
darf ich so sagen ich finde es manchmal
eine deutsche mediale Krankheit dass wir
nur in extremen
diskutieren dass wir uns plötzlich so
so schlecht reden die Lichter die
Lichter und die Heizung im letzten Jahr
sind nicht ausgegangen Salzgitter
baut das erste Stahlwerk mit grünem
Stahl ThyssenKrupp kommt hinterher neue
Batterie Firmen werden in Deutschland
angesiedelt ich meine Damen und Herren
kann mich dem Eindruck nicht erwehren
diese gesamte Diskussion ob wissentlich
und willentlich oder einfach nur indem
man nicht genau hinschaut bereitet
wieder einer Debatte die ich aus
Deutschland kenne Vorschub nämlich den
Sozialstaat zum Sündenbock zu machen und
da sage ich ganz klar hier sagen
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
nein auch wir haben eine Schmerzgrenze
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen ich
glaube
ich glaube es ist gut
gemeinsam zusammen zu wirken für die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer für
die Familien für dieses Land und
deswegen sage ich sehr deutlich es lohnt
sich in den nächsten Wochen miteinander
über vieles noch zu reden vielen Dank
Rolf Mütze nicht der Fraktionschef der
SPD am Montag zum dritten Mal als
fraktionsschrift gewählt mit 94,7
Prozent der Stimmen hat hier gesagt
eine verlässlich unaufgeregte
parlamentarische Arbeit zugesagt beim
Gebäude Energiegesetz habe man gesehen
dass auf die Parlamentarier Verlass ist
man habe dieses Gesetz geändert jetzt am
Ende die das Bekenntnis zum sozialsta
von einem sozial und kann nicht unüblich
ist aber auch natürlich eine Ansage an
den Finanzminister der gesagt hat es
gibt keine sozialstaatsreform mehr jetzt
eine Anleitung von Peter Paul Beratung
zu Einzelplan 17
der Abgeordnete Bollmann hat zu Beginn
seiner Rede die entsprechend der
parlamentarischen geflogenheit
ordnungsgemäße Anrede der
Sitzungsleitung instrumentalisiert um
seine politische Auffassung gegen das
geplante selbstbestimmungsgesetz
darzulegen
durch dieses Verhalten hat er die mit
der Anrede bezweckte Respekt Begründung
vor der Sitzungsleitung hat absurdung
geführt ich Rüge diesen Teil seiner Rede
ausdrücklich als unparlamentarisch
dem geschmacklose Kommentierung seiner
Worte in Form eines zwischenrufs durch
seinen Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer
Brandner weil sie hiermit zugleich auf
der schärfste zurück
wir fahren nun fort in der Debatte zum
Einzelplan 04 Bundeskanzler und
Bundeskanzleramt das Wort hat die
Abgeordnete Gerit hui für die
afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen liebe Besucher als der
Finanzminister gestern den Haushalt 2024
den Parlament vorgelegt hat sagte er
dass wir wieder wachsen müssen um weiter
führend in der sozialen Absicherung zu
sein
von welchem Land spricht der Minister
tatsächlich befindet sich unsere soziale
Absicherung schon seit längerem in
Singflug das gilt besonders für die
Rente Arbeitsminister Heil brüstet sich
zwar damit dass er das deutsche
Rentenniveau mit einem neuen Gesetz
festschreiben will nämlich bei 48
Prozent der EU-Durchschnitt für das
Rentenniveau liegt aber um 40% höher
die Dramatik zeigt sich im Vergleich mit
Österreich ein Rentner bekommt dort nach
45 Arbeitsjahren durchschnittlich 2600
Euro das sind fast 1100 € mehr als ein
vergleichbarer deutscher Rentner bekommt
auch Belgier denen finden in Isländer
Franzosen Italiener und so weiter
bekommen deutlich mehr Rente aus Konto
bei gleicher Arbeitsleistung dort kann
man noch vernünftig von der Rente leben
nicht so in Deutschland wo mehr als 40
Prozent der Rentner nur ihre kleine
Rente als Alterseinkommen haben
wo bleibt da der Respekt meine Damen und
Herren von der Regierungsbank der
Respekt für die eigenen Bürger die
unseren Wohlstand erarbeitet haben den
sie gerade zerstören
auch der Respekt vielleicht für die
Bürger oder die Rentner mit Fremden Pass
auch deren Renten sind verdammt niedrig
sie liegen weit unter der Grundsicherung
und müssen mit Steuergeld aufgefüllt
werden also die Annahme dass die
Einwanderer mal unsere rentenzahlen die
es schlicht verwegen sie verdienen ja
nicht mal ihre eigenen
ich gebe ihnen aber einen Tipp wie sie
die Renten zumindest ein wenig
aufbessern können nämlich indem sie
endlich die
versicherungsfremdenleistungen komplett
aus der Steuerkasse zahlen
wenn Sie das Umsetzen hat jeder Rentner
im Jahr fast 1800 Euro mehr das wäre
doch endlich mal vernünftiger
Inflationsausgleich
können sich ein bisschen beliebt machen
hätten sie dringend nötig
und noch ein kleiner Hinweis die Rente
ist bis auf die eben genannten
versicherungsfremden Leistung keine
Sozialleistung von Staates Gnaden sie
ist eine Versicherungsleistung für die
die Bürger hart gearbeitet haben
sie hat sich im übrigen auch gut
verzinst mit drei Prozent in den letzten
Jahren deutlich besser als in der
privaten Rentenversicherung weshalb auch
viele Beamte freiwillig in die
Rentenversicherung einzahlen trotz ihrer
eigenen hohen pensionserwartung es ist
also ein gutes System es wird noch
schlecht gefüllt
eine
Bereich ist Deutschland tatsächlich
führen nämlich in der Absicherung von
billig die meisten von ihnen landen sehr
schnell im Bürgergeld dass sie
spätestens seit dem Ukraine Krieg zu
einem echten
einwanderungsmagneten entwickelt hat
es wurde erst letzten Januar um 12%
erhöht und im nächsten Jahr wird es
wieder um 12 Prozent erhöht die meisten
Bürgergeld Empfänger Arbeiten nicht
viele von ihnen haben tatsächlich noch
nie gearbeitet und trotzdem werden ihre
Einkommen innerhalb von 13 Monaten um
25% erhöht da ist es doch kein Wunder
dass es zwar immer noch mehrere
Arbeitslose auf eine leere Stelle gibt
noch eine freie Stelle dass sie aber
trotzdem nicht besetzt werden kann nicht
mal einfacher Helfer Jobs also auch hier
rate ich Ihnen dringend mal den Fehler
zu suchen
wir haben ihn gesucht und mit der
aktivierenden Grundsicherung beantwortet
die klarstellt dass arbeitsfähige einen
Job auch annehmen müssen und das
einwandererleistung nur noch über eine
Debitkarte beziehen können was das
Bürgergeld weniger attraktiv macht es
gibt keine Auslandsüberweisung mehr das
ist aus unserer Sicht auch dringend
notwendig damit unsere Sozialsysteme
sicher leiden
die Rente ist übrigens den gleichen
Zeitraum in dem das Bürgergeld um 25%
erhöht worden ist gerade mal um den
halben Prozentsatz erhöht worden und
auch das zeugt nicht gerade von Respekt
für unsere Rentner wir aber haben uns
die Mühe gemacht und den Fehler in ihrer
Rentenpolitik gesucht und wir haben ihn
auch gefunden deswegen können Sie sicher
sein dass wir auch in der Rentenpolitik
eine echte Alternative bieten werden
[Applaus]
das Wort hat die Staatsministerin beim
Bundeskanzler Claudia Roth
die kulturstaatsministerin Claudia rot
hat jetzt das Wort denn in diesem Metall
wird traditionell auch die Kultur mit
Bedacht
Kreativität Fortschritt Freiheit
Offenheit Menschlichkeit all das ist
Kultur ist die Grundlage unseres
Zusammenlebens als ich an dieser Stelle
meine erste Haushaltsrede als
Staatsministerin für Kultur und Medien
hielt war der Krieg gegen die Ukraine
einen Monat alt in der Zwischenzeit sind
560 Tage und Nächte brutalen Tötens und
systematischen Zerstörens vergangen
eineinhalb Jahre Krieg gegen die Ukraine
Krieg gegen eine offene und
demokratische Gesellschaft Krieg gegen
ihre Kultur aber wir sind nicht machtlos
wir sind nicht schwach unsere Stärke hat
Namen Freiheit und Solidarität
es ist das Privileg Privileg von
DemokratInnen anderen im Kampf um
Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung zur Seite
zu stehen und genau das tun wir
als
kulturstaatsministerin kämpfe ich für
die Kultur und ebenso für die Kultur der
Demokratie heute mehr denn je denn es
geht um die Freiheit der Kunst um die
Freiheit der Kreativität eine offene
Gesellschaft lebt von Kreativität lebt
von widerstreitenden Ideen und dafür
brauchen wir die Vielfalt der ganzen
Gesellschaft brauchen wir Diversität
brauchen wir Respekt und Wertschätzung
füreinander eine solche Kulturpolitik
wird auch Widerspruch aushalten können
und aushalten müssen
unbedingt dazu gehört Teilhabe teil zu
haben an kulturellen an
gesellschaftlichen an politischen
Entwicklungen und Entscheidungen das ist
die demokratische Kulturpolitik für wie
wir stehen
Teilhabe das bedeutet Barrieren
niederreisen und rein ins Leben und das
wollen wir gerade für die junge
Generation wer ins eigenständige Leben
startet will sich umtun will
ausprobieren will kennenlernen und das
will der Kulturpass allen ermöglichen
die in diesem Jahr 18 Jahre alt werden
und er ist jetzt schon ein Erfolg es
haben sich viele viele viele
tausende Nutzer und NutzerInnen
registriert und diesen Erfolg wollen wir
gemeinsam fortsetzen und dafür werbe ich
bei ihnen ja
die Rahmenbedingungen sie sind schwierig
gerade auch für die Kultur doch wir
haben als Bundesregierung unter widrigen
Bedingungen viel erreicht für die Kultur
auch dafür geht mein Dank an den
Finanzminister wir haben gelernt und
gehandelt eine Lehre aus der corona-zeit
war das hervorragende
zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement gerade
der freien Kulturszene zu stützen und
deswegen haben wir die Förderung der
bundeskulturfonds auf fast 35 Millionen
Euro heraufgesetzt
wir sorgen für Kontinuität und
Stabilität bei unseren Einrichtungen
denn gerade in Zeiten der Unsicherheit
sind öffentliche Kulturinstitutionen
Orte der Begegnung Orte der
Vergewisserung Orte des Austauschs und
der Vielfalt geschützte Räume sie sollen
Leuchttürme sein die den Weg in eine
gute Gesellschaft weisen neben vielen
anderen Einrichtungen wird die Stiftung
Preußischer Kulturbesitz mit zusätzlich
vier Millionen Euro für den
betriebshaushalt in ihrem wichtigen und
notwendigen Reformprozess begleitet und
gefährdet wir stärken die Deutsche Welle
in ihrem Kampf gegen Desinformationen
und Propaganda mit zusätzlichen 10
Millionen Euro und wir stellen sicher
dass die Kulturstiftung des Bundes der
wichtige kreative Anker in
unserem Land bleibt liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
Kultur ist auch Erinnerung ohne sie ohne
Erinnerung gibt es keine Kultur sagt uns
Elli Wiesel keine Zivilisation keine
Gesellschaft und keine Zukunft und
deswegen bauen wir die Förderung der
unverzichtbaren Arbeit der Gedenkstätten
aus wie
unverzichtbar das ist wird gerade in
diesen Tagen deutlich es geht darum
Verantwortung zu erkennen Verantwortung
anzunehmen es geht nicht um ab bitte und
Absolution
nur
wer auch in die Abgründe der eigenen
Geschichte blickt wird die
Herausforderungen der Gegenwart erkennen
und das sage ich mit Blick auf die
aktuelle Debatte um die Reform der
beratenden Kommission der sogenannten
limbach-kommission hier wollen wir
deutlich weitergehen als die vorränge
Vorgänger Regierungen das getan haben
denn es geht um faire und gerechte
Lösungen vor dem Hintergrund des
menschheitsverbrechens der shower zur
Erinnerungskultur für die wir uns
unvermindert intensiv einsetzen und das
ist ein echtes Herzensanliegen von mir
gehört selbstverständlich auch die
Auseinandersetzung mit dem SED Unrecht
und wir widmen uns verstärkt unsere
kolonialen Vergangenheit und den blinden
Flecken in unserem kollektiven gedenken
daran
aber
erinnern müssen und wollen wir auch an
die rassistischen Mordtaten der jüngeren
Vergangenheit und Gegenwart vom
Brandanschlag auf ein jüdisches
Altenheim in München 1972 über
Hoyerswerda über Rostock Lichtenhagen
Mölln Solingen den NSU die Anschläge von
Halle und Hanau und den Mord am Kasseler
Regierungspräsidenten Walter Lübcke
zieht sich die Spur des rechtsextremen
rassistischen Terrors durch Deutschland
wir könnten nicht von Erinnerungskultur
sprechen würden wir diese Taten würden
wir diese
Opfer verschweigen das ist moderne
Erinnerungskultur in einer
Einwanderungsgesellschaft aus der eine
bessere gemeinsame Zukunft wachsen kann
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine der
größten Herausforderungen vor der wir
weltweit stehen ist die Klimakrise wir
sehen Sie in den letzten Stunden die
dramatischen Ereignisse in Griechenland
die Klimakrise sie wird mehr und mehr zu
Überlebensfrage dieses Jahrhunderts es
geht uns daher auch darum auch in der
Kulturpolitik die Rahmenbedingungen für
eine Kultur der Nachhaltigkeit für eine
Ästhetik der Nachhaltigkeit zu schaffen
denn die Klimakrise sie geht uns alle an
und ich bin sehr froh und es ist sehr
gut dass die Anlaufstelle green culture
jetzt ihre Arbeit aufnimmt
in einer Zeit in einer Zeit die geprägt
ist von Krisen von Konflikten von Krieg
braucht es Kunst und Kultur mehr denn je
Kunst und Kultur sind kein Luxus den man
sich nur in guten Zeiten leisten kann
sie sind die Stimme sie sind der Sound
unserer Demokratie und deswegen bitte
ich Sie um Unterstützung für unseren
Haushaltsentwurf vielen Dank
das Wort hat der Kollege Thomas Hacker
für die FDP-Fraktion
und Thomas Hacker ist der
medienpolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen manchmal hat
mir den Eindruck wir leben in einer
Gesellschaft die auseinander zu fallen
droht in der einzelne glauben nur laut
genug schreien zu müssen um Recht zu
bekommen eine Gesellschaft in der uns
Ausgrenzung die Vermehrung
Fremdenfeindlichkeit und Antisemitismus
leider täglich begegnen eine
demokratische Gesellschaft die immer
intensiver um ihre Zukunft trinkt und
auch eigentlich nur ihren inneren
Zusammenhalt sucht das Zaubermittel
dafür dass saubermittel diesen
Zusammenhalt zu stärken finden wir
überall dort wo Menschen zusammenkommen
miteinander neue Lebenswirklichkeiten
entdecken dort wo sie sich kreativ
entfalten können und wir als
Gesellschaft im Ganzen zum Nachdenken
und miterleben eingeladen werden es ist
die Kultur die uns Menschen
zusammenbringt zurecht können und wollen
wir nie auf sie verzichten
daher
daher ist es unsere politische
Verantwortung die notwendigen Mittel
bereitzustellen um das Fundament unserer
Gesellschaft zu stützen und zu festigen
gerade in Zeiten großer Polarisierung
die andere Koalition ist aus tiefer
Überzeugung mit ihrem ehrlichen
Bekenntnis zu Kulturen Medien angetreten
wir wollen Kultur für alle und mit allen
ermöglichen klar ist aber auch
gesellschaftlicher Aufbruch und neue
debattenräume erschaffen sich nicht aus
gutem Willen allein sie brauchen eine
richtige auch eine finanzielle Basis
wir Freien Demokraten liegen auf eine
zielgerichtete Förderung die nachhaltige
Stärkung von kulturelle und medialer
Vielfalt voranbringt zu recht weiß es
sogar der Deutsche Kulturrat daraufhin
eins fehlt dem Kulturbereich immer Geld
es gibt stets mehr künstlerische Ideen
und Vorhaben als Mittel um diese
realisieren zu können
nach einer Zeit vieler krisenbedingter
Sonderprogramme die fast alle sicher
auch ihre Berechtigung hatten müssen wir
aber in den haushaltspolitischen
Normalzustand zurückkehren es ist
richtig der Staat muss mit dem Geld
auskommen das zur Verfügung steht
gleiches gilt für uns Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Stabilität ist nie eine
Selbstverständlichkeit und doch schafft
der vorgelegte Haushalt für Kulturen
Medien in einer volkswirtschaftlich
äußerst anspruchsvollen Zeit ein
mittelaufwuchs gegenüber der bisherigen
Finanzplanung ein gutes Signal und dafür
bin ich Finanzminister Christian Lindner
und kulturstaatsministerin Claudia Roth
sehr dankbar
die kulturpolitischen schwerpunkte sind
dabei wohl überlegt die
Kreativwirtschaft ist nicht nur hier zu
Lande zu einem riesigen zu einem
bedeutenden Wirtschaftsfaktor
herangewachsen und wird doch noch oft
unterschätzt wir werden Startups und
Künstlerinnen und Künstler dabei
unterstützen innovative Ideen zu
entwickeln und erfolgreich umzusetzen
neu gezielte Förderprogramme erleichtern
den Zugang zu Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten
made in Germany als internationaler
Maßstab für höchste Qualität wird nicht
nur für Maschinen
Präzisionsinstrumente oder Autos sondern
gerade für die Ideen und Produkte aus
dem Games Laboren Ateliers und Kurve
King spaces dieser Republik
unser kulturelles Erbe ist da ein
kostbares Gut das bewahrt werden muss
der halt von Denkmälern Gedenkstätten
Museen und Archiven ist lebenswichtig um
zukünftigen Generationen einen
unverbauten Zugang zu unserer Geschichte
und Kultur zu gewährleisten und doch
gilt es unserem kulturellen Erbe aller
künstlerischen Sparten auch eine
digitale Zukunft zu ermöglichen
digitales kuratieren digitale Produktion
digitale Vermittlung und Kommunikation
sind nicht nebenbei zu erreichen sie
gehören ins Zentrum unsere Anstrengungen
nur dann machen wir unsere Kultur
zukunftsfit
[Applaus]
Kultur-
die widerliche bayerische
hetzsplatzaffäre und der noch viel
beschämendere Umgang mit der Politik der
politischen Verantwortungsträger zeigt
wie unerlässlich die
erinnerungspolitische Arbeit in unserem
Land bleibt es gibt in unserem Land
immer noch Menschen die mit Anfang 50
die Tragweite unserer historischen
Verantwortung nicht greifen können oder
wollen umso wichtiger
umso wichtiger ist dass auch dieser
Bundeshaushalt unsere
erinnerungspolitische Verantwortung
gerecht wird und ihre Institutionen
weiter stärkt es bleibt dabei nie wieder
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
sich einen letzten Punkt hier in dieser
Debatte ansprechen zunächst freue ich
mich dass er im Entwurf diesen Haushalts
die Filmförderung stabil bleibt es ist
absolut zu begrüßen dass der
Bundeskanzler die Zukunft der
Filmproduktion in Deutschland
für kommende Jahr weitreichende
Entscheidungen verspricht und auch auf
die Realitäten im europäischen
Nachbarländern hinweist eine wirksame
und erfolgreiche Filmförderung werden
wir erst mit einer Förderung erreichen
die auch Steueranreizen passiert die vor
der Sommerpause vorgestellten Eckpunkte
unterstützen wir sie sollten wir
schnellstmöglich umsetzen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Herausforderungen die in unser Land
entgegenzieht erfordern
haushaltspolitische Vernunft genauso wie
starke kulturpolitische Schwerpunkte
eins aber erfordern sie vor allem die
Rückbesinnung auf die Vorteile auf die
Kraft einer Gesellschaft die
zusammenhält die Vertrauen in sich
selbst hat und die mit Mut und
optimistische Optimismus in die Zukunft
geht
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Thorsten frei
für die cdu/csu-fraktion ja nach diesem
kleinen Kulturblock der etwas früher
heute gekommen ist als sonst üblich
jetzt quasi wieder zurück mit Thorsten
frei in das globale
generaldebatterie im Deutschen Bundestag
dazu gehört aber auch zum tageskanzlers
die Kultur ist geschafft
der in diesen Tagen gefragt hat ob
Deutschland abermals der kranke Mann
Europas ist und interessant ist es ja
vor allen Dingen deshalb weil der
Economist auch eine Analyse der großen
ökonomischen Herausforderungen unseres
Landes macht und ich will mal drei
Punkte herausgreifen die aus meiner
Sicht hier zentral sind erstens wir
müssen feststellen dass Deutschland in
der Rezession steckt das ist ein
toxischer Cocktail an unterschiedlichen
Faktoren die am Ende den industriellen
Kern unseres Landes schmelzen lassen das
müssen wir erkennen wenn wir die nackten
Fakten uns anschauen und sehen wie
Kapital flieht wie Arbeitslosigkeit
steigt und wie industrielle Produktion
in unserem Land zurückgeht
und ich will nicht den Teufel an die
Wand malen aber es hat mich schon
irritiert dass heute Morgen während der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
beispielsweise das Institut für
Weltwirtschaft in Kiel die
Wachstumsprognose für das laufende Jahr
von 0,3 auf Minus von -0,3 auf -0,5
reduziert hat und das dokumentiert
einfach dass wir gewaltige
Herausforderungen haben die wir lösen
müssen und die sind nicht in der
weltweiten Wirtschaft zu suchen die
stabil wächst sondern die sind
insbesondere in den Verhältnissen hier
bei uns zu suchen in Deutschland und
dafür brauchen wir Lösungsansätze ich
will einen zweiten Punkt ansprechen
bevor ich zu den Lösungsansätzen kommt
das ist die Migration wir müssen der
Tatsache ins Auge sehen dass wir in
einer weiteren migrationskrise stecken
im vergangenen Jahr hat Deutschland mehr
Schutzsuchende Menschen aufgenommen als
sie den Krisenjahren 2015 und 16
zusammen
und auf der anderen Seite ist es so dass
bereits im ersten Halbjahr diesen Jahres
die migrationszahlen die Asylbewerber
zahlen um 78% gestiegen sind und wir
mutmaßlich in diesem Jahr etwa 350.000
Asylanträge haben werden ich sag das vor
dem Hintergrund als das eine gewaltige
Herausforderung ist die ja insbesondere
Gesellschaft und Städte und Gemeinden zu
schultern haben es ist eine gewaltige
Herausforderung weil sie nichts
unternehmen um Migration zu ordnen zu
steuern und zu begrenzen sondern auf der
Gegenseite alles tun damit der
umgekehrte Effekt eintritt und was ich
ganz besonders perfide finde wenn ich
den wenn ich in den Haushaltsplan schaue
ist dass sie im Grunde genommen nichts
tun um diejenigen zu unterstützen die
die Konsequenzen und Folgen ihrer
Politik auszubieten haben ich fand es
schon bemerkenswert dass sie im
Bundeshaushalt die Mittel für die
Migrationsberatung um nahezu ein Drittel
kürzen wollen für das kommende Jahr und
das dokumentiert einfach dass ihr
wünschen und machen nicht zueinander
passt und das sollten sie im Laufe der
Haushaltsberatungen schauen dass sie da
etwas mehr Konsistenz in ihre
Überlegungen bringen und der dritte
Punkt den ich möchte das ist die
Inflation darauf sind Vorredner bereits
eingegangen es ist keine nackte Zahl
wenn unsere Währung in den letzten drei
Jahren 16,5% weniger wert geworden ist
und Alexander Dobrindt hat insbesondere
darauf hingewiesen dass im Bereich der
Lebensmittel die Inflation doppelt so
hoch ist und deshalb insbesondere
Familien mit kleineren und mittleren
Einkommen ganz besonders gekniffen sind
Politik und erfolgreiche Politik muss
sich danach ausrichten diese Inflation
zu bekämpfen weil sie ist genau das was
Norbert Blüm einmal formuliert hat sie
ist der Taschen gibt es kleinen Mannes
und deshalb müssen wir alles dafür tun
dagegen zu kämpfen
und es ist nicht nur so dass keine
Besserung in Sicht ist im Gegenteil der
Bundesgesundheitsminister kündigt ja
bereits an dass die
Krankenkassenbeiträge steigen sollen das
führte zu dass die sozialabgabenquote
erstmals wieder über 40 Prozent steigt
und damit den traurigen Rekord von vor
20 Jahren einstellt meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das sind genau die
Punkte um die wir uns kümmern müssen das
ist das was die Menschen in unserem Land
beschäftigt Rezession Inflation
Migration das sind die Themen und nicht
die Themen die die sie zum Mittelpunkt
ihrer Politik machen der Bundeskanzler
hat vorher in seiner Rede darauf
hingewiesen dass wir uns um die
richtigen Themen kümmern müssen aber
genau das passiert doch überhaupt nicht
wenn wir uns mit der Frage beschäftigen
warum die Weltwirtschaft wächst und
Deutschland das einzige Industrieland
ist das schrumpft dann müssen wir uns
doch mit den Ursachen auseinandersetzen
und dazu gehören die weltweit höchsten
Energie und Strompreise und lieber Herr
dürsi haben das hier in den Raum
gestellt dass sie sagen lasst uns doch
die Stromsteuer auf das europarechtliche
Minimum senken das wäre ein 40 dessen
was derzeit an Stromsteuer verlangt wird
mir reichen Ihnen gerne die Hand lassen
Sie uns das machen das wäre eine
Möglichkeit sehr schnell zu reagieren
das gleiche gilt für eine Reduktion der
Netzentgelte das wäre etwas was man
sofort zum ersten Oktober umsetzen
könnte und ich will Ihnen ein zweites
vorschlagen auch darauf sind sie im
Grunde genommen eingegangen natürlich
ist es ein Irrsinn dass man mit
verschiedenen Instrumenten die
Strompreise
heruntersubventionieren will die man
zuvor durch politische Entscheidungen in
die Höhe getrieben hat und deswegen sie
reden von der Verbreitung des Angebots
in diesem Bereich aber sie tun nichts
dafür gar nichts weder beim Bau der
Gaskraftwerke noch bei den
Speicherkapazitäten und erst fassen Sie
das Eisen Kernenergie nicht an es war
ein gravierender Fehler die drei noch am
Netz befindlichen Kernkraftwerke Mitte
April abzustellen das hat mindestens so
hat es die Wirtschaftsweise Frau Grimm
ausgerechnet mindestens zu einer
Steigerung der Preise von 12,1% geführt
das sind doch die Tatsachen mit denen
wir uns beschäftigen müssen und dafür
haben sie keine Angebote ich habe mich
schon sehr gewundert das ausgerechnet
die Frau Tröge beim Thema
Bürokratieabbau und Beschleunigung von
genehmigungs- und Planungsverfahren so
kesse Aussagen gemacht hat
Abbau was ich total interessant fand
haben jetzt
eckpunktet für die Kindergrundsicherung
was immer da auch drin steckt wir wissen
es nicht weil es kann ja nicht das
Gleiche sein je nachdem ob man 12
Milliarden dafür ausgeht oder ob man 2,4
Milliarden ausgibt sie haben Eckpunkte
gemacht vieles wissen sie noch nicht
darüber aber eines wissen Sie dass man
500 Millionen Euro erfüllungsaufwand
dazu hat 500 Millionen Euro zusätzliche
Personalkosten sind es tatsächlich sie
müssen 2000 zusätzliche Stellen schaffen
um diese Kindergrundsicherung umzusetzen
sie haben davon gesprochen dass sie
digitalisieren und vereinfachen wollen
das Gegenteil ist der Fall anstatt den
Jobcentern sind zukünftig die Jobcenter
und familienservicestellen zuständig und
keiner weiß wie man dieses Kuttel am
Ende organisieren will das ist
Bürokratie sie reduzieren nicht
Bürokratie sondern sie schaffen
zusätzliche Bürokratie
und im Bereich der Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren
ja es ist richtig wir haben positive
Beispiele wenn wir schauen in welch
kurzer Zeit lng-terminals in Deutschland
geplant genehmigt und gebaut werden
konnten dann macht es Mut für die
Zukunft aber sie haben doch in der
Koalition darüber gestritten was das
denn jetzt eigentlich bedeutet im
Bereich der Energieinfrastruktur aber
eben auch im Bereich der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur wir sind in
Deutschland überall zu langsam überall
zu träge wir müssen besser und schneller
werden hierfür und deswegen geht es
darum dass wir Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen wenn
sie da gute Vorschläge haben wir haben
auch welche wir können das auch zusammen
machen wir können Deutschland schneller
machen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren aber am Ende des Tages bleibt es
dabei dass wir uns um die richtigen
Themen kümmern müssen und das bedeutet
eben auch dass wir aus der Gesellschaft
heraus wachsen müssen sie schaffen es
eben nicht
hast als in ihren Reden vorgetragen zu
trennen zwischen einer
fachkräftezuwanderung die wir brauchen
zur Stärkung unseres Landes und der
Bekämpfung der illegalen Migration auf
der anderen Seite das was sie in den
vergangenen Monaten gemacht haben war
exakt das Gegenteil und die Folgen
dieser Politik können Sie in Deutschland
beobachten und alles was Sie für die
Zukunft planen verspricht keine
Besserung ganz im Gegenteil wenn sich
europäische Länder auf Fortschritte in
diesem Bereich verständigen können ist
es die Bundesregierung die im
bremsehäuschen sitzt und europäische
Verständigung an dieser Stelle
verhindert genau so ist es und das sind
die Themen die wir brauchen um unser
Land wieder stark zu machen und dafür zu
sorgen dass wir in einem guten Haushalt
auch die Voraussetzungen und
Rahmenbedingungen für gutes Leben in
Deutschland setzen können das was sie
vorgelegt haben ist dazu kein Schritt in
die richtige Richtung vielen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun Achim Post
das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
man merkt an dieser Debatte auch an der
gestrigen Debatte dass es in diesen
Tagen und Wochen um was geht und das ist
gut das ist um was geht und es ist auch
gut dass ich das in großen Teilen in
diesen Haushaltsdebatten und in diesen
haushaltsbeiträgen widerspiegelt nicht
in allen aber in den meisten worum geht
es es geht auch um die richtigen Themen
um die wichtigen Themen wir können
darüber streiten was das ist ich sage
Ihnen mal was ich für wichtig halt es
geht um unsere Städte und Gemeinden es
geht um unseren Wirtschaftsstandort es
geht um unseren Sozialstaat und ja es
geht auch um unsere Demokratie
und in diesen Zeiten von Putins
Angriffskrieg einer sich zuspitzenden
Klimakrise sich überlappender Krisen ist
es gut wenn man einen Bundeskanzler hat
der nachdenkt und handelt nicht eins
davon weglässt ist es gut wenn man einen
Bundeskanzler hat
der der Garant für die Unterstützung der
Ukraine ist und der daran dafür ist dass
man alle Gesprächsmöglichkeiten und alle
Möglichkeiten des Einflusses nutzt um
den Krieg zu beenden liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und deshalb ist es gut dass der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz heißt
und dann kommen wir mal zu den dann
kommen wir mal zu den Punkten ich glaube
Herr frei und auch Herr Merz sie haben
angesprochen wir müssen was für die
Städte und Gemeinden tun da sind wir uns
völlig einig
ich
schlage Ihnen was vor Herr märz vor
allen Dingen denn wir haben einen klaren
Vorschlag nicht nur der Sozialdemokratie
in diesem Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel
wie man gerade den Städten und Gemeinden
die viele Altschulden haben helfen kann
durch einen Altschulden vor das steht
die Ampel wie eine Eins wir brauchen
aber eine zwei Drittel mehr wir brauchen
eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit dafür das
heißt ich lach immer was ganz
außergewöhnliches vor aber ich sage
immer was ganz außergewöhnliches vor
mein Heimatland Nordrhein-Westfalen
würde davon stark profitieren machen Sie
mal was
außergewöhnliches was gemeinsames mit
Herrn wüst
und stimmen Sie im Bundesrat und
Bundestag für einen Schulden vor
und ich will mal ein Thema ansprechen
das ja Herr frei ansprechen muss dann
nämlich Wirtschaftspolitik das bei Ihnen
ja nicht vorgekommen ja März ja es geht
in einer wirklich schwierigen Lage
um folgende große Aufgaben um die
Transformation unserer Volkswirtschaft
und es geht darum dass wir industrielle
Fertigung hier bei uns in Deutschland
behalten und dafür muss man was tun das
kommt nicht von alleine liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und diese
Bundesregierung mit Olaf Scholz mit
Robert Habeck und mit Christian Linda
die tut was mit einer aktiven Industrie
Energie und Wirtschaftspolitik glauben
sie allen Ernstes das was geschildert
wurde was vom Bundeskanzler geschildert
wurde was ist an neuen
Industrieansiedlungen gibt in Magdeburg
in Brandenburg was es gibt im Bereich
der Stahlindustrie bei Salzgitter und
bei mir in Nordrhein-Westfalen bei
ThyssenKrupp dass das von alleine kommt
das kommt deshalb weil wir eine aktive
Bundesregierung haben und im übrigen
auch aktive Landesregierung die das auch
wollen die Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland
erhalten wollen und wenn sie dazu
bessere Vorschläge haben dann können Sie
sich wieder melden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der CDU
und ich will mal eins sagen glauben sie
allen Ernstes dass die Konzerne sich
jetzt neu in Deutschland ansiedeln Tesla
als Beispiel Intel der größte
Halbleiterhersteller der Welt hier ist
MC aus Taiwan dass die das machen weil
sie denken sie investieren in einem
Standort und an einem Standort wo es
sich nicht lohnt meinen sie die
investieren hier weil sie glauben das
ist der kranke Mann Europas das ist doch
alles Unfug investieren hier weil sie an
die Potenziale Deutschlands glauben und
weil sie an den Standort Deutschland
glauben weil sie ihr Geld verdienen
wollen das ist es doch und Sie werden
mir Geld verdienen und sie werden
beschäftigen
und was auch dazu gehört liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das kann alles
nur dann funktionieren das kann alles
nur dann funktionieren wenn es einen
handlungsfähigen und starken Sozialstaat
gibt und kein geringerer als Helmut
Schmidt nun wahrlich bekannt nicht
bekannt dafür Sozialromantiker zu sein
hat ein Zitat gesagt die größte
Errungenschaft der Europäer in so
fürchterlichen 20 Jahrhundert ist der
Sozialstaat und wir als Ampel wir als
Sozialdemokratie wie als
sozialdemokratische Fraktion zusammen
mit unserem Partnerinnen tun alles um
diesen Sozialstaat weiter zu stärken
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mit
Bürgergeld Wohngeld Kindergeld das sind
alles keine Kleinigkeiten und im übrigen
auch sie haben doch vorhin darüber
geredet auch am gestrigen Tage auch mit
der Kindergrundsicherung seien Sie
sicher die Kinder Grundsicherung kommt
und zwar nicht als Wohltat das ist keine
Wohltat das ist eine angemessene
Leistung eine notwendige Leistung für
Millionen von Kindern in diesem Land die
es bisher nicht so gut gegangen ist
und wir werden alles dafür tun die sind
Sozialstaat weiter auszubauen denn das
ist dringend notwendig im Bereich
Gesundheit Pflege Krankenhäuser da
möchte ich sehen wer von ihnen dagegen
ist und wenn es einen Angebote des
Bundeskanzlers gibt für einen
deutschlandpackt dann gilt dieses
Angebot für unsere Städte und Gemeinden
für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
und auch für den Sozialstaat Deutschland
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ganz zum und ganz zum Schluss wir
müssen und da sind wir uns
wahrscheinlich alle einig alles tun 75
Jahre nach dem ersten Treffen am Herren
Chiemsee wo unser Grundgesetz ein gutes
Grundgesetz eines der besten Verfassung
der Welt erarbeitet wurde von den
Müttern und Vätern des Grundgesetzes
alles tun dass wir weiter in einem
freien liberalen Rechtsstaat leben und
die Toleranz der Respekt für alle
Menschen geht und nicht für einige
wenige schönen Dank
Achim Post war das für die SPD-Fraktion
und ihm folgt jetzt hier als nächster
Mark Yong für die
afd-fraktion er ist der Kultur und
hochschulpolitische Sprecher der AFD
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wer als abbruchkommando Deutschlands
Auftritt ich übernehme ihren Begriff
sehr gern herr Scholz denn er passt
perfekt auf diese Bundesregierung der
muss offenbar einen hohen Aufwand an
Propaganda betreiben auf sogenannten
green culture Konferenzen schwört
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia Roth die
Kulturbranche auf Klimaschutz und
Nachhaltigkeit ein und zwar nicht nur
was den Energieverbrauch und ähnliches
betrifft sondern wir haben es gehört es
wird auch zur ästhetischen
Auseinandersetzung mit der Klimakrise
zur Sensibilisierung des Publikums in
Bezug auf den Menschen gemacht und
Klimawandel aufgerufen Gender und
diversity Vorgaben in der Filmförderung
sind auch bereits angekündigt es ist
erschreckend mit welcher Unverfrorenheit
Kunst und Kultur von dieser Regierung
instrumentalisiert werden das hat mit
Kunstfreiheit nichts zu tun warum das
ist verordnete Staatskunst
aber die Erfolglosigkeit der wirken
netflix-serien oder der politisch
korrekten deutschen Filme zeigen sehr
deutlich was das Publikum von solcher
erziehungs-
ganz wichtiges Thema für diese
Bundesregierung sexuelle Belästigung und
Gewalt nein nicht auf Deutschlands
Straßen am Abend sondern in der Kultur
und Medienbranche der Kulturrat soll
jetzt einen Verhaltenskodex ausarbeiten
zunächst zur freiwilligen
Selbstverpflichtung aber Frau Roth rote
bereits sollte das keine durchgreifende
Wirkung zeigen werden wir den nächsten
Schritt gehen und das für alle unsere
Förderungen verbindlich machen Zitat
Ende sprich wer vor dem staatsfeminismus
nicht brav Männchen macht erhält keine
Fördergelder mehr meine Damen und Herren
man muss kein Fan von Till Lindemann
sein aber die Affäre Rammstein hat doch
gezeigt dass Denunziantentum und
Empörungsindustrie längst frei drehen in
diesem Land nach dem Motto erstmal mit
Dreck werfen irgendwas wird schon hängen
bleiben und diese Unkultur fördern sie
systematisch auch mit dem Hinweisgeber
Schutzgesetz oder welcher Titel wonach
jetzt jeder Bürger ungestraft
angeschwärzt werden kann bei eigenes
geschaffenen Meldestellen das ist der
Weg in einen totalitären Staat meine
Damen und Herren
und die
anti-rassismusbeauftragte Frau Alaba Ali
Radovan will ja dann natürlich nicht
zurückstehen und fordert mehr
Beschwerdestellen für die Opfer von
Rassismus wo dann fröhlich denunziert
werden kann wer zum Beispiel die
falschen Ansichten zur Massenmigration
äußert und sich damit als struktureller
Rassist erwiesen hat was sagen sie denn
eigentlich zu dem Museum Zeche Zollern
in Dortmund Frau alabali wo weiße am
Samstag die Kolonialismus Ausstellung
nicht betreten dürfen offenbar um ihre
an ihre historische Schuld aufgrund
ihres weisst Seins erinnert zu werden
das ist der Rassismus der uns heute
beunruhigen muss in Deutschland und der
geht nicht von der Mehrheitsgesellschaft
aus sondern von einer aggressiven
Ideologie der längst auch diese
Bundesregierung verfallen ist was sehen
wir sonst noch in diesem Kulturhaushalt
aufwuchs für die Stiftung Preußischer
Kulturbesitz ja das ist gut aber
Verdreifachung der Mittel auf rund 6
Millionen Euro für die tiefroten
soziokulturellen Zentren deren
Verbandschef die Idee einer deutschen
Kultur schonmals als nationalistisch
verunglimpft und null Euro für das
Denkmal für die Opfer der
kommunistischen Gewaltherrschaft sie
schieben den Bau erneut auf die lange
bankfrarot das sollten Sie hier auch
ehrlich zu scheunlichen Antisemitismus
verbreitet hat und sei es mit 17 Jahren
gewesen ist es völlig inakzeptabel sich
als 52-jähriger verantwortlicher
Politiker selbst zum Opfer zu
stilisieren
wer das tut und versucht genau diese
Rolle dann auch noch für sich zu
vermarkten hat die Dimension dessen um
was es gerade geht nicht erfasst und wer
so agiert stellt in vollem Bewusstsein
und gezielt den eigenen Populismus über
die Grundfesten der Erinnerungskultur
und über die Grundfesten unserer
Demokratie und das dürfen wir niemals
akzeptieren
ich teile an dieser Stelle die Analyse
des früheren CSU-Chefs Erwin Huber
Aiwanger ist nicht Trump hat Herr Huber
gesagt und nicht teile das aber die
Methoden ähneln sich verblüffend man
nimmt erst gar nicht zur Kenntnis dass
ein Problem vorliegt man leugnet
schlicht und ergreifend alles was
passiert ist man droht man macht sich
selber zum Opfer das sind die Methoden
all das erinnert eins zu eins an die
Methode Trump und ich stimme Erwin Huber
auch darin zu dass er sagt diese Art von
Politik darf in Deutschland niemals
Schule machen das was wir in Bayern
gerade beobachten ist brandgefährlich
wann immer
mit Populismus übergangen wird
was antisemitistisches was
antisemitisches gesagt wird wird
Menschenverachtung Schritt für Schritt
ein Stück weit weiter normalisiert und
verrutscht unser demokratischer Konsens
alle DemokratInnen und Demokraten ob
hier im Haus ob in Bayern ob in anderen
Bundesländern sollten über die Debatte
die wir in Bayern erleben nicht einfach
hinweggehen weil es uns alle braucht
weil es uns Grüne braucht sPD Linke FDP
und cdu/csu dass das was wir dort
beobachten so nicht weitergeht wir
brauchen Anstand wir brauchen
grundsätzliche Tugenden und wir brauchen
einen Bekenntnis zu den grundfressen
unserer Demokratie und an der Stelle
darf es keinerlei Zweideutigkeit geben
der Missbrauch von Erinnerung ist
weltweit zu einem Einfallstor für
Rechtsextremist Gedankengut geworden
weil auf der Hand liegt dass sich daraus
aus der Erinnerung Kultur auch das
speist was heute die Grundfeste unserer
Gesellschaft sind wenn wir unsere
liberale Demokratie aufrecht erhalten
wollen wenn wir das bewahren wollen was
den meisten hier im Haus glaube ich viel
wert ist dann müssen wir er Orte müssen
wir Orte der Erinnerung an das
menschenverachtende Nazi-Regime an die
Shoa dann müssen wir die Stärken ich
selber war vor einigen Wochen in der
KZ-Gedenkstätte in Buchenwald in der
Nähe von Weimar seit in Thüringen
rechtsextremes Gedankengut in einem
erschreckenden Maße Raum greift ist dort
die Nachfrage nach Führungen ist dort
die Nachfrage nach
sich befassen mit dem was damals
passiert ist enorm nach oben gegangen
das ist das was uns berichtet wurde
viele Menschen wollen sich
auseinandersetzen mit dem was passiert
ist und das gilt auch für andere
Gedenkstätten das gilt auch für die
KZ-Gedenkstätte in Dachraum und deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir gerade an einem
neuen Gedenkstättenkonzept arbeiten und
natürlich werden wir in den Beratungen
des Haushaltes auch die
Erinnerungskultur mit der nötigen
Aufmerksamkeit bedenken
eine zweite Sache ist wichtig in dem
Kontext Kontext und der Kollege Hacker
hatte es sehr gut schon auf den Punkt
gebracht wir brauchen demokratischen
Diskurs wir brauchen ein Miteinander an
allen Orten dieser Gesellschaft vor
allem auf dem Land in der Stadt in den
kleinen Kreisen da wo Menschen
zusammenkommen und sich austauschen wer
Kultur vor Ort erlebt egal wo im Land
der erlebt auch die Gemeinschaft an
diesem Ort die kulturelle Arbeit abseits
der großen Häuser ist für den
Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft von
enormer Bedeutung und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir in Etat der jetzt
vorliegt die
bundeskulturfonds Stärken deswegen ist
richtig dass wir einen amateurmusik vor
aufgelegt haben deswegen ist richtig
dass wir ein festival-förderfond
aufgelegt haben der gerade den
ländlichen Raum ganz besonders
adressiert weil es dort diese Orte noch
viel stärker braucht es ist richtig dass
wir die Orte Demokrat der Demokrat ie
von denen die wir hier sprechen dass wir
die stärken denn wer vor Ort
Gemeinschaft in einem Chor erlebt oder
in einem theatert denken Sie an Ihre
nachfolgenden Kollegen der wird auch ein
Stück weit immun gegen das was
Populisten und Demagogen in unsere
Gesellschaft wollen
andreas audritsch war das für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und ihm
folgt jetzt hier in der Aussprache in
der generalaussprache Otto Fricke der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion nachdem ich ja beim letzten
mal Ärger bekommen habe bringe ich das
Zitat jetzt von Shakespeare am Anfang
Hamlet vierte Akt 50 Szene Ophelia wir
wissen wohl was wir sind aber nicht was
wir sein können und das ist das wenn man
die Haushaltsdebatte bis heute verfolgt
was glaube ich diesem Land ein wenig
innewohnt man will mit dem Hier und
Jetzt da will man fest verankert bleiben
manche wollen in die 80er zurück manche
in die 50er manche noch später aber die
Frage was wir alles sein können was wir
alles schaffen können wenn wir uns denn
auf einen Kurs jedenfalls dem Grunde
nach einigen können darüber reden wir
gern für sagen was schlecht ist wir
gucken im Haushalt wirklich immer nur ja
aber da ist das passieren da ist jenes
passiert ich gebe das bei der cdu/csu
gerne mal als ein Beispiel Helge braun
2021 im Sommer der berühmte
handelsplatzartikel als die CDU gezeigt
hat wie sich denn dann wirklich mit der
Schuldnerin hat gesagt die
Schuldenbremse ist in den kommenden
Jahren auch bei ansonsten strenger
Ausgaben Disziplin nicht einzuhalten da
wusste der noch nichts von dem Angriff
auf die Ukraine und was schafft jetzt
diese Koalition jedenfalls verschafft
dieses Kabinett es legt einen Haushalt
vor indem die Schuldenbremse eingehalten
wird weil wir eben mehr können als
manche konservative glauben dass es so
wäre und das ist der Unterschied
zwischen konservativer Politik und einer
modernen Politik so wie wir sie
betreiben und wer das anders sieht
wenn ich das aufjaulen dann schon wieder
von der rechten Seite hört der muss dann
auch mal konkrete Vorschläge machen an
der Stelle wir es den haben will will er
den Sozialstaat über Bord werfen will er
die Nachhaltigkeit über Bord werfen will
er unser Wirtschaftssystem über Bord
werfen die Lösungen und das ist das
schöne an Haushaltspolitik lassen sich
immer konkret Nachrichten und
nachschauen und das ist das worauf wir
nach meiner Meinung achten müssen warum
sind dann Schulden so schlimm ja da
gibt's ganz viele die uns immer sagen
Japan hat ja 240% das
bruttoinlandsproduktion und andere auch
mehr jetzt stellen wir das mal an die
Seite und stellen uns nur vor unsere
Vorgängerinnen und Vorgänger hätten die
Hälfte der Schulden gemacht die wir
jetzt haben weil sie nachhaltiger
gewesen wären weil sie sich früher
überlegt haben sich von alten Dingen zu
trennen ich sage das als jemand der aus
einer Steinkohle Region kommt und
überlegt was haben wir da an Milliarden
ausgegeben und was hätten wir für
Chancen gab wenn wir früher ich denke an
die Frage was der Fraktion für diese SPD
19 Leute das wird auf Dauer nicht
funktionieren und dann hätten wir wie
viel wie viel weniger Zinsen müssten wir
zahlen 20 Milliarden Euro weniger Zinsen
und dann überlegen Sie mal was 20
Milliarden Euro weniger Zinsen für den
Haushalt bedeuten würden einen
theoretischen Überschuss den ich
übrigens gar nicht haben weil meine
Fraktion die FDP klar sagt eine
Schuldenbremse erlaubt ein gewisses Maß
von Verschuldung um Investitionen in die
Zukunft zu machen und weil ja nachher
auch noch meine Kollegin radomsky als
bildungskollegen von der cdu/cs merke
ich schon wenig Geld was könnte man
alles für Bildung was könnte man alles
für Forschung tun was könnte man alles
für Zukunft tun und das leitet mich zu
dem Punkt um dem es uns eigentlich gehen
muss und den wir als Haushälter auch
wenn wir wenig darüber reden immer als
den Kern von Bedrohung aber auch von
Chance für Haushalt sehen und das ist
der Arbeitsmarkt denn wir können alle
möglichen Dinge sparen oder mehr
ausgeben oder sonstiges tun auf Dauer
wird ein Haushalt wird eine Nation wird
Europa nur funktionieren wenn es
qualifizierte Arbeitsplätze hat egal ob
es akademische sind oder nicht
akademische und das muss die Aufgabe
sein und da komme ich dann wenn wir über
dem Thema Arbeitsmarkt reden
zwei Dinge machen einen Arbeitsmarkt in
Zukunft aus die Qualifikation die wir
selbst für uns tun und die Frage der
Schaffung von qualifizierten
Arbeitsplätzen tut die cdu/csu irgendwas
für qualifizierte für Qualifizierung bei
unseren Mitbürgern und Mitbürgern ich
höre da wenig ich kann auch keine
länderinitiativen erkennen jetzt schlägt
der Bundeskanzler in Deutschland packt
vor zudem übrigens auch gehört der
zweite Teil für moderne Arbeitsplätze
nämlich Investitionen ein Arbeitsplatz
ein moderner der Zukunft hat kann nur
existieren wenn auch investiert wird und
welche Partei sagt als erstes also
Beschleunigung durch Investitionen
Anreize vertrauen dass die Arbeitgeber
mehr investieren das machen wir nicht
und dann habe ich mit großem Interesse
ist jetzt leider nicht mehr da ist aber
auch okay gehört wie Herr März gesagt
hat wie er sich vorstellt wie er seine
Sparpläne macht indem er nämlich gesagt
hat die Länder und die Kommunen da
machen wir viel zu viel da sparen wir
ein erstens die müssen dann die Aufgaben
selber wahrnehmen was vielleicht auch
gut wäre weil sie nämlich mehr
Steuereinnahmen haben als der Bund
zweitens dann bin ich auf die Nagelprobe
gespannt der Bundeskanzler hat die
Chance gegeben aber ich bin auf die
Nagelprobe gespannt für Herrn märz bei
der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
schaffte er es die cdu/csu
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten dazu zu bringen
Investitionen in moderner Arbeitsplätze
zu ermöglichen oder ist das hier nur
eine große Show gewesen die am Ende
nicht dafür sorgt dass Arbeitsplätze
entstehen die für mehr Steuereinnahmen
sorgen die dafür sorgen dass die
sozialen Sicherungssysteme gut werden
und so weiter und so weiter ich bin
gespannt und ich weiß Herr Dobrindt aus
Bayern kann ich da nichts erwarten das
ist dann irgendwo vielleicht wieder ganz
nett aber schauen wir mal meine Damen
und Herren ich komme zum Schluss ich
komme zum Schluss wenn wir diese
Haushaltsberatungen gut machen wollen
dann sollten wir sehen nicht nur wer wir
sind sondern was wir alles sein können
herzlichen Dank
Otto Fricke der Haushälter der
FDP-Fraktion ja und die Frage der
Schuldenbremse die ja in diesem Haushalt
mehr für 2024 wieder eingehalten werden
sollen nach
ausgesetzter Schuldenbremse in den
vergangenen Jahren wegen Corona und
wegen des russischen angriffskriegs und
den Auswirkungen die Schuldenbremse wird
eingehalten sofern es nach
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner geht es
gibt eine Neuverschuldung die vorgesehen
ist zumindest von 16,6 Milliarden Euro
das wäre noch im Rahmen der
Schuldenbremse
dabei gehört diese mit 1,8 Millionen
Beschäftigten zur drittgrößten und
wachstumsstärksten Wirtschaftsbranche
doch im ganzen
wachstumschancengesetz und das ist 300
Seiten lang findet sich kein einziges
Wort zur Kulturwirtschaft obwohl der
Beauftragte für die Kreativwirtschaft
direkt im Wirtschaftsministerium sitzt
doch das ist nicht das einzige Problem
der Kulturszene die vergangenen Jahre
haben gezeigt dass unsere
Kultureinrichtungen und Kunstschätze
besser vor Angriffen und Katastrophen
geschützt werden müssen wir als Union
haben das immer wieder betont bei der
Bundesregierung ist diese Forderung
nicht angekommen denn im aktuellen
Gesetzentwurf zum Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur wird die Kultur als nicht
relevant eingestuft während in Berlin
für 450 Millionen Euro 450 Millionen
Euro
ein neues klimafreundliches Museum der
Moderne gebaut wird fehlt es an
ausreichend sicherheitsräumen zur
Verwahrung von unseren national
wertvollen Kulturgütern
und nun zum Haushalt ein Blick in den
Haushalt offenbart sechs Millionen Euro
Kürzung weiter Förderung der Kultur und
Kreativwirtschaft 15 Millionen Euro
Kürzung bei der Serienproduktion dabei
ist der Filmstandort Deutschlands schon
heute nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig und
steht auf der Kippe auch die
Computerspielbranche sieht den Standort
Deutschland in Gefahr wenn an dem
massiven Kürzungsplänen von ca 20
Millionen Euro festgehalten wird
als nicht schlimm genug stellen sie sich
Frau Staatsministerin Roth heute hier
hin und verkünden die Erhöhung des
kulturhaushaltes doch in Wahrheit gehen
sie an die Substanz der bundeskultur und
kürzen hintenrum nämlich bei dem
selbstwirtschaftungsmitteln und die sind
das Fundament der Kultureinrichtungen
konkret heißt das zum Beispiel Millionen
Kürzungen bei langjährigen Projekten bei
der Deutschen Nationalbibliothek der
Kulturstiftung des Bundes und dem Haus
der Geschichte in Bonn führen Sie uns
also nicht in das Licht sondern spielen
sie wenigstens mit offenen Karten das
macht es nicht besser aber ehrlicher
sie kürzen einer Kultur und das ist
erstmals seit 18 Jahren mit uns hat es
als cdu/csu noch nie gegeben in
Gegenteil es gab ein jahrelangen Konsens
überparteilichen Konsens wonach an der
Kultur nicht gespart wird das schafft
die Ampel ab die
bundeskultureinrichtungen brauchen
Verlässlichkeit und eine ausreichende
Finanzierung um ihren kernauftrag zu
erfüllen das ist uns als Union wichtig
das ist seriöse Kulturpolitik
stattdessen
spendiert die Ampeln 100 Millionen Euro
für Symbolpolitik für den Kulturpass für
18-Jährige obwohl die Mittel in diesem
Jahr noch gar nicht abgeschlossen sind
wird schon mal vorangestellt dass es
eine Verlängerung im nächsten Jahr geben
soll klar das ist nice das ist ein süßes
Bonbon aber sie investieren in die Kür
und sparen an der Pflicht weder für das
mal für die Opfer von Kommunismus noch
für das Forum von Opposition und
Widerstand sind im Haushalt Gelder
eingestellt beide Vorhaben wurden hier
mit breiter Mehrheit auch von uns hier
im Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen
11 für die freie Theaterszene ist
hingegen reichlich da 20 Millionen Euro
übrigens war das schon immer eine
Kernforderung der Grünen aber es keine
Pflichtaufgabe des Bundes hier wird
offensichtlich Parteipolitik
Klientelpolitik gemacht
und noch ein Punkt zum Abschluss in den
Haushaltsberatungen müssen diese Fragen
alle natürlich geklärt werden aber
merkenswert ist dass die Ampel im
Kulturausschuss für die
Haushaltsberatungen eine nicht
öffentliche Sitzung beantragt hat dabei
fordern Sie doch immer die Transparenz
was haben Sie zu verbergen wir als
cdu/csu werden die Beratungen nutzen um
die Mittelkürzungen und Unklarheiten
aufzudecken und wir werden sie den
Betroffenen mitteilen danke schön
war das für die Unionsfraktion ja fast
alle Ressorts müssen im Haushalt 2024
oder sollen sparen es kann natürlich
eine der anderen Stelle noch was
verschoben werden in den
parlamentarischen Beratung aber außer
dem Verteidigungs Einzelplan und
beispielsweise auch bei Verkehr und
digitales gibt es Einschnitte in fast
allen Ressource eben auch beim
Kanzleramt und bei der Beauftragten für
Kultur und Medien
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
es läuft die Generaldebatte in der
haushaltswoche der Bundeskanzler hat
eben ausführlich erklärt wie sich sein
Deutschland packt vorstellt und wir
haben einen
Bundeshaushalt einen Entwurf der
Bundesregierung zum Haushalt vorliegen
wir diskutieren seit 9 Uhr und ich will
mit einem Zitat von Helmut Schmidt
beginnen dass da lautet Demokratie und
Streit gehören zusammen eine Demokratie
die nicht in der nicht gestritten wird
ist keiner und darum ist es gut dass wir
hier diese Debatte führen diese Debatte
die der traditionelle Schlagabtausch
zwischen den Regierungsfraktionen der
Koalition und der Opposition ist und
diesen Streit brauchen wir in unserem
Land den brauchen wir ganz dringend weil
unsere Demokratie aufgrund der großen
multiplen Krisen unter Druck ist und ich
verstehe diesen Streit mit der
demokratischen
Opposition vor allem als ein
konstruktives Ringen um den besten
Lösungsweg für die Herausforderungen
unserer Zukunft
und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich bin jetzt
seit neun Uhr dabei und ich bin ein
Stück weit enttäuscht ob der Vorschläge
die aus der Opposition kommen um das
Ringen für die besten Lösung denn wir
diskutieren seit drei Stunden und ich
muss sagen wo bleibt denn in diesem
Moment wo die Gesellschaft so unter
Druck ist wo der gesellschaftliche
Zusammenhalt so unter Druck ist die
Vorschläge der Linken womit Ali sie
haben geredet von ganz vielen was ganz
schlecht ist ich will auch jetzt meine
Redezeit nicht dafür aufwenden welche
zahlen Sie welche zahlen Sie
kreativ interpretiert haben aber ich
habe nicht einen einzigen konkreten
Vorschlag für nicht einen einzigen
Vorschlag was geändert werden müsste und
die Berufe aus der Union muss sie auch
ganz ehrlich sagen finde ich auch
bemerkenswert das Wort Popanz dass der
kanzlergriff hat trifft es glaube ich
ganz gut
wenn der einzig konkrete Vorschlag den
ich bei Herrn März gefunden habe ist die
Kindergrundsicherung und das GEG zu
stoppen ansonsten wird alles schlecht
geredet aber es kommt kein konstruktiver
Vorschlag auch nicht von Herrn Dobrindt
Herr Dobrindt sie haben ihre Rede
eingeleitet mit die Menschen wollen
Antworten
ich nicht gefunden mich würde eine
Antwort von Ihnen interessieren wie
viele der Sondervermögen die sie beklagt
haben in wie vielen der Sondervermögen
hat die Union eigentlich zugestimmt
meiner Meinung nach meine Erfahrung nach
hat sie allen Sondervermögen zugestimmt
die wir in diesem hohen Haushalt gerade
vorliegen haben oder ist mir eins
entgangen den Sie nicht zugestimmt haben
und der frei wenn Sie fragen ob
Deutschland der Krankheit oder der
connemist schreibt Deutschland wäre der
kranke Mann Europas dann drängt sich mir
erstmal der auf Eindruck auf dass der
Economist vielleicht einmal mehr ein
zweites Mal zu dieser Frage kommt weil
wir eine so lange CDU geführte
Kanzlerschaft hatten in der die ganzen
Zukunft
fortschrittmodernisierungsanliegen so
ausgebrannt worden sind dass wir in
diesen Krisen jetzt mit richtig viel
Tempo da reingehen müssen aber die
Aufgaben eben besonders groß sind
meine Damen und Herren Demokratie und
Streit gehören zusammen und darum werden
wir jetzt beginnend in dieser Woche mit
den Haushaltsberatungen gucken wir
werden guten Regierungsentwurf noch
besser machen können einer der nicht
einfach ist aber als selbstvermänden
bewusstes Parlament nicht als
Vollzugsorgan sondern als Auftraggeber
an die Regierung werden wir in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten und davon
bin ich oder überzeugt die Vereinbarung
gibt es unter den Haushälterinnen und
Hauseltern bereits relativ geräuschlos
vielleicht vollkommen geräuschung
vereinbaren an welchen Stellen wir noch
Änderungen vornehmen werden wir werden
das sachlich an der Sache konstruktiv
diskutieren unaufgeregt und ich will
abschließend mit einem Wunsch den ich an
dieser Stelle als parlamentarian auch
noch an das Kabinett formulieren möchte
die Geräuschkulisse auf Twitter oder x
sollte aus Regierungskreisen meines
Erachtens auch ein bisschen leiser und
vor allem von kürzerer dauerwerden wenn
die öffentliche auseinander Setzung die
wir brauchen den Streit den wir brauchen
der gewinnt dann wenn wir Gesetzentwürfe
vorliegen haben wenn Konzepte
ausgeschrieben sind weil wir dann
sachlich diskutieren können herzlichen
Dank
war das für die SPD-Fraktion sitzt sie
im Haushaltsausschuss der er dann in den
kommenden wochenen Monaten dieses ganze
Werk noch mal an allen Posten prüft und
natürlich das ein oder andere noch
verändern kann und interessant was gibt
es da gesagt hat dass es anscheinend
eine Vereinbarung zwischen den
Hauseltern gibt diese Beratung doch
geräuscharm zu machen und diese
Diskussion eher im Inneren zu führen das
immer mal gespannt
wird und wenn sich negative Dynamiken
beschleunigen
ich frage mich haben wir auch
gesellschaftlich ein Kipppunkt erreicht
Angriffe auf unsere plurale Gesellschaft
haben in den letzten Jahren zugenommen
Vorfälle rechter rassistischer
antisemitischer Gewalt sind auf einem
Höchststand Lehrerin die rechtsextreme
Vorfälle an ihrer Schule melden werden
bedroht antisemitische Schriften werden
verharmlost und bleiben folgenlos Nöte
und Krise werden gezielt
instrumentalisiert und das häufig auf
dem Rücken von marginalisierten Gruppen
ob in der corona-pandemie oder der
Energiekrise
geringverdienende arbeitslose Menschen
und geflüchtete dürfen nicht
gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
was was bedeutet die Überschreitung
dieses kipppunktes für unsere Demokratie
die Grenzen des Sagbaren werden immer
weiter verschoben Friedrich Merz
wetterte diese Woche Kreuzberg sei nicht
Deutschland dieser blanke Populismus
negiert nicht nur die Vielfalt in
Deutschland sondern würde ich doch all
die Menschen herab die Deutschland als
ihr zu Hause begreifen und Teil dieser
Gesellschaft sind
durch solche die Vermehrung werden sie
als Fremde markiert abgewertet und
ausgegrenzt Rassismus bedroht nicht nur
unsere Demokratie insgesamt sondern
diese Menschen ganz konkret auch ihre
Ängste und Sorgen müssen zählen Gewalt
und Hetze dürfen nicht normalisiert
werden
es ist beeindruckend wie viele Menschen
sich in unserer demokratischen
Zivilgesellschaft engagieren tausende
Vereine und Initiativen stellen sich
Demokratie feindlichen Tendenzen
entgegen sie setzen sich für eine
vielfältige Gesellschaft ein und eine
starke wehrhafte Demokratie denn als
Gesellschaft tragen wir die
Verantwortung Hass und Rechtsextremismus
den Nährboden zu entziehen im Alltag in
unseren Institutionen in unserem
Parlamenten in den Kommunen in den
Ländern aber auch direkt aus dem
Kanzleramt heraus die Schaffung des
Amtes der antirassismusbeauftragten war
ein wichtiger Schritt um Rassismus
endlich koordiniert und strukturell
bekämpfen zu können
doch der Haushalt und die Politik müssen
eine gemeinsame Sprache sprechen die
Verantwortung des Bundes für Integration
und zu Bekämpfung von Rassismus und
Extremismus muss im Etat finanziell
unterlegt werden es wäre fatal genau
jetzt nicht in diese Maßnahmen zu
investieren an einem Kipppunkt
verfestigen und Beschleunigen sich
negative Dynamiken wir müssen jetzt
dagegen halten
geschlossen und solidarisch vielen Dank
das Wort hat Sepp Müller für die CDU
csu-
frakt Müller ist der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in der
Generaldebatte zum kanzlerital
unterhalten wir uns auch über
Ostdeutschland da der Staatsminister für
Ostdeutschland sein Etat auch mit
einbringen gut ist dass wir in der
großen Koalition gemeinsam vereinbart
haben ein zukunftszentrum deutsche
Einheit auf dem Weg zu bringen gut ist
auch dass die Entscheidung gefallen ist
gut ist dass nach Halle Saale das
zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit kommen
wird dafür danke Ihnen herzlich dass das
auf dem Weg gebracht wird im
zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit werden
wir auch über Transformation reden
Transformation im europäischen Rahmen
weg von der Planwirtschaft hin zur
sozialen Marktwirtschaft interessant
dabei ist aber dass man aktuell das
Gefühl haben muss dass diese
Bundesregierung die Rolle rückwärts
Antrieb weg von der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft hin zur Planwirtschaft
ich mache Ihnen ein Beispiel
Herr Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
garantiert eine Einspeisevergütung für
Solarstrom von 8 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
auf der anderen Seite fordert der
sogenannte Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck einen industriestrompreis von 4
Cent die Kilowattstunde haben sie das
gemerkt
Einspeisevergütung 18 auf der anderen
Seite 4 Cent Industriestrom das erinnert
irgendwie an unsere ehemalige DDR dort
hat man hinten an dem Konsum eine kleine
Supermarkt für viele Pfennig
eierverkauft und ist vorne hingegangen
und hat an der Kasse für deutlich
weniger diese Eier wieder zurückverkauft
herzlichen Glückwunsch wir sind auf dem
Weg in die Planwirtschaft deswegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ist es
auch richtig dass wir das
zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit auf dem
Weg bringen
beim zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit
werden wir uns sicherlich auch über
Energiewirtschaft unterhalten wir
brauchen 24 Stunden 7 Tage die Woche 365
366 Tage im Jahr
grundlastfähigen Strom und ich sage das
eineindeutig hier dazu gehört die
Kohleverstromung bis ins Jahr 2038 dazu
Herr Bundeskanzler beflügen sie
befähigen sie endlich ihre Regierung das
auch auszusprechen und das nicht nur
ihrem oststaatsminister zu überlassen
und dieser
Verstromung von Kohlestrom Liebe Grün
das geht auch klimafreundlicher das
Stichwort lautet technologieoffenheit
wir können CO2 nutzen wir können CO2
nutzen anstatt es zu verteufeln das geht
bereits technisch und was haben wir als
Unionsfraktion gemacht wir haben ein
Positionspapier zur CCS CCU auf dem Weg
gebracht und haben Ihnen einen
Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt CO2 zu nutzen was hat die
streitampel gemacht diesen Gesetzentwurf
abgelehnt sie sehen also es geht nur um
grüne Ideologie und nicht um
Klimapolitik bleiben wir bei der
grundlastfähigkeit die Unionsfraktion
fordert seit Monaten die Atomkraftwerke
die letzten drei weiterlaufen zu lassen
wir müssen doch in dieser Energiekrise
alles am Markt halten wir haben Ihnen
nicht nur Anträge dazu vorgelegt sondern
auch einen Gesetzentwurf wo ist die
Zusammenarbeit die von ihrem
Bundeskanzler gefordert ist was hat die
Ampel die streitampel gemacht diesen
Gesetzesentwurf abgelehnt wenn wir im
Ostdeutschland reden dann reden wir auch
über ein kleines ländchenindustrie und
da gehört zum Beispiel der Raffinerie in
Schwedt dazu
sie werden und das ist vielleicht auch
wichtig im zukunftszentrum deutscher
Einheit sich anzuschauen
Physikunterricht war da sehr gut gewesen
sie werden die Regeln der Physik nicht
außer Kraft setzen können durch das
kleine Rohr die Pipeline zwischen
Rostock und Schwedt kann nicht so viel
Öl gehen damit dieser damit diese
Raffinerie zu 100% versorgt ist wir
haben ihn den Vorschlag hier gemacht
eine zweite 40 cm Pipeline zu bauen
damit diese Raffinerie nicht nur mit Öl
versorgt werden kann sondern mit wir
auch Wasserstoff transportieren können
was hat die streitampel gemacht unseren
Antrag abgelehnt sie streiten nur sie
reichen nicht die Hände sie sind das
Gegenteil von Fortschritt sie sind
abgewandt und die rückschrittskoalition
und wenn wir uns Transformation
anschauen und das möchte ich noch mal
Richtung FDP sagen liebe Kollegen dann
reden wir auch über Reparationszahlungen
zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit in der
ehemaligen sowjetischen Besatzungszone
hat man 2000 bis 2400 wichtigste und
bestausgerüstete Betriebe als
Reparationszahlung auf dem Weg gebracht
fast 12.000 km Eisenbahnschienen wurden
abgebaut und in diese Welt Union
gebracht bis 1953 hat die ehemalige
sowjetische Besatzungszone und DDR die
höchste Reparationszahlung auf dem Weg
gebracht was macht ihre ampelregierung
144 Straßenbau Projekte sollen
beschleunigt werden davon nicht eines in
Ostdeutschland das habe ich bereits im
März kritisiert und da kam aus ihrer
Fraktion Liebe Freie Demokraten die
Frage warum nur ich empfehle Ihnen gehen
sie ins zukunftszentrum wenn es gebaut
ist schauen Sie sich das an für die
Zukunft der deutschen Einheit ist mir
nicht lange sondern ich bin sicher mit
den Vorschlägen der Unionsfraktion gibt
es eine gute Zukunft für Deutschland für
die deutsche Einheit in diesem Sinne
herzlichen Dank
Sepp Müller war das für die
Unionsfraktion aber er hat auch
gewürdigte dass der ostbeauftragte
beispielsweise sich auch dafür
eingesetzt hat dass ein zukunftszentrum
deutsche Einheit entsteht Halle hat im
April den Zuschlag dafür bekommen das
zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit in
Halle das soll Erfahrungen und Leistung
der Menschen im Osten sichtbar machen
ein Ort der Wissenschaft und Kultur der
Neubau soll dann ab 2028 eben auch als
Museum und Wissenschaftszentrum
fungieren
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
Kultur und Medien sind die tragende
Säule unserer Demokratie dazu haben wir
heute schon einiges gehört sie sorgen
für Austausch und Dialog und sind damit
entscheidend für den Zusammenhalt in
einer vielfältigen Gesellschaft die
Pandemie mit ihren Kontakt
Beschränkungen und den vielen
geschlossenen Kultureinrichtungen hat
gezeigt wie stark sich Einschränkungen
auswirken deswegen bin ich froh und
erleichtert dass es uns im
Haushaltsentwurf 224 gelungen ist den
Kulturetat auch trotz der
Haushaltskonsolidierung und der
Einsparungen und der Einsparvorgaben
stabil zu halten stabil auf dem erhöhten
Niveau der nach corona-jahre für das
kommende Jahr planen wir mit 2,15
Milliarden Euro das ist meine Damen und
Herren ist ein klares Signal es zeigt
wie ernst es uns damit ist Kultur und
Medien als stabilitäts-
zu verstehen
in Kürze werden wir neue Zahlen haben
zur sozialen Lage der Künstlerinnen und
Künstler wichtig ist jetzt dass im
Haushalt die Tarifsteigerungen abgedeckt
werden damit diese nicht zu Lasten der
Kultureinrichtung oder das Programms
gehen aber letztlich müssen alle die mit
Kunst Kultur und Medien ihr Geld
verdienen davon gut leben und auch
vorsorgen können darum werden wir uns
weiter kümmern
wenn direkt gewählte Abgeordneter aus
Brandenburg aus einer sehr ländlich
geprägten Regionen jeden Tag erlebe ich
wie wichtig es ist austauscht zu
ermöglichen faktenbasiertes Wissen für
alle erreichbar zur Verfügung zu stellen
in die politische Bildung auch der
Erwachsenen zu investieren und für
Gerechtigkeit und soziale Sicherheit zu
sorgen mit unserem Ansatz ermöglichen
wir Kultur für alle mit dem Kulturpass
für alle 18-Jährigen überall im Land den
wir ganz konkret den Zugang zu Kultur
gerade nach der Pandemie Ebenen
genau wir investieren massiv in die
Kulturfonds und in die freie Szene um
kulturelle Angebote überall im Land zu
ermöglichen wir stocken massiv auf den
Fond darstellende Künste die Literatur
der Amateur musikfond zeigt exemplarisch
dass wir die Vielfalt der Kultur im Land
im Blick haben neben den großen Häusern
und den bundesweiten Festivals haben wir
zum Beispiel auch den Karneval und den
Zirkus im Blick hier wird ein breites
Publikum erreicht dass ich vielleicht
nicht selbst als Kultur interessiert
bezeichnen würde aber ja auch Zirkus und
Kultur auch Zirkus und Karneval meine
Damen und Herren sind Kultur die
Kultur im ländlichen Raum unterliegt
besonderen Herausforderungen die
Angebote sind weit verteilt Vernetzung
und gegenseitige Unterstützung sind
notwendig das fördern wir etwa über die
Kulturstiftung des Bundes der Zugang zu
kulturellen Angeboten und verlässlichen
Informationen muss überall im Land
gleichermaßen gewährleistet sein deshalb
sorgen wir dort wo es in die
Zuständigkeit des Bundes-
Bibliotheken wir werden auch weiter in
die Erinnerungskultur investieren und
einen Beitrag damit Aufarbeitung und
Versöhnung leisten als Vorsitzende des
Bundesverbandes der deutschen der
deutsch-polnischen Gesellschaften das
ist mir sehr wichtig dass wir uns
intensiver mit unserem Nachbarland Polen
und unserer gemeinsamen Geschichte
auseinandersetzen ich freue mich dass in
der vergangenen Woche das
Eckpunktepapier für das
deutsch-polnische Haus vorgestellt
werden konnte meine Damen und Herren
Kultur und Medien sind grundlegend für
unsere demokratische Gesellschaft der
vorliegende Haushaltsentwurf bildet
diese Priorität ab lassen Sie uns diese
starke Signal gemeinsam aussenden vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
hier Simone
[Applaus]
und ihr folgt jetzt am Rednerpult Stefan
Seidler er ist fraktionslos hier im
Bundestag und der einzige Abgeordnete
für den südschlesischen wählerverband
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen halten
Sie sich fest denn für mich durch dieser
Haushalt ein wenig eine Achterbahnfahrt
mal gings schnell aufwärts und mal ein
tiefer Sturz und dass mein Blick
zunächst auf die Finanzierung der
nationalen Minderheiten und den
dazugehörigen Organisationen landete
überrascht sie hoffentlich nicht und
hier schienen auch so weit alles in
Ordnung die Unterstützung des Sinti und
Roma die Friesen und die SATA friesen
sind von Kürzungen verschont geblieben
dafür erstmal ein nordfriesisches
polytrung liebe Frau Roth nur meine
Leute
nur meine Leute die denen die kann ich
nicht finden das bereitet mir ein wenig
Bauchschmerzen besonders wenn ich mir
angucke wo die Bundesregierung sonst
klare Einsparungen plagt beim BMI sollen
unter anderem 30 Prozent der Zuschüsse
des minderheitensekretariat ist
weggestrichen werden ebenso düster sieht
es bei den Mitteln für die Unterstützung
der Gremien unserer nationalen
Minderheiten und Regionalsprachen aus
werden etwa die vorgeschlagenen Kürzung
von einem Drittel des Budgets des
niederdeutsch-sekretariat des
beschlossen wird das fatale Folgen haben
besonders die Jugendarbeit wird leiden
und die ist für das Fortbestehen der
niederdeutschen Sprache essentiell so
leben
die Demokratie in Europa steht unter
Druck ganz konkret müssen wir in Bayern
in Bayern allen Ernstes diskutieren wie
rechts ein Wirtschaftsminister sein darf
und ob Antisemitismus Verjährungsfrist
hat gerade jetzt sollten wir als Vorbild
vorangehen und deshalb auch noch mal
vielen Dank Frau Roth für ihr klares
Bekenntnis zur Demokratie und zur
kulturellen Vielfalt lassen Sie mich
aber hinzufügen
lassen Sie mich hinzufügen dass die
Förderung von gesellschaftlicher
Vielfalt durch Minderheiten und
Regionalsprachen nicht von
konjunkturabhängig gemacht werden darf
bei
bei den Freiwilligendiensten sieht es
auch nicht gut aus 78 Millionen Euro
sollen aus dem Etat des
Bundesfamilienministeriums gestrichen
werden damit fällt jede vierte FSJ oder
bfd-stelle weg ich habe mich vor wenigen
Tagen in einem AWO-Kindergarten in Kiel
noch mal versichern können wie wichtig
diese Arbeit ist und wie wichtig der
Freiwilligendienst für junge Menschen
ist der FSJ setzt ein klaren Schwerpunkt
auf persönliche Entwicklung und lassen
Sie mich mit meinem norddeutschen
Demokratieverständnis hier auch noch mal
ganz klar sagen gerade solche
freiwillige Arbeit braucht es wenn es in
der Demokratie ein wenig kränkelt liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen mit den
Einsparungen bei den
Freiwilligendiensten nehmen wir vielen
jungen Menschen die Möglichkeit sind
stiften etwas für die Gesellschaft zu
tun und bei unseren Minderheiten und
regionalsparaten sparen wir an einen
kleinen aber tragenden Pfeiler unserer
demokratischen Vielfalt beides finde ich
bedenklich und ich hoffe dass wir hier
noch gemeinsam daran arbeiten können
vielen Dank
darauf macht hier Stefan Seidler eben
aufmerksam als einziger Abgeordneter das
ist Süd Schleswig schon wählerverbandes
sieht ja hier im Bundestag so jetzt
geht's weiter mit einem Redner aus den
Reihen von Bündnis 90 grünen das ist der
Abgeordnete Stefan seitler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich möchte über
Ost und West reden zunächst der Osten
ist keine westdeutsche Erfindung der
Osten ist aber eine zu einfache
westdeutsche Schublade und die gehört
abgeschafft denn
denn die Schublade die quietscht die
spaltet und ist rissig Jammer aussieht
und besserwiss darüber hinweg der Osten
ist rechtsradikal das ist jedoch so ein
weiteres falsches Bild oberverschluss
wie Bernd höcke sind zum Beispiel
Importe und ein Hubert einwanger darf
ungestört in der Regierung in Bayern
weitermachen der Osten ist so bunt wie
der Westen auch so seine Ausfälle hat
diese Schubladen helfen nicht und müssen
also raus aus den Köpfen der Osten ist
keine Abweichung von einer fiktiven Norm
und für ihre Unterschiede anzusprechen
wie bei Einkommen und Vermögen das ist
richtig dass der richtige Weg und das
macht diese Koalition
die Koalition hat die
Kindergrundsicherung das Bürgergeld die
rentenangleichung und die Mindestlohn
vorangebracht bzw erhöht das ist wichtig
ebenso wichtig ist es nachhaltige
wirtschaftliche wirtschaftspolitische
wirtschaftliche Strukturen zu schaffen
klar Tesla aber eben nun auch Intel
Infineon TSMC und ja das bedeutet eben
auch das Robert Habeck dass diese
Bundesregierung gewichtige Förderung
nach Sachsen-Anhalt bringt wir brauchen
[Applaus]
wir brauchen moderne industriepolitische
Kerne in Brandenburg in Sachsen und so
weiter von den Top 500 Unternehmen in
Deutschland sind gerade einmal 42 42 im
Osten angesiedelt das muss mehr werden
und zum Thema Planwirtschaft Herr
Kollege wer die Kohle bis 2038 sichern
will der ist ganz schön Planwirtschaft
[Applaus]
ost-west-lücke Lohnlücke von 13.000 Euro
pro Jahr die muss geschlossen werden
dazu braucht es Tarifverträge dazu
müssen die Sonderzahlungen aus dem West
gleich hoch sein und das sehe ich als
eine vornehme Aufgabe des
ostbeauftragten das anzugehen
ein gesamtdeutschen Diskurs wie ich nun
mal ansprechendes ein richtig richtiges
anspruchsvolles Ziel im Osten zum
Beispiel gibt es keine emotionale
Westbindung zum Beispiel Richtung USA
deswegen muss exakter informiert werden
die Vorsitzende Linksfraktion hat hier
heute z.B gesagt dass die russische
wirtschaftsachse die Sanktionen also
nicht verfangen würden und dieser
Gedanke der verfängt natürlich wiederum
aber das unterschlägt dass dieses
Wachstum können Sie nachlesen dass
dieses Wachstum auf einer massiven
Ausbreitung der Kriegswirtschaft beruht
das sind also Panzer Munition und die
Form Medizin der russische
Staatshaushalt derweil der dreht hart
ins Minus und deswegen geht es
informieren einzuordnen auch falschen
Informationen entgegenzutreten und
deswegen müssen wir bürgerschaftlichen
Engagement entgegentreten das ist
deswegen ein letztes Wort wir müssen im
Westen auch für den Osten interessieren
deswegen reicht ein Trans
deutsch-französisches jugendticket nicht
mehr genauso notwendig ist ein Deutsch
polnisches oder in deutsch-technisches
jugendticket es ist viel zu tun vielen
Dank
ist Stefan Gelbhaar war das für die
Fraktion der Bündnisse in 90 die Grünen
Matthias Helferich
er ist einer der fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten die hier im Deutschen
Bundestag sitzen frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ein Staat ist nicht nur
eine kluge Veranstaltung zum Schutz der
Individuen gegeneinander wie es
Nietzsche ausführte und er geht auch
über den Zweck der rational
organisierten Selbsterhaltung so gehen
eines Volkes hinaus der Staat ist
zumindest sein Ideal nach der vitale
Garant einer Gemeinschaftsordnung die
auf Identität und Solidarität Fuß wie in
der publizismen die Kaiser
charakterisierte aber was passiert wenn
Identität und Solidarität nicht
ineinander greifen erleben wir
alljährlich bei den Haushaltsberatung
seit 2010 musste unser Volk bis zum
heutigen Tage 132 Milliarden Euro für
ausländische sozialleistungsbezieher
Zahlen zu keinem Zeitpunkt in der
deutschen Geschichte finanzierten wir
mehr aus dem Stück Kinder als heute
deutsches Geld für Millionen fremde
Kinder jede staatliche
Solidargemeinschaft braucht ein
identitären Kit der ist erst ermöglicht
füreinander einzutreten indem sie die
Massenzuwanderung weiter befeuern
befeuern sie auch den Niedergang unserer
Sozialstaatlichkeit und der
Gesundheitsminister der hat Recht wenn
er sagt dass die Luft immer dünner wird
sie wird immer dünner für Einheimische
in unserem Land jeder Blick in den
Einkaufskorb auf die Stromabrechnung auf
die Tankquittung löst immer bei uns
immer größeren Teilen unseres Volkes
Verzweiflung Wut und Hoffnungslosigkeit
aus und der Ausritt ins interessiert
sich auch keiner im Lande für die
sinisterin Inhalte von alwanger
Schulranzen die Leute interessiert was
sie noch in der Brieftasche haben und da
wundern sie sich ernsthaft noch das
zweite der deutschen Wähler die
Bundesregierung ablehnen 818 Millionen
Euro für das Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge 93 Millionen Euro mehr zum
vorher 34 Millionen Euro für ihr her aus
integrations- und rassismusbeauftragten
was ist für die Einheimischen vorgesehen
die ihre Menschheit durchfüttern sollen
sie müssen sich von einer vorlauten
verfugen anhören das Deutschland
niemanden aber vor allen Dingen nicht
den deutschen gehört das ist aber immer
noch unser Land und immer mehr Teile
unseres Volkes erkennen das und erkennen
auch dass es Zeit ist ihre Stimme zu
erheben die AFD wird Identität und
Solidarität oder wie Frau bärburg sagen
würde Solidarität wieder ins
Gleichgewicht bringt kümmern sie sich
weiterhin um die Menschheit wir kümmern
uns um Deutschland vielen Dank
Matthias Helfrich war das einer von
insgesamte sechs fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten derzeit im Bundestag für
die AFD ist er einstmals hier ins
Parlament eingezogen Herr Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren bei den
Haushaltsberatungen über den Etat des
Bundeskanzlers möchte ich zuerst einen
Blick auf den Bereich Kultur werfen
bereits zur Halbzeit scheint hier leider
die Puste auszugehen die Ambitionen und
der Gestaltungswille in diesem Bereich
die so dringend nötig werden sind im
Kulturbudget kaum zu erkennen die
Pressemitteilung der BKM
vom Juli mag uns 111 Millionen Euro mehr
im Kulturhaushalt versprechen frei nach
dem Motto traue keiner Statistik die du
nicht selbst gefälscht hast im Vergleich
schaut man sich das mal genauer an
zwischen den etat-entwürfen 2023 und
2024 sehen wir einen Rückgang um 43
Millionen
weitere wichtige Vorhaben im
Kulturbereich liegen brach ein besonders
papierendes Beispiel ist die Situation
der Filmförderung die deutsche Film und
Pferden sie Wirtschaft steht vor enormen
Herausforderungen die Kosten steigen und
die Branche erwartet zu Recht eine
Reform wichtig ist die Betonung auf
Reform die deren Weiterentwicklung
fördert in im Entwurf steht eine Kürzung
und ich möchte hier darauf hinweisen es
geht nicht immer nur um Geld manchmal
geht es einfach darum dass man
Reformprozesse anschiebt auch als Ampel
jetzt sagt die Kultur-
[Musik]
Starten der Bundeskanzler sagt im
nächsten Jahr wird entschieden es ist
höchste Zeit dass endlich echte Schritte
unternommen werden um die Filmwirtschaft
zu stärken und nicht zu schwächen
ein weiteres Versprechen das ins Leere
zu verheilen scheint betritt betrifft
den Vertrieb von Presse Erzeugnissen im
Koalitionsvertrag wurde zugesichert eine
flächendeckende Versorgung mit
Presseprodukten sicherzustellen doch
seit zwei Jahren warten wir vergeblich
auf konkrete Maßnahmen oder Reformen die
diese Versorgung gewährleisten sollen
die Bundesländer wie Sachsen
Nordrhein-Westfalen Rheinland-Pfalz
Bremen und Schleswig-Holstein
unterstützen das Vorhaben es ist
enttäuschen zu sehen wie wenig Interesse
hier an der Unterstützung eines
lebendigen und vielfältigen
medienumfeldes besteht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
konstruktive Opposition möchte ich auch
erwähnen die wenigen positiven Aspekte
die von der Ampelkoalition umgesetzt
worden oder in dem Fall eher nicht
umgesetzt worden während der letzten
Beratung haben wir eine Debatte über die
kuppelinnenschrift am Berliner Schloss
geführt die ursprünglichen Pläne der
Bundesregierung sahen vor diese
Inschrift zu überblenden hier gebührt
Frau Roth unser Dank dafür dass sie von
diesem Vorhaben Abstand genommen hat
schon in meiner vorherigen Rede habe ich
darauf hingewiesen dass die Kosten für
diese Überdeckung ja nicht feststehen
würden und nun wissen wir diese
Überblendung hätte alleine 700.000 €
verschlungen also danke schön dass Sie
an dieser Stelle einsparen
für uns als Union ist ein Thema ganz
wichtig in Zeiten der Flucht und
Vertreibung es ist für uns
unverständlich warum die Förderung zur
baulichen Notsicherung von Schloss
Steinort nicht fortgeführt wird
wir hatten immer über alle
Fraktionsgrenzen hinweg uns für die
Sanierung eingesetzt und ich fände es
schön wenn wir da in den
Haushaltsberatungen noch mal drauf
schreiben neben dem Bereich Kultur
gehört natürlich zum etat-bundeskanzler
Bundeskanzleramt auch der
Erweiterungsbau des Bundeskanzlers schön
dass Sie da sind Herr Bundeskanzler
schauen wir uns das mal genau an ihr
Bundesfinanzminister hat von diesem
bauabstand genommen zu werden ist
medienmäßig und der Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzlers wird derzeit noch mit
777 Millionen Euro geplant der
Bundesrechnungshof geht schon jetzt
davon aus dass dieser Kostenrahmen nicht
gehalten werden kann und ich bin
gespannt ob es jetzt schon Makulatur ist
und das werden sicherlich auch die
kommenden Haushaltsberatung zeigen und
wir sind alle gespannt auf dem Bericht
ihres Amtes zum Fortschritt des Baus und
zu den zukünftigen Kosten die damit
verbunden sind
eines steht nämlich hier jetzt fest die
Entscheidung zu Fortführung dieses
Bauvorhabens sendet ein Signal aus dass
die zeitenwände die von ihnen immer
bedient wurde nicht ernst genommen wird
in ihrem eigenen Etat und heute haben
wir gelernt es gibt einen neuen Begriff
den Deutschland packt Herr Bundeskanzler
das ist das neue was wir bedienen wollen
ich habe mir das mal etwas angeguckt der
erste Punkt in Deutschland packt ist
packt für Planung Genehmigung und
umsetzungsbeschleunigung zwischen Bund
und Ländern und jetzt kann man sich
Unterpunkte anschauen ein wichtiger
Punkt dabei ist die Digitalisierung von
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
dabei soll auch künstliche Intelligenz
ein Intelligenz eingesetzt werden und
die der Bund und die Länder sollen enger
miteinander zusammenarbeiten
wie passt es dazu oder haben sie das
geschrieben bevor Sie mit dem
Finanzminister in die Haushaltsberatung
gegangen sind dass sie im Kanzleramt
eine Kürzung im Titel Stärkung der
datenkompetenz des Kanzleramtes
vornehmen ich kann auch in anderen
Einzelplänen etwas dazu finden bei der
digitalen Infrastruktur und Verkehr
Einschnitte im Bereich digitale
Verwaltung Kürzungen im Bereich innen
und Heimat kommt es zu Kürzungen in
diesem Bereich und natürlich auch die
Bildungs- und Forschungsministerin ist
da im Einzelplan Bildung und Forschung
innovative
software-infrastruktur im Bereich
künstliche Intelligenz und so weiter und
so fort also so stelle ich mir das
eigentlich nicht vor ein Pakt für
Deutschland der digitalisieren soll und
überall da wo ich KI finden kann in
einzelnen Einzelplänen kürzen Sie ich
finde das sehr schade
sie kündigen nur an aber sie setzen
nicht um und nicht mal in den Bereichen
wo sie als Regierung wirklich die
Möglichkeit haben in diesem Entwurf ich
setze meine Hoffnung jetzt auf die
Kollegen von der Ampel und auf unsere
gemeinsamen Haushaltsberatungen dass wir
dann noch einiges zum Guten wenden
können danke schön
kerstin radamski war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und einen Redner haben
wir jetzt noch zum Abschluss dieser
Generaldebatte das ist er hat Grundel
für die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren für die Alte Synagoge
in der Reichenbachstraße in München
konnte im Juni das Richtfest gefeiert
werden der Wiederaufbau dieser Synagoge
ist bemerkenswert die Stadt München der
Freistaat Bayern die Bundesregierung und
ein unglaubliches Engagement aus der
Gesellschaft heraus hat diesen
Wiederaufbau möglich gemacht diese
Synagoge ist Zeugin deutscher Geschichte
und Geschichte erledigt sich nicht
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder hat
kürzlich ein antisemitisches Flugblatt
aus dem Schulranzen seine
Stellvertreters als besonders eklig
bezeichnet als ginge es hier um eine
Geschmacksfrage der Umgang mit
menschenverachtenden ist keine
Geschmacksfrage
unsere gemeinsame Erinnerungspolitik ist
eine der bedeutendsten Errungenschaften
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland unsere
Erinnerungskultur ist nicht ohne
Selbsterkenntnis und der Übernahme von
Verantwortung möglich wir haben uns
bisher gemeinsam dieser Verantwortung
gestellt
zur änderungskultur gehört natürlich die
Erkenntnis dass die deutsche
Nationalsozialisten 1933 nicht von
irgendwoher oder von einem Raumschiff
heruntergebimt wurden und natürlich auch
die schmerzliche Erkenntnis heute mehr
denn je dass das nationalsozialistische
rassistische und antisemitische
Gedankengut
1945 eben nicht für immer besiegt wurde
[Applaus]
es geht immer um mehr als um den Blick
zurück aktive Erinnerungskultur er
richtet sich auf Gegenwart und Zukunft
sie sucht nach weltanschaulichen
Kontinuitäten sie schließt Wissenslücken
und sie steht derzeit vor großen neuen
Aufgaben es geht um
Geschichtsvermittlung in unserer
Einwanderungsgesellschaft es geht darum
bewährte Programme wie Jugend erinnert
zu stärken es geht um die Restitution
von NS Raubgut aus jüdischen Vorbesitz
und die Stärkung der Rechte der
Nachkommen es geht darum neue Formate zu
finden für die Zeit in der uns die
ZeitzeugInnen mit ihrem Wissen und ihren
Erfahrungen nicht mehr zur Seite stehen
es geht um die Aufarbeitung deutscher
kolonialverbrechen um die Restitution
von Raubgut aus kolonialen Kontext und
die Rückgabe von menschlichen Gebeinen
umso wichtiger ist es dass der
Kulturhaushalt 2024 auf hohen Niveau
stabil ist umso wichtiger ist es die
Erinnerungskultur weiter zu stärken ich
hoffe darauf
dass dieses Anliegen ohne Abstriche
Regierung linke und Union im Deutschen
Bundestag
herzlichen Dank
er hat Grundel war das der letzte Redner
hier in der generalaussprache gut vier
Stunden oder fast genau vier Stunden
muss man sagen gab es hier diesen
Schlagabtausch zum Etat des
Bundeskanzlers und Bundeskanzleramtes
rein Formalia obwohl der weniger als ein
Prozent des Gesamthaushaltes ausmacht
Olaf Scholz der Bundeskanzler hat den
Bundesländern den Kommunen und der
demokratischen Opposition einen
sogenannten Deutschland packt heute
vorgeschlagen also eine beschleunigte
Modernisierung das Landes der
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz der
aber vor ihm übrigens sprach der hat die
Politik der Ampel zumindest einmal
massiv kritisiert und hat stolz auch
vorgeworfen die Zeiten während die er
selbst
ausgerufen hat nicht mit Leben zu füllen
beispielsweise hat mehr als gewarnt vor
einer
Unterfinanzierung der Bundeswehr da sind
wir beim Stichwort was kommt heute noch
an Einzelplänen hier an diesen zweiten
Tag der Haushaltsberatung auf den
Deutschen Bundestag auf die Abgeordneten
hierzu sie sehen Annalena Bär Bock die
Außenministerin hier auf der
Regierungsbank sitzen denn ihr tat der
das auswärtigen der ist jetzt hier in
den nächsten anderthalb Stunden zu
verhandeln und am im Verlauf des
Weiteren nachmittags dann eben auch noch
Stichwort Bundeswehr der
Verteidigungshaushalt Boris Pistorius
sehen wir dann hier noch mal erleben
werden und um das Ganze komplett zu
machen was der Tag noch bringt der
Verkehrs und digital Italien jetzt aber
erstmal der Auftrag zum Auswärtigen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der letzte Freitag war für
Millionen von Mädchen und Jungen in der
Ukraine eigentlich ein besonderer Tag
denn am ersten September hat in der
Ukraine eigentlich für alle Kinder das
neue Schuljahr begonnen
der Schulstart ist normalerweise in der
Ukraine ein Festtag noch viel größer als
bei uns bei Einschulungsfeiern für
Erstklässler mit Blumen im Haar mit ganz
vielen Süßigkeiten mit Familie und
Freundinnen und Freunden
seit 559 Tagen ist aber nichts mehr
normal in der Ukraine
viel öfter als die Schulglocke hören die
Kinder dort den Bombenalarm
weil sie seit
559 Tagen im Krieg leben
laut Unicef können weiterhin nur ein
Drittel der ukrainischen
schulpflichtigen Kinder
regelmäßig die Schule besuchen
seit Beginn des Krieges wurden jeden
zweiten Tag eine Schule zerstört
und zwar ganz bewusst eine Schule ganz
gezielt
ein Bruch des Völkerrechts ein Bruch der
Menschlichkeit
mein ukrainische Amtskollege dimitro
Kollege hat mir vor ein paar Tagen beim
EU-Außenministerin Treffen in Toledo von
der Schule in seinem Heimatdorf erzählt
auch hier sollte am 1 September
eigentlich wieder die Schule starten
aber ein paar Tage vorher als alle
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer im Land den
Schulstart vorbereiteten kreiste in
diesem kleinen Ort über der Schule eine
Drohne nur eine einzige Drohne über dem
Ort ganz gezielt über dieser Schule und
die kreiste und kreiste obwohl die
Kampflinie in der Hauptplatz Sumi
eigentlich relativ weit weg war
nach einigen Kreisen schlug sie zu ganz
gezielt ganz gezielt auf die Schule
mehrere Lehrkräfte wurden getötet
weitere verletzt
der eigentlich schönste Tag im Leben von
Erstklässlern wurde zum Trauertag
warum sage ich das erneut auch hier in
dieser Debatte weil wir aus meiner Sicht
bei unseren Diskussionen der letzten
Wochen manchmal etwas vergessen haben
das mitten in Europa weiterhin ein Krieg
tun jeden Tag
500 59 Tage
ein Krieg der jeden Tag Menschen tötet
der jeden Tag Frauen Männer und Kindern
ihr Zuhause nimmt ein Krieg der uns in
unserer Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
aber auch in unseren wirtschaftlichen
Antworten zu einem neuen denken zwingt
das ist die Lage in der wir den Haushalt
für das nächste Jahr aufstellen
und ja wir müssen alle schmerzhafte
Einschnitte akzeptieren
ich kann jede und jeden verstehen der
auf mehr Spielraum gehofft hätte das
haben wir ja in den letzten anderthalb
Tagen gemeinsam diskutiert aber ich
glaube es hilft relativ wenig
sich einfach was zu wünschen
wir können uns die Schuldenbremse nicht
wegwischen trotz der Zeitenwende so
ehrlich müssen wir sein gibt es
schlichtweg und zwar hier im gesamten
deutschen Bundestag nicht die nötige
parlamentarische zwei drittelmehrheit um
das zu ändern und deswegen arbeiten wir
mit den Rahmenbedingungen die wir haben
pragmatisch und zielgerichtet
denn das ist das was die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in unserem Land von uns erwarten
und ja
da brauche ich glaube ich keinen Hehl
draus zu machen dass gerade in dieser
Lage in der ein Krieg in Europa tobt
auch mir die Einschnitte in meinem
Einzelplan für das Budget des
Auswärtigen Amtes weh tun
deshalb setzen wir auch hier unter den
gegebenen Rahmenbedingungen die wir nun
mal alle miteinander haben
Prioritäten pragmatisch und
zielgerichtet
erstens werden wir unsere Unterstützung
für die Ukraine fortsetzen solange die
Menschen in der Ukraine das brauchen
mit Waffenlieferungen zur
Selbstverteidigung um weitere Drohnen
abfangen zu können mit humanitärer Hilfe
mit großen entminungsprogrammen und mit
vor allen Dingen politischer
Unterstützung in den Vereinten Nationen
der EU der NATO aber und das darf man
nicht vergessen und ich bin da gerade
den zuständigen Abgeordneten dieses
Hauses sehr dankbar gerade auch mit der
Unterstützung der OSZE und des
Europarates denn es geht hier auch um
die Sicherung unserer Friedensordnung in
Europa
und zweitens
wir investieren
prioritär und stärker als zuvor in
unsere globalen Partnerschaften die
Zusammenarbeit mit unseren engen
Partnern in Europa und den USA bleibt
wichtig aber es wird in Zukunft noch
stärker darauf ankommen wie wir mit
Ländern zusammenarbeiten deren
Freundschaft wir in den letzten Jahren
vielleicht als etwas zu
selbstverständlich hingenommen haben
wir senden daher nicht nur ein klares
Signal das sagt wir vergessen euch nicht
auch wenn in Europa ein Krieg tobt wir
vergessen nicht eure Sicherheit sorgen
sondern wir sagen auch sehr deutlich so
wie ihr auf der Welt für uns Europäer da
seid wenn die europäische
Friedensordnung angegriffen wird so sind
wir für euch da
zum Beispiel jetzt für unsere Partner
von eco was
denn wie sagte meine senegalesische
Kollegin die gerade hier zu Besuch in
Berlin war so richtig
wenn eine Demokratie weggeputscht wird
dann können andere Demokratien nicht
einfach weggehen
deswegen haben wir auf
deutsch-französische Initiative hin eine
eu-sanktionsregime angestoßen mit dem
wir unsere Partner in Westafrika genau
jetzt noch stärker unterstützen können
denn unsere Partnerschaften sind für uns
das spüren wir das haben wir in der
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie
verankert überlebenswichtig
wenn es darum geht unsere Sicherheit zu
verteidigen aber auch wenn es darum geht
die Klimakrise einzudämmen die größte
Sicherheitsgefahr weltweit
und auch wenn wir für Menschen
Verantwortung übernehmen die unsere
Hilfe dringend weltweit brauchen
auf der ganzen Welt gehen fast 800
Millionen Menschen jede Nacht hungrig
ins Bett
deswegen war es mir wichtig dass wir
weiterhin einen schlagkräftiges Budget
für humanitäre Hilfe haben mit einem
pragmatischen Ansatz der ist uns erlaubt
schnell zu handeln und ja auch hier
mussten wir gewaltige Einschnitte
hinnehmen aber wir haben uns in der
Koalition gemeinsam darauf verständigt
dass wir Spielräume nutzen werden und
man Hock auf neue Krisen mit humanitärer
Hilfe reagieren zu können
wir investieren in unsere
Partnerschaften auch mit schnelleren
digitalen visa-verfahren und mit einer
starken auswärtigen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik denn gerade für die
Fachkräftegewinnung braucht es mehr als
deutschangebote weltweit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
befinden uns im größten Außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen Umbruch seit Ende
des Kalten Krieges
das haben wir uns nicht ausgesucht aber
wir können entscheiden jeden Tag aufs
neue wie wir darauf reagieren
und das tun wir geschlossen europäisch
gemeinsam mit unseren weltweiten
Partnern damit auch den Schülerinnen und
Schülern in der Ukraine irgendwann auch
wenn wir nicht wissen wann die
Schulglocke vertrauter klingt als der
Bombenalarm für ein friedliches und
freies Europa für die Sicherheit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
herzlichen Dank
die bundesaußenministerin Annalena
beerburg hier zum Auftakt ihre
[Applaus]
etab-05 ist das in der
haushaltssysteme gut anderthalb Stunden
sind dafür vorgesehen er ist ja jetzt
hier Präsident
ich möchte für die cdu/csu-fraktionen
sagen dass wir die Einschätzung der
bundesaußenministerin was die
Herausforderungen für die westliche Welt
für Europa für Deutschland angeht teilen
ich halte es für einen Wert an sich dass
wir einen breiten Konsens im Deutschen
Bundestag haben in der Mitte dieses
Hauses ganz links und ganz rechts unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender hat das heute
morgen schon angesprochen
der eindeutig ist und der klar ist und
der diese russische Aggression niemals
akzeptieren wird es darf nicht so sein
dass im 21 Jahrhundert eine atomar
bewaffnete revanchistische Kraft wieder
landgewinne macht das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen wir müssen hier zusammen stehen
und die regelbasierte Ordnung
verteidigen
dafür sind wir zusammengerückt und haben
unter anderem das Sondervermögen
verabschiedet das ist Ausdruck dieser
Einigkeit das war ein weiter Weg für
manche und das möchte ich noch mal sagen
von der Bemerkung des Bundeskanzlers
heute was den Zustand der Bundeswehr
angeht der in der Tat
an manchen Stellen wirklich
beklagenswert ist und niemand aus der
Union hat je bestritten dass wir dafür
politische Verantwortung getragen haben
und auch weiterhin tragen
in
Deutschland bloß Herr Kollege Kossel
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde der
sozialdemokratischen Fraktion sie haben
zwei Prozent verhindert wir hätten sie
gewollt sie waren es sie waren dagegen
Finanzminister Scholz war dagegen und
sie haben noch Bundestagswahlkampf gegen
die Bundeswehr und gegen bessere
Finanzausstattung der Bundeswehr gemacht
das ist schon noch teil
der Wahrheit und ich muss sagen wenn man
sich heute hinstellt und sagt ja wir
brauchen dann 20 26 27 30 Milliarden
Euro
dann ist doch der Punkt gerade derjenige
den Friedrich Merz heute morgen auch
gemacht hat es ist doch völlig
illusorisch denken Sie doch noch mal an
ihre finanzauseinandersetzungen und die
Finanzierung der Kindergrundsicherung
zwischen 12 und 2 Milliarden sind sie
bei 2,4 Milliarden gelandet ist doch
völlig illusorisch dass irgendeine
Wunderkiste sich 2027 öffnet aus der
dann ein Finanzminister 30 Milliarden
herausnimmt sie arbeiten was die
Bundeswehr angeht mit ungedeckten Checks
und das ist unverantwortlich
und wenn sie die Situation eindringlich
und richtig und traurig in der Ukraine
jetzt schildern Frau Außenministerin
dann kann ich auch der Ampel insgesamt
nicht ersparen dass die gesamte
Kriegssituation die wir vorfinden und
die zu dem nur langsam zu der langsamen
gegen Offensive mit hohen Verlusten der
Ukraine führt eine Situation ist die
daran liegt dass Deutschland zu spät
geliefert hat der Bundestag hatte schon
im vergangenen Frühjahr gab starke
Initiativen aus denen aus den
Koalitionsfraktionen klar beschlossen
schwere Waffen zu liefern und es ist
ihre gemeinsame politische Verantwortung
dass diese Waffen so spät geliefert
wurden das hat es in Russen ermöglicht
sich einzugraben und alles zu vermieden
und darunter leidet in der Kriegsführung
jetzt die Ukraine die ganze
Situation militärisches Dilemma was wir
jetzt dort in der Ukraine erleben das
tut mir leid das können Sie nicht nur
auf die Zögerlichkeit des Herrn
Bundeskanzlers schieben sondern dafür
tragen auch Sie die politische
Verantwortung meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren
nach zwei Jahren kann man ja so eine
erste Zwischenbilanz Frau
Außenministerin ziehen und ich muss
sagen wir sind stark desillusioniert sie
sind ideenlos in vielen Bereichen
konzeptionslos und stehen mit leeren
Händen da das gilt ja selbst für
Vorzeigeprojekte wie die feministische
Außenpolitik die sie formulieren die Sie
für sich in Anspruch nehmen die aber
leider nur schöne Worte sind wenn es um
die Situation beispielsweise der Frauen
im Iran gibt die Bundesregierung nutzt
keine ihrer Möglichkeiten um auf dieses
Regime im Iran wirklich Druck auszuüben
und die Situation der Menschen dort und
der Frauen wirklich zu verbessern die
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie ein
Vorzeigeprojekt deutlich verzögert am
Ende ein Torso weshalb weil die
bundesaußenministerin dagegen war dass
wir ein Nationalen Sicherheitsrat
einrichten obwohl alle Fachleute sagen
wir brauchen eine koordinierende
analysierende aber auch die Reaktion
Ionen steuernde Stelle in der
Bundesregierung die FDP hat das klar
gefordert an der Stelle konnte sie sich
nicht durchsetzen die sonst ja an
manchen Stellen in jüngerer Zeit schon
aber man muss sagen die nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie in der Form ist das
Papier nicht wert auf dem auf dem sie
steht
und ihre Reisen die letzte missglückte
Reise steht ein bisschen exemplarisch
für den Anspruch den Sie damit verbinden
das kommt mir immer mehr zu groß
Inszenierung der Außenministerin und
nicht zu arbeitsbesuchen die stattfinden
müssen
sie verstoßen ja selber gegen den
eigenen Grundsatz mehr Linie zu fliegen
gerade bei der letzten Reise wäre das
glaube ich mal ganz wichtig gewesen aber
warum haben Sie nicht die Chance genutzt
dort in der Region dann besuche
nachzuholen der Kollege Trittin bei der
Arabischen Liga zu diskutieren warum
Syrien viele aufgenommen wird mit
Saudi-Arabien zu besprechen ob es
richtig ist bei Brix einzutreten außer
Ministerin heißt nach draußen gehen
Diplomatie Gespräche führen da sein in
der Region sein jetzt auch in der Sahel
Region sein das was sie dort machen ist
Arbeitsverweigerung vor Außenministerin
da erwarten wir von der Amtsinhaberin
mehr
und Stichwort Sahel dass die Lämmer in
dem wir uns befinden ist erheblich ihre
Verantwortung das BMVg wollte schon im
letzten Jahr verlangt recht damals noch
raus und hat gesagt der Auftrag ist
nicht mehr ausführbar
Bundesminister Pistorius hat gleich nach
Amtsantritt gesagt das ist nicht
sinnvoll dass wir dort bleiben
cdu/csu-fraktion hat mehrere Anfragen
Anmahnung gestellt und am Ende haben wir
gesagt dass man tatsächlich mir nicht
fort sie haben uns gesagt dass sei
unverantwortlich wir würden unsere
internationale Verantwortung nicht
wahrnehmen sie haben uns gesagt zum
31.12 können wir gar nicht rausgehen
jetzt wird uns gesagt zum 31.12 schaffen
wir es und wir müssen es schnell
schaffen aber wir sind in einer hohen
Gefahrensituation für die Soldaten und
Soldaten und wir hoffen dass wir Sie
alle herausbekommen es gibt einen hohe
Gefahr dass wir viel Material dort
verlieren meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren kann es ihnen nicht ersparen in
diese Situation sind wir in den
Blindflug rein geflogen sie haben das
alles mitgemacht was die Außenministerin
an der Stelle wollte das war nicht
notwendig und an der Stelle ist es ihre
politische Verantwortung dass wir hier
vor einem Trümmerhaufen in der Sahelzone
der deutschen Politik stehen und das
Soldaten Soldaten sich dort in
erheblichen Gefahren befinden wir können
nur hoffen dass alles am Ende gut geht
aber diese Gefahr wäre nicht nötig
gewesen danke schön
massive Kritik von Johann warde wohl dem
unionsfraktionsvize der hier der
bundesaußenministerin sogar
Arbeitsverweigerung vorwarf zum Teil
oder zwei Jahren Zwischenbilanz und
sagte er sei man Ideen und
konzeptionslos im Auswärtigen Amt
schwere Waffen so noch mal sein Vorwurf
sein zu spät an die Ukraine geliefert
worden wegen der Zögerlichkeit in der
ampelregierung
und zwar in den Februar als Teil der
Türkei und Syriens von einem schweren
Erdbeben zerstört wurden Deutschland hat
unmittelbar nach dem Leben
Rettungsdienst und die betroffenen
Regionen entsandt diese Soforthilfen
sind Teil unserer deutschen Außenpolitik
das Deutsche Rote Kreuz war nur ein Tag
nach dem Leben vor Ort und die Suche
Bergungsteams vom Technischen Hilfswerk
wurden ebenfalls in mindest eine
mobilisiert unsere Katastrophenschutz
haben also sehr schnell herausragende
Hilfe geleistet und dafür möchte ich
allen Helferinnen und Helfern an dieser
Stelle einmal meinen großen Dank
aussprechen
das Beispiel unserer Nothilfe im
türkischen Grenzgebiet macht deutlich
dass wir sehr schnell reagieren können
und was wir da sind wenn es darauf
ankommt es macht deutlich dass wir zu
unserer internationalen Verantwortung
stehen und auch wenn der Etat des
Auswärtigen Amtes im nächsten Jahr
voraussichtlich kleine ausfällt
Deutschland war immer verlässlich und
wird es auch bleiben
viele Menschen in der Türkei und in
Syrien sind infolge des Erdbebens auf
humanitäre Hilfe angewiesen nach den
Soforthilfen geht es jetzt um den
Wiederaufbau und darum die Folgen des
Unglücks ab zum Federn dabei werden die
Türkei und Syrien unter anderem vom
Bundesministerium für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung
unterstützt hier möchte ich noch mal
betonen dass die Zusammenarbeit der
beiden Häuser also Auswärtiges Amt und
Bundes-
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Programme die Prognosen für die Zukunft
erstellen sie sind auch schon bei uns im
Einsatz und arbeiten unter anderem mit
künstlicher Intelligenz ziel ist es dass
Notlagen im voraus erkannt werden und
dadurch besser eingedämmt werden können
so lassen sich letztlich auch die
Haushaltsmittel effektiver und
effizienter einsetzen die
IT der Bundesverwaltung wird und muss
dafür in den nächsten Jahren weiter
ausgebaut werden auch weil die
cybersicherheit immer wichtiger wird ich
denke da sind wir uns alle einig
die Digitalisierung war schon in den
vergangenen beiden Jahren ein
Schwerpunkt von uns ampelhaushältern und
sie wird es auch bleiben wenn wir jetzt
in die Beratung zum Haushalt 24 gehen
wir wollen das Thema unbedingt
voranbringen
digitale Lösung spielen auch bei der
Visum und passvergabe für ausländische
Fachkräfte eine wichtige Rolle lassen
Sie mich das mal anhand des Bundesamtes
für auswärtige Angelegenheiten erläutern
die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter des
Amtes kümmern sich bei uns zentral um
die Vergabe der Visa die von Deutschland
aus bearbeitet werden der Bedarf ist
hier groß und wir wissen ja alle dass
wir diese dieser Verfahren brauchen das
Bundesamt für auswärtige Angelegenheiten
möchte ab dem nächsten Jahr etwa 100.000
dieser Bearbeitung pro Jahr erreichen
und damit man sich das besser vorstellen
kann das ist eine Vervielfachung und
darum wird es auch gehen wenn wir jetzt
in die parlamentarischen Beratung
einsteigen dass wir alles daran setzen
die Vorteile der Digitalisierung voll
für uns zu nutzen
ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch mal ein
Beispiel nennen wo wir schon weit
gekommen sind das ist das auslandsportal
was auslandsportal ist die digitale
Plattform des Bundes über das sich
künftig viele Anträge online erledigen
lassen für die man bisher in eine
Botschaft gehen musste so sollen zum
Beispiel deutsche die im Ausland leben
über das auslandsportal ihren Reisepass
oder Personalausweis online beantragen
können hier läuft derzeit unter anderem
in London und Oslo ein Pilotprojekt ziel
muss es sein die weltweit rund 230
deutschen Vertretungen im Ausland soweit
nach vorne zu bringen das
Papierformulare durch schnelle
digitalanträge ersetzt werden ein
wichtiges vorliegen
wir investieren also in die
Digitalisierung und entlasten damit
unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
Unternehmen und Behörden außerdem sorgen
dafür dass wir auch international weiter
zusammenhalten
und hier möchte ich zum Schluss noch auf
ein anderes Thema zu sprechen kommen was
mir sehr am Herzen liegt unsere
auswärtige Bildungspolitik hier geht es
mir vor allem um die Förderung der
deutschen Sprache Sprache verbindet wer
sich versteht kommt schneller zusammen
und das wollen wir ja dass ich Menschen
verstehen sich an einen Tisch setzen und
sich austauschen ich will das mal an
einem Beispiel aus meinem Wahlkreis
deutlich machen der Landkreis Prignitz
Nordwesten Brandenburgs arbeitet seit
einigen Jahren mit dem Kreis Alba in
Rumänien zusammen das liegt in
Siebenbürgen und zentral Rumänien
kürzlich war die Delegation um unseren
Landrat dort und bei diesem Besuch wurde
beschlossen diese Partnerschaft
auszubauen unter anderem bei der dualen
Ausbildung bei Praktika und beim
Austausch von Azubis
einige dieser junge Menschen möchten
vielleicht später für uns nach
Deutschland kommen um hier zu arbeiten
und zu leben und andere nehmen
vielleicht einen Job bei einem deutschen
Unternehmen in der Niederlassung in
Rumänien sagen wenn es also um
berufsschancen geht hilft es sehr wenn
man in der Schule Deutsch gelernt oder
an einem Austausch nach Deutschland
teilgenommen hat und was heißt das nun
für unsere deutsche Außenpolitik
die Bundesrepublik fördert gezielt
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die an
staatlichen Schulen und
Bildungseinrichtungen in Rumänien
deutschunterrichten und das ist nur
eines von vielen Beispielen das zeigt
die wir weltweit unsere Sprache fördern
als Haushälterin ist mir diese
Sprachförderung ein besonderes Anliegen
und deshalb nehme ich auch dieses Thema
jetzt mit in die Beratung ich freue mich
auf Ihre breite Unterstützung vielen
Dank
das Wort für die AFD hat Dr Michaela
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im
Saarland bei Youtube und natürlich sehr
geehrte Frau Außenministerin wir haben
heute den 6 September 2023 noch immer
sind die Strompreise in Deutschland
ebenso astronomisch hoch wie die Preise
für Gas Öl Benzin oder hier sind sie
etwas gefallen Lebensmittel der
Lebensstandard beginnt für immer mehr
Menschen in Deutschland zu sinken Jobs
gehen verloren während Unternehmen aus
dem Land abwandern oder dicht machen das
liegt natürlich zum einen an der
dümmsten Energiepolitik der Welt wie das
Wall Street Journal einmal so
schmerzhaft treffend auf den es auf den
Punkt gebracht hat und es liegt an viel
zu hohen Steuern Abgaben und einer irren
Bürokratie kurz um an einer grünen
industrievernichtungspolitik
es liegt aber auch an der deutschen
Außenpolitik wenn wir also heute über
den Etat des Auswärtigen Amtes sprechen
dann reden wir nicht nur über die 6,2
Milliarden Euro die das Haus von Frau
baerbock den Steuerzahlern direkt kostet
sondern wir müssen auch über die
indirekten Kosten reden die die Politik
der ampelregierung in Deutschland
verursacht Frau bärbock sie wissen
vermutlich schon worauf ich hinaus will
seit Beginn des ukrainekrieges die nach
unsere Fraktion klar verurteilt erzählen
wir Ihnen hier wieder und wieder und
wieder das Sanktion gegen Russland die
falsche diplomatische Antwort auf diese
Angriffskrieg sind und wieder und wieder
haben wir ihnen gesagt dass wir damit
nicht Russland Schaden sondern uns
selbst unserem Land unserem
Industriestandort und unserem Wohlstand
und jetzt haben wir den Salat und das
Geheule ist wieder mal groß exemplarisch
darf man sich das aktuelle Cover des
Magazins der Spiegel anschauen alle
schaffen Wachstum wenig steht dazu lesen
während alle anderen Länder positive
Wachstumsraten haben hat Deutschland
negative Wachstumsraten glücklicherweise
hat man in dieser Grafik Bundesland
weggelassen aber selbst dort rechnet man
mit einem vip-wachstum von 1,5
Prozentpunkten und siehe da nachdem wir
ihn genau das von Anfang an prophezeit
haben und sie nach anderthalb Jahren
nicht mehr an der Realität vorbeikommen
sagen sie selbst Frau bärburg ich
zitiere eigentlich hätte
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen
wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen das ist
aber nicht so Zitat Ende und auch da
muss ich sie korrigieren Frau beerburg
ihre Sanktion haben wirtschaftliche
Auswirkungen und zwar negative aber eben
nicht auf Russland sondern auf uns
selbst
das Land dem sie mit Sanktion Schaden
wollten hat ein Wirtschaftswachstum
während unsere Wirtschaft schrumpft das
Schrumpfen unserer Wirtschaft sieht man
exemplarisch auch an den gelb-abflüssen
aus Deutschland rund 125 Milliarden Euro
an direkt Investitionen flossen 2022 aus
Deutschland ab als im gleichen Zeitraum
in die Bundesrepublik investiert wurde
das heißt konkret das deutsche
Unternehmen im Ausland ca 135 Milliarden
Euro investiert haben während
ausländische Unternehmen in Deutschland
gerade einmal 10,5 Milliarden investiert
haben es geht also viel mehr raus als
rein Faktor 13 dass das ein
Riesenproblem ist liegt auf der Hand und
da wäre es an der Zeit dass sie als
Außenministerin sich mal an ihre
kernaufnahme erinnern und zwar die
Vertretung deutscher Interessen es wäre
an der Zeit dass sie mal ihren Charm
spielen lassen ein paar Staatsbesuche
machen und neue ernsthafte
Partnerschaften auf Augenhöhe begründen
aber sie machen leider das Gegenteil
dazu wird der Kollege kräuterweise
gleich noch ausführlich ausführen ich
will stattdessen noch auf einen anderen
Punkt eingehen den ich Ihnen und Ihrer
gesamten ampelregierung besonders übel
nehme weil er unserem Land im
internationalen Ansehen in einem Ausmaß
geschadet hat dass wir jetzt noch gar
nicht vorausberechnen können als am 26
September letzten Jahres die Nord Stream
Pipelines gesprengt wurden von Namen von
dieser Bundesregierung im Wesentlichen
nichts als Schweigen es gab keine
Empörung über diese Anschlag auf unsere
Infrastruktur und damit auf den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland es gab
auch keine ernsthaften
Aufklärungsbemühungen jeder auf dieser
großen weiten Welt hat gesehen dass
Deutschland nicht in der Lage ist seine
Infrastruktur zu schützen und dass seine
Regierung weder will uns noch in der
Lage ist die Verantwortlichen für diesen
Anschlag zu finden und zu verantworten
zu ziehen
jeder hat gesehen dass wir schwach
verwundbar und angreifbar sind und dass
wir uns selbst dann nicht wehren wenn
einer unserer wirtschaftlichen
Lebensadern angegriffen wird wer soll
uns denn bitte international noch ernst
nehmen durch diese Regierung sind wir
von einer weltweit respektierten und
führenden Industrienationen zu einem
internationalen Witz geworden und es ist
kein Wunder dass jetzt auch ihre
heißgeliebten EU-Partner mehr und mehr
ihr eigenes Ding machen Spanien und
Belgien zum Beispiel sind jetzt nach
China die zweit- und drittgrößten
Importeure von russischem LNG trotz
Sanktion da geht sie hin ihre
Solidarität in der EU ab jetzt heißt es
ganz offenbar rette sich wer kann und
glücklicherweise erkennen das auch jeden
Tag mehr Wähler in Deutschland ich danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
der Kollege hat das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nach der letzten Rede tut es
gut und ist wichtig immer wieder daran
zu erinnern dass wir Deutsche nicht
alleine auf der Welt sind wir leben
davon dass wir funktionierende
internationale Beziehungen haben
Partnerschaften Bündnisse und nicht
zurückfallen in völkische Aussenpolitik
wir leben davon
dass wir die Bedrohungen ernst nehmen in
denen wir stehen und wir sind bedroht es
war gut dass die Außenminister hat noch
mal auch in welcher Kriegssituation
tatsächlich ein großer Teil dieses
Kontinent ist nämlich die Ukraine
weiterhin in diesem Situation eines
brutalen Angriffs aus Russland und wir
sollten in der Tat überlegen was wir
noch zusätzlich tun können damit die
Ukraine diesen Verteidigungskampf
gewinnt und zwar auch schnell der Faktor
Zeit spielt eine Rolle und da werden
dann auch weitere Lieferungen
zusätzliche sowie Taurus eine Rolle
spielen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Sommerpause die in der Außenpolitik
wahrlich keine ist übrigens ist das Wort
von der Sommerpause falscher an der
Außenpolitik hat uns das gezeigt bei
allen Ereignissen der Niger natürlich
aber auch wenn wir Richtung Putin und
rigorien blicken aber ganz besonders war
das der Fall in dem Bereich mit bricks
und China es ist gut dass wir kurz vor
der Sommerpause genauer gesagt die
Bundesregierung eine China Strategie
beschlossen hat die ist international
sehr wohlwollend aufgenommen worden das
muss man sagen ja wir haben lange darum
gerungen als Fraktionen auch Input zu
geben in der Tat aber es war wichtig und
sehr wichtig dass tatsächlich am Ende
dann auch sowohl das gar nicht
Kooperation als auch Menschenrechte
beides deutlich angesprochen wurde die
krassen Menschenrechtsverletzungen die
durch China Geschehen genauso wie unser
kooperationswunsch denn wir wollen ja
nicht Konfrontation wir wollen dort
Kooperation womöglich aber nicht um den
Preis das Aufgeben von Werten allerdings
müssen wir uns fragen
und da kommt der Punkt bricks ins Spiel
und das war für mich das entscheidende
Datum diesen Sommer was uns und die
deutsche Außenpolitik und
Entwicklungspolitik jetzt massiv
beschäftigen muss die nächsten Wochen
und Monate wie reagieren wir wie
reagieren wir auf diese Herausforderung
Durchblicks brexit keine homogene
Staatengruppe Brasilien Russland Indien
China Südafrika aber sie wird jetzt
größer und sie könnte sich in der Tat
sondern echten gegenorganisation
entwickeln gegen G7 gegen den Westen
wenn wir nicht aufpassen und deshalb
müssen wir und das ist glaube ich ein
Punkt wo wir ein bisschen Selbstkritik
auch üben müssen müssen wir überlegen
wie können wir gegenüber diesen Staaten
mehr auf ihre Interessen achten mehr
zuhören die Präsidentin die Chefin des
der WHO gestern war ja eingeladen Frau
Außenministerin von ihnen Frau Konto
idealer und sie hat selbst und sie
stammt aus Nigeria daran erinnert dass
vieles vom Auftreten eben unserer
Staaten manchmal einfach zu belehrend zu
von oben herab rüberkommt also wie
können wir mehr
können wir tatsächlich mehr kooperativ
machen damit wir weniger starten in
diese Abhängigkeit der Einflussnahme aus
China und Russland sozusagen ist ihnen
überlassen das ist die große
Herausforderung vor der wir stehen und
die wird nicht funktionieren wenn wir
sozusagen nur belehrend auftreten wir
müssen überlegen wie können wir Ihnen
entgegenkommen das ist glaube ich eine
ganz große Aufgabe der wir uns gemeinsam
stellen müssen natürlich aber auch
insgesamt hier als Parlament
Michael Georg Klink war das für die
FDP-Fraktion hier in der Aussprache zum
Einzelplan des Auswärtigen Amtes und
jetzt erwarten wir Gregor Gysi für die
Fraktion
die Linke
deren außenpolitischer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
bringt Putins imperiales denken zum
Ausdruck seine Sicherheitsinteressen
kann Russland anders durchsetzen die
Ukraine hat das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung und wir müssen
solidarisch mit ihr sein woran es aber
bei der Bundesregierung fehlt ist eine
Anerkennung von Realitäten diese
gefallen mir auch nicht aber es hilft ja
nichts der generalstaatschef der USA
general Melli also der höchste Soldat
des Landes nach dem Präsidenten kommt
zur Einschätzung dass die Ukraine den
Krieg nicht gewinnen kann auch nicht mit
aller Unterstützung der NATO wir
brauchen also einen Waffenstillstand und
Verhandlungen mir wird entgegnet dass
Putin für einen Waffenstillstand nicht
bereit sein was halten sie von folgender
Idee mit Einverständnis der ukrainischen
Führung könnte die NATO doch erklären
dass sie vorübergehend keine einzige
Waffe mehr an die Ukraine gelieferte
wenn die russische Führung einem
Waffenstillstand zustimmte das setzte
diese beachtlich unter Druck das
Ergebnis stand von Friedensverhandlungen
muss einer auch vom Westen gesicherte
Ukraine sein die Alternative sie wollen
den Sieg der Ukraine aber was heißt das
das haben die Nato und auch die
Bundesregierung nie erklärt ist gemeint
dass die Russen das dornbird-gebiet zu
verlassen haben oder es gemeint dass sie
auch die Krim zu verlassen haben oder
ist etwas Drittes gemeint geht das
Abkommen von mindestens zwei noch für
die Krim danach sollte er zu einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt wieder über die
Krim verhandelt werden übrigens hat die
Ukraine Minz zwei verletzt denn das
Gebiet wurde nicht innerhalb der Ukraine
für autonom erklärt und es fanden auch
keine Regionalbahn und da auch sich der
urzeite statt ich weiß es gibt nur einen
bösen und guten so einfach ist die Welt
leider nicht denken Sie an den jungen
auch dort gab es ein militärisches hat
und sehr viel Ruhe wurde und ich
Verhandlungen über China erreicht
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
nannte den Abzug der russischen Truppen
von ukrainischen Gebiet als
Voraussetzung vereinbarstillstand gut
aber was machen Sie wenn Russland diesen
Weg nicht geht wollen sie noch für viele
Jahre tote verletzte und Zerstörungen in
Kauf nehmen der Berater selensky sagte
mir bei Maischberger dass sie bei der
Frühjahrsoffensive die Krim zurückholen
werden nun ist schon fast der Sommer um
aber die Krim ist nach wie von den
Händen Russlands die Sanktionen treffen
unsere Bevölkerung härter als Russland
Länder wie Brasilien Argentinien
Südafrika und Indien können den
Moralismus der NATO der EU der
Bundesregierung und vor allem der USA
nicht nachvollziehen denn er galt nicht
bei der israelischen Besetzung der
Golanhöhen nicht beim völkerrechtspflege
kriegt der NATO gegen Serbien nicht bei
der Abtrennung des Kosovo die einem noch
heute gültigen Beschluss des
Sicherheitsrates widerspricht und auch
nicht während des Völkerrecht
der USA anderer gegen den Irak es ist
kein Zufall dass die Gemeinschaft der
bricks also Brasilien Russland Indien
China Südafrika wächst sechs neue
Mitglieder mit Beginn des Jahres 2024 14
weitere Länder haben einen Antrag auf
Mitgliedschaft gestellt schon mit ihrer
ersten Erweiterung entsteht ein Bündnis
mit mehr als der Hälfte der
Weltbevölkerung diese Länder wollen
keine basalen der USA sein und eine
Währung gegen den Dollar aufbauen
übrigens will Frankreich auch teilweise
sein die Bundesregierung scheint es
gerne zu sein
kurz nach dem Beginn des Angriffskrieges
Russlands gegen die Ukraine war ich mit
einer leitenden Diplomatin der
US-amerikanischen Botschaft verabredet
ich fragte sie ob man sich befürchten
müsse das bricht sich zu einer neuen
Blockbildung erweitere sie verneinte
dies weil die Widersprüche zwischen
Indien und China zu groß sein nun kommt
es aber doch dazu das geologische denken
das fehlt leider das globale denken
fehlt leider der große deutsche
Sozialdemokrat Egon Bahr sagte einmal
vor Schülerinnen und Schülern das ist in
der Außenpolitik immer um Interessen
ginge nie um Werte auch wenn häufig das
Gegenteil behauptet werden würde die
gigantische Aufrüstung die der Haushalt
ohne Widerspruch von einem Lindner
vorsieht während er bei allen sozialen
Fragen immer auf die Knappen
kassenverweis es überhaupt nicht nötig
Schweden und Finnland wollen
beziehungsweise sind in der NATO weil
sie in ihrer Logo und der Logik der
Bundesregierung von Russland dann nicht
angegriffen werden können weil dies den
Dritten Weltkrieg bedeutet der Russland
vollständig zerstörte wir sind schon in
der NATO und haben mithin auch keinen
Angriff Russland zu befürchten das
zivile die Diplomatie die Abrüstung der
Interessenausgleich und die Einhaltung
des Völkerrechts von allen Seiten sind
unsere wahre Chance zum Schluss möchte
ich mich bei den Mitgliedern des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses für den fairen
Umgang miteinander auch bei
unterschiedlichen Auffassungen bedanken
in Zukunft werden sie die Freude haben
ihre Arbeit ohne mich nachgehen zu
können da ich meine Funktion als
außenpolitischer Sprecher meiner
Fraktion und als Mitglied des
Ausschusses ab der nächsten
Sitzungswoche nicht fortsetzen werden
ich bedauere es dass diese Regierung
bisher keine einzige Initiative an den
Tag gelegt hat die zu mehr Frieden auf
dieser Welt geführt hat ich kenne keine
ich wünsche Ihnen allen trotzdem Erfolg
in Wahrheit
Greger hier ankündigt dass er nicht
weiter aus dem politischer Sprecher der
Linksfraktion sein wird was das bedeutet
für die Zukunft der Linksfraktion für
deren Aufstellung die ja auch im Moment
Probleme hat bei der Nachbesetzung der
Fraktionsspitze das werden dann die
nächsten Wochen zeigen jetzt aber weiter
hier zum Thema zum Auswärtigen ETA
Jamila Schäfer von den Grünen
und Kollegen und lieber Herr Gisi es tut
mir leid zu hören dass die ihre
Funktionen einstellen werden sage ich
aufrichtig
es ist so dass ich aber trotzdem einmal
inhaltlich darauf antworten möchte was
Sie gesagt haben Verhandlungen wollen
wir ja auch wir wollen auch dass die
Waffen endlich schweigen aber weder die
Verhandlungsposition der Ukraine jetzt
in der aktuellen Situation zu schwächen
oder die Unterstützung an sie zu
konditionieren und einzustellen würde
uns einen Zentimeter weiter dorthin
bringen und deshalb haben wir da doch
dann eine ganz andere Auffassung Putin
hat mit seinem Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine die europäische Friedensordnung
Zert und jetzt sollte eigentlich auch
dem letzten begreiflich geworden sein
dass die These vom Ende der Geschichte
ist
es ist eine Frage des ethischen
Anstandes die Ukraine zu unterstützen
aber es ist auch in unser aller
Interesse ihrem Kampf für das
Völkerrecht und die Stärke des Rechts in
der Welt zu verstärken und zu
verteidigen und ist eben nicht
zuzulassen dass die Methode Gewalt sich
durchsetzt und in Zukunft unsere
Weltordnung prägt im übrigen auch um
eine atomare aufrüstungsspirale zu
verhindern wir müssen uns diesen
Aufgaben gemeinsam stellen und das tun
wir auch und dafür gilt mir dank auch
insbesondere unsere Außenministerin
wir haben im letzten Jahr sehr viel über
die notwendigen militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine diskutiert und
auch einiges auf den Weg gebracht das
bleibt auch weiterhin wichtig und
richtig Michael Link hat darauf auch
hingewiesen aber es kommt eben auch
darauf an ob wir es schaffen Putin
diplomatisch auf der Weltbühne zu
isolieren denn am Ende müssen die
diplomatischen und politischen Kosten
für diesen Krieg höher sein als der
Nutzen den er als Autokrat daraus ziehen
kann und dafür braucht unsere
Außenpolitik Handlungsfähigkeit auch in
finanzieller Hinsicht und deshalb ist es
gut dass der Etat des Auswärtigen Amtes
mit
6,155 Milliarden Euro über der
mittelfristigen Finanzplanung liegt bei
die werden nämlich bei 5 Milliarden
gewesen aber es ist eben auch klar dass
die Aufgaben nicht kleiner sondern
größer geworden sind und deshalb lohnt
es sich finde ich auch den Aspekt der
humanitären Hilfe sich noch mal aus
menschlicher Perspektive anzugucken
weltweit sind nach aktuellen Schätzungen
der Vereinten Nation mehr als 326
Millionen Menschen auf humanitäre Hilfe
angewiesen das ist jeder 22 Mensch auf
dieser Erde Tendenz steigend
260 Millionen Menschen sind von akuter
Ernährungsunsicherheit betroffen das
bedeutet diese Menschen haben zu wenig
zu essen deswegen schmälert natürlich
die Kürzungen bei der humanitären Hilfe
unsere internationale Position als
verlässlicher Partner und als Geber und
sie bedeutet natürlich auch dass wir
Hungernden und leidenden Menschen
aktuell nicht genügend zur Seite stehen
können wenn wir daran nichts ändern und
das können wir nicht wollen weder aus
moralischen Gründen noch aus
geopolitischen
wir wissen ja auch alle dass die
Lehrstellen die wir hinterlassen
ausgenutzt werden und zwar von
denjenigen die das Völkerrecht
zurücktreten wollen deswegen brauchen
wir eine aktive Diplomatie und
Weltpolitik und zwar eine die die Fehler
aus der Vergangenheit nicht wiederholt
sondern glaubwürdig für die Stärke des
Völkerrechts und die globale
Gerechtigkeit einsteht und deshalb ist
auch die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik so wichtig sie ist kein
nice to have sondern sie ermöglicht es
uns auf Augenhöhe Beziehung aufzubauen
nicht nur zu Regierung sondern auch zur
Zivilgesellschaft vor uns liegen also
große Aufgaben es geht keine Zeit zu
verlieren deshalb freue ich mich dass
wir jetzt in die Haushaltsberatung
starten ich freue mich aus dem auf dem
Austausch mit dem Auswärtigen Amt und
natürlich auch mit allen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen im Ausschuss vielen Dank
hat das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion er
ist der europapolitische Sprecher der
Union
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Deutschland
ist wieder zurück
zwei Jahre Ampelkoalition haben gereicht
um Deutschland wieder zum kranken Mann
in Europa zu machen wir haben eine
Rezession nämlich eine Schrumpfung des
Wirtschaftswachstums das nicht nicht als
Wachstum bezeichnen lässt das dritte
Quartal in Folge und wenn wir in einer
haushaltswoche sind dann können wir ja
auch mal in den Zahlen reden denn die
Rede des Bundeskanzlers heute morgen hat
gezeigt wie sehr sie in einer
Parallelwelt leben wir haben einen
Anstieg der Arbeitslosigkeit
mittlerweile auf 2,7 Millionen Menschen
2,7 Millionen das heißt 150.000 mehr als
letztes Jahr die Prognose für die
Europäische Union Deutschland wird am
Ende dieses Jahres auf Platz 24 stehen
von 27 Mitgliedstaaten wir sind nicht
mehr die Lokomotive des
Wirtschaftswachstums in Europa wir sind
längstens das bremserhäuschen und nicht
zuletzt zu vergessen dass die hohen
Energiepreise in Deutschland und die
hohe Bürokratie in Deutschland genau
hausgemacht sind und damit auch
verantwortlich sind für diese Zahlen
deswegen meine Aufforderung an die
Regierung tun sie endlich etwas dagegen
tun sie es denn sie haben es selbst in
der Hand sie können die Stromsteuer
beispielsweise auf ein Minimum
herabsenken sie können insbesondere
Druck machen in Brüssel was Bürokratie
angeht in meiner Heimatstadt Pforzheim
wir sind mittelständisch geprägt wir
haben sehr viel Medizintechnik bei uns
Medizintechnikunternehmen in unserer
Region dort hat ein Unternehmen der
Dentaltechnik eine Bericht bekommen
einen Prüfbericht mit 48 Seiten 48
Seiten mit Gängelungen die man kaum
überbieten kann hier wäre Brüssel
gefordert aber insbesondere die
Bundesregierung Druck zu machen wenn es
hier um die Umsetzung solche Richtlinien
geht dann ist man hier eben in der
Verantwortung und der werden sie hier
nicht gerecht und das ist das Problem
für Deutschland insoweit sind die Dinge
hausgemacht oder in Sachen Bürokratie
die EVP hat gefordert dass wir es ein
Bürokratie Moratorium geben muss wirken
sie doch ein in ihren jeweiligen
parteifamilien bei S&D oder Herr Trittin
meinwegen auch bei ihnen dass ihr
endlich einmal gebremst wird dass ihr
die deutsche Wirtschaft nicht doch mit
mehr Bürokratie überzogen wird weil das
ist schädlich für uns und schädlich für
Europa denn
wir müssen bei alledem immer
berücksichtigen wenn bei uns die
Wirtschaftsleistungen die
Wirtschaftskraft zurückgeht dann treibt
das auch bei unseren Nachbarländern die
Sorgen auf die Stirn Deutschland hat an
dieser Geschichte es ist auch wenn hier
ein Deutschland packt heute morgen
angekündigt wird vielleicht in alter
remedizzentrum anzuknüpfen an die Agenda
2010 dann war damals die Agenda 2010
sehr konkret als sie hier von Gerhard
Schröder vorgestellt worden war genau an
dem Vorschlägen fehlt es ja fakt ist
aber doch dass sie sich innerhalb ihrer
eigenen Koalition nicht einigen können
hier herrscht Streit hier herrscht Zank
hier herrscht Uneinigkeit das ist doch
das Problem mit dem hier Deutschland
auch an jedem Tag zu kämpfen hat weil
diese Regierung keine Orientierung
vorgibt weder für Deutschland noch in
Europa es war der deutsche Vertreter der
ständige Vertreter Michael Klaus der mit
einem Brandbrief vor wenigen Monaten
hier montiert hatte dass es keine
Einigkeit gibt in der Koalition und er
überhaupt nicht mehr weiß wie er sich in
Brüssel positionieren soll deswegen es
fehlt die Orientierung eben auch in der
Europäischen Union die Uneinigkeit die
uns belastet auch im
deutsch-französischen Verhältnis
es soll ja hier stagniert es auf
niedrigstem Niveau man kann auch gar
nicht mehr davon reden dass es eine gute
Zusammenarbeit ist wir reden und
verhandeln zeigt vielen Jahren
mittlerweile um die Nachfolge des
Leopard 2 Main ground combat system Andy
CCS abgekürzt steht vor dem Scheitern
weil es hier von Deutschland an die Wand
gefahren wird jetzt läuft zur Stunde
über die Ticker dass Deutschland eine
neue Kooperation mit Italien Spanien und
Schweden eingehen möchte das ist ein
offener Frau gegenüber Frankreich von
Abstimmung wieder einmal keine rede hier
unser Verteidigungsminister hat sich mit
dem französischen
Verteidigungsminister noch vor wenigen
Monaten in die Presse gestellt mit
sebastiani und hat noch das
ngs-system Hoch geredet es ist wenn es
dazu nicht kommt mit Frankreich nicht
nur ein Scheitern des
Verteidigungsministers
und auch ein herberückschlag einmal mehr
für dieses
zeitenwendeprojekt ich möchte ein
letztes noch sagen im Hinblick auf die
Balkanstaaten auch hier ist die
Bundesregierung gefordert der Berliner
Prozess wurde seinerzeit angestoßen von
Angela Merkel allerdings es fehlt an
einer echten Perspektive wir müssen die
beitrittspolitik neu denken wir machen
aber Beitrittsverfahren wie wir sie
immer gemacht haben fakt ist wir
brauchen hier Perspektiven in Form einer
assoziiert Mitgliedschaft auch für die
Staaten mit denen wir heute verhandeln
weil die Verhandlungsdauer immer länger
werden und wir müssen darauf schauen
dass wir diese Länder auf diesem Weg
nicht verlieren weil wir ein großes
geopolitisches Interesse daran haben und
jedenfalls auch an der Stelle gefordert
sind hier muss die Bundesregierung mehr
tun herzlichen Dank
Sachs untergericht Baum für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion und ihm folgt jetzt hier
Michael Müller Michael Müller ist unter
anderem Vorsitzender der und
cat-kommission Lehren aus dem
Afghanistan Einsatz für das künftige
pfennigster Engagements Deutschland seit
einem Jahr gibt es diese Rocket
Kommission
vielfältiger Krisen
Klimawandel damit oft einhergehend
Nahrungsmittel Knappheit bittere Not und
Hunger regionale Konflikte Migration
alles das beschäftigt uns aber natürlich
wie die Außenministerin gesagt hat seit
559 Tagen erreichen uns wie furchtbaren
Bilder aus der Ukraine der Krieg dieser
brutale Krieg der in Russland gegen die
Ukraine führt hat unsere europäische
Friedensordnung erschüttert und wir
sehen weltweit wie sich neue Bündnisse
und Partnerschaften formieren ja der
brutale russische Angriffskrieg hat uns
die Notwendigkeit vor Augen geführt
notfalls unsere Werte Freiheit und
Sicherheit auch mit militärischen
Mitteln zu verteidigen es ist daher
notwendig und richtig dass die
Bundeswehr finanziell entsprechend
ausgestattet wird für die Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung ja die Bundeswehr
spielt eine entscheidende Rolle aber ein
gut ausgestattetes Militär alleine kann
nicht für Sicherheit und Frieden stehen
auch im Rahmen der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie hat die
Bundesregierung den Wert der Diplomatie
vielfältiger Beziehung in der Welt
betont und ich glaube wir dürfen als
weiteren Baustein die auswärtige Kultur
und Bildungspolitik nicht vergessen
unsere Außenministerin
hat einmal treffen formuliert wenn wir
die Freiheit von Kultur Wissenschaft und
Medien fördern dann stärken wir damit
auch die Freiheit und die Sicherheit von
Menschen aber wenn wir sehen dass die
Ressourcen knapp wie ein Gerät auch die
Bildungs- und Kulturpolitik in
Bedrängnis liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich sage auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik ist kein Luxusgut
sondern es ist eine nachhaltige
Investitionen in unsere Zukunft und in
eine friedlichere Welt wir beobachten
doch weltweit geopolitische
Machtverschiebung autoritäre Regime
gewinnen zunehmend an Einfluss ja die
sicherheitspolitischen Herausforderung
werden komplexer aber gerade deshalb
brauchen wir nicht weniger sondern mehr
Investitionen in Bildung Kultur und
Wissenschaft wie schafft Möglichkeiten
der internationalen Zusammenarbeit
schwierige Partnerschaften können sich
Partnerländer können sich trotzdem
begegnen wir schaffen Schutzräume
Freiräume gerade für die Aktiven vor Ort
die bringt unsere Unterstützung brauchen
damit sie weiter frei arbeiten können
die Künstlerinnen und Künstler die
Wissenschaftler die Studierenden die
Journalistinnen und Journalisten all
diejenigen brauchen auch unsere
Unterstützung und ich glaube in der
Debatte um die geopolitische
Machtverschiebung wird die Rolle von
kulturellen Faktoren sehr häufig
unterschätzt es hat doch ein Grund warum
gerade China und Russland in Kultur
weltweit investieren weil sie genau
darüber ein Transmissionsriemen haben um
ihre oft kruten Vorstellungen von der
Welt und ihre narrative verbreiten zu
können meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Kampf der
narrative wird aber nicht mit Panzern
oder Marschflugkörpern entschieden nein
im Gegenteil über Kultur Wissenschaft
und Bildung wird viel in diesem Bereich
entschieden der Kollege Link von der
FDP-Fraktion hat die Situation der
brix-staaten angesprochen wir erleben
unsere Überzeugung unsere Werte nicht
zwangsläufig von allen geteilt werden
auch nicht mit die von denen mit denen
wir bisher oft und gut
zusammengearbeitet haben die Gruppe der
brickstaaten erweitert sich wir haben
weitere Aufnahmeanträge wir sehen dass
das was wir vorhaben Russland immer
weiter zu isolieren in der Gruppe dieser
Staaten nicht selbstverständlich ist und
dass es weiter Kooperation mit Russland
gibt das bedeutet doch aber wir müssen
aktiv auf diese Länder zugehen wir
müssen um Dialog werden ein Dialog auf
Augenhöhe muss stattfinden wir müssen
die
zivilgesellschaftlichen Beziehungen
Stärken gerade oft die Opposition und
die zivilgesellschaftlichen
Institutionen vor Ort darauf kommt es an
meine Damen und Herren auch die
auswärtige Kultur und Bildungspolitik
steht natürlich auch in Zeiten knapper
Kassen vor großen Herausforderung die
geplanten Mittel sind geringen
zu gering möglicherweise um den
vielfältigen Anforderungen und Aufgaben
gerecht zu werden in der auswärtigen
Kultur- und Bildungspolitik existieren
wir dürfen das nicht vergessen oft
langjährig aufgebaute Strukturen und
Netzwerke die
gegebenenfalls durch Kürzung auch
zerschlagen werden die man aber eben
nicht schnell und ohne weiteres wieder
aufbauen kann ich weiß es ist keine
leichte Aufgabe für die anstehenden
Haushaltsberatung aber ich glaube wir
dürfen nicht vergessen in der akbp
können wir mit relativ geringen Mitteln
sehr viel erreichen gerade auch an
humanitärer Unterstützung meine Damen
und Herren wer den Anspruch einer
wertebasierten Außenpolitik erhebt
braucht dafür auch eine gut finanzierte
auswertige Kultur und Bildungspolitik
und ich hoffe in diesem Sinne auf ihre
aller Unterstützung vielen dank
Michael Müller hier für die SPD-Fraktion
ja insgesamt der Haushalt das
Außenministeriums sieht für das nächste
aus Gaben von rund 6 Milliarden Euro vor
für die Pflege der kulturellen
Beziehungen zum Ausland ist davon
zumindest eine Milliarde eingeplant
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Gäste auf der
Tribüne die Party ist vorbei dieser
Rausch diese berauschungen des Links
grünen Geld verschwendens unsere
steuergeldes ist vorbei die Kassen sind
leer wir sind mitten in einer Rezession
ausgelöst durch eine völlig gescheiterte
Energiewende das Abschneiden vom
russischen Gas der die
Industrialisierung unserer Heimat und
völlig ihr sie in den dämm und
heizungsvorschriften die die
Bauindustrie fast komplett zum Erliegen
bringen werden die Konzerne wandern ins
Ausland ab das Steueraufkommen schrumpft
da fallen eine
Unfug Klima und Genderpolitik
feministische und Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik gar nicht mal mehr ins
Gewicht den Schwarzwald spüren wir in
diesem Haushalt
Sprachförderung deutscher Minderheiten
in Osteuropa Rüstungskontrolle deutsche
Kulturarbeit finanzielle Unterstützung
der Goethe-Institute hier wird der
Rotstift angesetzt da wo mehr Geld
ausgegeben wird ist die Versorgung der
ihren Frau bärbock der Personal die
Personalkosten steigen und ihre
Verwaltungskosten dafür geben Sie Geld
aus dieses Land hat Außenminister vom
Schlager eines Willy Brandt und eines
Hans-Dietrich Genscher hervorgebracht
für diese
für diese zählte das Erreichte für sie
reicht offensichtlich Frau beerburg das
erzählte und das oft schlecht erzählt
wie beispielsweise ihre Biografie
korrigieren Sie mich die inzwischen bei
der 9 Version angelangt ist
wissen Sie Frau Ministerin im
Unterschied zu ihnen komme ich zwar
nicht vom Völkerball Entschuldigung
Völkerrecht aber ich habe tatsächlich in
Großbritannien gelebt und bin der
dortigen Sprache einigermaßen mächtig
ich sage Ihnen sparen Sie lieber bei der
steuerfinanzierten Visagistin und
investieren Sie lieber in
Englischunterricht sonst haben wir bald
more Beef mit unseren Nachbarn was wir
alle nicht wollen wenn Sie verstehen was
ich meine und ich bin den Russen sowas
von dankbar dass die ihre
Kriegserklärung we are in Worbis Russia
nicht ernst genommen haben wir sind es
nämlich nicht dies ist nicht unser Krieg
und jetzt für alle einmal zum
Mitschreiben schon im
Bundestagswahlkampf 1957 attackierte
Bundeskanzler Adenauer die SPD mit den
Worten die Politik die die
sozialdemokratische Regierung will macht
Deutschland zu einem russischen
Satelliten und heute wir sind wehrlos
und abhängig Angela Merkel zu Gutenberg
Steinmeier Gabriel Schwesig und viele
andere aus ihren Reihen haben dieses
Land in Abhängigkeiten getrieben und
über 16 und mehr als 16 Jahre lang
niedergewehrt schafftet
abgesehen von einem böhmischen befreiten
hat noch nie jemand so viel Unglück über
Deutschland gebracht wie diese ehemalige
Bundeskanzlerin von 2016 bis 2020 gab es
insgesamt rund 2000 Tötungsdelikte in
Deutschland bei den mindestens ein
Zuwanderer als Tatverdächtiger ermittelt
wurde von Verletzten und vergewaltigten
in riesigen tausenderschritten ganz zu
schweigen so viele Menschen hat nicht
einmal die SED an der Mauer erschießen
lassen deren Nachfolgepartei heute hier
unter uns sitzt und sich als lupenreine
Demokraten geriert in wenigen Wochen
werden wir den 33 jahrestag der
deutschen Einheit feiern 33 Jahre danach
hat Deutschland sich in Europa des
Umbruchs von einem Hort der Stabilität
in den kranken Mann Europas ja sogar zum
Sorgenkind entwickelt für eine relativ
längeren Zeitspanne hatte das
wiedervereinte Deutschland wie einst die
alte Bundesrepublik seinen Platz in
Europa gefunden im Einklang und zur
Zufriedenheit seiner Nachbarn und
Partner von Lissabon bis Warschau für
Paris und Warschau standen wir als
Nachbarn ganz oben dies war in unserer
langen Geschichte einmalig meine Damen
und Herren
entscheidend hierfür versteht unsere
Glaubwürdigkeit und unsere
Verlässlichkeit was Deutschland im mehr
als 60 Jahren an Vertrauen bei unseren
Nachbarn erworben hatte war unser
wertvollstes außenpolitisches gut was
waren da für die Grundlage ich sag es
ihnen die deutsche Verankerung in Europa
die partnerschaftliche Einbindung
Russlands und drittens der Erhalt der
historischen Brücke über den Atlantik
und heute in Europa sind wir isoliert
für Paris sind sie das Problem an der
Ostgrenze und für für Polen das Problem
an seiner Westgrenze Grenzen übrigens
ihre Kabinettskollegin die jetzt schon
wieder weg ist nicht schützen möchte den
Satz Konrad Adenauers wonach feste
Außenpolitik die Wahrnehmung der eigenen
Interessen ist ist unser Ansporn
deutsche Interessen Frau bärburg haben
Sie noch nie verteidigt ganz im
Gegenteil und zum Schluss möchte ich
nach darauf hinweisen dass Sie unser
parlamentarisches frageicht regelmäßig
verletzen wir haben sie im Ausschuss im
Plenum schriftlich befragt wann sie
davon erfahren haben dass ihr Haus eine
Anweisung erteilt hat gefälschte
afghanische Pässe zu visieren und wer
berechtigt war Personen aus Afghanistan
zu benennen die nach Deutschland zur
Rundumversorgung eingeflogen werden dies
haben sie verwehrt wir haben daraufhin
Verfassungsklage eingereicht wir bleiben
am Ball und Frau Werbung zum Schluss
sagt ihm mit diesem antidemokratischen
Verhalten während sie aus der
polisierung ist vorbei ja das Haus
geworfen worden der Heimat der
Demokratie
[Applaus]
Herr Kollege Keuter wir sind ja ein
freies Land und ein freies Parlament man
kann hier in diesem Parlament alles
sagen und jede Meinung äußern auch wenn
wenn ich in die Gesichter schaue viele
ihre scheinbaren Fakten hier niemand
teilt aber was nicht geht sind
persönliche Beleidigungen und was auch
nicht geht ist so Oppa Song Personen aus
der Politik dieses Landes gleichzusetzen
mit solchen die im Nationalsozialismus
Macht hatten deswegen sage ich Ihnen
ganz klar dass es um parlamentarisch und
das werden wir in diesem Haus nicht
dulden herzlichen Dank
das Wort hat Otto Fricke für die
FDP-Fraktion
schätzte frau Präsidentin meine liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
leider passt es nicht aber ich hatte
eigentlich gedacht vielleicht wird es ja
mal freundlicher verpackt von von dieser
Seite aber sie lagen schaffen es ja noch
nicht einmal Freundlichkeit mit
türkischen Gemüte irgendwie ineinander
zu verknüpfen es ist irgendwie schon
bemerkenswert dass sie nicht versuchen
etwas nach vorne zu bringen wie es
eigentlich in einer Demokratie notwendig
ist sondern nur nach Schuldigen zu lösen
sie ist entschuldigen sie lösen
weiterhin keine Probleme und Tun diesem
Land damit den größten Schaden an dem
man ihm nur antun kann meine Damen und
Herren gehen wir zurück zum Haushalt
entschuldigen Sie dass ich nicht in die
große weiter Außenpolitik gehe das ist
für mich als Haushälter und Jurist dann
doch etwas zu komplex aber ich muss dann
doch als Zahlen kontrollieren an der
Stelle ein wenig auf bestimmte Dinge
hinweisen ja der Haushalt wird etwas
geringer aber ich will noch mal darauf
hinweisen
wir sind über 300 Millionen höher als
wir noch 2019 waren wir ziehen den
Anstieg der eine zusätzliche Ausbeutung
durch viele Krisen bekommen haben ziehen
wir weiterhin fort und Frau Ministerin
deswegen kann man sich auch hinstellen
und sagen im Rahmen der Verfassung die
jeder Minister sicherlich gerne
einhalten will bin ich stolz darauf dass
ich eine weitere Erhöhung gegenüber der
vor Krisenzeit erreicht habe und werde
das Beste daraus machen ich bin mir
sicher die koalitionshaushälter werden
sie dabei ausdrücklich unterstützen den
Außenpolitik ist für unser Land
essentiell nicht nur als Teil Europas
sondern auch als ein Land das gezeigt
hat dass es mit seiner Geschichte
umgehen kann mit seiner Verantwortung
mit seiner manchmal auch persönlichen
Schuld in der Vergangenheit und anderen
Ländern damit auch zeigen kann wie sehr
aus Krisen in die sich selber hinein
gebracht haben rauskommen und dafür
brauchen wir eine gute eine starke
Außenpolitik meine Damen und Herren
ich weiß aber auch darauf hin das ist
jetzt technisch aber ist wichtig im
Einzelplan 60 der allgemeinen
Finanzverwaltung gibt es einen
ertüchtigungstitel da sehe ich auch
Milch habe ich auch nicht von den
Kollegen und Kollegen der Koalition
gehört dass wir den absenken wollen
dieser ertüchtigungs Titel ist wie in
der Vergangenheit auch eine Reserve weil
wir nicht wissen wie sich die Länder
entwickeln weil wir sie nicht wissen wie
Russland agiert und Herr Kollege Gysi
das war wieder so ein schönes Beispiel
da passt dann wahrscheinlich sogar die
Freundlichkeit den türkischen Gemüter
sahen sie was wäre denn wenn wir mal so
ein Vorschlag machen keine
Waffenlieferung also wir tun etwas und
dann macht Russland einen
Waffenstillstand das Spannende ist dann
machen die den Waffenstillstand nee ich
habe schon genau zugehört sie haben das
bewusst zu formuliert eine
Waffenstillstand aber einhalten wird
Russland das wissen wir doch alle den
Waffenstillstand nicht weil sie uns
wieder erklären können aus welchen
Gründen eigentlich die Ukraine den ich
eingehalten und nicht und was haben wir
dann gemacht wir haben mal wieder einen
Schritt nach vorne gemacht und Russland
an der Stelle nutzt das einfach nur aus
und dann guck mal wieder ob man die
Waffen wieder geliefert während an der
Front der nächste Ukrainer die nächste
Ukrainerin stirbt nein solche Spielchen
macht man einfach nicht hier muss hier
muss Russland von sich aus etwas zeigen
es gibt einen Moment an dem auch diese
Nation Europa sagen muss jetzt kommt von
dir ein Vertrauensbeweis und dann
reagieren wir und nicht immer ihr
Spielchen erst muss Europa einen
Vertrauens beispielsweise und dann
könnte Russland vielleicht ja auch mal
etwas tun worüber werden wir meine Damen
und Herren in den nächsten Wochen noch
reden wir werden über keine reden wir
werden über die Frage reden müssen was
da noch an finanziellen Notwendigkeit
ist dass wir diesen Einzelplan betreffen
in Einzelplan 60 betreffen es wird den
Verteidigungshaushalt betreffen es wird
aber auch wegen der Flüchtlinge den in
Einzelplan treffen und unsere Kommunen
da müssen wir noch sehr sehr genau
schauen wie wir das alles genau
finanziert bekommen eines allerdings
kann ich an der Stelle klar sagen hier
wird Deutschland außen wie
innenpolitisch seiner Verantwortung als
großer Staat mitten in Europa gerecht
werden auch gegenüber unseren östlichen
Nachbarn das will ich hier ganz
besonders hervorheben denn
ich glaube da sollten wir mehr Fokus
darauf legen wann immer ich nach
Osteuropa Reise kommt so dieses Gefühl
ja wir sind froh dass wir da seid aber
es kommt was zweites wir haben immer
noch das Gefühl ihr guckt ganz viel nach
Westen und ihr guckt so ein bisschen
nach Osten aber uns in dem was wir an
Möglichkeiten an Stärken haben dass das
nehmt ja noch nicht so richtig ernst und
da glaube ich müssen wir sehr sehr viel
tun und damit komme ich zum
Goethe-Institut unser außen
Kulturpolitik ich will das deutlich
sagen hier reden alle wieder darüber
dass wir dafür tun müssen und Frau
Ministerin da ein ernsthaftes Wort es
ist gut wenn der Haushaltsausschuss
regelmäßig die Ausbildung Kultur und
Bildungspolitik unterstützt aber wenn
das Ministerium in 2022 und ich hören
2023 hingeht und die 75 Millionen
globale Minderausgabe Übersetzung da
sparen die jeder Geld aus dem Haushalt
zu 80% aus diesem Bereich nimmt obwohl
er nur 14% am Haushalt ist wird uns das
zwingen als Haushälter als auswärtige
Kultur und Bildungspolitiker an der
Stelle dann klar zu stellen
dass eine globale Minderausgabe so
eingespart wird wie auch die Anteile am
Haushalt sind ich hoffe wir finden da
eine Lösung ohne dass der
Haushaltsausschuss das machen muss denn
dafür ist die Kultur und Bildungspolitik
viel zu wichtig auch die auswärtige
meine Damen und Herren zum Schluss
ich möchte hoffen dass dieser Haushalt
eine bessere Klarheit auch findet in dem
was unsere Verantwortung ist und ich
möchte auch hoffen dass wir in der
Außenpolitik dass mein Wunsch auch etwas
mehr darauf reagieren wenn andere Länder
unsere Werte angreifen wenn andere
Länder unsere Werte ich sage das
manchmal auch mit Füßen treten da müssen
wir noch schauen welche wir kriegen
herzlichen Dank
der Haushälter der FDP-Fraktion Otto
wricke in dieser Woche besonders
gefordert wenn ich richtig gezählt habe
der mindestens dritte Redebeitrag in der
am zweiten haushaltstag aber diesmal
ohne Shakespeare Zitat übrigens
nächste am Redner politin der
außenpolitische Sprecher der Grünen
meine Damen und Herren frau Präsidentin
ich bin Ihnen ausdrücklich dankbar dass
sie das hier klargestellt haben es geht
nicht
dass man die gewählte Bundeskanzlerin
die 16 Jahre hat dieses Land und ich
habe 60 Jahre gegen sie Opposition
gemacht vergleicht mit dem größten
Kriegsverbrecher aller Zeiten der
verantwortlich ist für den Mord an sechs
Millionen Juden und Juden und der
verantwortlich ist für den Tod von 60
Millionen Menschen das ist Relativierung
internationalsozialismus was sie hier
getrieben haben und das ist nicht
akzeptabel
wenn ja froh darüber dass unter der
demokratischen Parteien der Opposition
wie der Regierung hier außenpolitisch so
ein großer Konsens besteht dass der
geschätzte Kollege Johann wadepool sich
darauf beschränken musste zu sagen die
Ministerin sei nicht so fleißig wie er
sich das wünschte und gelegentlich hätte
sie auch mal Schwierigkeiten mit denen
von vormaligen Regierungen übernommenen
flugwerkzeug
aber ich will nun mal darauf hinweisen
was diese Ministerin in den vergangenen
zwei Jahren gemacht hat sie hat auch
ihre Naivität gegenüber Russland beendet
wir sind heute derjenige die am
zweitmeisten nach den USA Waffen an die
Ukraine liefern sie hat zum ersten Mal
haben sie nie hinbekommen eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie als
regierungsstrategie definiert wehrhaft
resilient und nachhaltig an dieser
Stelle sie hat auch ihre Naivität
gegenüber China beendet mit einer neuen
china-strategie die Schluss gemacht hat
mit dem frommen Wunsch dass Handel eben
nicht nur Wandel sondern auch Demokratie
schafft und klargestellt hat dass all
business ist
und
sie arbeitet zur Zeit an einer
klima-außenpolitik Strategie die klar
stellt das hat sie auf der letzten
Klimakonferenz erreicht dass die Länder
die verantwortlich sind für die
Klimakrise auch verantwortlich sind für
die Behebung der Schäden und Verluste in
anderen Ländern und sie wird ich bin
ziemlich sicher auf der nächsten
Klimakonferenz durchsetzen das ist ein
globales Ziel zum Ausbau erneuerbare
Energien geben wird das ist eine
Leistungsbilanz die sich sehen lassen
kann lassen Sie mich eine
Schlussbemerkung noch machen Daten sind
ja oft wichtig und die erzeugen dann
einen Blick auf Außenpolitik wir
sprechen viel über den 24.02 aber ein
Teil des Problems was wir haben
Bündnispartner für eine solche Politik
zu finden hat etwas mit dem 11 September
zu tun nicht dem 11 September an denen
die meisten von uns jetzt denken sondern
mit dem 11 September 1973
damals putschte des Militär in China ein
Sozialdemokraten aus dem Amt ermordete
ihn wie Tausende von anderen
und das ist eines der Punkte warum wir
aufhören müssen als selbstgerechter
Westen aufzutreten in der Erinnerung der
Völker wenn Sie einen Grund suchen warum
Indien sagt wir machen in der Ukraine
ein balancierten Ansatz warum Südafrika
sagt wir sind in dieser Frage neutral
dann hat das damit zu tun gehabt dass
wir unsere Werte nicht ernst genommen
haben und das war schlechte
kluge Realpolitik ist eine Werte
gebundene Realpolitik und die ist bei
anderen
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie bei der
Annalena Werbung ja unter anderem
federführend war die ist im Juni
allerdings nach monatelang bringen
innerhalb der Ampel dann im Kabinett
verabschiedet worden
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich durfte vor
zwei Wochen mit zwei weiteren
Abgeordneten dieses Hauses am
ukrainischen Unabhängigkeitstag zu Gast
im ukrainischen Parlament sein eine
emotionale und ergreifende Sitzung und
man spürte Dankbarkeit für dieses
Zeichen der Solidarität das Abgeordnete
aus ganz Europa nach Kiew gekommen sind
man spürte stolz auf das was die Ukraine
in den letzten 32 Jahren als
eigenständiger Staat erreicht hat aber
vor allem auch die Entschlossenheit dass
diese freiheitliche und demokratische
Ukraine ihnen niemand mehr nehmen wird
und dass die Ukrainerinnen Ukraine ihr
Land verteidigen werden
bei allen aggressiven hausagen der
russischen Führung wird auch klar die
Ukrainer verteidigen auch Europa auch
uns wenn Russland mit diesem brutalen
Angriffskrieg erfolgreich ist dann leben
wir in einem anderen Europa in einer
anderen Welt und das können und dürfen
wir nicht zulassen Menschenrechte
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Freiheit unsere
Grundpfeiler werden nicht überall auf
gleich auf der Welt auf gleiche Weise
geschätzt leider sind viele Länder
abwartend Herr Kollege Trittin hat auch
das beschrieben und orientieren sich
möglicherweise am Schluss einfach an den
stärkeren oder bauen anti-westliche
Bündnisse wie Brix aus das kann uns
nicht gefallen meine Damen und Herren
aber wer hat denn die Kraft sich so
einer Entwicklung entgegenzustellen das
sind die mit den starken Schultern das
sind eben auch wir und in einer Zeit in
der uns eben die Welt um die Ohren zu
fliegen scheint ist der Haushalt des
Auswärtigen Amtes der der am
drittstärksten gekürzt werden soll und
das kann man auch nicht schön reden mit
vor Krisen Niveau das ist am Schluss
Fakt und das ist das völlig falsche
Signal meine Damen und Herren
und das kann am Schluss eben auch nicht
unser Anspruch sein und es ist schade
dass die Außenministerin in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen hier nicht mehr
Gewicht einbringen konnte denn am
Schluss geht bei diesen Beträgen auch
nicht um Schuldenbremse sondern einfach
nur um Prioritätensetzung
und wenn Sie schon
rausministerin mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auch ihre Rede beginnen
und eindrücklich auch diese grauenhaften
Dinge schildern dann muss man
feststellen die Erwartung und das was
auch war auch das was ich in Ukraine
spüren konnte ist einfach sehr sehr groß
und ich glaube dass wir hier noch mehr
Entschlossenheit zeigen können dann dass
wir jetzt wieder bei einzelnen
Waffensystemen wie Taurus zögern
versteht dort wirklich niemand
wichtig ist jetzt wir müssen ein
verlässlicher Partner sein wir müssen
auch Entschlossenheit zeigen bei
munitionsbeschaffung weil
Ersatzteilen Verschleißteilen ich glaube
dass wir da noch ein stärkeres Bild
abgeben können wir brauchen einen Plan
Pfad der maximalen militärischen
Unterstützung und das ist übrigens auch
die Grundlage für Verhandlungen aus
einer Position der Stärke wer meint man
sollte Waffenlieferungen einstellen
liefert die Ukraine ans Messer des
russischen Kriegsverbrechers und sonst
nichts
es ist richtig wir müssen neue Allianzen
schmieden müssen unsere Partnerschaften
Stärken ob das für Rohstoffe Handel oder
auch beim Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
ist es gibt viele Länder die uns sehr
zugewandt sind und wir müssen dieses
Potenzial endlich noch stärker nutzen
Deutschland hat verlässlicher Partner
und neue Allianzen ich glaube dass wir
in diesen Zeiten dafür eben auch unsere
Präsenz in der Welt stärken und eben
nicht zurückfahren müssen und das sowohl
diplomatisch als auch bei der
zielgesellschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit
wir reden von Fachkräften und kürzen
ausgerechnet da wo diese für die Zukunft
auch entstehen werden nämlich beim
Studentenaustausch bei den
Auslandsschulen einige
Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben das auch
ihre in ihren Reden angesprochen aber
die Realität der Haushaltsentwurf das
schwarz auf weiß sieht eben leider
anders aus und dabei sind wir in Zeiten
von wachsender Propaganda und das
Information
auf jeden einzelnen angewiesen der sich
für unser Land interessiert der unsere
Sprache lernen möchte oder unser Land
noch genauer verstehen möchte aber hier
wird leider der Rotstift angesetzt das
kann nicht so bleiben
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie wieder im
Auswärtigen Amt noch im BMVg ist ein
einziger Euro zusätzlich für diese
Umsetzung sichtbar ich glaube in Zeiten
globaler Krisen leisten wir uns eine
Mittelkürzung auch im Bereich der
Stabilisierungsmittel die gerade zur
krisenvermeidung dienen das kann niemand
wollen der Etat zeigt vor allem eins die
groß angekündigte Zeitenwende bleibt aus
da ist noch viel Nacharbeit notwendig
wir werden da gerne unterstützen
herzlichen Dank
jetzt hat die Kollegin aida-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch lange kein
Frieden lautet der Titel des
friedensgutachtens in diesem Jahr und
wir spüren ja alle dass auch wir
angegriffen werden durch diesen
furchtbaren Krieg der jetzt schon in
vielen Reden selbstverständlich auch
angesprochen wurde diese ich ich werde
sie vermissen aber warum bringen sie es
nicht einmal fertig zu sagen Russland
soll sein Angriff einstellen Russland
soll nicht mehr bombardieren warum nicht
einmal ich
wir spüren die
Desinformationskampagnen wir spüren
Cyber-Attacken des betrifft auch uns
direkt und deshalb ist es gut dass wir
unsere innere wie auch äußere Sicherheit
mit diesem Haushalt stärken werden und
wir haben es ja gleichzeitig mit einer
Vielzahl von Krisenherden zu tun ich
möchte jetzt hier natürlich nicht alle
aufzählen aber
Äthiopien jedem Somalia Sahelzone Balkan
die latente gefallener Eskalation im
Indopazifik man könnte hier vieles dazu
fügen das alles gibt ja nun Anlass zur
größten Aufmerksamkeit und zu einem
Bewusstsein dass wir es eben mit einer
sich sehr verändernden Weltordnung zu
tun haben wir müssen Deutschland und
Europa stärken und die Außenministerin
hatte die
Generalsekretärin der
Welthandelsorganisation ja gerade ins
Auswärtige Amt eingeladen und sie hat
vorgestern noch gesagt unser Kanzler
Scholz sei ein sehr starker Anwalt für
größere Diversifikation und resil
Präsenz innerhalb einer offenen
regelbasierten globalen Ökonomie und das
ganz besonders auch im Hinblick auf den
sogenannten globalen Süden das ist auch
die Lehre aus den Erfahrungen mit
Russland und das ist der richtige Weg
die aktuelle Ballung von Faro
Herausforderungen haben wir nun jetzt
seit Jahrzehnten ja nicht gekannt und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass dieser
Haushalt sich auf drei Dinge
konzentriert nämlich investieren
entlasten und darauf lege ich den
größten Wert zusammenhalten denn das
wird ja die zukünftige Herausforderung
für uns sein und in der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie haben wir uns ja
auch der integrierten Sicherheitspolitik
verschrieben das heißt wir wollen die
Sicherheit in allen Politikfeldern mit
einbeziehen und vor allem das
Zusammenwirken aller Akteure stärken die
eben für Sicherheit sorgen
Herr Fricke hat es vorhin gesagt ist
auch übrigens eine der wichtigsten
Lehren aus unserer onkette-kommission zu
Afghanistan es geht es gibt nicht
entweder Außenpolitik oder
Verteidigungspolitik oder
Entwicklungspolitik wir brauchen ein
besser abgestimmtes Vorgehen um eine
erfolgreiche und kohärente Politik
gestalten zu können und genau das ist
auch so in diesem Haushalt aus
abgepeilt worden so unser erstes mal
besonders wichtig im Sinne der
integrierten Sicherheit müssen wir dann
auch die Verteidigungsfähigkeit neben
der Verteidigungsfähigkeit Deutschlands
auch die zivilenkomponenten der
Friedenssicherung und Verständigung
stärken und deshalb ist es eben auch so
wichtig dass wir trotz der bereits
angesprochenen begrenzenhaushaltsmittel
die Mittel für das Zentrum für
internationale Friedenseinsätze stabil
halten und das ist etwas was mir
wirklich wichtig ist denn diese
expertenexperten leisten wichtige Arbeit
in aller Welt und sie sind ja gerade
dabei auch die Beweissicherung von
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine zu
sammeln und nur so kann
Kriegsverbrechern später der Prozess
gemacht werden und wir wissen dass aus
dem Balkan ich habe das auch schon in
früheren reden hier sehr betont dass
gerade wenn das nicht aufgearbeitet wird
wenn eben nicht Kriegsverbrecher
bestraft werden und womöglich noch von
einer Generation zur nächsten Generation
sehr falsche und unterschiedliche
Geschichten weitergegeben werden dann
ist das für uns alle ein Problem wir
brauchen eine Strafverfolgung und wir
sollten es in der Ukraine von Anfang an
besser machen
und zum Abschluss möchte ich schon noch
mal auf Michael Link ganz kurz eingehen
denn ich hatte schon die
Generalsekretärin der
Welthandelsorganisation angesprochen und
sie hat ja doch noch mal jemanden aus
den Entwicklungsländern zitiert und es
ist schon ein gutes und wichtiges Zitat
und ich glaube gerade von den
außenpolitikern werden das viele kennen
wenn nämlich dann gesagt wird wenn wir
es mit China zu tun haben haben wir am
Ende ein Flughafen wenn wir es mit euch
zu tun haben haben wir am Ende einen
Vortrag den wir bekommen und ich habe
mich wirklich gefreut dass das im
Auswärtigen Amt ja von uns allen
sozusagen unterstützt so deutlich
gemacht wurde und es zeigt wir haben das
verstanden was ich so lange entwickelt
hat und wir wollen endlich auch einen
neuen Weg gehen ganz herzlichen Dank
Alter das war das für die SPD-Fraktion
hier zum Auswärtigen Amt zum einzelplane
05 der noch nicht so eine besprochen ist
es folgt jetzt eure schlechte für die
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
wo es Präsidium sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
gestatten Sie mir zu Beginn eine
persönliche Anmerkung ich möchte heute
nämlich ganz besonders meine
Grundschulklasse in Neckarbischofsheim
grüßen im schönen Baden-Württemberg
heute vor 40 Jahren war mein
ersteinschulungstag und da habe ich bei
der Frau Philipp in der Grundschule
rechnen gelernt das braucht man ja im
Haushalt also vielen herzlichen Dank an
die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die Beratung
des Haushalts wir hoffen sie hat ja
bekanntermaßen auch als Königsdisziplin
des Parlaments bezeichnet und in dieser
Disziplin wird deutlich wenn nur schöne
Schaufenster Reden hält und wer wirklich
liefert werden schwierigen Zeiten
Verantwortung übernimmt und
verantwortlich handelt es reicht nicht
einfach nur alles mögliche zu fordern
sondern man muss auch sagen wo das Geld
dafür herkommen sollen zur
Königsdisziplin des Parlaments gehört es
die verschiedenen Anlagen gegen eine
Anliegen gegeneinander abzuwägen und
Prioritäten zu setzen künftigen
politiker-generationen genügend Luft zum
Atmen zu lassen so dass sie nicht an den
Schulden von heute ersticken das fällt
nicht immer leicht aber es muss gemacht
werden und wir als Ampel machen ist das
führt auch im Haushalt für das
Auswärtige Amt zu Entscheidungen die
wirklich nicht leicht fallen trotz
vieler Krisen in der Welt müssen wir das
Budget für humanitäre Hilfe auf das vor
corona-niveau zurückfahren aber wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass die Gelder
jetzt effizienter eingesetzt werden
können wir haben mit einem
haushaltsvermerk klargestellt dass
mindestens 30% der Gelder als flexible
Mittel eingesetzt werden müssen so
können wir die Hilfsorganisation von
unnötiger Bürokratie befreien und geben
Ihnen den Handlungsspielraum den sie
dringend benötigen die humanitären
Hilfsorganisationen wie beispielsweise
das Welt Ernährungsprogramm oder der
UNHCR sind da für mehr als dankbar und
begrüßen diese Vorgehensweise
ausdrücklich
versprochen hat diese
Entbürokratisierung bereits die groko
beim humanitären Weltgipfel 2016 in
Istanbul aber erst die Ampel hat dieses
Ziel zunächst im Koalitionsvertrag und
dann im ersten Haushalt festgelegt wir
liefern also wo früher Regierungen
Versprechungen gemacht haben das gleiche
gilt für das 2% Ziel der NATO das hat
die groko 2014 bei Martin Gipfel im
Wales vollmundig und üblicher merkelmann
hier versprochen aber besetzt ist um die
Ampel meine Damen und Herren und das war
auch bitter nötig denn der
völkerrechtswidrige russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine hat uns
allen vor Augen geführt dass Frieden
keine Selbstverständlichkeit ist dass
der Frieden der Wohlstand und damit die
Demokratie in Europa in Gefahr sind
meine Damen und Herren unsere Freiheit
ist in Gefahr
Populismus und Spaltung sind auf dem
Vormarsch aufrechte Demokraten aller
Parteien sind gefordert diese Auswüchse
zu bekämpfen und standhaft jeden Tag
unsere Werte unsere freiheitliche
demokratische Grundordnung zu
verteidigen dazu gehört dass wir
gemeinsam in der Europäischen Union der
NATO den G7 und in den Vereinten
Nationen zusammenstehen um die Ukraine
zu unterstützen und Putin und seinen
Freunden Grenzen zu setzen
Autokratie und
Illegalität sind die natürlichen Feinde
vom Menschenrechten von Freiheit und
Demokratie stehen wir zusammen gegen
diese Feinde anstattung ständig zu
streiten vielen Dank
wirklich schlechte war das für die
FDP-Fraktion er ist ob man im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss und wir hören
jetzt als nächsten Frank schade für die
SPD-Fraktion den Sprecher für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe
frau Präsidentin verehrte Damen und
Herren wir haben jetzt viel gesprochen
schon in dieser Debatte über die
weltweiten Herausforderungen und
natürlich ist es so und das kann man
nicht oft genug sagen dass wir natürlich
weiterhin sehr stark unter dem Eindruck
stehen jedenfalls auch hier in Europa
unter dem russischen verbrecherischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und
deswegen kann man auch das nicht oft
genug sagen es ist unsere zentrale
Aufgabe alles zu tun damit die Ukraine
als eigenständiger souveräner Staat in
seinen eigenen Grenzen bestehen kann es
ist wichtig alles zu tun damit die
Ukraine wirtschaftlich ökonomisch sozial
wieder aufgebaut werden kann und wir
müssen alles tun damit Verbrecher zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden am Ende wenn
nötig auch mit internationalen sonder
Tribunalen und das wird auch deutlich in
dem im Haushalt im Entwicklungsbereich
im Verteidigungsetat der gleich
diskutiert wird aber eben auch in der
humanitären Hilfe alles das fokussiert
sich und konzentriert sich auf die
Ukraine diese Politik und deswegen will
ich aber weil wir über dich über die
humanteriehilfe geredet habe auch nicht
drum rumreden die Außenministerin hat es
auch nicht getan natürlich ist die
Reduzierung der humanitären Hilfe in
diesem Haushalt des Ansatz jedenfalls um
ein Drittel etwa schmerzlich das ist so
und es ist auch international schwierig
das zu erklären und wir sehen ja welche
geschätzten Partner wir in der
internationalen Politik sind im
Gegensatz zu manchen anderen
Behauptungen dass im Grunde haben alle
international Organisationen zu uns
kommen und uns bitten unser Engagement
weiterhin aufrecht zu erhalten bei der
humanitären Hilfe geht es um die
verletzlichsten Menschen auf der Welt
die täglich um mir Überleben ringen in
Südsudan im Sudan in Myanmar in jedem in
Syrien in Afghanistan und nur ein paar
Beispiele zu nennen das schlichtweg am
Ende die Prävention von weiteren Krisen
die Prävention von Kriegen und übrigens
auch die Prävention vor irregulärer
Migration wir reden über 300 Millionen
Menschen ungefähr auf der Welt die
täglich um dieses Überleben kämpfen
müssen so viel Menschen wie in den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika in etwa
Leben und wir reden von humanitären
Bedarfen von 50 Milliarden US-Dollar die
nur zur Hälfte gedeckt worden sind etwa
ein bisschen mehr im letzten Jahr das
ist weniger als der Verteidigungsetat
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ich sage
das immer wieder in diesen Debatten um
deutlich zu machen wie wenig ist
eigentlich international bedürfte um
solche leidenden Menschen ein bisschen
jedenfalls solchen leidenden Menschen
ein bisschen zu helfen deswegen ist die
Kürzung die dort vorgeschlagen ist
bitter das ist so und gleichzeitig will
ich aber auch deutlich machen dass
Deutschland sich in den letzten Jahren
zu einer wahrhaftigen Weltmacht im
Bereich der humanitärenhilfe entwickelt
hat und politische Leistung von vielen
hier auch in diesem Deutschen Bundestag
dass wir das hinbekommen haben wir sind
weltweit auf Platz 2 der internationalen
Gegner Nationen nach den USA und wir
bleiben das auch
auch mit diesem neuen Haushalt und wir
sind in der Tat das ist vielfach gesagt
worden immer noch über dem Niveau vor
der vor corona-zeiten und wir haben den
Haushalt mehr als ver fünffacht in dem
Bereich gegenüber dem Jahr 2012 auch das
muss entsprechend gesagt werden aber was
bleibt eine Aufgabe eine zentrale
Aufgabe deutsche Außenpolitik alles zu
tun dass diese internationalen Gelder
organisiert werden können und es ist
natürlich klar auch für zukünftige
Haushalte das ist schwieriger möglich
wenn am Ende der humanitäre als
Steinbruch betrachtet würde und deswegen
will ich daran erinnern worauf wir auch
die Außenministerin eingegangen ist das
ist so höre ich zu sagen dass
Finanzminister gibt in dem Moment wo
humanitäre Krisen auftreten die wir im
Moment noch nicht absehen können muss
auch dafür zusätzliches Geld da sein
die deutsche Außenpolitik verpflichtet
sich internationale Organisation zu
stärken die Außenministerin hat gesagt
wir stärken in der zollorganisation in
Europa hat sich das ausdrücklich noch
mal sagen Deutschland ist die führende
Kraft im Europa-Rat die dafür sorgt dass
der Europarat als wichtigste europäische
Institution und was war wahrscheinlich
weltweit vorbildlich für Menschenrechte
für Demokratie und für Rechtsstaat sich
einsetzen kann und dass wir dort führen
sind und
andere Beispiel für andere entsprechend
auch in Europa finanziell ausgestatten
ist ein gutes Beispiel und ein großes
Problem vielen Dank
ja einsparen und Einschnitte gerade bei
der humanitären Hilfe die um etwa ein
Drittel im Ansatz gekürzt wird das ist
für viele Parlamentarier hier bitter das
kam auch gestern schon bei der Debatte
rund um den Etat für wirtschaftlichen
Sommer wird und Entwicklung immer wieder
thematisch vor und die Sprache und was
dann passiert wenn sozusagen wirklich
ein aktueller Konflikt ausbricht und ob
das dann noch aufgestockt wird das muss
dann der Finanzminister mit absegnen ja
schwierigen Zeiten
all das wirkt auch ins Inland und
betrifft auf vielfältige Art und Weise
einen jeden von uns aber noch relativ
neu an dieser Situation ist seit
ungefähr zwei Jahren dass im Inland nun
der bei weitem größte
Unsicherheitsfaktor die eigene
Bundesregierung ist das hat es so in
dieser Form noch nicht gegeben Millionen
Menschen in unserem Land befürchten den
eigenen wirtschaftlichen Abstieg unsere
Wirtschaft leidet unter einer Politik
der nichts anderes einfällt als zu
bevormunden zu gängeln und zu verbieten
diese
abstiegskoalition kocht weiter ihr
dünnes Süppchen wie ich es gestern bei
der Debatte zum BMZ etwa nannte zu
keinem Haushalt vorher hat es jemals
eine so harsche Kritik vom
Bundesrechnungshof gegeben
ich möchte vorab grundsätzlich
klarstellen dass wir als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse und die
damit notwendigen Kürzungen im gesamter
von gut sechs Prozent nicht in Frage
stellen denn mit insgesamt über
445 Milliarden Euro ist dieser Haushalt
trotzdem einer der größten in der
Geschichte unseres Landes
kritisieren hingegen muss man die
Schwerpunktsetzung in diesem Haushalt
eins bezogen auf den Haushalt des
Auswärtigen Amtes muss man sich die
Fragestellung hat dieser
Haushaltsentwurf Substanz geht dieser
Haushaltsentwurf dort in die Vollen wo
es nötig und angebracht ist und die
Analyse zeigt nein das tut er leider
nicht warum dieser Etat sinkt um fast 18
Prozent im Vergleich 6% der
Gesamthaushalt fast 18 Prozent der
Einzelplan 05 er ist damit der Etat der
am trittstärksten singt innerhalb des
Bundeshaushalts und das in einer
Situation in der niemand ernsthaft
glauben kann dass der Bedarf an
humanitärer Hilfe und auch ein
stabilisierungsmitteln im kommenden Jahr
geringer ausfallen dürfte als heute von
einer guten Regierung kann und muss man
daher erwarten dass der Etat für solche
Situationen haushaltsvorsorge trifft der
in die einschlägigen Haushaltstitel
jedoch lässt auch den wohlwollsten
Beobachter mit einiger Ernüchterung
zurück die Mittel für die so wichtige
humanitäre Hilfe sinken um ein sattes
Drittel von ungefähr 2,7 auf 1,7
Milliarden der Ansatz für die
Stabilisierungsmittel sinkt ungefähr um
ein Viertel dabei stehen
Stabilisierungsmittel meist nicht so im
Fokus aber diese Gelder die sind immens
wichtig sie dienen nämlich dazu Krisen
gar nicht erst in Katastrophen ableiten
zu lassen
das heißt jeder Euro für
Stabilisierungsmittel spart ein
Mehrfaches an humanitärer Hilfe und da
frage ich mich schon wie kann das
Auswärtige Amt ist zulassen dass dieses
wichtigste außenpolitische
Förderinstrument des AA so massiv
absinkt und wie immer
spielt die Bundesregierung auch in
diesem Jahr im Haushaltsverfahren dieses
altbekannte Spiel sie kürzt genau dort
wo völlig klar ist dass das Parlament in
irgendeiner Form reagieren muss es
drängt sich aber doch die Frage auf
wieso das Auswärtige Amt sich das
gefallen lässt immerhin aber hat die
Ministerin eine
Protokollnotiz zum Kabinettsbeschluss
abgegeben sollte also der Bedarf an
einer internationalen Krise entstehen
werde das BMF zusätzliche Mittel für die
humanitäre Hilfe freigeben aber jedem
ist völlig klar diese Protokoll Notiz
kann nur ein Notbehelf sein
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sie wissen
ich habe sie des öfteren für ihr klares
auftreten und für ihre klaren Worte
gelobt mit ihrer deutlichen Sprache
mögen sie leicht dem einen oder anderen
Diplomaten in Ihrem Hause den Schweiß
auf die Stirn getrieben haben ich finde
das in dieser Form dennoch spannend und
habe eine Sympathie für klare Sprache an
den Stellen wo es angebracht und nötig
ist
aber im Entwurf des Haushaltsgesetzes da
war zum Beispiel das zwei Prozent NATO
Ziel ursprünglich festgeschrieben diese
zwei Prozent haben sie dort leider
streichen wollen und aus den jährlich
zwei Prozent lesen wir stattdessen etwas
von einem langjährigen Mittel das
verstehe ich nicht das ist auch das
Gegenteil von klaren Ansagen und klaren
Worte gerade an einer Stelle wo es nötig
wäre sie senden damit eine unheilvolle
Botschaft auch an unsere
naturverbündeten und Freunde die sagen
wir sind keine verlässlichen Partner
das halte ich für einen Fehler und
dennoch freue ich mich auf die mit
Sicherheit sehr spannend werden und
intensiven Beratung zu dem Haushalt des
Auswärtigen Amtes herzlichen Dank
sie sagt Carsten und Körper und ein
bisschen Verteidigung war ja auch schon
dabei dass zwei Prozent NATO Ziel das
wird dann auch gleich wenn hier der
verteidigungsetan nämlich gelesen wird
noch mal eine Rolle spielen letztendlich
aber zum Auswärtigen Christian Petry für
die SPD
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Europa stellt sich neu auf Europa muss
sich neu aufstellen denn wie die
vielfach hier genannt worden ist hat
auch Europa eine Antwort darauf zu geben
und gibt eine Antwort auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg neue
Sicherheitsstrukturen gemeinsam mit der
NATO wir werden den
Verteidigungshaushalt gleich beraten da
bin ich froh dass Boris Pistorius dort
Verantwortung trägt das wird eine große
Aufgabe die am Laufen ist für Europa
Bewältigung der Kurve Krise da bin ich
sehr froh dass in dieser Krise ist
gelungen ist ein flexibles
Aufbauprogramm mit neuen
Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten die vorher
nicht möglich waren sind etablieren auch
darüber müssen wir reden wie wir dies
weiter gestalten können die
Klimaneutralität mit den großen
Programmen und vor allem auch die
Transformation auch für uns im großen
Teilen der Bundesrepublik wichtig wie
wir unsere Industriegesellschaft
transformieren in Klimaneutralität dort
wünsche ich mir natürlich im Rahmen der
Beihilfe bei Europa Flexibilität und
individuelle Lösungen die uns
weiterbringen vor Ort
der 24er Haushalt
[Musik]
da bin ich ganz froh trotzdem Kürzungen
sind eigentlich es ist mehrfach Herr
Fricke hat es genannt es sind mehrfach
genannt worden ist es eigentlich die
Stabilisierung und die fortfolgung vom
19er Haushalt insoweit ist da immer noch
eine Steigerung reinzurechnen hat aber
was die europa-titel angeht Gott sei
Dank und das ist sehr gut und das finde
ich als besonders wichtig die Stärkung
des Zusammenhaltes die Titel die zur
Stärkung des Zusammenhaltes da sind
unberührt gelassen die
deutsch-französische
Projekte die deutsche polnischen
Projekte die blieben erhalten bleiben
erhalten und bilden einen wichtigen
Baustein für uns denn investieren
entlasten und zusammenhalten das Motto
dieses Haushaltes gilt auch hier
ich bin Michael Link ganz froh jetzt ist
er gerade im Moment nicht da an der
Stelle sag ich es immer ach da oben ist
ja prima Michael das ist in gelungen ist
in den Koalitionsvertrag das Ziel wo wir
hin wollen hineinzuschreiben mit deiner
tatkräftigen Unterstützung steht da drin
wir wollen einen föderalen europäischen
Bundesstaat das müssen wir erreichen wie
wollen wir dahin kommen wir wollen
selbstverständlich die Vorschläge zur
Reform der der Europäischen Union nutzen
dramatischerweise die
erweiterungsdebatte unter den
Kriegsbedingungen hat drei Verhalten
viele Länder wollen zu uns da sieht man
mal wie attraktiv wir sind da brauchen
wir Reformen ein Vehikel könnten
Beitrittsverträge sein ein
diskutierbares Phänomen wird sein dass
wir beispielsweise die Mitgliedschaft
quasi in wirkungskreisen näher bis zur
Mitgliedschaft bringen und den Ländern
die Chance im System geben zu uns zu
kommen dass es eben auch schon mehrfach
angesprochen worden das halte ich für
sehr wichtig und hier ist es entgegen
allen reden in der Opposition besonders
von der CDU und Herr grießbaum ich
verstehe nicht was sie da über das
deutsch-französische Verhältnis gesagt
haben vielleicht waren sie schon lange
nicht mehr in Paris das was wir an
Reformvorschlägen seit Jahren
vorschlagen findet immer mehr
Unterstützung findet auch in Frankreich
Unterstützung deutsch-französische
Arbeitsgruppen Arbeiten an den
Vorstellungen werden es repräsentieren
wir sind dort ein starker Motor in der
deutschen Außenpolitik in der deutschen
Europapolitik und alles was so an
Bildern an die Wand gemalt werden
entspricht nicht der Realität darauf
können wir stolz sein
und wir werden diese Reformen der
Institutionen daran knüpfen
Rechtstaatlichkeit und
rechtsstaatmechanismus werden aber ein
hohes Gut bleiben und müssen gestärkt
werden denn neue Orbans brauchen wir
nicht wir brauchen Länder die unsere
liberalen Demokratien stärken und dort
werden wir auch den Maßstab ansetzen
deswegen halte ich es auch für wichtig
den Konvent wieder vorzuführen auch wenn
er kein Ergebnis bringen wird was direkt
umsetzbar ist so ist der absolut
notwendig um die Orientierung und die
Basis für gemeinsames Arbeiten zu
schaffen ich lade alle ein hier
mitzumachen investieren
[Musik]
und Zusammenhalt das wird dem Maßstab
sein wir bringen uns hier ein hier
orientieren sich viele an uns das ist
eine dankbare Aufgabe liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Liebe Demokraten in diesem
Hause lassen wir uns gemeinsam diese
Aufgabe angehen denn das ist ein
dankbares Ziel wir bringen Europa voran
auch mit diesem Haushalt vielen Dank
ja und damit hat Christian Petri für die
SPD das Schlusswort zumindest hier zur
Debatte zum Einzelplan 05 das
auswärtigen Abend ist ja die
Schuldenbremse soll im nächsten Jahr
wieder eingehalten werden das heißt
viele Ministerien müssen sparen auch das
Auswärtige Amt 6,16 Milliarden Euro
sieht es im nächsten Jahr sieht der
Bundesfinanzminister für das auswärtige
Ausgaben vor das sind
-1,32 Milliarden im Vergleich zu diesem
Jahr also eine ordentliche Einsparung
und die bundesaußenministerin Annalena
bärburg die hat sich unzufrieden gezeigt
mit den strengenden haushaltsvorgaben
der Schuldenbremse hier zu Beginn dieser
Debatte dass der Italiens Auswärtigen
Amtes im kommenden Jahr wegen sparzing
gekürzt wurde dass er schmerzhaft hat
Annalena bärburg hier gesagt und das
insbesondere angesichts der Lage in der
ein Krieg in Europa tobt ja nicht nur
Anna-Lena baerbock ist von schwarzwängen
getroffen wie gesagt viele Ministerien
müssen Spanien nicht sparen muss
hingegen brauchst Pistorius der wird
jetzt als nächstes Jahr am Rednerpult
erwartet denn es geht jetzt um den
einzelplanen 14 den Nivea Boris
Pistorius hat im nächsten Jahr etwas
mehr zur Verfügung als diesem Jahr
51,8 Milliarden und dann gibt es ja noch
Geld aus dem Sondervermögen Präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Frau werbeauftragte lieber
Eva Högl die erste Feststellung voran es
geht voran das ist die Kernaussage des
verteidigungshaushaltes für das kommende
Jahr mit insgesamt 71 Milliarden Euro
aus dem Einzelplan 14 und den Mittel aus
dem Sondervermögen steht uns im
kommenden Jahr so viel Geld für unsere
Bundeswehr zur Verfügung wie noch nie
und das sind Mittel meine Damen und
Herren die wir brauchen die wir brauchen
um unsere Sicherheit zu investieren für
die Männer und Frauen die jeden Tag
einen so wichtigen und oftmals
gefährlichen Dienst für unsere
Sicherheit und Freiheit leisten und
dienen möchte ich an dieser Stelle
besonders herzlich von hier aus danken
das gilt besonders natürlich für die
vielen Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
aktuell im Auftrag des Deutschen
Bundestages im Einsatz sind
meine Damen und Herren wir investieren
in die Menschen der Bundeswehr wir
investieren in die Bundeswehr wir
investieren in die Beschaffung von
modernen geeignetem Gerät für die Truppe
um unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit zu
verbessern und wir können uns keine
Abstriche bei unserer eigenen Sicherheit
leisten erst recht nicht wenn für
unserer Türe einen brutaler
Angriffskrieg tobt denn dieser Krieg das
kann man nicht oft genug wiederholen ist
nicht nur ein Angriff auf die souveräne
und freie Ukraine sondern auch ein
fundamentaler Angriff auf unsere
internationale sicherheitsordnung das
Völkerrecht und unsere Art zu leben
meine Damen und Herren
aber wir dürfen nicht eine Sekunde ein
Zweifel daran lassen Putin darf damit
nicht durchkommen und deswegen werden
wir die Ukraine auf allen Ebenen
unterstützen auch militärisch solange
wie das nötig ist
und ich kann
durchaus mit Stolz sagen es ist heute
morgen schon gesagt worden die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist nach den
USA der zweitgrößte Unterstützer der
Ukraine und diese Unterstützung ist von
zentraler Bedeutung für ihre
Selbstverteidigung jeden Tag retten
deutsche Waffen in der Ukraine
ukrainisches Leben und wir unterstützen
mit Material
aber auch mit Ausbildung da werden wir
bis Ende des Jahres in Deutschland
insgesamt 10.000 ukrainische Soldatinnen
und Soldaten ausgebildet haben und ich
weiß aus der Ukraine das gerade die
Qualität dieser Ausbildung immer wieder
gelobt wird
zusätzlich übernehmen wir international
Verantwortung und tragen zur
abschreckungsfähigkeit unseres
Bündnisses bei mit unserem breiten
Engagement an der NATO Ostflanke
und ja meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland muss Führung übernehmen
deshalb wollen wir erstmals überhaupt
eine Brigade dauerhaft in Litauen
stationieren wir zeigen damit unseren
Alliierten dass wir an ihrer Seite
stehen das auf uns Verlass ist und wir
machen damit die Zeitenwende sichtbar
und spürbar für unsere Sicherheit und
die Sicherheit unserer Partner und
Freunde meine Damen und Herren
und die Umsetzung dieser Entscheidung
wird natürlich mit den NATO
verteidigungsplänen in Einklang stehen
und eng mit unseren Partnern vor Ort
abgestimmt die ersten Planungsschritte
sind bereits gemacht jetzt muss die
nötige Infrastruktur vor Ort geschaffen
werden
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren in
Zukunft werden wir zwei Prozent unserer
Wirtschaftsleistung in Verteidigung
investieren dabei ist die Maus den Faden
nicht ab damit halten wir unser
Versprechen gegenüber unseren
Bündnispartnern und kommen unseren
Verpflichtungen in der NATO endlich nach
vor allem aber
investieren wir damit in die
Einsatzbereitschaft unserer Bundeswehr
und in unsere Sicherheit
lassen Sie mich einen Blick zurückwerfen
auf das was wir im laufenden Jahr
bereits geschafft haben wir haben
wichtige Rüstungsvorhaben unter Vertrag
genommen dazu zählen unter anderem die
Beschaffung von weiteren 50
Schützenpanzern Puma von 60 schweren
Transporthubschraubern ca 47 von 227
über schneefahrzeugen der neuesten
Generation und von mehreren Systemen
ihres tslm für die bodengestützte
Luftverteidigung außerdem beabsichtigen
wir in Kürze gemeinsam mit den
Ausschüssen die Beschaffung für das
Luftverteidigungssystem Arrow zeitnah
abzuschließen und meine Damen und Herren
vor
und 2024 bei den Ausgaben für die
munitionsbeschaffung noch einmal mehr um
das Doppelte zu steigern deutlich
steigern werden wir auch unsere Ausgaben
bei der Materialerhaltung auch das ist
notwendig da ist in den letzten 30
Jahren viel
heruntergewirtschaftet worden und das
ist jetzt notwendig das zu ändern und
die Einsatzbereitschaft unserer
Waffensysteme sicherzustellen und wir
sind das große Thema Beschaffung
angegangen
angegangen und haben unnötige Hemmnisse
abgebaut
unser Ziel schneller werden der Faktor
Zeit hat nun höchste Priorität bei der
Beschaffung und ist bestimmend für alle
laufenden und neuen Rüstungsvorhaben
damit machen wir endlich Tempo bei der
Beschaffung und schon jetzt das will ich
sagen haben wir in diesem Jahr bis zum
heutigen Tag mehr 25 Millionen Euro ins
Parlament gebracht als im ganzen
vergangenen Jahr meine Damen und
Herren wir arbeiten gleichzeitig mit
Hochdruck daran eine angemessene
personelle Ausstattung der Bundeswehr zu
erreichen auch eine wichtige Aufgabe
denn eines ist klar wir werden mit all
unseren Bemühungen nur erfolgreich sein
wenn wir auch weiterhin hochmotivierte
und qualifizierte Soldatin und Soldaten
für unsere Bundeswehr gewinnen können
meine Damen und Herren
die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie die
wir im Juni beschlossen haben
unterstreicht die Bundeswehr ist eines
der kerninstrumenten der integrierte
integrierten Sicherheit ihre Aufgabe ist
es unsere Freiheit und Sicherheit wenn
es nötig ist zu verteidigen diese
Aufgabe kann sie aber nur erfüllen wenn
sie für die Zukunft entsprechend
aufgestellt ist deshalb müssen unsere
Verteidigungsaufgaben auch die
Leistungsfähigkeit gewährleisten die wir
uns selbst mit dieser Strategie ins
Lastenheft geschrieben haben wir stehen
heute besser da als vor einem Jahr ganz
eindeutig und mindestens genauso wichtig
wie investieren nun endlich wieder zur
Wahrheit meine Damen und Herren gehört
aber auch dass ich in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen für einen
deutlich stärkeren steigenden
Verteidigungsetat eingetreten bin und
ich werde mich auch weiter dafür stark
machen
das Sondervermögen wird voraussichtlich
[Applaus]
Opposition kleine Ausflug in die
Geschichte gefällig seit 2005 haben sie
als Union die Verteidigungsminister
gestellt wo war da eigentlich ihre große
Unterstützung nichts als
Lippenbekenntnisse ohne
loyalitätsadressen und Sonntagsreden
meine Damen und Herren und wenn sie seit
2005 wenn sie seit 2005 diese Bundeswehr
nicht ja und ja mit einem Sparprogramm
überzogen hätten wenn sie nicht in der
Früh nicht immer Herr Scholz
2009 bis 13 haben sie
Strauß hat mal gesagt ein Kehlkopf
ersetzt noch keinen Kopf ich weiß nicht
wieso ich da jetzt gerade drauf komme
aber
sie haben seit 2005 eine Sprache und
nach der nächsten durchgeführt und sie
haben in ihrer Periode 2009 bis 13 da
war die SPD nicht beteiligt aus
fiskalischen Gründen sowohl die Heeres
Flugabwehr abgeschafft als auch die
Wehrdienst ausgesetzt das gehört zur
Wahrheit in der Geschichte auch dazu
meine Damen und Herren und wenn die
Lücke nicht so groß wäre wie wir
vorgefunden haben dann hätten wir heute
weniger Hausaufgaben zu machen aber
meine Damen und Herren
das Sondervermögen wird voraussichtlich
27 28 verbraucht sein und nur ein
dauerhaft auch dann steigender
Verteidigungsetat sorgt dann das föder
für auch in Zukunft ausreichend Geld für
die Truppe haben und das nato-ziel
erreichen und darauf wird es ankommen
und nur eine starke
Verteidigungsindustrie das will ich auch
noch dazu sagen in Deutschland und
Europa sorgt dafür dass wir das Geld in
Form von Material und Ausrüstung und
auch schnell und verlässlich auf den Hof
bekommen dafür muss die Industrie die
entsprechenden Kapazitäten vorhalten ja
aber dafür braucht sie auch
Verlässlichkeit und Planbarkeit auch mit
Blick auf unsere mittelfristigen
Verteidigungsausgaben meine Damen und
Herren ich bitte sie zeigen Sie mit der
Zustimmung zu diesem Haushalt dass wir
unseren Soldatinnen und Soldaten das
geben wollen das geben was sie brauchen
dass sie fest an der Seite unsere Truppe
stehen an der Seite ihrer
Parlamentsarmee zeigen sie dass wir als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland bereit sind
gemeinsam mit unseren Bündnispartnern
Verantwortung zu übernehmen für die
Sicherheit und Freiheit in Europa und
für eine internationale Ordnung des
Rechts vielen Dank
der Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius Herr der Etat ist sehr
zweitgrößte Einzelplan im Gesamthaushalt
mit 51,8 Milliarden das ist vorgesehen
für 2024 das sind 1,7 Milliarden mehr
als dieses Jahr aber dieser Betrag der
deckt den Bedarf der wegen
Tarifsteigerungen nötig ist und dann
gibt es aber noch 19,2 Milliarden aus
dem Sondervermögen aber nicht als Teil
des weathers 2024 sind geprägt von
Eigenlob Ablenkungsmanövern unter dem
Versuch mit der Ankündigung des
Bundeskanzlers mehr Tempo machen zu
wollen vor die kommunikative Welle zu
kommen ich kann das ja verstehen ich
kann das ja verstehen vor allem
angesichts der deserströsen
wirtschaftlichen Situationen unseres
Landes die hat der Bundeskanzler ja
heute selbst attestiert und der Krise in
die Sie uns diese Bundesregierung in
vielen Bereichen in einem
atemberaubenden Tempo geführt haben
allerdings möchte ich sie waren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
dass sie dieser Propaganda die sie da
verbreiten nicht selber aufsetzen ich
fürchte aber genau das tun sie und Ihnen
sehr geehrter Herr Bundesminister
Pistorius möchte ich raten hören sie auf
ihrem Parlament und vor allem den
betroffenen Soldaten und zivilen
Angestellten der Bundeswehr was vor zu
machen das sorgt gerade in der Truppe
für einen immensen Vertrauensverlust im
Moment
ihre ihre
Rede ihre Rede verdient die Überschrift
tricksen täuschen tarnen Herr
Bundesminister sie tricksen wenn sie
behaupten dass sie zwei Prozent würde
erreicht werden schließlich buchen Sie
nicht nur das Sondervermögen gegen die
eigene Ankündigung des Bundeskanzlers
bei seiner Rede letztes Jahr in die zwei
Prozent rein nein sie buchen auch noch
mehr als 14 Milliarden Euro aus anderen
Resorts genaues weiß man nicht dazu all
die billigen fiskalischen Taschenspieler
Tricks mit denen das zwei Prozent Ziel
auf dem Papier erreicht werden soll
helfen der Bundeswehr aber nicht
verteidigungsfähiger zu werden
Bundesminister und das ist das
entscheidende
und der Bundesminister und der
Bundesminister sieht täuschen sie
täuschen eine ordnungsgemäße Verwendung
des Sondervermögens vor dieses
Sondervermögen war dazu gedacht die
Bundeswehr wieder fit zu machen und das
Geld in die Finanzierung bedeutsamer
ausrüstungsvorhaben zu stecken sie
verwenden es aber zunehmend zu
Finanzierung anderer alltagsmaßnahmen
die sich nicht mit dem ursprünglichen
Zweck denken das ist rechtlich
unzulässig Herr Minister und das sagen
nicht nur wir von der Union sondern das
bestätigte diese Woche auch der
Bundesrechnungshof
und Herr Bundesminister
zitarnen sie tarnen tarnen ihre eigene
völlige Niederlage bei diesen
Haushaltsverhandlungen als Erfolg sie
hatten eine jährliche Steigerung des
verteidigungshaushaltes unabhängig vom
Sondervermögen von 10 Milliarden Euro
gefordert nichts ist daraus geworden sie
konnten sich in keinster Weise
durchsetzen sie haben gerade mal die
steigenden Kosten für das Personal
erstattet bekommen das ist eine wirklich
bittere Niederlage für Sie
und liebe liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Ampel fährt mit diesem Haushalt die
Bundeswehr gerade mit Vorsatz an die
Wand spätestens in drei Jahren stehen
wir vor dem finanziellen Abgrund denn
nach dem Sondervermögen klafft eine
gewaltige Finanzierungslücke von 30
Milliarden Euro das hat sogar der
Bundeskanzler heute bestätigt und meine
Damen und Herren der
Verteidigungshaushalt 2024 ist aber auch
ein fatales Signal deutscher Politik ein
fatales Signal an die eigene Truppe die
an die zeitenwände des Kanzlers geglaubt
hat und nun feststellen muss dass sich
nichts ändert zweitens eine fatale
Signal an unsere Verbündeten in NATO und
Europäischer Union Deutschland ist
wieder wortküche und liefert gegenüber
dem Bündnis nicht ausreichend und
drittens ein fatales Signal ein fatales
Signal an Vladimir Putin denn Putin weiß
jetzt dass Deutschland nicht konsequent
an einer rapiden Verbesserung seiner
Bündnis und Verteidigungsfähigkeit
arbeiten
der Bund stellt Streitkräfte zur
Verteidigung auf so steht es im
Grundgesetz und dazu braucht es
angesichts der aktuellen Bedrohungslage
eine klare Steigerung unserer
Fähigkeiten und Anstrengungen im
Verteidigungsbereich wir als Union haben
das schon 2014 erkannt Herr Minister und
die ersten dringenden notwendigen
Maßnahmen und Trendwenden eingeleitet
doch und so ehrlich will ich schon sein
doch zu ehrlich sind wir auch wir
konnten uns gegen unseren damaligen
Koalitionspartner die SPD nicht völlig
durchsetzt und das und das meine Damen
und Herren das war fahrlässig das wissen
wir heute aber auch mehr oder weniger
Konsens in der politischen Landschaften
der damaligen Zeit und spätestens aber
mit dem Überfall der Russischen
Föderation auf die Ukraine müssten sich
auch der letzte einen gestehen dass die
Bundeswehr nicht ausreichend
verteidigungsfähig ist umso lieber haben
wir alle dem Bundeskanzler geglaubt als
er uns letztes Jahr eine Zeitenwende
zugunsten der Bundeswehr versprochen hat
endlich das Geld bereitzustellen zu
wollen was die Bundeswehr braucht um
vollständig und tatsächlich
verteidigungsfähig zu sein mit Blick auf
diesen Haushalt kann ich nur sagen
nichts als Lehre Versprechungen und
meine Damen und Herren das ist nicht
mehr so fahrlässig nicht nur mehr
fahrlässig wie in der Vergangenheit
sondern das ist wieder besseren Wissens
und damit Vorsatz und wir fordern als
Union erstens das Sondervermögen muss
endlich und ausschließlich eingesetzt
werden wofür es da ist die Bundeswehr zu
modernisieren zweitens jährlich 10
Milliarden mehr für den
Verteidigungshaushalt um das zwei
Prozent Ziel auch real zu erreichen und
drittens Bürokratieabbau schlankere
Strukturen und eine Reform des
Beschaffungswesen müssen endlich auf dem
Weg gebracht werden wo ein Wille ist da
ist auch ein Weg der Haushalt ist noch
nicht beschlossen sie können noch
Umsteuern liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Ampel damit Deutschland endlich
Bündnis und verteidigungsfähiger wird
und die Zeiten wenn der auch wirklich
stattfindet herzlichen Dank
vor der Tür Florian Hahn der
Verteidigungsmittel zu Sprecher der CDU
CSU-Fraktion ja mindestens zwei Prozent
der Wirtschaftsleistung für Verteidigung
auszugeben das haben sich die
NATO-Staaten sozusagen zugesagt sich
diesen Wert anzunehmen die
Bundesregierung will im kommenden Jahr
erstmals auf diesen Wert kommen auch
durch das Sondervermögen sagte liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja so ehrlich
wollten sie sein aber es hat nicht
geklappt und ich meine dieses Bild haben
viele ihrer Rednerinnen in den anderen
Debatten auch schon bedient sie
behaupten hier dass die wirtschaftliche
Lage in Deutschland so schlecht ist und
natürlich erleben die Menschen viele
Probleme in ihrem Alltag auch die
Unternehmen das ist eine Folge dieses
brutalen russischen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine und es gehört schon einiges
dazu Teil der Bundesregierung zu sein
die uns trotz zahlreicher Warnung
übrigens der Leute die gerade ihre
Versäumnisse aufgeräumt haben ja sie
haben uns in diese fossile Abhängigkeit
geführt die uns teuer zu stehen gekommen
ist da gehört einiges dazu und ehrlich
ist das nicht
dieser Krieg es bedeutet 18 Monate voll
von Gewalt von Terror und Tod er war ein
völkerrechtswidriger Überfall Russlands
auf sein friedlichen Nachbarn die
Ukraine 18 Monate in denen die
russischen Truppen fast jedes Tabu und
jede Regel des Kriegsvölkerrechts
gebrochen haben 18 Monate in den
Kindesentführung Folter und Zerstörung
von Städten Theatern und Krankenhäusern
stattfinden und Tag vertragt trotzdem
seit 18 Monaten mutige Menschen in der
Ukraine dieser brutalen Gewalt des
kreml-regimes und verteidigen dabei mehr
als nur ihr Land ihr Leben und ihre
Freiheiten sie schützen auch unsere
Sicherheit die Sicherheitslage auf
unserem Kontinent hat sich fundamental
verändert und vor diesem Hintergrund
diskutieren wir diesen Bundeshaushalt
und gerade auch den Verteidigungsetat
man sieht es Tag für Tag an so vielen
Tatsachen es ist Vladimir Putin der
nicht verhandeln will und der immer
weiter mit Gewalt eskaliert dazu braucht
er auch kein Anlass von irgendjemandem
sein brutales Kalkül scheint zu sein
diesen Krieg und Terror immer weiter in
die Länge zu ziehen damit die Menschen
in der Ukraine und auch ihre vielen
Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer
weltweit müde werden aber diesen
Gefallen werden wir ihm nicht tun
solange Russland nicht bereit ist die
Gewalt zu beenden und zu Verhandlungen
über ein gerechten Frieden zukommen
solange haben wir zwei Optionen wir
könnten beschließen die Unterstützung
der Ukraine bei ihrer legitim
Selbstverteidigung zu beenden ich will
das nicht denn das würde bedeuten dass
Russland früher oder später diesen Krieg
gewinnt mit verheerenden Folgen für die
Menschen in der Ukraine es ist doch auch
eine Illusion zu glauben dass in diesem
Fall die gewaltendet das zeigt der
Alltag in den besetzten Gebieten das
zeigen die Verbrechen in Städten wie ihr
hin und Botschaft
aber auch die Folgen für unsere
Sicherheit wären katastrophal besetzte
Territorium können wir die für die
Stationierung von Waffensystemen
deutlich näher an uns geografisch dran
genutzt werden und wer garantiert dass
dort nicht früher oder später einem
militärische Übungen beginnt sie dann
zum nächsten völkerrechtswidrigen
Überfall führt und nicht zuletzt würde
von einem russischen Sieg die Botschaft
an alle anderen Aggressoren und
Autokraten dieser Welt ausgehen dass ich
völkerung Brüche am Ende lohnen ein
solchen Weg kann ich und können viele
hier nicht verantworten und zwar nicht
nur aufgrund unserer Werte und der
Solidarität mit den Menschen in der
Ukraine sondern auch weil die wenn wir
die Risiken für unser Land und die
Folgen für unsere gesamte regelbasierte
Ordnung sehen denn diese beruht auf dem
Grundsatz das Konflikte zwischen Staaten
mit Worten und Verhandlungen ausgetragen
werden und nicht mit Raketen und
Kriegsverbrechen und diesen Anspruch
dürfen wir niemals aufgeben und auch
nicht den Recht des militärisch
stärkeren und skrupelloseren beugen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
andere Alternative ist die Ukraine
weiter entschlossen und unermüdlich zu
unterstützen so wichtig Diplomatie und
Sanktionen sind und man muss hier immer
mehr tun und alles versuchen am Ende war
es vor allem die mutige gegenwäre
Ukraine mit unserer Unterstützung die
zur Befreiung besetzter Gebiete und
einem Ende des Terrors zumindest dort
geführt hat Waffenlieferungen sind nicht
das Gegenteil von Diplomatie sondern
unser Kalkül besteht doch genau darin
Putin an den Verhandlungstisch zu
zwingen indem er endlich realisiert dass
er seine Ziele auf dem Schlachtfeld
niemals wird erreichen können
und deshalb geht auch von der zweiten
Haushaltsdebatte die wir seit dem
Kriegsbeginn am 24 Februar 22 führen
ganz klar die Botschaft aus Deutschland
steht als zweitgrößter Unterstützer nach
den USA weiter solidarisch an der Seite
der unschuldigen Menschen in der Ukraine
die Jüngsten mit der Lieferung von
weiteren Leopard 1 Panzern der Übergabe
eines feldlers oder endlich endlich neu
produzierter und dringend benötigter
Munition für den Gepard und natürlich
wegen wir die Risiken die mit
Waffenlieferungen und jedem Waffensystem
verbunden sind sorgfältig ab aber ich
will auch einmal sehr klar sagen auch
verweigern und verzögern kann ein hohen
Preis haben und am Ende sicher nicht
gewollt zu Eskalation beitragen
angesichts der brutalen russischen
Luftangriffe auf zivile Infrastruktur
auf Krankenhäuser Schulen
Kultureinrichtungen und
Energieversorgung ist gerade das
Schwerpunkt bei der Luftverteidigung so
besonders wichtig die militärisch
größten Schwächen der russischen
Streitkräfte in ihrem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine sind Logistik Versorgung und
Material alle Fähigkeiten die der
Ukraine hier eine größere Reichweite für
gezielte Schläge gegen militärische
Ziele ermöglicht haben haben im letzten
Jahr ein sehr relevanten Unterschied
gemacht die Ukraine hat gezeigt dass sie
beim Einsatz von gelieferten Waffen ein
verlässlicher Partner ist und deshalb
befürworten wir auch die Lieferung von
Taurus
und eins will ich aber auch Richtung
Bundeswehr und die Soldaten und Soldaten
in aller Deutlichkeit sagen wir wissen
als Abgeordnete demokratischen
Fraktionen im Verteidigungsausschuss
dass wir in die ohnehin unzureichende
Ausstattung der Bundeswehr große
lückenreißen die Sie gerade bei Übungen
und Ausbildungen beeinträchtigen wir
brauchen in diesen unsicheren Zeiten
mehr denn je eine gut ausgestattete und
einsatzbereite Bundeswehr das schließt
auch die zügige Nachbeschaffung der an
die Ukraine gelieferten Systeme ebenso
mit ein wie neu Beschaffung dafür haben
wir in diesem Haushalt und mit dem
Sondervermögen wichtige erste Grundlagen
geschaffen und diese Fragen haben für
die Bundesregierung und für unsere
Koalition eine hohe Priorität
meine Damen und Herren vielleicht haben
sie die ein oder andere Schlagzeile der
letzten Jahre über unsere Bundeswehr in
Erinnerung trümmertruppe bedingt
einsatzbereit ich will an der Stelle
einmal sagen was ich und glaube ich
viele im Verteidigungsausschuss die
letzten Jahre gesehen und erlebt haben
was unsere Soldaten und Soldaten Tag für
Tag geleistet haben ob das die
Bewältigung der Pandemie die Versorgung
von geflüchteten die Flutkatastrophe war
die Ausbildung der ukrainischen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
Unterstützung unserer Verbündeten an der
Ostflanke der NATO oder in gefährlichen
Einsätzen wie jüngst bei der
evakuierungsmission aus dem Sudan all
das zeigt eine Bundeswehr die als
Gesellschaft unsere größte Hochachtung
entgegenbringen sollten für ihren
wichtigen und schweren
[Applaus]
die Bundeswehr ist nämlich immer da und
packt an wo es brenzlig und schwierig
wird und wo wir sie brauchen und dafür
ein großes Danke meine Damen und Herren
es gibt sehr grundsätzliche Fragen nach
dem Ende des Krieges nach der neuen
sicherheitsordnung in Europa nach dem
Wert von Sicherheit in unserer
Gesellschaft auf die dieser Haushalt
keine abschließende Antwort gibt und
geben kann und das sind wichtige
Debatten die wir miteinander in diesem
Haus in den nächsten Jahren führen
müssen vielen Dank
auch akneschka proger hier für die grüne
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
sagte Unterstützung für die Ukraine
weiterhin zu die grüne Fraktion übrigens
unterstützt auch den Wunsch aus Kiew
nach Lieferung von Marschflugkörpern vom
Typ Taurus aus Deutschland auch die
FDP-Fraktion unterstützt das Kanzler
Scholz der hat sich bisher dazu eher
zurückhaltend es gibt Befürchtungen dass
die marschflowkörper auch russisches
Territorium erreichen könnten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im
Saarland bei Youtube der Kernhaushalt
des Verteidigungsministeriums soll nach
dem Willen der Ampel 2024 ein Volumen
von
51,8 Milliarden Euro verfassen damit
wächst der Etat um fast 1,7 Milliarden
Euro und das ist angesichts des Zustand
des Zustandes unserer Streitkräfte erst
einmal eine gute Nachricht daneben
sollen aus dem sogenannten
Sondervermögen eigentlich sonderschulden
weitere 19,2 Milliarden Euro abfließen
was grundsätzlich auch erstmal gut ist
endlich passiert was jetzt bleibt nur
noch die Frage was eigentlich genau
passiert denn Geld ausgeben hast Du noch
lange nicht dass man Geld auch
vernünftig ausgibt fangen wir mal mit
der ersten Schwachstelle ihrer Pläne an
Sie haben immer noch viel zu wenig
Munition auf dem Einkaufszettel und da
hilft es auch nicht dass sie dann sowohl
aus dem Kernhaushalt als auch aus dem
Sondervermögen finanzieren insgesamt
wollen sie Munition für rund 3,5
Milliarden Euro beschaffen was jetzt
erstmal viel klingt doch sollte einmal
über Nacht der Ernstfall eintreten
werden wir immer noch wahnsinnig
schlecht ausgerüstet und nur sehr
schlecht in der Lage die Menschen in
diesem Land adäquat zu beschützen
von daher hatten wir uns gerade hier wo
es um den unmittelbaren Schutz unserer
Bevölkerung geht deutlich mehr
Anstrengungen erwartet Herr Minister
insbesondere da sie im Rahmen des
Nato-Gipfels im Juli der Ukraine weitere
Waffen und Munitionen im Wert von 700
Millionen Euro zugesagt hat da wäre dann
auch schon mal knapp die Hälfte der
etat-erhöhung Weg deshalb werden wir
auch in dieser Haushaltsberatung bei der
Munition wie wir es immer gemacht haben
nochmals eine deutliche Erhöhung
beantragen die zweite Sache die ich
heute ansprechen will ist die wieder mal
das in Diskussion stehende Abschaffung
der 25 Millionen Euro Vorlagen zum
Verständnis für alle die uns gerade
zuschauen was sind 25 Millionen Euro
Vorlagen bei 25 Millionen Euro Vorlagen
handelt es sich um Rüstungsprojekte oder
beabsichtigte Beschaffungen im
Zuständigkeitsbereich des
Verteidigungsministeriums die ein
Volumen von 25 Millionen Euro
überschreiten daher der Name logisch
diese Projekte müssen dann im
Haushaltsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestags zur Billigung vorgelegt
werden das heißt dass der
Verteidigungsminister den
Haushaltsausschuss bei jedem Projekt das
mehr als 25 Millionen Euro kostet um
Erlaubnis fragen muss und das obwohl er
ein jährlich festgelegtes Budget hat
wenn der Haushaltsausschuss dann zum
Beispiel sagt rein wir kaufen jetzt
keine Hubschrauber dann hat der
Verteidigungsminister halt Pech gehabt
in der Regel ist das natürlich kein
Problem weil die jeweilige Regierung
über eine entsprechende Mehrheit im
Haushaltsausschuss verfügt so dass der
Minister die Hubschrauber dann schon
bekommt allerdings versetzen diese 25
Millionen Vorlagen die Opposition
grundsätzlich erst einmal in die Lage
Einblick in das Beschaffungswesen des
Verteidigungsministeriums zu nehmen und
nur wenn man Einblick hat kann man auch
Verbesserungsvorschläge machen nur wenn
man Einblick hat kann man die Rolle als
Opposition überhaupt wahrnehmen und das
haben wir in der Schule gelernt das ist
nun mal die Kontrolle der Regierung zu
dieser Kontrolle der Regierung gehört
natürlich auch die Beteiligung der
Öffentlichkeit und das Führen von
öffentlichen Debatten die zahlreiche
Artikel die man immer mal wieder in der
Presse liest über jeden oder diesen
schaffenskandal bei der Bundeswehr das
sind alles auch Ergebnisse von diesen 25
Millionen Euro Vorlagen und da liegt der
Fahrt Hase im Pfeffer ohne 25 Millionen
Euro Vorlagen hätte der
Verteidigungsminister kein schnelleres
oder effizienteres Beschaffungswesen
aber dafür zumindest ein Geräusch
größeres ihm und der Regierung bliebe so
manche öffentliche Debatte erspart und
das ist es worum es am Ende geht Deckel
drauf Klappe halten nun haben sowohl die
ehemalige Ministerin Frau Lambrecht als
auch Herr Minister Pistorius gegenüber
dem Haushaltsausschuss erklärt dass sie
die 25 Millionen Vorlagen keinesfalls
antasten werden und das haben wir hier
auch alle sehr gerne gehört allerdings
kam in diesem Jahr ein Gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen Beirats beim
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz sinngemäß zu dem Ergebnis
dass diese ganzen 25 Millionen Vorlagen
in die Quatsch sind nur hinderlich und
abgeschafft gehören Demokratie gehört im
Grünen geführten Wirtschaftsministerium
offenbar zu den lästigen Dingen die man
lieber heute als morgen loswerden will
und wer weiß vielleicht ist der Habiger
nicht der Einzige der das Parlament hier
entmachten möchte dass diesen Grund will
ich Ihnen Herr historisch sollte sagen
nach egal die treppensen wenn ihre
Regierung den Versuch unternehmen sollte
diese 25 Millionen Euro verlang
abzuschaffen wird sie auf ein wehrhaftes
Parlament stoßen
anstatt diese Vorlagen abzuschaffen
sollten Sie im Gegenteil viel mehr
Verbreitung finden auch in ganz anderen
Fachausschüssen das würde die Arbeit des
Parlaments und unserer Fachausschüsse
ungemein aufwerten und ganz neue
Debatten und vielleicht sogar viel viel
bessere Lösung ermöglichen aber klar das
werden wir in dieser Legislaturperiode
wohl kaum erleben auf die nächste 25
Millionen Euro Vorlage ihres Hauses der
Minister freuen uns jedenfalls jetzt
schon und werden weiterhin konstruktiv
mitwirken ich danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner ist Carsten klein für
die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Westintegration in den 50ern die
Ostpolitik in den 70ern die
Wiedervereinigung 1990 und jetzt heute
die Zeitenwende die Unterstützung der
Selbstverteidigung der demokratischen
Völker für all diese Entscheidungen
haben wir Freien Demokraten hat die FDP
Verantwortung übernommen
und die Geschichte hat gezeigt dass es
richtige Entscheidungen war aber es
waren für die jeweiligen politischen
Generation auch für die Gesellschaften
keine einfachen Entscheidungen es war
jeweils ein großer Kraftakt und dieser
Kraftakt der Zeitenwende den Schultern
SPD Grüne und FDP den Schuld hat diese
Ampelkoalition
und wir Schultern diesen Kraftakt indem
wir die Verteidigungsausgaben die Mittel
für unsere Landesverteidigung erheblich
aufwachsen lassen im Kernhaushalt des
Einzelnen Plan 15 ist geplant für 2024
51,8 Milliarden Euro und hinzu kommen
die Möglichkeiten aus dem Sondervermögen
in Höhe von 100 Milliarden Euro das sind
viele Milliarden Euro mehr die zur
Verfügung stehen als noch die
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung für die
Jahre mit 47 Milliarden Euro geplant
hatte und diese Mittel ermöglichen uns
auch Projekte durchzuführen über die wir
zwar in der letzten Legislatur liebe
Kollegen der Union sehr intensiv
diskutiert haben aber für die niemand
die Finanzierung sichergestellt hat die
Nachfolge des Tornados die Beschaffung
der 35 die Fortsetzung der nuklearen
Teilhabe als
integriertaler Bestandteil unserer
Sicherheitsarchitektur ist dafür nur ein
Beispiel die Raketenabwehr ein anderes
aber diese Mittel ermöglichen uns auch
Verlässlichkeit in die Finanzierung der
Verteidigungsausgaben zu bekommen und es
ist ein wichtiger Baustein wenn es um
Abschreckung geht ja es ist ein
wichtiges Zeichen an unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten an unsere Partner Nationen
an die Rüstungsindustrie für die
Planungssicherheit aber es ist vor allem
auch ein wichtiges Zeichen einer
diejenigen die uns nichts Gutes wollen
dass wir es ernst meinen mit der
nachhaltigen Finanzierung unserer
Verteidigungsausgaben
und weil von der Union ja so vollmundig
immer mehr Forderungen kommen noch mehr
Mittel einzusetzen wir haben das heute
mehrmals gehört möchte ich doch hier
noch mal festhalten der Union ist es
nach 2014 nicht gelungen diesen Kraftakt
zu schultern die Verteidigungsausgaben
sind nicht in den Umfang angewachsen wie
ist die Kanzlerin Merkel versprochen hat
2015 lag die NATO wurde bei 1,18 Prozent
2018 bei
1,25% und zuletzt obwohl schwächelnde
Wirtschaft 2021 bei 1,49% und damit weit
weg von 2% Ziel wir die Ampel wir werden
aber das 2% sind 2024 erreichen wir
Schultern diese zeitenwände
und der Minister
jetzt erst zu Putz gesprungen nur über
diese zwei Prozent Linie als
Zielrichtung zu reden sondern ist ja
wichtig was wir mit diesen Mitteln
erreichen und deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir die Verausgabung zügig
zielorientiert und effektiv vornehmen
wollen am Anfang des Jahres waren ein
Drittel des Sondervermögens für Ausgaben
gebunden mittlerweile sind aber ca 50%
und wir haben uns alle gemeinsam
vorgenommen dass am Ende des Jahres
mindestens zwei Drittel des
Sondervermögens gebunden sein wird und
wir stehen alle gemeinsam aufgrund der
hohen Mittel die uns die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler zur
Verfügung stellen auch vor einer enorm
Verantwortung und deshalb muss der
Minister natürlich auch weiterhin daran
gearbeitet werden dass die
Beschaffungsprozesse bei der Bundeswehr
optimiert werden
aber
selbstverständlich werden auch weiterhin
die Beratungen die Kontrolle die
Entscheidungen dieses Hauses Parlaments
und die Hinweise des Bundesrechnungshof
eine zentrale Rolle bei den Prozessen
der Beschaffung spielen und weil heute
ist schon mehr als angeklungen ist es
gibt ja ein Formulierungsvorschlag für
eine Änderung der Zweckbindung des
Sondervermögens die auch kritisch
beleuchtet wird aber ich will dazu
zweierlei sagen erstens ist es ein
Formulierungsvorschlag der
Bundesregierung wir werden das hier im
Haus sehr intensiv diskutieren in
welchen Umfang und in welcher Art und
Weise sondern auch überhaupt wir die
Zweckbindung des Sondervermögens ändern
und das zweite ist und das muss man
vielleicht auch noch mal festhalten in
keiner Weise
widerspricht die Formulierungsvorschlag
der Bundesregierung der in der
Verfassung niedergelegten Formulierung
letztendlich geht es natürlich auch um
die Diskussion wie wir dauerhaft dass
zwei Prozent Ziel erreichen wenn das
Sondervermögen ausläuft und zu dieser
Debatte liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gehört dazu dass noch kurz vor Ende des
Kalten Kriegs
1989 fast 20 Prozent des Bundeshaushalts
für Verteidigungsausgaben veranschlagt
waren wir liegen heute bei 11,6 Prozent
und das zeigt welchen Diskussionsprozess
wie in den nächsten Wochen Monaten und
Jahre führen müssen denn es ist eine
Frage der Prioritätensetzung die wir
durchführen müssen 1 steht für uns frei
Demokraten fest Frieden und Freiheit
sind die Basis für alles was wir hier in
diesem Hause diskutieren und was
passiert wenn Frieden und Freiheit nicht
mehr selbstverständlich ist das können
wir uns in der Ukraine anschauen deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir uns
Unterstützung die wir bisher gegeben
haben als stärkster Partner der Ukraine
in Europa fortsetzen und Freiheit für
Europa und natürlich für die Ukraine von
unseren Freunden in der Ukraine auch
verteidigt werden können vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin ist für Fraktion DIE
LINKE dr Gesine Lötzsch
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren zurzeit gibt
es auf dieser Welt 20 Kriege und 164
gewaltsame Konflikte und die Linke sagt
alle diese Kriege und Konflikte müssen
beendet werden
nach nadelkriterien berechnet wollen sPD
Grüne FDP in diesem Jahr
85,5 Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr
ausgeben und noch nie hat eine
Bundesregierung so viel Geld für Krieg
und Aufrüstung eingeplant wir sagen wir
sind gegen ein neues wettrüst meine
Damen und Herren sie wissen doch alle
wir haben in unserem Land ein Personal-
und investitionsnotstand in den
Pflegeheimen in den Krankenhäusern in
den Schulen im öffentlichen Verkehr in
den Bürgerämtern das darf doch der
Bundesregierung nicht gleichgültig sein
die Aufrüstung an die erste Stelle zu
stellen ist die falsche Priorität meine
Damen und Herren
und wir haben sehr im Laufe der Debatte
noch mehrfach gehört alle Probleme in
diesem Land führt die Bundesregierung
auf den Überfall auf den Krieg Russland
gegen die Ukraine zurück und wenn
wirklich alle diese Probleme mit diesem
Krieg Zusammenhängen warum setzt sich
dann die Bundesregierung nicht
entschieden und entschlossen für einen
sofortigen Waffenstillstand ein das wäre
doch die logische Folge
und seit dem russischen Überfall auf die
Ukraine am 24 Februar 2022 hat
Deutschland der Ukraine bereits Hilfen
von nach Aussagen der Regierung im
Gesamtwert von knapp 22 Milliarden Euro
zur Verfügung gestellt ein
Waffenstillstand wäre also gut für die
Ukraine und gut für die gesamte
Weltbevölkerung und darin müssen wir
arbeiten meine Damen und Herren aber
jetzt werden sogar neue Marschflugkörper
auch an dieser Debatte schon wieder
gesagt gefordert das ist eine
gefährliche Eskalation dazu darf es
nicht kommen und bei jeder neuen Waffe
erklären sie das wäre die Wende in
diesem Krieg ich sage Ihnen wir brauchen
eine Wende zum Frieden die
Bundesregierung muss jede diplomatische
Initiative ernsthaft unterstützen und
ich immer in Frage stellen ansonsten
machen sie die Rüstungsindustrie Reich
und die Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben wir
brauchen einen Waffenstillstand jetzt
sagt sie eine Lötsch hier für die
Linksfraktion
für die SPD-Fraktion den Abgeordneten
Andreas Schwarz erst Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren liebe
werbeauftragte ich beginne mit einem
Zitat des von mir sehr geschätzten
ehemaligen Bundespräsident Richard von
Weizsäcker der einmal sagte die Kunst
die ganze Kunst der Politik besteht
darin dass langfristig notwendige
kurzfristig mehrheitsfähig zu machen
meine Damen und Herren das langfristig
notwendige kurzfristig mehrheitsfähig zu
machen ist das was der
Verteidigungshaushalt 2024 benötigt und
wofür ich auch hier werden möchte es
geht auch um den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt es geht um Glaubwürdigkeit
Verlässlichkeit und es geht um Vertrauen
aber es geht darum das Leben und die
Gesundheit unserer Soldaten und Soldaten
und an dieser Stelle ganz ganz
herzlichen Dank an unsere Gruppe wir
sind stolz auf euch
meine Damen und Herren
die Gewährleistung der äußeren
Sicherheit die GEW Dienstleistung der
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung ist eine
wichtige staatliche Aufgabe der
russische Überfall auf die Ukraine hat
viel Bewegung in unsere Gesellschaft
gebracht aber auch viel Bewegung in die
Sicherheitsarchitektur aber auch in die
Bundeswehr und es ist viel passiert und
es wird noch viel passieren alleine bis
Ende des Jahres werden wir mit bis zu 40
25 mio-vorlagen rechnen können und jede
dieser 25 mio-vorlage ist ein Stück
gelebte zeitenwände diese
Bundesregierung steigt Sicherheit und
Verteidigung der Verteidigungshaushalt
24 ist damit ein der einzige Etat der
richtigerweise nicht dem notwendigen
Sparkurs unterworfen ist im Gegenteil er
wurde erhöht um ca 1,7 Milliarden Euro
fast 52 Milliarden und dazu kommen
nochmal 19,2 Milliarden aus dem
Sondervermögen es ist ein Kraftakt und
er ist einmalig in der Geschichte der
Bundeswehr in unserem Land das sind
zusammen gut 71 Milliarden Euro ein
Verteidigungshaushalt der sicherlich vor
zwei Jahren noch undenkbar erschien
hinzu kommen noch Ausgaben aus anderen
Ministerien aus dem Einzelplan 60 somit
meine Damen und Herren werden wir das 2%
Ziel erfüllen das ist ein deutliches es
ist ein klares Signal an unsere
Verbündeten Deutschland ist zuverlässig
und erfüllt seine Bündnisverpflichtungen
Dank dafür an unseren Kanzler dem
Verteidigungsminister aber auch dem
Finanzminister und sie haben auch
weiterhin unsere Unterstützung auf dem
Weg verdient dieser Haushalt verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist deshalb ein
klares Zeichen des Investierens des
entlastens aber auch das Zusammenhaltens
ohne dient der Sicherheit und der
Freiheit der Menschen in unserem Land
und an das Wohnen der Welt meine Damen
und Herren ist es richtig die
Herausforderung für den
Verteidigungshaushalt sind enorm in den
kommenden Jahren und es wird wie gesagt
ein Kraftakt aber diese Ampel stellt
sich der Verantwortung und nimmt die
Herausforderungen an nur so schaffen wir
den fähigkeitshalt und Aufbau für die
für das Zeiten wendeprojekt Bundeswehr
das braucht die Bundeswehr und unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten haben das auch
verdient meine Damen und Herren neben
dem reinen Budget müssen wir aber auch
die Beschaffungsprozesse im Auge
behalten und der Minister hat hier schon
ganze Arbeit geleistet und das spürt man
auch an den Veränderungen bis Ende des
Jahres werden ca zwei Drittel des
Sondervermögens der Bundeswehr
vertraglich gebunden sein da steckt viel
Power und Arbeit dahinter auch in
Beschaffungsamt der Bundeswehr aber auch
im
Verteidigungsministerium und wir haben
sicherlich teilweise auch schon
historische Abschlüsse geschafft ich
nehme zum Beispiel das
Raketenabwehrsystem ihres Tee
übrigens ein Name der mir vor zwei
Wochen beim ein Besuch in der Ukraine
ständig begegnet ist jeder Mensch weiß
was ihres ist die Ukraine hat dieses
deutsches System in Einsatz und viele
Menschen haben ihres Tee schätzen
gelernt man empfindet dort tiefen Dank
für diese überlebensversicherung aus
unserem Land
historisch ist in diesem Zusammenhang
auch die Zusammenarbeit bei der
Raketenabwehr mit Israel beschaffen wir
hier arro3 welches uns vor der Bedrohung
von Langstrecken Waffen schützt es ist
das erste Mal dass Israel dieses System
ins Ausland liefert und es geht nach
Deutschland damit garantiert Israel
einen wichtigen Beitrag für die
Sicherheit der Menschen in unserem Land
welch ein Zeichen auch vor dem
Hintergrund unserer Geschichte
historisch ist aber auch die deutsche
Initiative in diesem Zusammenhang diesen
Schutzschirm nicht nur für Deutschland
sondern für ganz Europa wirken zu lassen
und viele Länder haben auch hier schon
Interesse bekundet über die es
investieren wir in viele wichtige
Projekte wie Beschaffung von Leoparden
und Pumas in flottendienstboote U-Boote
F35 Euro weit das
Satellitenkommunikation aber auch in
dringend benötigte Munition alleine hier
für 3,5 Milliarden 2015 waren es noch
296 Millionen Euro lassen sie uns
zusammenhalten nutzen wir den
Deutschland packt unseres Kanzlers um
langfristig um das langfristig
notwendige in der Bundeswehr umzusetzen
und kurzfristig mehr als fähig zu machen
es geht um die Sicherheit der Menschen
in unserem Land und unserer Soldatinnen
und Soldaten in diesem Sinne freue ich
mich auf die Diskussion in den kommenden
Wochen wir haben viel zu tun packen wir
es an
die nächste Rednerin ist Kerstin
Vierecke für die cdu/csu-fraktion
diese auf Frauen Verteidigungsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Minister Pistorius liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
10 Jahre nach dem NATO-Gipfel in Wales
soll Deutschland 2024 erstmalig das zwei
Prozent Ziel erfüllen manch einer wird
sagen besser spät als nie aber machen
wir uns nichts vor die Lage hat sich
seit 2014 fundamental geändert zwei
Prozent stellen seit dem NATO-Gipfel in
vilius nicht mehr die Zielmarke da
sondern die Untergrenze mehr ist
ausdrücklich erwünscht
und trotzdem kann sich die
Bundesregierung nicht einmal dazu
durchringen diese Untergrenze ja für
Jahr zu erreichen die Ampel behaart auf
weiter zwei Prozent im Jahr mehrjährigen
schnitt dabei hat doch auch der
Bundeskanzler das abschlusskommunikier
von Vilnius unterzeichnet
internationale Entscheidungen umsetzen
Fehlanzeige Deutschland ist mal wieder
das schwarze Schaf der NATO aber damit
nicht genug sie gehen ja noch drei
Schritte weiter um die zwei Prozent zu
erreichen tricksen täuschen und tarnen
sie bis sich die beiden biegen die
Erhöhung des kernhaushalts um 1,7
Milliarden Euro deckt nicht einmal die
erhöhten Betriebskosten und damit diese
gedeckt werden können will die Ampel
immer mehr Projekte in Sondervermögen
verlagern
somit wird das ohnehin schon überplante
Sondervermögen noch weiter strapaziert
für viele wichtige Projekte könnte es
nur noch als Anschubfinanzierung dienen
diese geplante Zweckentfremdung ist mehr
als nur ein Wortbruch gegenüber dem
Parlament es wäre laut dem
Bundesrechnungshof sogar ein klarer
Rechtsbruch
einer weiteren Erklärung bedarf auch
dieser ominöse Anstieg bei den
verteidigungsrelevanten Ausgaben anderer
Ressorts auf über 14 Milliarden Euro
all das um gemäß den derzeitigen
prognungen Prognosen bei genau
2,0% zu landen
manche mögen glauben dass die
Symbolkraft der Erfüllung der zwei
Prozent diese Tricksereien rechtfertigt
aber ich sehe das anders und unsere
Partner auch sie erwarten von uns eine
nachhaltige Stärkung der Bundeswehr und
nur darauf kommt es an
dafür braucht es einen aufwachsenden
Kernhaushalt so wie damals angekündigt
der Wunschtraum der umfassen
Ertüchtigung der Bundeswehr mit Hilfe
des Sondervermögens ist doch schon
längst ausgeträumt das Wissen ihre
Verteidigungspolitiker doch genauso und
der Bundesminister Pistorius hat doch
auch nicht ohne Grund 10 Milliarden Euro
mehr für den Einzelplan gefordert
und trotzdem stellen Sie sich hier hin
und wollen diesen Haushaltsentwurf als
großen Erfolg verkaufen
selbst die gefällige Überschrift zwei
Prozent erreicht kann nicht kaschieren
dass die Ampel bei den haushalterischen
Umsetzungen der zeitenwände nach wie vor
auf Rot steht
und das spüren auch unsere Soldaten die
anfängliche Aufbruchstimmung ist der
Ernüchterung und einer bitteren
Erkenntnis gewichen der Wendekreis der
Zeitenwende ist weitaus größer als der
politische Wille diese auch konsequent
umzusetzen
dies schlägt sich leider auch in den
Personalzahlen nieder in der größten
sicherheitspolitischen Krise Europas
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gehen uns die
Soldaten aus
seit Ausrufung der Zeitenwende ist der
militärische personalkörper um knapp
3000 Männer und Frauen geschrumpft die
Folge zunehmende Aufgaben verteilen sich
auf immer weniger Schultern der Beruf
Soldat wird somit nicht attraktiver
sondern leider immer unattraktiver uns
läuft also nicht nur die Zeit davon
sondern auch unsere Soldaten
ein Lösungsvorschlag des Ministers mehr
Frauen für die Bundeswehr gewinnen sehr
gut
doch wenige Wochen nach dieser
absichtsbekundung kommt heraus dass ein
General der in der Vergangenheit
mehrfach mit sexistischen Äußerungen
aufgefallen ist die Überarbeitung der
Personalstrategie verantwortet was ist
denn das für ein Signal
nein ich bin eine Frau und ich nehme die
Sache sehr ernst so zeigt sich also
einmal mehr Ankündigung werden
bestenfalls halbherzig umgesetzt und das
muss sich dringend ändern ein weiter so
verzeihen uns weder unsere Partner noch
unsere eigenen Soldatinnen und Soldaten
sie haben besseres verdient
sagt Kerstin Vierecke hier für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion heute morgen um 9 Uhr zum
Auftakt für dieses zweiten Tages der
Haushaltsberatung in der Generaldebatte
hat der unionsfraktionschefs Friedrich
Merz auch schon die Regierung kritisiert
für den zu geringen Verteidigungsetat
Sebastian Schäfer jetzt für die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Frau
werbeauftragte Herr Minister sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
sind mitten in der Zeitenwende die der
Bundeskanzler hier im Februar 2022
ausgerufen hat nach dem Überfall
Russlands auf die gesamte Ukraine
die bisherige Unterstützung des Westens
für die Ukraine wirkt auch wenn sie für
eine schnellere Offensive in vergangenen
Herbst zu spät und nicht ausreichend war
es war eine wichtige Entscheidung dass
wir Ende März die Mittel für die
ertüchtigungsinitiative nochmals
deutlich um 12 Milliarden Euro steigern
konnten damit finanzieren wir ganz
wesentliche Ausrüstung für die Ukraine
und auch die Ersatzbeschaffung von
Waffen und Material die aus dem
Beständen der Bundeswehr an die Ukraine
abgegeben werden
ich will an dieser Stelle unterstreichen
dass unsere Bundeswehr durch diese
Ersatzbeschaffung exzellentes neues
Material erhält das wird deutlich beim
Leopard 2 abgegeben haben wir das Modell
A6 die Bundeswehr erhält das deutlich
verbesserte Modell A8 auch die Panzer
2000 erhält die Bundeswehr
selbstverständlich in der neuesten und
weiter verbesserten Form so wird die
Bundeswehr durch die Abgaben an die
Ukraine zwar kurzfristig geschwächt
mittelfristig aber wird die
abschreckungskraft durch modernis des
Material weitergestellt
dem geschätzten Kollegen Andreas Schwarz
und mir gegenüber wurde bei unserem
Besuch in der Ukraine vor zwei Wochen
große Dankbarkeit geäußert insbesondere
für die modernen Systeme der Luftabwehr
die wir der Ukraine zur Verfügung
gestellt haben und die mehr Sicherheit
für die Zivilbevölkerung gebracht haben
Dankbarkeit für die Aufnahme von mehr
als eine Million Menschen aus der
Ukraine in unserem Land
hauptsächlich Frauen und Kinder
uns wurde aber auch berichtet was die
Ukraine für weitere Erfolge braucht
Marschflugkörper mit großer Reichweite
stehen da ganz zentral auf der Agenda es
wurde aber vor allem immer wieder betont
dass bei der Wartung und der
Instandhaltung der modernen
Waffensysteme aus Deutschland
Optimierungsbedarf besteht die Ukraine
hat keine Zeit für Verzögerungen da ist
die Rüstungsindustrie in der Pflicht
unbürokratisch und schnell Abhilfe zu
schaffen mit der Bereitstellung von
Ersatzteilen aber auch mit Handbüchern
und Service Manualen insbesondere in
ukrainischer oder englischer Sprache wir
brauchen mehr reparaturzentren direkt in
der Ukraine um Wege möglichst kurz zu
halten und eine verlässliche Planung
sicherzustellen
wir sind weiterhin in der Pflicht alles
dafür zu tun dass die Ukraine ihre
Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung
verteidigen kann mehr Luftabwehr mehr
Munition mehr schweres Gerät die Ukraine
kämpft diesen Kampf auch für uns
ich werde einen Satz eines ukrainischen
Soldaten mein Leben lang nicht vergessen
unser Ziel ist dass unsere Kinder nicht
mehr wissen was krieg ist darum geht es
dafür setzen wir uns ein und dafür muss
die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen und
ihr Territorium befreien
das Sondervermögen ist das Herzstück der
finanziellen zeitenwände in
Verteidigungshaushalt die Notwendigkeit
des Sondervermögens zeigt sich auch am
Haushaltsplan 2024 die investiven Posten
für Beschaffungen und Forschung sinken
im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr im
Kernhaushalt obwohl es seine
etagesteigerung gab als Ampel öffnen wir
das Sondervermögen damit das Geld
schneller bei der Truppe ankommt und die
Bundeswehr angemessen ausgerüstet wird
auch und insbesondere mit Blick auf
unsere internationalen Verpflichtungen
der Schwerpunkt des Sondervermögens muss
aber weiterhin auf der Finanzierung von
Großvorhaben liegen um die Lücken bei
der Ausrüstung möglichst schnell zu
schließen
wir haben das Sondervermögen bisher klug
eingesetzt wir haben nach Jahren der
Unterversorgung dafür gesorgt dass
zukünftig ausreichend persönliche
Ausstattungen der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten sichergestellt ist
gefechtshelme Schutzwesten
kampfbekleidung Stiefel Rucksäcke was
wie eine Selbstverständlichkeit klingt
Wein unserer Bundeswehr leider keine
wir haben mit der Beschaffung der F35
als Nachfolger des Kampfflugzeugs
Tornado zu nuklearen Teilhabe und dem
schweren Transporthubschrauber dafür
gesorgt dass mit dem Sondervermögen die
Luftwaffe eine moderne Ausstattung
erhält fliegende Oldtimer bei der
Bundeswehr sind teuer in der
Unterhaltung und werden weder unserer
Verantwortung noch der
Leistungsfähigkeit unserer
Volkswirtschaft angemessen sein
wir erweitern die Fähigkeiten bishers
quantitativ und qualitativ durch die
Bestellung des zweiten los zu
Schützenpanzers Puma und der Nachrüstung
der bisherigen hummerflotte dazu kommen
noch weitere Projekte wie das über
schneefahrzeug oder künftig der schwere
Waffenträger für die Infanterie für
unsere Marine bedeutet das
Sondervermögen die sichere Finanzierung
der neuen Fregatten U-Boote und
korrekten
insgesamt
ermöglicht das Sondervermögen dass wir
die von uns versprochenen Fähigkeiten im
Rahmen unserer Bündnisverpflichtungen
besser erfüllen werden können unsere
Partner können sich auf unser Land
verlassen
allein mit der Finanzierung ist es nicht
getan wir müssen weiter aktiv daran
arbeiten wo wir Bremsen bei der
Beschaffung lösen und gleichzeitig
Kosten sparen können wir dürfen uns
nicht in der Entwicklung von vielen
verschiedenen Rüstungsprojekten
verzetteln die erst einmal erforscht und
erprobt werden müssen auch wenn wir es
an dieser Stelle schon oft gesagt haben
es gilt konsequent auf Markt verfügbare
Rüstungsgüter zu setzen
wir sollten weiter gemeinsam
Bestellungen mit anderen Bündnispartnern
vorantreiben ein gutes Beispiel ist das
potenzielle pooling bei den neuen
Leopard 2 A8 oder bei der Beschaffung
gemeinsam mit Schweden und
Großbritannien der neuen über
schneefahrzeuge für die Gebirge die
gemeinsame europäische
rüstungskooperationen zur Entwicklung
der Waffensysteme der Zukunft müssen wir
endlich konsequent umsetzen da dürfen
wir keine Zeit verlieren wir müssen auch
europäisch handlungsfähig sein mich
beunruhigen die Berichte über
verschiedene Kooperationen beim
Panzerbau Wettbewerb ist sicherlich
grundsätzlich hilfreich aber wir sollten
wissen wo wir landen wollen wenn wir mit
neuen Projekten beginnen
die Umsetzung der zeitenwände bleibt
eine langwierige Aufgabe der
Bundeskanzler hat das heute morgen in
seiner Rede beschrieben da haben wir
auch große haushaltspolitische Aufgaben
vor uns wir müssen die Zeitenwende zum
Erfolg machen daran arbeiten wir auch in
diesem Haushalt herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Schäfer war das für die
Bündnis grünen debattiert wird hier im
Bundestag der Einzelplan 14 und Rüdiger
lukasten ist der verteidigungspolitische
Sprecher der AFD er hat jetzt das Wort
frau Präsidentin Frau werbeauftragte
meine Damen und Herren das ist die
sechste Haushaltsdebatte seit dem Einzug
der AFD in den Deutschen Bundestag nicht
ein einziges Problem der Bundeswehr
wurde in diesen sechs Jahren gelöst
nicht ein einziges 50 Milliarden Euro
stellt die Regierung im diesjährigen
Verteidigungshaushalt ein es müssten
eigentlich 70 sein weil die Ampel aber
mit 50 Milliarden bereits überfordert
ist brauchen wir an dieser Stelle auch
nicht über den tatsächlichen
Finanzbedarf der Bundeswehr sprechen und
so stehen wir hier jedes Jahr und
stellen wieder fest die Personallage der
Bundeswehr schlechter die Materiallage
der Bundeswehr ist schlechter die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr
schlechter und vierten s die Kosten für
weniger Verteidigung sind gestiegen
zusammengefasst die Regierung Scholz
ersetzt so viel Geld wie noch nie für
die Bundeswehr ein und kann weder den
grundgesetzlichen Auftrag
Landesverteidigung noch die
Bündnisverpflichtung erfüllen ein
totales scheitern meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren jedes Jahr wieder
analysieren wir die gleichen Schwächen
in der deutschen Landesverteidigung
jedes Jahr hören wir die gleichen
Durchhalteparolen der Regierung und die
gleichen
stellschraubenvorschläge der sogenannten
Verteidigungsexperten wenn sie nicht
gerade damit beschäftigt sind
Marschflugkörper gegen Russland zu
fordern aber handfeste Ergebnisse sehen
wir nie
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius tritt
bewusst kernig auf starke Stimme
methanjacke bei der Truppe nur ganz
wenig wooknis sieht man mal von dem
Regenbogenfahnen Unfall vor dem BMVg ab
nur das reicht nicht um die
Einsatzbereitschaft zu erhöhen Minister
Pistorius wollte aus der Bundeswehr die
stärkste Armee der EU machen 10
Milliarden extra wollt er dafür haben in
24 wofür sind wo aber sind die dafür
notwendigen Großaufträge an die deutsche
Industrie und ich betone an die Deutsche
in de facto gibt es weniger
Kampffahrzeuge als vor einem Jahr die
Abgaben an die Ukraine sind nicht
ersetzt der
mali-einsatz steht vor dem Kollaps die
Bewerberzahlen gehen weiter runter kein
einziges
strukturelles Problem ist gelöst der
Bundeskanzler sprach von Zeitenwende und
nahm 100 Milliarden Euro zusätzliche
Schulden auf und jetzt passiert genau
das wovor die AFD damals gewarnt hat die
Ampel verwässert die eigenen Kriterien
und stopft damit Löcher im regulären
Haushalt aus dem Sondervermögen für
neues Großgerät wird Verfügungsmasse für
Haushaltslöcher meine Damen und Herren
von der Bundesregierung
ihre Politik scheitern scheitert
umfassend mit großem Schaden für
Deutschland weil sie sich von der
Realität entkoppelt haben weil sie sich
selbst betrügen die Menschen betrügen
und weil sie über die Realität den
Schleier einer falschen Sprache gelegt
haben sie
[Applaus]
sie befinden sich im Kampf gegen die
Realität und setzen auf Verschleierung
diesen Kampf werden sie verlieren denn
gegen die Gesetze der Ökonomie der
internationalen Politik und der Natur
kommen sie nicht an meine Damen und
Herren das Sondervermögen ist kein
Vermögen es sind Schulden Staaten haben
Interessen aber keine Werte Putschisten
sind keine Partner
Feminismus ist keine Außenpolitik die
Regenbogenfahne gehört nicht vor das
BMVg Männer sind keine Frauen und
Soldaten sind nicht links hören Sie auf
zu lügen und machen Sie Politik
Rüdiger lukasten
politische Sprecher der AFD die nächste
rinderin ist Marie eine Zimmermann sie
ist die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses und man kann
gespannt sein ob sie das Problem mit den
taunus-raketen hier ebenfalls ansprechen
wird
meine Damen und Herren
562 Tage in der Ukraine morgen
vergewaltigen foltern verschleppen
verhindern der Ausfuhr von Getreide an
dem 400 Millionen Menschen abhängen doch
Herr giesi es gibt einen bösen und das
ist Vladimir Putin und seine Schergen
die dieses Langzeit anderthalb Jahren
mit dem Bösen überziehen und wir wir
unterstützen die Ukraine weil dieser
Krieg auch
etwas angeht mit Wirtschaft humanitär
und ja auch mit Waffen und ja wir müssen
die Taurus auf den Weg bringen und wer
das nicht will und argumentiert er würde
der Ukraine nicht trauen dem empfehle
ich mal dringend die Reise in die
Ukraine anzutreten meine Damen und
Herren der Haushalt Einzelplan und die
19 Milliarden die wir aus den 100
Milliarden jetzt drauflegen der Minister
sagt es 71 Milliarden Euro das ist
doppelt so viel wie 20 15 nach der
Annektion der Krim nach dem ersten
russischen Angriff auf den Donbass
doppelt so viel seinerzeit waren es 33,9
Milliarden das heißt wir haben und
nehmen Geld in die Hand wir investieren
das wurde hier gesagt endlich ist die
Tornado Nachfolge geregelt endlich kommt
der schwere Transporthubschrauber
endlich zweites los Puma und die
Luftverteilung alles was in den letzten
Jahren nicht auf den Weg gebracht wurde
um meine Damen und Herren ich höre ja
immer sei ja nur eine Milliarde
abgeschlossen der Herrgott wir sind doch
hier nicht im Supermarkt und gehen wir
im Körbchen durch die Gänge und greifen
einfach ins Regal die Industrie braucht
Verträge die Industrie braucht
Verlässlichkeit damit das Material auch
an uns und uns erreicht und meine Damen
und Herren ich wende mich an die
Menschen heute hier die auch hier sind
zeitenwände greift auch in ihren Alltag
ein das wissen wir wir sprechen von 51
Milliarden 100 Milliarden das sind
gigantische Summen wenn man sich nicht
damit beschäftigt aber meine Damen und
Herren unser aller Sicherheit unser
aller Sicherheit hat ihren Preis und
nachdem das jahrelang nicht wahrgenommen
wurde in diesem Land haben wir uns jetzt
auf den Weg gemacht und ja wir werden
die zwei Prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktproduktes für die
Sicherheit ausgeben weil ohne Sicherheit
ist nicht und wenn sie in eine Wohnung
ziehen oder in ein Haus dann schauen Sie
dass die Türen geschlossen sind und die
fensterdicht sind bevor Sie Ihr
Fernsehen an die Wand hängen und das
Sofa reinschieben und deswegen meine
Damen und Herren Sicherheit hat ihren
Preis und wenn wir nicht nur wir hier
nicht nur sie heute wenn unsere Kinder
in Frieden und Freiheit in Deutschland
auf diesem Kontinent leben wollen dann
müssen wir umdenken das ist auch ein
Stück Zeitenwende und ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen wir haben eine starke Bundeswehr
dieses runterreden Herr Lukassen die
Soldaten würden nicht auf die Kette
bekommen ich finde es unsäglich und ich
danke den Soldaten und Soldaten dafür
dass Sie heute den Kopf hinhalten für
uns für uns und Sie haben das Glück dass
sie sogar für die AFD den Kopf hinhalten
und das mit Sicherheit nicht gerne
Frau steigt Zimmermann hat die 1000
nicht angesprochen den Streit innerhalb
der Ampel dann lieber hier nicht bemüht
das hat gesagt wir gehen ja nicht mit
dem Körbchen einkaufen und 1,2
Milliarden sind bisher abgeschlossen die
Begründung ist auch ganz einfach das
Geld kann das Haus der tierischen
Gründen erst abfließen wenn das
bestellte Gerät geliefert wurde das
macht Sinn und daher ist die Summe
bisher doch recht klein Plastik jetzt
von der Linken Sprecherin für Menschen
sprechen 85,5 Milliarden steigt der
verteidigungster es ist der größte seit
bestehende Bundesrepublik und die Werte
Ampel hat ganz offensichtlich ein Herz
für Waffen aber nicht für die deutschen
Kinder
Monate lange liefern sie sich eine
unwürdige Debatte über die
Kindergrundsicherung und das Ergebnis
wirklich eine Schande
und schauen wir weiter bei Bildung und
Forschung kürzen Sie um 1,7 Milliarden
bei der Vermittlung von Arbeitslosen 500
Millionen beim Bafög 440 Millionen und
das in Zeiten in den Deutschland das
wirtschaftliche Schlusslicht der
westlichen Industriestaaten ist übrigens
auch das alles ein Ergebnis ihrer
kopflosen Sanktionspolitik gegenüber
unserem wichtigsten Energielieferanten
Russland auch in Zeiten eines
gravierenden Fachkräftemangels zeigen
sie ganz offen wo ihre Prioritäten
liegen und während Finanzminister
Lindner der Bevölkerung verkauft der
Ukraine Krieg macht uns alle ärmer
verschweigt er das z.B in der
Rüstungsindustrie die Champagner gucken
knallen alleine rein Metall hat ein
satten Gewinn von 535 Millionen Euro 20
22 eingefahren Frau Strack Zimmermann
kennt sich da ja gut aus die größten
westlichen Ölkonzerne haben einen satten
Gewinn von
195 Milliarden US-Dollar abgesagt und
während bei Manövern die Puma Panzer
nicht fahren verschenken Sie alte
touristisch unser altes aber immerhin
funktionsfähiges Gerät
einige Medien schrieben dazu eine
Blamage für unser Herr nein es ist ein
komplett versagen dieser und der
vorherigen Bundesregierungen
und immer wieder Kosten ihre
Großprojekte und Summen an zusätzlichen
Geldern zum Beispiel Julius produziert
der zwei Tankschiffe die zusätzlichen
Kosten 250 Millionen sie eine
Zwischenfrage die drei Spionage Schiffe
Zusatzkosten 1,2 Milliarden schämen sie
sich eigentlich nicht dafür dass
Steuerzahlergeld so zu verschwenden und
gleichzeitig der Bevölkerung Sparsamkeit
zu predigen
und während sie selbst mit dem
moralischen Zeigefinger sich einer Werte
basierten feministischen Außenpolitik
loben ja und zu Recht den
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine anprangern schweigen sie aber zu
ihren Waffenlieferungen alle möglichen
Herren Länder z.B an die Golfstaaten die
den nehmen damit in Schutt und
aschebomben oder ihr NATO Bruder Erdogan
der die Kurden in Syrien damit tötet und
syrisches Land besetzt hält übrigens
auch völkerrechtswidrig und völlig
überrascht wurden sie erneut nachdem sie
saß dann Afghanistan von den Ereignissen
in Mali und Niger meine Damen und Herren
es ist offensichtlich dass sie die
Geschehnisse in der Welt völlig falsch
einschätzen die Linke sagt weiterhin
Nein zu ihrer verantwortungslosen
Verteidigungspolitik
und jetzt erhält das Wort Dr Christian
Klink für die SPD-Fraktion
bisschen Klink ist im
verteilungsausschuss für die
Sozialdemokraten sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren als Verteidigungspolitiker
besuche ich viele Bundeswehrstandorte
und besonders gerne besuche ich Sie in
meinem Wahlkreis und da passiert gerade
viel der Standort der
flugabwehrraketengruppe 61 in Todendorf
wird für das System ihres tefit gemacht
in der Marineunteroffizierschule Plön
werden die Unterkünfte saniert und der
Munition wird daran gearbeitet unsere
Bestände wieder aufzufüllen meine Damen
und Herren überall wird gehämmert und
geschraubt nicht nur in der
Ampelkoalition auch bei der Bundeswehr
da ist ganz viel Dynamik drin als
Reaktion auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine und das
ist auch notwendig denn Deutschland ist
wie ein Schüler oder Student der zu spät
angefangen hat für eine Prüfung zu
lernen jetzt gibt es über einen
Nachholbedarf in der Pflege beim
Wohnungsbau und auch bei der Bundeswehr
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Ampelkoalition geht die Probleme an
nicht immer perfekt aber sie geht sie an
und das ist der richtige Weg ja dabei
werden auch Fehler gemacht doch wir
können es uns nicht leisten zuzuschauen
wie die Probleme immer größer werden
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
kümmern und auch wenn es manchmal
ruckelt wir ziehen an einem Strang
und es werden sich auch Erfolge
einstellen das zeigt die Entwicklung bei
der Bundeswehr sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir befinden uns leider in einem
Konflikt der Systeme in einem Konflikt
der Demokratie gegen die Diktatur
Deutschland hat diesen Konflikt nicht
gewollt lange war bei uns die Auffassung
weit verbreitet dass wir ohne Bedrohung
von außen leben können wenn wir nur
selber friedfertig sind wir mussten erst
wieder lernen dass es Menschen gibt die
uns dennoch zu Feinden erklären die
unsere freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung verachten und den Ziel es
ist die Tyrannei an die Stelle der
Demokratie zu setzen in diesem Konflikt
müssen und werden wir uns behaupten
dafür brauchen wir eine starke
Bundeswehr damit wir hoffentlich nie
angegriffen werden und da sind wir auf
einem guten Weg Minister Boris Pistorius
und seine Männer und Frauen leisten eine
gute Arbeit Sondervermögen
beschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz Zimmer
Erlass wir kommen voran die F35 digitale
Funkgeräte und das Gewehr g95 bringen
hightech für unsere Bundeswehr die
ersten Ausrüstung Seite Rucksäcke Helme
Schutzwesten kampfbekleidung laufen
bereits zu wir werden das 2% Ziel der
NATO Einheiten im kommenden Jahr und
darüber hinaus damit zeigen wir wir sind
ein verlässlicher Partner im Bündnis
nur die CDU nur die CDU steigt aus dem
gemeinsamen Boot aus liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der CDU im kommenden Jahr
stehen unter Einbeziehung des
Sondervermögens 71 Milliarden Euro für
Verteidigung zur Verfügung und die CDU
das ist ein großer Kraftakt den die CDU
niemals bewältigt hat und die
CDU-Fraktion kritisiert allen Ernstes
das nach dem neuen Wirtschaftsplan für
das Sondervermögen nicht nur die F35
beschafft werden kann sondern aus dem
Sondervermögen jetzt auch die
dazugehörige Infrastruktur in den
Kasernen da kann ich nur mit dem Kopf
schütteln die CDU entfernt sich immer
weiter von der Realität wer in dieser
Debatte wer in dieser Debatte so
argumentiert wie die CDU ist tot der hat
von Seitenwände nichts aber auch gar
nichts verstanden
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich rate
der Opposition keinen kleinlichen Streit
zu beginnen in der Zeitenwende kommt es
auf Verlässlichkeit an und auch die
Opposition hat hier eine Verantwortung
und als Sicherheitspolitiker sage ich
Ihnen noch etwas Soldaten und Waffen
sind wichtig aber eine mindestens ebenso
wichtiger Quelle an Kraft für die
Verteidigung der Demokratie ist der
gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt und damit
der Rückhalt für unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten
inwieweit eine strikte Auslegung der
Schuldenbremse in dieser geopolitischen
Situation klug ist überlasse ich ihre
Urteilsvermögen klar ist jedenfalls die
Verteidigung der Demokratie gegen die
Tyrannei ist eine Generationenaufgabe
die wir nur gemeinsam lösen können dazu
brauchen wir Aufrichtigkeit
Verlässlichkeit und die Bereitschaft
ernsthaft an den tatsächlichen Problemen
zu arbeiten dazu sind wir bereit als SPD
und als Ampel und wir laden alle ein uns
auf diesem Weg zu folgen
nächste Redner ist Armin Schwarz für die
CDU CSU-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Bundesregierung hat uns ein
Verteidigungsetat vorgelegt den nur zwei
Deutungen zulässt entweder ist der
mutlos mutlos deswegen weil der
Verteidigungsminister offensichtlich den
Konflikt mit dem Kanzler und den anderen
Ministerien um mehr die entscheut oder
er ist Lebenswelt weil die Ampel
offensichtlich nicht begriffen hat was
seitenwende bedeutet Zeitenwende
bedeutet wir müssen zur Landes- und
verbündnis Verteidigung fähig sein und
es war der Inspekteur des Heeres general
meist der gesagt hat das sind wir nicht
es bedarf diesen Zeiten mutige
Entscheidung und vor allen Dingen
braucht es mehr Geld
Gradmesser radmesser dafür sind zur
vorders als Untergrenze die berühmten 2%
nicht nur als NATO Verpflichtung sondern
auch ganz besonders deswegen weil
Bundeskanzler Scholz in der berühmten
Zeitenwende Rede dieses versprochen hat
was ist nun das Versprechen des Kanzlers
wählen naja wir alle inklusive des
Verteidigungsministers sind enttäuscht
nein die sind sogar getäuscht über das
was geschehen ist trotz aller
Rechentricks bedeuten zwei Prozent beim
Bundeskanzler exakt 1,6 Prozent im Ethan
Scholz macht als Bundeskanzler genau
dort weiter wo er als Finanzminister der
großen Koalition aufgehört hat er
verweigert der Bundeswehr die nötige
Finanzierung Beschaffung Forschung und
Entwicklung sind so nicht möglich meine
Damen und Herren das muss man nicht
Neuigkeiten
[Applaus]
sie hat historius jetzt ist er gerade
nicht da
haben zehn Milliarden mehr für 2024
gefordert sie haben dabei unsere volle
Unterstützung das will ich Ihnen sagen
voller Unterstützung der Union das
Ergebnis können wir besichtigen 1,7
Milliarden sind der Aufwuchs mehrfach
zitiert die steigenden Personal und
Betriebskosten können damit noch nicht
einmal gedeckt werden deswegen sage ich
Ihnen sehr klar tun sie das was sie
sagen und sagen sie das was sie tun so
kann man mit der Truppe nicht umgehen
und sie den Umkehrschluss zu machen wir
wären es gewesen wie die Bundeswehr
unterfinanziert hätte würde ich gerne
mal in Umkehr Beweis antreten es steht
hier schwarz auf weiß frau Präsidentin
mit Ihrem Einverständnis das will die
CDU das ist etwas schwierig also das
habe ich jetzt vorher auch nicht gesehen
das kann auch kein Mensch lesen
vor hier steht das will die CDU teurere
Aufrüstung vom Panzer bis zur Drohne und
das will die SPD
kostenfreie Bildung von der Kita bis zur
Uni Dinge die Sie über den Bundestag
überhaupt nicht zu entscheiden haben
stand übrigens ja aus dem Jahr 2017 er
war Teil eines mindestens das zu ihrer
Erinnerung wie die Dinge sich
tatsächlich Verhalten
sie eine Zwischenfrage von der
Abgeordneten Hagedorn
[Musik]
danke dass Sie die Zwischenfrage
erlauben lieber Herr Kollege schwarz
jetzt möchte ich ihrer Erinnerung mal
ein bisschen auf die Sprünge helfen
unabhängig von dem was auf diesem Zettel
steht ich möchte Sie daran erinnern dass
es zwischen 209 und 2013 ein
bemerkenswerten Kahlschlag bei der
Bundeswehr gegeben hat die SPD hat
damals übrigens nicht regiert
8 Milliarden Euro wurden damals
weggekürzt Kollegen haben vorhin schon
darauf hingewiesen was dabei
eingestampft worden ist mit
unwiederbringlichen Schaden aber es war
das einzige Mal dass 8 Milliarden Euro
unter kalt hier nur zur Gutenberg mit
dessen Zustimmung sogar
weggestrichen worden sind
dann kamen die zweite große Koalition
und in der zweiten großen Koalition
haben wir mit der Unterstützung der
Sozialdemokraten den Verteidigungsetat
gestärkt und zwar bis 2017 solange wir
ein finanzmittelminister Wolfgang
Schäuble hatten auf die Summe von
ungefähr 37 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr und
wissen Sie wie groß der
Verteidigungsetat nach vier Jahren
Finanzminister Olaf Scholz war
50 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr das man ein
Plus von 13 Milliarden pro Jahr mit
einem Finanzminister Olaf Scholz und
jetzt sende ich es angemessen wenn Sie
sich für ihre falsche Bemerkung gerade
in ihrer Rede öffentliche entschuldigen
würden
Frau Kollegin ich konnte Ihre Frage
nicht erkennen bin aber dankbar für die
zusätzliche Redezeit erste Bemerkung ich
kann mich an keinen einzigen
Änderungsantrag seinerzeit in den Jahren
mit der FDP Erinnerungen der von der SPD
kam um tatsächlich aus und aufzurüsten
erste Bemerkung zweite Bemerkung wir
haben wir haben in den großen Koalition
sie getrieben und zwar massiv getrieben
um überhaupt bei der Bundeswehr nach
2014 wieder vor die Lage zu kommen
deswegen auch der massive aufwuchs
dritte Bemerkung wir hätten uns viel
viel mehr vorstellen können als es mit
ihnen möglich war wir haben seinerzeit
noch mal unterstrichen dass zwei Prozent
Ziel wir haben seinerzeit gesagt wir
machen unverzüglich die nukleare
Teilnahme Nachfolge Tornado da kümmern
wir uns um an ihnen gescheitert wir
haben seinerzeit gesagt Sie haben uns
Ihren es ja sogar in den plak wir haben
seinerzeit gesagt mit uns werden
bewaffnete Drohnen angeschafft ist dann
ihnen und ausschließlich ihnen
gescheitert ich will es Ihnen ersparen
ansonsten versenken sie und versenken
sie wahrscheinlich aus Scham gleich
selbst in ihrem Sitz das war ein
Redebeitrag der eine Steilvorlage war
aber sie haben quer im Stall gestanden
gegen den Großen Koalition bei der
Finanzierung unserer Streitkräfte und
nicht wir und wir haben trotz ihres
Widerstandes die Dinge nach vorne
getrieben und drehen Sie das bitte nicht
so rum vielen Dank für die
zwischenberatung
so und war das so schönes machen wir
jetzt weiter jetzt immer auch im
betriebsratur offensichtlich haben sie
sich nämlich verabschiedet bei der Ampel
vom 2% Ziel jetzt will ich immer
folgendes sagen Frau Kollegin in der
mittelfristigen Finanzplanung bis 2027
steht eine Absenkung des beethas und das
ist nicht die Erfindung der Union
sondern das Ifo-Institut rechnet vor
dass
2027 die Verteidigungsausgaben gemessen
am prognospizierten Bruttoinlandsprodukt
auf
1,2% sinken werden schöne Grüße noch mal
vielen Dank für Ihren Beitrag
[Applaus]
wir sprechen uns bitte mit denen liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen der Ampel zahlen
und Tränen haben eines gemeinsam sie
lügen nicht und diese
Finanzplanung die sie hier vorlegen ist
schlichter der greifen eine bankrotte
Erklärung anders kann man das nicht
sagen als gerichterstatter meiner
Fraktion für die Streitkräftebasis weiß
ich sehr genau woran es mangelt es gibt
ein Ungleichgewicht zwischen Wirkung und
Unterstützung unseren körperverbänden
fehlt es dadurch an Einsatz und
Durchhaltefähigkeit dabei gibt es
Rahmenverträge um unverzüglich das
benötigte Material zu bestellen und da
mal ganz konkret
geschützte und ungeschützte
Transportfahrzeuge kranfahrzeuge leichte
geländegängige LKW
1900 Dienstposten die im übrigen bei der
Streitkräfte Basis vor einem Jahr
versprochen worden nur mal Brande oder
dringend auch die
gefechtsverkehrssteigerung des
Kampfhubschraubers Tiger wie oft gehört
der Ausrede mehr Geld im Haushalt kann
nicht schnell und sinnvoll ausgegeben
werden ist insofern schlicht falsch und
damit widerlegt
darauf hinweisen dass ich auf die
Zielgerade kommen muss ich will
schließen jetzt direkt zum Schluss
kommen
die Sicherheit des freien Europas steht
auch dem Spiel meine Damen und Herren
ich weiß nicht welchen Weckruf sie noch
brauchen damit sie aus dem Reden ins
Handeln reinkommen unsere Unterstützung
haben sie bedanke mich bei unseren
Streitkräften ihre wichtige Arbeit und
bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
so was Pistorius hatte sich eben zu Eva
Hügel auf die bundesratsbank begeben auf
die andere Seite wir haben ihn auch
gesucht das war nur schwer zu sehen aber
er hat damit ihr verhügel der
werbeauftragten gesprochen und der
nächste Redner jetzt hier ist Alexander
Müller verteilungspolitischer Sprecher
der FDP Sprecher für Wehrtechnik und
Beschaffungswesen frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
wirtschaftlich schwierigen Zeiten wird
der Verteidigungshaushalt als einziger
deutlich angehoben nämlich um 1,7
Milliarden Euro und das ist ein klares
Signal dass diese Koalition Deutschlands
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit
übernimmt und durch das Sondervermögen
können wir das 2% glaubwürdig
unterfüttern und auch für die kommende
Legislatur hat der Kanzler ja heute was
gesagt vor vier Ecke hat heute morgen
nicht mitbekommen sie hat die gestern
vorbereitet Rede verlesen ist ja auch in
Ordnung für die zwei Prozent aber uns
vorgeworfen wir würden nicht dauerhaft
für die 2% Sorgen der Kanzler hat heute
morgen an dieser Stelle um 9:30 Uhr
garantiert das war Sport weil garantiert
dass er in den Jahren 28 29 30 ebenfalls
die zwei Prozent hinterlegen wird und ja
sie haben sich mitbekommen ist okay ich
bin im Kanzler und dem Finanzminister im
übrigen dankbar dass sie den Schwerpunkt
ihrer Haushaltsreden unserer
Verteidigung widmen Angela Merkel hatte
diesen Bereich regelmäßig mit keinem
Satz gewürdigt und der
Verteidigungshaushalt
lag im letzten Jahr der cdu/csu
geführten Bundesregierung noch bei 46,9
Milliarden und im kommenden Jahr steigt
er auf 51,8 Milliarden alleine der
Verteidigungsetat also um 10% gewachsen
und dazu kommen noch die Mittel aus dem
Sondervermögen on top und damit ergibt
sich eine Steigerung der Mittel für die
Verteidigung im nächsten Jahr von 50
Prozent gegenüber ihrem Rekordwert das
ist ein starkes Signal Kollege Hahn
nennt es ein fatales Signal und das fand
ich auch bemerkenswert heute und dieses
diese ständige Geheule fand ich
interessant immer wieder kriegen wir von
der Union zu hören das war unsere
Regierung von uns geführt wir hatten nur
einen Koalitionspartner anders als heute
mit mehreren unterhalten muss ja sie hat
einen Koalitionspartner aber der eine
Koalitionspartner hat sie immer
dominiert und hat Ihnen vorgegeben
wieder Verteidigungshaushalt aussehen
muss dieses Gejammer nimmt ihn doch
keiner mehr ab
und nun ist der Job der Opposition daran
rumzukrütteln die bemerkenswert war ja
heute wie Friedrich Merz heute morgen
gesagt hat der fordert die vollständige
Abschaffung des Solidaritätszuschlags wo
wir uns in der FDP alle am Kopf kratzen
und fragen warum ist Jamaika 2017
eigentlich noch mal gescheitert das war
die cdu/csu die den Solidaritätszuschlag
nicht abschaffen wollte heute morgen
sagt Friedrich Merz die Amnesie ist
schon interessant aber schlimm finde ich
auch die Einlassungen unserer Ultras
hier im Haus auf den beiden Seiten ganz
rechts und links die einfach zuschauen
möchten wie Putin Landstrich für
Landstrich in Osteuropa zerbombt mit
seinen Panzern und unsere beiden
Randgruppen hier im Parlament möchte das
im Fernsehsessel gemütlich zuschauen und
keinerlei Solidarität leisten sie würden
auch dabei zuschauen wie unsere
Bündnispartner und am Ende wir selbst
unsere Freiheit unsere demokratische
Grundordnung irgendwann verlieren weil
Putins unmittelbarer macht Hunger von
niemandem begrenzt wird zwei Fraktionen
in diesem Haus wollen zurück zur
Weltordnung die wir vor 100 Jahren
hatten wo der der die meisten Panzer
hatten einfach machen konnte was er
wollte das ist nicht die Weltordnung die
wir wollen dass sich das Völkerrecht was
diese Koalition will dieser
Verteidigungshaushalt wird unsere
Verantwortung gerecht vielen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert immer noch den
Einzelplan 14 Verteidigung und der
nächste Redner kommt wieder von der
cdu/csu Ingo gehtjens
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren auch auf den
Zuschauertribüne und werden die Frau
Präsidentin erlaubt würde ich
insbesondere die Uniformierten Kameraden
der deutschen Marine auf dieser Seite
der displayums begrüßen ich darf
Kameraden sagen weil ich über 30 Jahre
diese Uniform mit Stolz getragen habe
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren am
27 Februar hat der Bundeskanzler hier an
dieser Stelle seine Zeitenwende Rede
gehalten alle erinnern sich hat
versprochen und die ist seit dem
unzählige Male wiederholt unsere
Bundeswehr mit ausreichenden
finanziellen Mitteln auszustatten und
endlich so viel Material zur Verfügung
zu stellen wie benötigt wird viele
Soldaten und Soldaten haben diese
Ankündigung geglaubt und hatten die
Hoffnung dass ich etwas ändert
anderthalb Jahre später müssen wir
feststellen die Hoffnung ist gewichen
schlimmer
die Enttäuschung wächst jeden Tag und so
beraten wir heute über den dritten
Haushalt dieser Ampel Regierung und zum
dritten Mal müssen wir feststellen
dieser Haushalt ist für die Bundeswehr
kein positives Signal wir alle wissen
was eigentlich notwendig wäre für eine
einsatzbereite Bundeswehr brauchen wir
kurz mittel und auch langfristig
deutlich mehr Geld jedes Jahr müsste der
Kernhaushalt des
verteidigungsetats deutlich aufwachsen
und Perspektiven für die Truppen
aufzeigen zu können was aber macht die
Bundesregierung sie friert den
Verteidigungshaushalt erneut auf Jahre
ein die Regierung fährt somit Ansage die
Bundeswehr gegen die Wand
wie dramatisch die Regierungspolitik ist
zeigt sich zwar in der ganzen Wucht und
das hat der Kanzler ja heute morgen auch
eingestanden in der ganzen Wucht erst in
der kommenden Wahlperiode man könnte
auch sagen das ist Politik nach uns die
Sintflut aber diese Wucht wird kommen
da schlägt uns die Bundesregierung allen
Ernstes vor die Mittel für
rüstungsbeschaffung um zwei Drittel um
fast 66 Prozent zu kürzen ähnlich
schlimm sieht es bei der wehrforschung
aus hier sollen fast 40 Prozent
gestrichen werden dafür wachsen die
Betriebsausgaben logischerweise rasant
an kurz die Regierung macht aus dem
Verteidigungshaushalt einen reinen
betriebshaushalt Innovation und
Investitionen in die Zukunft werden
komplett gestrichen es ist mir
schleierhaft wie die Bundesregierung so
eine desaströse Planung ernsthaft im
Parlament und der Öffentlichkeit
vorlegen kann
natürlich erwidert die Regierung darauf
wir haben ja noch das Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr das stimmt erst einmal bloß
wird dieses Sondervermögen wir hörten es
bereits immer stärker
zweckentfremdet es war ursprünglich auch
mit uns mit der cdu/csu vereinbart große
und wichtige Rüstungsvorhaben aus dem
Sondervermögen zu finanzieren jetzt will
die Regierung aber die Spielregeln
ändern und alles Mögliche aus dem
Sondervermögen finanzieren ohne
zugleich eine langfristige und
tragfähige Bundeswehr Finanzierung im
Kernhaushalt aufzubauen das führt zu
einer ganz sonderlichen Situation Sie
Herr Minister haben einen Bericht des
Bundesrechnungshof auf dem Tisch der
ihren Plänen beim Sondervermögen ein
Verfassungsbruch attestiert und was tun
sie bis jetzt erkennbar nichts sie
zeigen zielgenau muss der gespannt wie
zielgenau muss der Warnschuss noch
werden bevor die Regierung endlich
handelt da kann ich nur an die Ampel
appellieren akzeptieren Sie diesen
katastrophenhaushalt für die Bundeswehr
nicht sorgen sie in den Beratungen dafür
dass endlich die Weichen in die richtige
Richtung gestellt werden und den Einsatz
dafür erwarte ich auch von Ihnen Herr
Minister in den Umfragen sind sie ja
wohl der einzige das einzige
Kabinettsmitglied das von der
Öffentlichkeit nicht als Totalausfall
wahrgenommen wird nutzen sie doch diesen
Vorteil und setzen sie sich mit ihrer
ganzen politischen Kraft für eine
Steigerung des Verteidigungshaushalts
ein es reicht nicht wenn sie vor einigen
Wochen hier an dieser Stelle 10
Milliarden Euro mehr gefordert haben am
Ende aber mit leeren Händen da stehen
meine Damen und Herren ich stelle sehr
ernüchtern fest dass die Bundesregierung
aktuell wieder Willens noch in der Lage
ist die Bundeswehr ausreichend zu
finanzieren darüber hinaus versuchen sie
immer wieder mit allen möglichen täusche
rein und rechten Tricks ihre eigene
Bilanz aufzuhübschen hierzu möchte ich
Ihnen einen Hinweis geben
wenn Sie und Ihr Haus Herr Minister die
Öffentlichkeit das Parlament und die
Truppe fortwährend hinters Licht führen
wollen geben Sie sich doch bitte etwas
mehr Mühe was wir nämlich im Vorfeld
dieser haushaltswoche an öffentlichen
Täuschungsversuchen erlebt haben schlägt
eigentlich dem Fass dem Boden aus da
verkündet die Bundesregierung voller
Stolz angeblich im nächsten Jahr das
zwei Prozent Ziel einhalten zu wollen
erreichen zu wollen auch das haben wir
gehört und nicht ein bisschen mehr und
nicht ein bisschen weniger und da werde
ich natürlich misstrauisch wenn man ganz
genau eine Punktlandung hinlegen will um
diese zwei Prozent zu erreichen nur das
wo das Geld herkommen soll das weiß man
noch nicht dazu müsste man erst einmal
so heißt es so schön im Beamtendeutsch
eine ressortabfrage durchführen auf
deren Ergebnis dieser ressortabfrage
warten wir übrigens bis heute damit ist
offenkundig es geht der regierenden gar
nicht darum wirklich die zwei Prozent
für Verteidigung zu erreichen sondern es
geht einzig und allein darum die
politische Glaubwürdigkeit des Kanzlers
zu retten und da ist jedes Mittel recht
damit ich am Ende auf diese zwei Prozent
komme da werden sogar die Zinsen noch
mit eingerechnet wie absurd ist das
eigentlich könnte noch viele Beispiele
nennen wie hier die Bundeswehr versucht
den Verteidigungsetat aufzuhübschen dass
der
Verteidigungshaushalt wächst wir haben
es ja gehört hängt ausschließlich mit
den steigenden
Personalausgaben aufgrund der
Tariferhöhungen im nächsten Jahr
zusammen
Hysterien
für einen Zuschlag nur beim Einzelplan
14 ist der Zuschlag schon im
eigentlichen Etat enthalten und kommt
nicht wie bei allen anderen Häusern und
top oben drauf heißt im Ergebnis keine
Priorisierung für Verteidigung nur ein
übler und leicht durchschaubarer
Rechentrick
politische Führung das gilt besonders
für die Bundeswehr lebt von Vertrauen
dieser Haushalt ist ein weiterer Schritt
dieses Vertrauen sowohl der deutschen
Bevölkerung als auch der Soldaten und
Soldaten vollkommen zu verlieren meine
Damen und Herren wir brauchen dringend
eine 180 Grad Wände in der
Haushaltsberatung
ehrlicherweise bin ich pessimistisch
aber es gibt ja das wunderbare Lied
wunder gibt es immer wieder ich hoffe
aber auch und das haben die Zwischentöne
meiner haushaltskollegen schwarz klein
und Schäfer ja signalisiert das noch
eine Menge Arbeit vor uns liegt das
insbesondere die Berichterstatter im
Haushaltsausschuss hier aus diesem
Verteidigungsetat am Ende noch ein
wirklich guten Etat machen herzlichen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
noch einmal vor gerechnet dass der
Verteidigungsetat so nicht ausreicht für
das 2% Ziel dafür muss dann das
Sondervermögen von 100 Milliarden
herangezogen werden das haben wir heute
schon häufig gehört immerhin wächst aber
der Etage
verteilungsministers als einziger
ordentlich auf um 1,7 Milliarden 51,8
Milliarden der Kanzler hat heute morgen
auch gesagt in Zukunft muss es deutlich
mehr geben für die Bundes
gesagt und in der Kürze der Zeit ist es
gut dass wir im verteidigungsethanen
aufwuchs sehen können der Etat soll 2024
steigen um rund 1,7 Milliarden Euro das
ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit denn in
den anderen Ressort sehen wir diese
Aufwüchse aktuell nicht wir leben in
einer herausfordernden Zeit die uns vor
herausfordernden
finanzpolitische Entscheidungen stellt
die Steigerung im Verteidigungsetat sind
erforderlich und notwendig um die über
Jahrzehnte erfolgte Vernachlässigung der
Bundeswehr in Material und Ausrüstung
auszugleichen und zusätzlich die
Anpassung an Personal und Gerät an die
Herausforderungen der aktuellen Zeit zu
tätigen und ja ja das ist ein riesiger
Berg oder Eisberg wie es hier schon
mehrfach in der Debatte angeklungen ist
das kann man auch nicht wegdiskutieren
und darum bitte ich auch dass wir hier
gemeinsam unserer Verantwortung Rechnung
tragen wie wir diesen Berg
in den nächsten Jahren bezwingen wollen
denn für die zeitenwände ist ein
gemeinsames Agieren notwendig da reicht
nicht der Fingerzeig auf die jetzige
Regierung den bereits angehäuften Berg
der vorigen Regierung in einer Phase
multipla-krisen abzuräumen wir sitzen da
gemeinsam im Boot dabei hat sich im
Bereich der Beschaffung und der
Investition einiges getan in einer
Geschwindigkeit die auch wenn sie aus
einigen Ecken beklagt und bemängelt wird
in den letzten Jahren so nicht vorhanden
war und ja auch da müssen wir noch
besser und schneller werden und das ist
auch genau unser Anspruch und wir sehen
dass Minister Pistorius hier ganz neue
Weichen stellt das sollte man vielleicht
an dieser Stelle auch einfach mal
neidlos anerkennen
die Landes- und bündnisverteidigung ist
auch in der Öffentlichkeit mehr in den
Fokus gerückt was ich absolut richtig
finde daneben sind unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten im Verbund mit der EU NATO
und den Vereinten Nationen im Rahmen
unserer internationalen Verantwortung in
weltweiten Friedens einsetzen aktiv und
die Krisen häufen sich immer weiter
darum ist es eine gute und richtige
Entscheidung dass im Verteidigungsetat
im Titel für die internationalen
Einsätze mehr Geld eingestellt ist und
ich führe auch gerne aus warum das gut
ist wir haben mehrfach in der letzten
Zeit gesehen wie schnell Regionen und
Länder die vermeintlich sicher Schienen
zu einem neuen Krisen Herd werden können
die Bundeswehr muss gegebenenfalls in
solchen Fällen sehr schnell und flexibel
reagieren können um Evakuierung oder
Abtransporte effektiv durchführen zu
können beste Beispiele sind die letzten
Einsätze der Bundeswehr in Niger oder im
Sudan an Stelle möchte ich einen
Einsatzkräften danken die bei den Flügen
den Evakuierung und den
Rettungsmaßnahmen beteiligt waren und wo
professionell agierten
im Ernstfall kann es also sein dass
wenig Zeit da ist dafür aber ein
erhöhter finanzieller Bedarf sodass es
folgerichtig ist bei zunehmend
weltweiten Krisen einen finanziellen
Puffer zu schaffen um eben im Ernstfall
schnell reagieren zu können zum Schluss
möchte ich noch mal festhalten dass der
Zuwachs Imitat wichtig ist wir müssen
zudem immer auch die Mittel- und
langfristige Perspektive berücksichtigen
Olaf Scholz und seine Entscheidung als
Kanzler ein Sondervermögen aufzulegen
ist zu verdanken dass wir bereits heute
wichtige Investitionen tätigen konnten
und damit den Einzelplan entlastet haben
angesichts der neuen
sicherheitspolitischen Herausforderungen
in Europa und der andauernden
Verpflichtung in den internationalen
Einsätzen als verlässlicher Partner kann
sich nur eine gut ausgerüstete
Bundeswehr ihren Aufgaben stellen daher
müssen und werden wir vorausschauen
investieren in Personal und Material für
Verlässlichkeit Stabilität und
Planungssicherheit danke schön
nächster Redner ist der fraktionslose
Abgeordnete robertale
in diesem Deutschen Bundestag gibt es
sechs fraktionslose Abgeordnete alle
waren ehemals Mitglieder der
afd-fraktion und Robert fahle einer der
fleißigsten von ihnen hat jetzt das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren nach einem Jahr
Zeitenwende ist unsere Bundeswehr noch
blanker als blank und Deutschland um
mindestens 20 Milliarden Euro
ärmer
mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin zitiere
ich den heutigen Bundeskanzler und
damaligen juso-vorsitzenden Olaf Scholz
der am 5 September 87 bei einer FDJ
Friedenskundgebung folgendes sagte Zitat
frieden kann heute und in dieser Welt
nicht mehr militärisch hergestellt
werden
Sicherheit und Frieden sind nur
politisch herstellbar
Zitat Ende diese Position finde ich
richtig und vernünftig warum weil man im
nuklear Zeitalter mit allen Nachbarn nur
in Frieden leben kann wenn man
gegenseitiges Vertrauen schafft und die
Sicherheitsinteressen der anderen
jeweils ernst nimmt und auf Augenhöhe
berücksichtigt am 18.38 sagte der
jetzige Kanzler Scholz bei einer
wahlkampfkundgebung in München nicht
zitiere
und die die hier mit Friedenstauben
rumlaufen sind deshalb vielleicht
gefallene Engel die aus der Hölle kommen
weil sie letztendlich einem
Kriegstreiber das Wort reden Zitat Ende
ich frage den Herrn Scholz was steckt
hinter dieser 180 Grad Wände in seiner
Person
sind Sie ein Mann ohne Überzeugung der
seine Fahne nach dem Mainstream
ausrichtet je nachdem woher der Wind
gerade weht Herr Pistorius sie haben die
Losung ausgegeben von stark Zimmermann
und Frau bärburg die Ukraine muss
gewinnen sie sorgen mit immer weiteren
Waffenlieferungen und Kriegstechnik und
Munition dafür dass das Töten immer
weitergeht und weitere zehntausende
Ukraine und Russen sterben
ich sage Ihnen niemand kann diesen Krieg
gewinnen die Ukraine nicht Russland
nicht wir brauchen einen sofortigen
Waffenstillstand in Verantwortung des
Sicherheitsrats und wir wollen auch in
Deutschland
Sozialstaat kostet vielen Dank
ja und das war Robert fahle fraktionslos
der sehr häufig das Wort ergreift zu
verschiedenen Debatten vor allen Dingen
aus dem politikverteidigungspolitik aber
er hat mich sicher auch in anderen
Wolfgang Helmig ist jetzt der letzte
Redner von der SPD der
verteidigungspolitische Sprecher
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen keinen falschen Eindruck
eintreten lassen das was an den beiden
Flügeln und auch von einzelnen Personen
die gesagt hat ist isolierte Meinungen
der Stelle die mehr dieses Hauses steht
an der Ukraine solange es notwendig ist
und nötig ist und wir stehen zu unserem
Wort der Unterstützung jederzeit
jederzeit und nachhaltig
ansonsten habe ich aber den Eindruck
dass ich sag mal die popanzerei heute
weitergegangen ist
wenn die rhetorischen Piraten schon
nicht dazu reichen der Realität des
Haushalt des nahezukommen und dann
Personalfragen hier und das Podium zu
ziehen tiefer kann man nicht sinken das
ist unanständig Frau Kollegin Vierecke
das ist unanständig trotzdem herzlichen
Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag
wir haben im Laufe dieses Jahres im
Haushaltsausschuss und im
Verteidigungsausschuss noch ich glaube
60 25 Millionen Vorlagen auf dem Tisch
liegen um das Sondervermögen umzusetzen
wir haben persönliche Ausstattung
geschafft werden der Entscheidung
getroffen über die F35 wir haben
Entscheidungen getroffen über den
schweren Transporthubschrauber wir haben
viele viele Entscheidungen getroffen die
darauf ausgerichtet sind die Bundeswehr
personell und materiell so in den Stand
zu setzen wie sie das für eine kampf-
und Bündnisfähigkeit braucht und in
diesem Haushalt um es klar zu machen
trotz schwarzer Null trotz keine Ahnung
trotz Milliarden Einsparungen ist die
Bundeswehr diejenigen die als einzige in
diesem Haushalt dazu gewonnen hat wir
hätten uns vielleicht mehr gewünscht ja
das hat der Minister gesagt
aber der Kanzler hat heute morgen auch
gedacht und dargestellt wie auf der
Strecke der Finanzierung jede
Bundesregierung da gebunden sein wird
diese zwei Prozent die Zusagen nicht nur
an die NATO sondern in die Bundesbahn
hineinzustecken und das an der Stelle
auch nachhaltig zu finanzieren ein Wort
gilt und ein Wort steht und wir halten
unsere internationalen Verpflichtungen
ein und die Soldaten können Sie darauf
verlassen dass wir zu unserem Wort
stehen und das auch entsprechend
umsetzen
[Applaus]
die Unterstützung der Ukraine gilt bis
ein Krieg zu Ende ist und die
Ausstattung der Bundeswehr und die
Instandsetzung der Bundeswehr als
kampffähiger mäh und
durchsetzungsfähiger Armee gilt auch
über diesen Tag hinaus
der Kanzler deutlich gemacht dass nach
dem auslaufende Sondervermögens aus dem
Kernhaushalt finanziert werden muss ja
das werden wir tun und er hat auch
gesagt dass es dafür jetzt gilt Vorsorge
zu treffen aber die partielle Amnesie
oder das nicht hinhören können der
Opposition ist dann nicht drauf
eingegangen
im Interesse der Sicherheit des bereits
erreichten werden wir auch diese
Finanzierung des Haushaltes
sicherstellen über die Zeit hinaus und
damit auch und damit auch die
Verausgabung des Sondervermögens gelingt
brauchen wir mehr Flexibilität und
Planungssicherheit für unsere Industrie
deshalb ist es genau richtig diese
Flexibilität im Sondervermögen so
anzugehen dass man mit dem Kauf der F-35
gleichzeitig auch die Infrastruktur
durch diesen bauen und es ist richtig
mit dem Kauf von Panzern und anderen
auch den munitionstitel zu erhöhen und
über das Sondervermögen sicherzustellen
dass das gelingt sie haben immer zum
Ende eines jeden Haushaltsjahres Reste
zusammengeklappt um Übungsmunition zu
kaufen und in ihrer Verantwortung sind
die Munitionsdepots geschlossen werden
wir gehen genau in anderen Weg weil
unsere Verantwortung ist es in unserer
Verantwortung liegt es die Bundeswehr
wieder entstanden zu setzen das Wort an
die Soldaten Soldaten gilt wir werden
dieses tun wir werden die Bundeswehr
ausstatten als dem Ziel dass der
Bundeskanzler ausgegeben hat die
modernste und best ausgestattete Armee
Europas vielen Dank
Wolfgang Helmig war der letzte Redner
hier zum Einzelplan weitere Wortmeldung
14 Verteidigung und
an den Geschäftsbereich jetzt weiter
genau mit dem nächsten Einzelplan
nämlich Einzelplan 12 digitales und
Verkehr dieser Einzelplan ist
traditionell der größte
investitionshaushalte des
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing plant für
das nächste Jahr mit mehr Ausgaben als
in diesem Jahr der Etat liegt bei 38,7
Milliarden Euro gegenüber
35,85 Milliarden
Ballon 5,8 Milliarden Euro im laufenden
Jahr das sind über 3 Milliarden oder 8,8
% mehr das Bundesverkehrsministerium
gehört zu den 10 Ministerien die mehr
Geld bekommen als in der bisherigen
Finanzplanung vorgesehen war das Plus
erklärt sich mit notwendigen
Investitionen in die Deutsche Bahn so
und jetzt geht's los und bevor der
Verkehrsminister das Wort kriegt
hat Frau ösus hier noch einmal um Ruhe
gebeten und es ist ja immer so nach
einem Einzelplan die
Politiker verlassen hier das Hohe Haus
jetzt und jetzt kann es weitergehen mit
dem
Bundesverkehrsminister Volker bisschen
von der FDP
frau Präsidentin ich danke Ihnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Januar bis
Ende Juli sind fast 70 Millionen
Menschen zusammen knapp 22 Milliarden
Kilometer in einem ICE oder IC gefahren
das ist liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ein historischer Rekord nie zuvor haben
Fahrgäste in einem halben Jahr mehr
Personenkilometer entfernt der Deutschen
Bahn zurückgelegt
wir sind also auf dem richtigen Weg zur
Wahrheit gehört aber auch die Zahl der
Menschen die ihr Ziel nicht pünktlich
erreicht haben ist gewachsen jetzt recht
sich dass unsere Schieneninfrastruktur
Jahrzehnte lang vernachlässigt wurde und
an ihre absoluten Grenzen gebracht wurde
im August das zeigen neuen Zahlen der DB
waren nur noch knapp zwei von drei
Fernzügen pünktlich ähnlich
herausfordernd ist die Lage im
Güterverkehr das ist nicht nur extrem
ärgerlich für die Reisenden so kann das
für ein Land wie die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland nicht bleiben liebe
Kolleginnen
und deshalb ist die Bundesregierung fest
entschlossen dass zu ändern mit neuen
strategischen Ansätzen und mit einem
massiven Finanzpaket das seinesgleichen
sucht schon jetzt stellen wir 24
Milliarden Euro zusätzlich für die Bahn
bereit damit drücken wir die Schiene
dahin wo sie hingehört ins Zentrum einer
modernen nachhaltigen und guten
Mobilität
und so werden wir im kommenden Jahr in
Mammutprojekt starten nämlich
nacheinander die hochbelasteten Korridor
unseres kernnetzes zu sanieren das heißt
an den wichtigsten Stellen werden
weichen Oberleitungen Schwellen
Stellwerke Bahnhöfe während einer kurzen
sperrphase gebündelt generalüberholt und
technisch auf den neuesten Stand
gebracht nur so können wir unser
ehrgeiziges Ziel erreichen bis 2030
eines der leistungsfähigsten und
zuverlässigsten und digitalisierten
Schienennetze Europas zu schaffen
und davon werden Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft gleichermaßen profitieren
ein modernes Schienennetz ist
Voraussetzung dafür dass Gütertransporte
in Zukunft verlässlich und pünktlich
sind und Menschen gerne und noch mehr
mit der Bahn fahren und unser Erfolgshit
das Deutschland Ticket das bereits mehr
als 11 Millionen Mal abonniert wurde
braucht eine leistungsfähige Schiene
damit seine Vorteile vollumfänglich zur
Geltung kommen
mit diesem Finanzpaket und den
begleitenden weiteren Maßnahmen etwa der
Novellierung des Bundes Schienenwege
ausbaugesetzes gehen wir eine gewaltigen
und entscheidenden Schritt in Richtung
einer klimafreundlichen Mobilität doch
die Schiene ist nur ein Baustein auch
Wasserstraßen Radverkehr Ladesäulen für
Autos und LKW der Umstieg auf
alternative Antriebe werden von uns im
kommenden Jahr wieder mit sehr viel Geld
unterstützt und natürlich investieren
wir auch weiter in unserer Straßennetz
und insbesondere und unsere maroden
Brücken die in einem Zustand sind der
alarmierendes das alles arbeiten wir
auch mit den notwendigen finanziellen
Mitteln
selbst mit unserem riesigen Finanzpaket
für die Schiene wird das niemals möglich
sein den gesamten Transport per Bahn
abzuwickeln deshalb wird auch der Lkw in
Zukunft ein dominierendes
Transportmittel bleiben aber natürlich
bald mit alternativen Antrieben und auch
diesen Umstieg fördern wir massiv
genauso wie die Digitalisierung das
Ausbautempo war nie so hoch wie zur Zeit
bereits heute kann jeder vierte Haushalt
in Deutschland leistungsfähige
Glasfaseranschlüsse nutzen
technologieübergreifend sind heute schon
mehr als 70 Prozent der Haushalte mit
Giga mit Anschlüssen versorgt 87 Prozent
der Fläche Deutschlands mit 5g und 97%
mit 4G und auch beim Umsetzen unserer
digitalstrategie kommen wir in großen
Schritten voran gerade jetzt zum Monat
Anfang haben wir die digitale
Fahrzeugzulassung auf das Niveau gehoben
wo sie hingehört digital zulassen sofort
losfahren und dabei können auch noch
rund 30 Millionen Euro pro Jahr an
Kosten eingespart werden für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die
Wirtschaft bedeutet das Gebühren
Senkungen das sind die Früchte einer
guten digitalpolitik
und wir haben auf unserer
Kabinettsklausur in Meseberg auch an
unsere datenstrategie verabschiedet denn
es ist wichtig dass wir künftig die
Daten Verfügbarkeit stärker in den Blick
nehmen ohne Daten keine Digitalisierung
das Verlegen von Glasfaseranschlüssen
und die Bereitstellung von 5g ist das
eine aber nutzbar ist das für die
Digitalisierung nur wenn Daten verfügbar
sind und da haben wir einen Aufholbedarf
und wollen konsequent vorangehen und wir
legen größten Wert darauf dass die
Verfügbarkeit von Daten zur Messlatte
all unserer politischen Entscheidungen
gemacht wir brauchen eine mutige
datenkultur
und das nutzen und Teilen von Daten dann
muss der Normalfall sein und Bedenken
dagegen dürfen nur greifen wenn sie
wirklich begründet sind und das ist der
gamechanger in der digitalpolitik ich
bin überzeugt damit schaffen wir die
Grundlage dafür dass innovative
datenbasierte Anwendungen künftig
verstärkt auch aus Deutschland kommen
wir haben einen starken
aufholeffekt im Bereich der digitalen
Start-ups was KI angeht
68 Prozent plus in einem Jahr über 500
digitale startup-bereich wir haben alle
Chancen und die Bundesregierung schafft
auch mit diesem Haushalt die
Voraussetzungen dafür dass wir sie
nutzen können
verantwortungsvolles Regierungshandeln
setzt vernünftige und weitsichtige
Entscheidung voraus und vor allen Dingen
auch solides Haushalten nur ein solider
Haushalt ermöglicht langfristige
Investitionen Infrastruktur
Digitalisierung und Klimaschutz der
vorliegenden Entwurf zum Einzelplan 12
den wir heute diskutieren entspricht
genau diesen Anforderungen wir können
die Digitalisierung engagiert
vorantreiben und zugleich mehr als je
zuvor in unsere Infrastruktur
investieren und damit in eine gute
Zukunft für Deutschland für die
Wirtschaft und für unsere gesamte
Gesellschaft vielen Dank
ein zufriedener bundesverkehrs und
digital Minister Volker Wissing
ja der Einzelplan 12 digitales und
Verkehr wird jetzt diskutiert werden und
der erste Redner nach dem Minister ist
reinhard Brandl der Sprecher für
digitales von der cdu/cs Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dieser Haushalt Herr Minister
pulverisiert eines der größten
Versprechen der Ampelkoalition und
dieses Versprechen bekannt begann im
Wahlkampf mit einem Plakat
digital first Bedenken second ein gutes
Plakat ein guter Spruch
nach dem Plakat kann der
Koalitionsvertrag
[Applaus]
218 mal kommt in dem Koalitionsvertrag
des Wort digital vor nur 198 wurde das
Wort Klima und nur 121 mal das Wort
sozial dann kam der digitalminister
Wissing der erste digitalminister in
unserem Land und jeder hat gedacht jetzt
geht's los Deutschland startet durch
heute zwei Jahre nach der großen
fortschrittskoalition schreiben die
Medienhäuser in Deutschland folgendes
über ihre digitalpolitik ZDF
Digitalisierung
Süddeutsche Zeitung also so vertragen
sich vor was sie vortragen möchten aber
jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit Plakate
hochhalten FAZ Kürzungen des
digital-budgets schaden dem Land
Heise Budget um 99 Prozent gibtürzt
Kritik am deutschen digitalen Sparpaket
meine Damen und Herren ich frage mich
wie kann man so ein Thema mit so einem
Anlauf in kurzer Zeit zu dermaßen an die
Wand fahren
jetzt waren wir jetzt waren wir im
Bereich Digitalisierung bei uns in
unserer Zeit auch nicht immer an der
Spitze aber mit ihnen fallen wir noch
zurück ihre ambitionslose digitalpolitik
ist ein Armutszeugnis und schadet
unserem Land
ich kritisiere sie ihr Wissen nicht
dafür dass sie sparen wir müssen auch
sparen ich kritisiere dass sie dafür
dass sie im Bereich der digitalpolitik
nicht priorisieren dass sie keine
Schwerpunkte setzen und auch nicht
erklären und ihre Rede von eben war ja
das beste Beispiel dafür sie haben mit
keinem Wort die Kürzungen im
Digitalbereich erwähnt dabei sind ja
mehrere große Elefanten hier im Raum
wenn wir mal einen ganz großen das Thema
Glasfaserausbau die Frage die sich doch
stellt ist reichen die weniger Mittel
aus um alle Zusagen um alle politischen
Versprechungen im Bereich
Glasfaserausbau zu beziehen ja oder nein
oder gibt es wie im letzten Jahr einen
Förderstopp und diese Frage stellen nur
ich nicht erstellen mich ich nicht
sondern diese Frage stellen sich Länder
und Kommunen im ganzen Land die brauchen
nicht nur mehr Geld die brauchen vor
allem Planungssicherheit und diese
Planungssicherheit haben sie mit der
Bundesregierung nicht und das was im
Moment
des im Moment was im Moment im Bereich
verwaltungsdigitalisierung abläuft 99
Prozent Kürzungen im Bereich der
verwaltungsdigitalisierung ist auch ein
Desaster für die bundländer für die
Bundesländer Beziehungen und es gilt der
Satz wer sich auf diese Bundesregierung
verlässt ist verlassen
aber jetzt
jetzt komme ich zu ihrem eigenen jetzt
komme ich zu ihren eigenen Haushalten wo
ist die Priorisierung wo ist die
schwerpunktssitzung und sie haben die
digitalstrategie erwähnt Herr wir sind
das ist keine Priorisierung es ist ein
Sammelsurium von Einzelprojekten die die
Ressorts gemeldet haben den sie dafür
auch zusätzlich Geld versprochen haben
das digital-budget steht im
Koalitionsvertrag das digitalbudget ist
nicht gekommen stattdessen macht die
Regierung genau das Gegenteil sie kürzt
im Mittel und in dieser Situation
bräuchten wir jetzt einen starken
digitalminister der entscheidet was
stehen bleibt und was nicht weil wenn es
da keinen gibt dann macht es der
Rasenmäher und wenn ich in ihren
Haushalt sehe schau dann sehe ich dass
der Rasenmäher drüber gegangen ist 25
Prozent Mittelkürzungen im Bereich
digitale Infrastruktur sie geben nur
noch zwei Prozent ihres Haushalts für
digitalprojekte aus lieber Herr Wissing
ihr Ministerium heißt Bundesministerium
für digitales und Verkehr ich würde
Ihnen raten langsam mal das
Klingelschild abzu montieren
weil langsam wird lächerlich in diesem
Sinne herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit und ich hoffe dass wir im
Bereich dass wir in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen diesen Haushalt
noch verbessern können herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
hat vor allen Dingen kritisiert dass die
Verwaltungs Digitalisierung quasi nicht
mehr stattfinden kann im digitalen
Infrastrukturbereich bekommen dass
Ministerium
95,7 Millionen Euro in diesem Jahr sind
es noch 1,21 Milliarden gewesen gekürzt
werden aber auch Ausgaben für Luft und
Raumfahrt
und das ist nur einer der vielen Posten
es ist der größte Investitionshaushalt
des Bundes das Bundesverkehrsministerium
ist auch für Digitalisierung zuständig
und jetzt hier noch mal die Ermahnung
dass man hier sich an die Redezeit hält
auch dass man nicht irgendwelche Plakate
bringt
jetzt für die SPD frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn wir unsere
Klimaziele erreichen wollen müssen wir
massiv in unsere Verkehrsinfrastruktur
investieren und genau das machen wir im
kommenden Jahr wird der Bund insgesamt
über 92 Milliarden Euro investieren
davon über 32 Milliarden Euro alleine
die Verkehrsinfrastruktur vor allem
investieren wir die Schiene alleine im
nächsten Jahr etwa 18 Milliarden Euro
und das ist auch nötig denn die Bahn
muss besser werden egal ob sie mit der
S3 von Hamburg Harburg zum Hamburger
Hauptbahnhof fahren oder mit dem ICE von
Köln nach Stuttgart sie muss
zuverlässiger und leistungsfähiger
werden denn die Bahn wird in Zukunft
noch mehr leisten müssen wir investieren
in den Ausbau des Netzes und wir
investieren in die Digitalisierung des
Netzes Digitalisierung ist der Schlüssel
für eine höhere Zuverlässigkeit und mehr
Kapazitäten auf der Schiene wenn wir
unsere Klimaziele erreichen wollen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen müssen wir
massiv in unsere Verkehrsinfrastruktur
investieren dabei investieren wir
deutlich mehr in die Schiene als in die
die Bundesfernstraßen werden aus Kapitel
1201 finanziert kann man alles nachlesen
dort werden 12,8 Milliarden Euro für die
Straße ausgegeben der bundesschienenwege
werden in Kapitel 1202 finanziert dort
stehen 12,1 Milliarden drin aber dazu
kommt Förderprogramme Kapitel 12 10 851
Millionen Euro für den Einzelwagen
Verkehr Trassenpreis für euren
baukostenzuschüsse dazu kommen die 4
Milliarden Euro für die Bahn aus dem
Klima Transformation vor ganz zu
schweigen von den Mitteln im Rahmen des
gemeindeverkehrsfinanzierungsgesetzes
die ganz überwiegend in die Schiene
fließen noch mal eine Milliarde
insgesamt sind das gut 18 Milliarden
Euro
aber
wir vergessen die Straße nicht
Investition für die Straße Infrastruktur
wurden auf hohem Niveau fortgeführt wir
lassen nicht zu dass uns unsere Brücken
zusammenbrechen übrigens was mich
besonders freut wird durchbrechen mit
der Verwendung der lkw-maut-einnahmen
den alten falschen Grundsatz Straße
finanziert Straße wir werden auf jede
Tonne CO2
CO2 Mission im Lkw-Verkehr eine Maut
über 200 € erheben wir tun das um Güter
von dir von der Straße auf die Schiene
zu bekommen und gleichzeitig und massiv
Anreize zu Elektrifizierung und damit
dekaronisierung des Frachtverkehrs zu
erzielen so geht kluge
Investitionspolitik
der Regierungsentwurf besonders
erfreulich schließt die
investitionslücke bei den Wasserstraßen
dort steigen Investition um 30 Prozent
gute Nachrichten für den
Nord-Ostsee-Kanal wenn wir unsere
Klimaziele erreichen wollen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen da müssen wir
massiv in unsere
Verkehrsinfrastruktur investieren dazu
gehört aber nicht nur Stahl und Beton
zum
Infrastrukturausbau gehören auch immer
Frauen und Männer die ihn betreiben ob
in Schutzanzug oder am Schreibtisch das
alles ist nur möglich wenn tausende
Menschen es mit ihrer Arbeit möglich
machen deshalb müssen wir auch in
Menschen investieren ich nenne hier nur
ein Beispiel von vielen aus dem
Einzelplan 12 und ich wähle die
Wasserstraßen und Schifffahrtsverwaltung
des Bundes sie ist gemessen an der Zahl
der Beschäftigten die mit Abstand größte
Verwaltungseinheit des
Verkehrsministeriums die Wasserstraße
und Schifffahrtsverwaltung verfügt über
13.200 Plan stehen von denen jedoch nur
11.400 Besätze eine Differenz von
800 Menschen nicht stehen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren sie glauben
doch nicht ernsthaft dass dieser
Fachkräftemangel an der investitionspowa
unseres Landes und mir nichts dir nichts
vorbei geht uns fehlen die Menschen wir
müssen die Qualifikation von
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern
investieren Erwerbsquote von Frauen
Gender Pay gibt zwischen Männern und
Frauen Einwanderung in den Arbeitsmarkt
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren das
Kita das Gute Kita gesetzt die Kinder
Grundsicherung Qualifizierung Chancen
gesetzt Gesetz zur Stärkung der aus- und
Weiterbildungsförderung Ausländer
Beschäftigungsförderungsgesetz das sind
keine sozial climbim Themen Einwanderung
in unser Land ist keine goodwillaktion
gegenüber Ausländern das ist eine hartes
Investitions Thema das über die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes
entscheidet
wir werden
wir werden unser Geld in die
schienestraße und Wasserstraße nur dann
verbaut bekommen wenn wir auch die
Ingenieuren bauarbeiterin wenn wir die
Verwaltungsangestellte und die Arbeiter
dazu haben die investieren und wir
entlasten auch im Verkehrsbereich
entlasten wir mit dem Deutschland Ticket
senken wir die Preise für die Nahverkehr
sensationell das ist ein riesen Erfolg
dieser Koalition
1,5 Milliarden stellt der Bund dazu
Verfügung bis 2025 die andere Hälfte
kommt von den Ländern
und noch ein Lieblingsthema gestatten
sie es für ein Hamburger Abgeordneten
unsere Häfen ihre Bedeutung für die
Wirtschaft und die Versorgung unseres
Landes ist vielen immer noch nicht klar
und die Bedeutung der Hilfen wird mit
der dekarbonisierung unserer Wirtschaft
und im Aufbau einer
wasserstoffinfrastruktur noch größer
werden unsere Häfen verändern unser Land
nicht nur an den Küsten deshalb müssen
wir auch in unsere Häfen investieren wir
brauchen die Hilfe damit die
Energieproduktion Energietransport und
die damit verbundene
wasserstoffindustrie funktionieren dafür
müssen wir die Häfen als Bundesaufgabe
ernst nehmen deshalb entwickeln wir
da können Sie übrigens auch klatschen
wenn sie nicht von der Küste kommen weil
es wird ganz für das ganze Land geht
deshalb entwickeln wir eine nationale
hafenstrategie die Zukunft unser Häfen
ist ein wichtiger Baustein der Zukunft
unseres Landes ich freue mich alle
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen nächste
Woche in Bremen auf der nationalen
maritim-konferenz wiederzusehen zum
Abschluss ich habe noch eine Minute Zeit
was unerfreulich ist was sehr
unerfreuliches
ich hätte heute gern noch mehr
Investitionen
umso bedauerlicher ist der
schadensansatz er Schadensersatzanspruch
der Eventim Aktiengesellschaft und der
Kapsch GmbH gegen den Bund
243 Millionen Euro müssen wir die
Menschen in diesem Land dafür auf den
Tisch des Hauses legen
243 Millionen Euro für die verhunzte
Pkw-Maut des an die scheuer wir werden
dieses Geld im haushaltsverlauf aus dem
Einzelplan 12 nehmen
243 Millionen Euro weil Herr scheuer
weil die CSU Wahlkampf gemacht hat
Europa Feindlichkeit
Ausländerfeindlichkeit ich erinnere mich
an die Sprüche von holländischen
gespannt die auf deutschen Autobahn
keine Gebühren zahlen
unverantwortlich alle alle haben es
Herrn scheuer gesagt es ist rechtswidig
ist Europa es wird nicht funktionieren
er hat es trotzdem gemacht
übrigens übrigens ganz ruhig übrigens
aus seiner Sicht war das ein gutes
Invest ein invest in den csu-wahlkampf
in den CS in den europafeindlichen
csu-wahlkampf in Bayern Glückwunsch
wissen Sie was wir mit den 243 Millionen
hätten machen können wir hätten drei
Raketenstarts der Ariane 6 finanzieren
können wir hätten sieben ICE Neos die
neuen Dinge mit dem man auch Handy
telefonieren kann kaufen können wir
hätten 172 km Eisenbahntrasse
elektrifizieren können wir hätten Sie
bitte zum Schluss 70.000 private
e-ladesäulen fördern wir hätten lieber
eine Million Quadratmeter
Fotovoltaikanlagen ins verkaufen können
Liebe CSU erst das Land dann die Partei
das hier wäre eine sehr sehr gute
Gelegenheit sich bei den Menschen in
diesem Land zu entschuldigen vielen Dank
Mädchen hat Verdi war das von der SPD
der nächste Redner hier im Einzelplan 12
digitales und Verkehr ist Markus Mühl
er ist von der AFD
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir beraten heute mit dem
Haushalt für digitales und Verkehr den
größten
Investitionshaushalt des Bundes
Investitionshaushalt heißt investieren
und da sind wir auch schon bei den
Problemen in ihrem Entwurf Herr Minister
Wissing sie gehen von ausgaberesten in
diesem Jahr von 6,7 Milliarden Euro aus
das ist nach den 7,2 Milliarden Euro in
2022 wieder ein hoher Spitzenwert
1,5 Milliarden Euro ausgabenreste bei
bundeschienenwegen und gleichzeitig
wollen sie diesen Bereich um 2,8
Milliarden Euro verstärken es ist völlig
unrealistisch dass sie diese
Größenordnung nächstes Jahr realisieren
können gleichzeitig sehen Sie weniger
Investitionen bei Bundes Fernstraßen vor
und sogar 30% weniger bei der digitalen
Infrastruktur
Investitionen auf dem Papier die nicht
realisiert werden sind Augenwischerei
und bringen 0 Fortschritt
Herr Minister die ehemalige
ramedetalbrücke stand sinnbildlich für
unsere verschlissene Infrastruktur
verschlissen weil man aus politischen
Gründen den Verkehrsträger Straße hinten
anstellt dabei sind unsere Straßen ohne
die grüne Ideologie Brille betrachtet
unsere Hauptschlagadern indem sie 80
Prozent des verkehrsabwickeln der
Straßenbau ist damit absolut prioritär
zu behandeln sie hingegen priorisieren
die Schiene
aber bleiben wir kurz bei der Schiene am
Beginn ihrer Amtszeit Herr Minister
sprachen sie über die Notwendigkeit die
Deutsche Bahn um zu strukturieren
geschehen ist bisher nicht
dennoch wollen sie auch im nächsten Jahr
das Eigenkapital der Deutschen Bahn um
1,1 Milliarden Euro erhöhen
ohne sehr grundlegende Strukturreform
bei der Bahn und ohne die Beendigung des
Auslandsgeschäfts darf es keine weitere
Kapitalerhöhung durch den Steuerzahler
geben
Herr Minister ihrer Verkehrspolitik und
das zeigen die Zahlen eindrücklich setzt
an den falschen Stellen an und
missachtet die wichtigen Punkte ihr
politisch angeordneter
e-mobilitätswahn geht völlig an der
Realität vorbei es geht ihnen um die
Umsetzung ihrer ideologischen Ziele sie
gefährden damit die Mobilität von
Millionen von Menschen und zwingen
unsere Automobilwirtschaft in ein
planwirtschaftliches Korsett mit
schwersten Verwerfungen bis hin zur
Existenzfragen
wir fordern
straßenvorrangig behandeln
technologieoffenheit bei den Antrieben
und individuelle Mobilität zu
finanzierbaren Preisen dafür werden wir
uns auch in den Haushaltsverhandlungen
stark machen danke schön
nächste Rednerin ist Dr Paula piacotta
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
ZuschauerInnen wenn man aktuell im
Ausland unterwegs ist muss man sich nach
dem großen internationalen Sport den wir
hatten nach dem ber Flughafen Desaster
und nach Stuttgart 21 muss man sich
gerade tatsächlich daran gewöhnen dass
man inzwischen im Ausland manchmal
positiv auf die deutsche Verkehrspolitik
angesprochen wird das äußert sich auch
nicht nur darin dass zum Beispiel als
diese Woche Präsident macron angekündigt
hat in Frankreich nach dem Vorbild des
deutschland-tickets ein Ticket in den
Regionen auszubringen sondern selbst
wenn wir uns mit Parlamentariern aus
befreundeten demokratischen Ländern eine
halbe Erdkugel entfernt wie gestern
Abend treffen dann ist eins der
zentralen Themen ihr habt doch dieses
deutschland-ticket wie finanzierte das
und welche Effekte seht ihr erst seit
vier Monaten
seit vier Monaten existiert dieses
Ticket 10 Millionen Tickets davon 40
Prozent 40 Prozent hatten vorher schon
den Abo aber die sparen jetzt kräftig
fast 50 Prozent hatten vorher kein Abo
und sind jetzt grenzenlos unterwegs
mobil und sogar acht Prozent von denen
sind mit dem Ticket vom Auto auf den
Nahverkehr umgestiegen und meine Damen
und Herren und gerade auch liebe Union
das ist auch ihr Erfolg weil ohne die
Landesverkehrsminister auch der cdu/csu
wäre das gar nicht möglich gewesen und
akzeptieren Sie doch endlich dass das
auch ihr Erfolg ist stehen sie auch zu
diesem Erfolg dieses Ticket gibt es nur
und es heißt Deutschland Ticket weil
alle demokratischen Parteien von
Linkspartei bis zur CSU am Ende mit
daran mitgewirkt haben und mit diesem
Titel der wird ja auch drüber gesprochen
wie teuer das ist aber zur Wahrheit
gehört auch dazu viele Millionen
ArbeitnehmerInnen in diesem Land kriegen
das Jobticket als Version für 34 € oder
weniger viele Länder gehen voran NRW mit
dem Schülerticket für 29 Euro Thüringen
mit dem jungen Menschen Ticket für 28 €.
das heißt auch Millionen von Menschen
sind noch günstiger unterwegs für 28 €
für 29 € für 34 € am Wochentag auf
Arbeit und zurück am Wochenende durchs
ganze Land das ist das neue normal in
Deutschland und es hat sich
rumgesprochen in nur vier Monaten bis
ganz andere Ende der Welt
mit dem deutschland-ticket ernten wir
jetzt die am niedrigsten am einfachsten
am niedrigsten hängenden Früchte der
Verkehrswende aber das reicht natürlich
nicht jetzt braucht es den Ausbau und
vor allen Dingen braucht es nach 12
Jahren CSU im Verkehrsministerium auch
das Auflösen des innovationsstaus im
verkehrsinfrastrukturwesen und meine
Damen und Herren
die Kollegen haben jetzt viel darüber
gesprochen wie viel allein in die Bahn
fließt aber von den 90 Milliarden die
werden Investitionen im Kernhaushalt und
dem KTF haben für 2024 kommen 24,3
Milliarden als Investitionen die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur aus dem
Kernhaushalt und 7,8 noch mal aus dem
KTF das ist nicht nur bemerkenswert weil
es so ein unglaublich großer Anteil am
gesamtinvestitionsbestand ist sondern es
ist vor allen Dingen bemerkenswert weil
es so wahnsinnig viel mehr Geld ist was
wir in wirtschaftlich und Haushaltshilfe
schwierigen Zeiten mobilisieren als das
was sie in deutlich rosigerin Haushalt
herrisch deutlich üppigeren Zeiten auf
den Weg gebracht haben für die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur in diesem Land an
die Steuer 2018
13,9 Milliarden setzt wenn man das
inflationsbereich nicht ist das von 20
18 bis 2024 fast nur Verdoppelung und
wenn man das scheuer Maut Desaster
bereinigen würde werden wir der
Verdopplung sogar noch deutlich näher
meine Damen und Herren
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
afd-fraktion von Herrn niemals in den
letzten Tagen gab es in den sozialen
Medien den video-schnäpsel von der
ehemaligen Kanzlerin Angela Merkel der
Videoschnipsel war aber sehr alt von
1997 und die damalige Umweltministerin
sitzt dort in einer Talkshow und ich
zitiere sie sagt
viele fühlen zwar dass vieles heute
nicht in Ordnung ist aber viele Menschen
sagen bitte heute noch kein Preis dafür
noch keine Last dafür übernehmen diesen
Menschen zu sagen passt auf wenn ihr es
heute nicht macht wird für eure Kinder
und Enkelkinder doppelt und dreifach
teurer Angela Merkel von 1997 hat das
grundlegende an Investitionen verstanden
die Angela Merkel von 2005 bis 2021
setzte dieses Wissen aber nicht um und
das Ergebnis im Verkehr sehen wir das
sind bröckelnde Brücken das sind
unzuverlässige Schienen und das sind
quälend langwierige Projekte im Bereich
Wasserstraße wenn man einen
ausgeglichenen Haushalt und das
Einhalten der Schuldenbremse wie die
Koko nur schafft dadurch dass man
dringend notwendige Investitionen die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur immer weiter nach
hinten schiebt dann hat man zwar auf dem
Papier die Schuldenbremse eingehalten
aber man hat sich schlicht und
ergreifend bei denen verschuldet die
vier oder acht oder zwölf Jahre später
in diesem Land leben und das machen wir
als Ampel nicht
2024 ist aber auch das Jahr wo endlich
Kollegen haben es teilweise schon
angesprochen die Schere zwischen den
Investitionen in die Schiene und in die
Straße deutlich aufgeht und wo zum
ersten Mal Geld aus der Maut auch in die
Wasserstraße und in die Schiene fließt
und es bedeutet nicht dass die Straße
benachteiligt wird im Gegenteil
Vorgängerregierung haben Schiene und
Wasserstraße wie Stiefkinder behandelt
haben sie links liegen lassen haben sie
verkümmern lassen und wir schaffen jetzt
die Voraussetzungen dass die endlich
aufholen können weil Deutschland ist nur
stark mit starker Straße Schiene und
Wasserstraße meine Damen und Herren wenn
jetzt so viel mehr Geld in den
verkehrsinfrastrukturbereich fließt dann
brauchen wir Ihre alle Augen um zu
verhindern dass wir uns das nächste das
nächste Stuttgart 21 oder vielleicht
auch ein Stamm stecken Stammstrecken
Desaster in München an den halsbinden
das wird extrem wichtig sein und ich
glaube aber dass das in unser aller
Interesse ist weil wir nicht nur allen
Interesse an der zuverlässigen
Verkehrsinfrastruktur in Deutschland
haben sondern weil wir alle Interesse
daran haben uns daran zu gewöhnen dass
wir in Zukunft nur noch positiv im
Ausland auf deutsche Verkehrspolitik
angesprochen werden vielen Dank
zu einer Kurzintervention hält das Wort
der Abgeordnete Bochmann
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Kollegin picotta vielen
Dank dass Sie die Kurzinformationen
zulassen als erstes
gut eine Frage sie haben vorhin vom 49
vom Erfolg des 49 Euro Tickets
gesprochen sie haben vorhin vom Erfolg
des 49 Euro Tickets gesprochen jetzt
erklären Sie mir bitte und das hier
unter vielen Zeugen wie ich das meinen
Wählern in meinem Landkreis Nordsachsen
und zwar in dem Ort Klitschen erklären
soll wo der Haltepunkt vom S-Bahn-Netz
genommen wurde das heißt die müssen
frühs ins Auto steigen einen Ort
weiterfahren um von diesem 49 Euro
Ticket zu profitieren also das ist für
mich nicht nachvollziehbar danke
möchten Sie Antworten nein okay dann
gehen wir weiter in der Debatte und das
Wort erhält Viktor Perli für die
Fraktion DIE LINKE
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
erstmal bin ich hier feststellen marode
Schienen kaputte Straßen und Brücken
sind kein Grund zum Feiern das war ganz
schön viel Schulterklopfen hier gerade
von der ampelkondition denn die
Infrastruktur in Deutschland wird
weiterhin auf Verschleiß Gefahren der
Investitionsstau bei dem Verkehrswegen
allein vor Ort beträgt inzwischen
unfassbare 372 Milliarden Euro euer Bahn
mindestens 89 Milliarden Euro der
Haushaltsentwurf mit dem
Sanierungsbedarf den Herausforderung
unserer Gesellschaft in keiner Weise
gerecht
alle reden alle reden vom Ausbau der
Bahn aber was macht die Ampel die
Gesamtlänge der Gleise und die Zahl der
weichen ist 2022 erneut gesunken in
diesem Jahr werden bundesweit nur 13 km
Schiene elektrifiziert 13 km das ist so
lächerlich wie es klingt sie haben
versprochen die Kapazitäten für den
Personenverkehr bis 2030 zu verdoppeln
und endlich mehr Güterverkehr auf die
Schule zu bringen aber mit diesem
Finanzplan ist das nicht mehr zu
schaffen sie müssten doppelt so viel
ausgeben deshalb fordern wir endlich
mehr Geld für die Schiene mehr Geld für
Züge statt immer mehr für Panzer meine
Damen und Herren
der Bundesverband ja hören Sie mal zu
der Bundesverband der Binnenschifffahrt
kritisiert ich zitiere das visionslose
kaputt sparen der Wasserstraße dass die
Verkehrsverlagerung hin zur Straße
weiter befeuern wird so der Verband der
Binnenschiff hat Herr Wissing
noch vollere Straßen noch mehr Staus ist
wirklich das Letzte was wir in diesem
Land brauchen
SPD Grüne und FDP wollen jetzt sogar die
Gelder für den Radverkehr drastisch
kürzen im Vergleich zu 2022 fast um die
Hälfte 350 Millionen Euro weniger wir
finden beim Radverkehr darf man nicht
kürzen man muss Fahrradwege ausbauen
meine Damen und Herren
im letzten Jahr waren viele Menschen
sehr begeistert über das 9 Euro Ticket
für den öffentlichen Nahverkehr das war
eine tolle Sache es ist endlich mal an
die Menschen mit wenig Geld gedacht
worden aber nach drei Monaten war
Schluss das 49 Euro Ticket ist für viele
zu teuer
Teile der Ampeln und ist jetzt sogar
noch teurer machen und Minister Wissing
stellt das Scheitern des gesamten
Tickets gerade auch in Frage und möchte
sie kaufen nehmen das finden wir völlig
falsch meine Damen und Herren muss und
Bahn müssen günstiger werden nicht noch
teurer
bisher ist kaum jemand vom bisher ist
kaum jemand vom Auto auf Busse um oder
Bahn umgestiegen das sagen die
verkehrsforscher von
Wissenschaftszentrum Berlin um das zu
ändern so die Forscher müsste der Preis
für das Ticket auf maximal 29 € pro
Monat sinken und das Angebot im
ländlichen Raum deutlich und massiv
ausgebaut werden genau das sollten wir
hier beschließen wir würden uns auf
jeden Fall dafür einsetzen Mobilität
muss für eine bezahlbar sein herzlichen
Dank
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Frank Scheffler
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wenn es ökonomisch schwierig ist was
kann dann der Staat in so einer
Situation tun
eigentlich kann er versuchen
Investitionen anzuregen Investitionen
anzuregen dort in der privaten
Wirtschaft aber auch als Staat versuchen
die Infrastruktur in diesem Land zwar
tüchtigen und das machen wir jetzt das
ist eigentlich die Kernbotschaft dieses
verkehrsetars wir steigern die
Investitionskosten in noch nie da
gewesenerweise
die Ausgaben natürlich
die Investitionsausgaben in noch nie
dagewesener Weise
mit 22 Milliarden
werden die wird die e-Linie jetzt im
straßenbaubereich im im Bahnbereich im
wasserstraßenbereich ausgebaut das ist
3,2 Milliarden mehr als im letzten Jahr
aber man muss es ja eigentlich mit 2019
vergleichen also vor der Krise und da
ist der Aufwuchs 7,5 Milliarden daran
sehen Sie wir investieren tatsächlich in
die Zukunft und dass das notwendig ist
das zeigen die 40.000 Brücken die wir in
Deutschland unter autobahnenverwaltung
haben und Bundesstraßen Brücken wo wir
das bis zum Jahre 2026 auf 400 Brücken
pro Jahr ausbauen wollen das eine
gigantische Leistung und das erfordert
alle das erfordert alle Anstrengungen
hier
des Verkehrsministers und gleichzeitig
und gleichzeitig werden wir in noch nie
da gewesener Weise die Investition im
Bahnbereich hochfahren das wird ja immer
wieder durchaus kritisiert die
Verspätung der Minister hatte selbst
vorhin genannt aber dass wir allein in
den nächsten Jahren allein 27 Milliarden
über den KTF und die Lkw-Maut zusätzlich
bereitstellen ist eine gigantische
Leistung wir haben als Koalition sogar
gesagt wir wollen bis zu 45 Milliarden
in die Deutsche Bahn investieren damit
das Elend was wir selbst tagtäglich
erleben auch verändert wird
lassen Sie mich noch
auch etwas zum deutschlandticket sagen
das deutschland-ticket hat der Bund mit
zusätzlichen Regionalisierungsmittel von
1,5 Milliarden Euro bis 2025
mitfinanziert
wenn ich jetzt höre dass die Länder
zusätzlich nach Geld rufen und schreien
dann kommen mir ehrlich gesagt die
Tränen denn die Länder denn die Länder
sind eigentlich von ihrem
Aufgabenbereich her verantwortlich für
den ÖPNV und ziehen sich seit Jahren aus
diesem Bereich zurück der
Bundesrechnungshof der
Bundesrechnungshof hat es den Ländern in
Stammbuch geschrieben es gibt Länder in
Deutschland die nicht mal zwei Prozent
ihrer Ausgaben
zusätzlich für den ÖPNV bereitstellen
faktisch finanziert der Bund den ÖPNV in
diesen Ländern es gibt nur ein
Bundesland das tatsächlich mehr Geld für
den ÖPNV zur Verfügung stellt als der
Bund dass da ein Skandal da kann man
doch nicht ständig nach mehr Geld rufen
wenn man selbst die eigene Aufgabe nicht
erfüllt
und auch das Thema Sondervermögen ist
immer wieder kritisiert worden was wir
jetzt hier an diesem Haushalt machen ist
dass wir ein Sondervermögen auflösen wir
holen das Sondervermögen digitale
Infrastruktur in den Kernhaushalt zurück
und wir bestätigen die finanzlinie die
wir beschlossen haben weiterhin 19
Leuchtturmprojekte der digitalstrategie
müssen jetzt aber auch prioritär
umgesetzt werden und Sie werden
prioritär umgesetzt
und lassen sie mich zum Schluss weil
mein Kollege Florian Osna von der CSU
gleiche auch noch spricht auch noch mal
das Thema Maut debake von an die Steuer
ansprechen mein Kollege hat Verdi hat
das ja vorhin schon gemacht aber er hat
es eigentlich mit Verlaub etwas
unzureichend gemacht
er hat das unzureichend deshalb gemacht
weil er den Betrag und das desasste
eigentlich schön gerechnet hat es sind
nämlich nicht 243 Millionen Schaden die
den Bund entstanden sind sondern 357
Millionen Euro denn ein Großteil sind
natürlich
Rechtsanwalt Gerichtskosten die
zusätzlich anfallen und da frage ich
mich dass alles auf dem Basar der CSU
Eitelkeit dass das alles Millionen
Steuergelder kostet da erwarte ich
gleich eine Antwort von Florian osnat
hier müsst ihr mal sehen wie die
rechtliche Situation tatsächlich
aussieht und wie er das Elend beseitigen
wollt dass ihr angerichtet habt vielen
Dank
Frank Schiffler war das für die FDP
Einzelplan 12 die digitales und Verkehr
die nächste Rednerin kommt aus der CDU
Franziska hoppermann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Minister wenn man ihnen zuhört dann
merkt man dass sie überhaupt kein
Verständnis davon haben was wirklich
digitalpolitik ist sondern sie immer
noch von digitaler Infrastruktur reden
die Frage die in digitalisierungskreisen
nämlich am häufigsten gestellt wird ist
wo ist Wissing und diese Frage ist mehr
als berechtigt es reicht nämlich nicht
aus lediglich den Namen Digitalisierung
im Ministerium voranzustellen es braucht
eben auch echtes Interesse und vor allem
wirkliches handeln und umsetzen und
genau das machen sie nicht
aber schon
aber schon zu Beginn ihrer
Regierungszeit haben sie bei der
Digitalisierung den Webfehler gemacht
und weder die Organisation noch die
Finanzierung des Themas vernünftig
aufgestellt dazu kommt die anhaltendes
persönliches Interesse gerade an
digitalpolitik wie wir heute wieder
gehört haben
der Haushaltsentwurf über den wir heute
beraten ist die Manifestation dieser
Haltung und dieser Fehler wenn wir einen
Blick auf ihren Einzelplan werfen stoßen
wir auf gerade einmal sechs Seiten und
insgesamt 900 Millionen Euro für
digitales und der Teil der nicht
digitale Infrastruktur sondern wirklich
digitalpolitik ist ist exakt ein Titel
um fast 5,9 Millionen Euro und das sind
[Musik]
0,001% ihres Etats
und darüber hinaus müssen wir
feststellen dass alles was tatsächlich
mit Digitalisierung zu tun hat nicht in
Ihrem Ressort stattfindet sondern
überall und nirgendwo in allen anderen
Ressorts und die Geringschätzung des
Themas setzt sich auch dort fort
Beispiel Innenministerium das Online
zugangsgesetz wird auf einen winzigen
Bruchteil auf ein Prozent der bisherigen
Finanzierung reduziert Kollege hat das
vorhin auch gesagt im Gesetzentwurf zum
online zugangsgesetz sind keinerlei
Ambitionen oder Fristen mehr dabei die
trinken notwendige neu Sortierung der
Gremien fehlt gänzlich auch der
Bundesrechnungshof kritisiert die
Haushaltsplanung für die
verwaltungsdigitalisierung mit der
Reduzierung um 30 %
Beispiel Wirtschaftsministerium die
Förderung der gamesindustrie wird im
Harbeck drastisch zusammengestrichen um
mehr als 30%
Beispiel für Wissenschaft und Forschung
dort werden die Mittel für KI-Forschung
um 25% gekürzt trotz der in Meseberg so
vollmundig angekündigten Strategie und
auf europäischer Ebene sieht es ja nicht
besser aus was unsere Bundesregierung
betrifft in den Abstimmungen über
europäische digitalisierungsvorhaben
blockieren sie sich stets mit anderen
Ministerien und das sogenannte
germanwood ist die Regel und nicht die
Ausnahme andere Länder setzen längst die
Standards wenn sie sich in der Regierung
weiter verhaken
was wir im Bereich der Digitalisierung
sehen ist Stillstand kein
digitalisierungsfokus sondern Bedenken
an erster Stelle keine zentrale
Steuerung keine Priorität eine
digitalstrategie die eine
Zusammenstellung bereits längst
bekannter Projekte aus dem Ministerien
ist
und vor allem kein digital Budget das
Ergebnis ist überall Kürzungen bei
vollmundigen Ankündigungen und jeder tut
was er will
sie reisen nach Estland um sich dort
Digitalisierung anzusehen wie sie
wirklich funktioniert und es bleiben
Bilder über wie sie Orgel spielen wer
mich kennt weiß dass ich dafür
persönlich sehr viel Sympathie habe aber
das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht wirklich
ihr Ernst ihre Glaubwürdigkeit gerade
als FDP haben sie beim Thema
Digitalisierung wirklich längst
eingelöst
meine Damen und Herren wir verlieren in
dieser Legislaturperiode schlichtweg
wieder vier Jahre um die Digitalisierung
mit Schwung Plan und Stringenz
voranzubringen und weil wir heute Gäste
der Feuerwehr Reutlingen zu Gast haben
Digitalisierung muss mit Sonderrechten
und Blaulicht Vorfahrt bekommen aber
hier gibt es
keine Perspektive und keine Verbesserung
in Sicht es wird höchste Zeit dass wir
unsere Digitalisierung in der Zukunft
ernsthaft in Angriff nehmen vielen Dank
der nächste Redner folgt wieder von der
SPD Detlef Müller ist der zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Sozialamt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir befinden uns als Gesellschaft
aktuellen besonders herausfordern
aber die von einigen im politischen Raum
herbeigere Untergangsstimmung hilft
niemanden außerdem Rechtspopulisten und
demokratten vielmehr gilt es in solchen
Zeiten anzupacken um sozialen
Zusammenhalt zu stärken und die Zukunft
zu gestalten daran arbeiten die
Bundesregierung und die
koalitionsfraktion verantwortungsvoll
und das zeigt sich auch in diesem
Haushalt Entwurf
warum sage ich das
weil man wichtig ist an die Kollegen der
Opposition mal zu appellieren Herr
brandli vielleicht verfolgen sie mal
hier im Deutschen Bundestag oder für den
TV-Geräten in ihrem Büro einfach mal die
Diskussion zu anderen Einzelplänen in
diesen Haushalt wie das in anderen
einzubringen aus welcher
Herausforderungen dort stehen wie dort
diskutiert wird und deswegen stelle ich
fest dass diese Einzelplan 12 dieser
Haushaltsplan Entwurf sehr solide
aufgestellt ist sehr gut aufgestellt ist
mit diesem Haushalt nämlich bekennt sich
die Koalition wie keine andere Koalition
in den letzten Jahren zur China die
Zahlen sind im Einzel waren 12 sind
zusätzlich 11,5 Milliarden Euro zu
Sanierung und modernisierungsmaschine
eingestellt im Einzelplan 60 sind im
Klima und Transformation 12,5 Milliarden
Euro vorgesehen hinzu kommen geplante
Eigenmittel der deutschen Banker gehen
in Höhe von 3 Milliarden Euro damit
werden in den kommenden Jahren in den
kommenden vier Jahren mindestens ich
sage Absicht mindestens 27 Millionen
Euro zusätzlich bereitgestellt um eine
zentralen Infrastrukturen unseres Landes
zukunftsfähig zu gestalten das ist eine
riesen Leistung
ja
und noch die Zahlen Geistern herum es
wird in den kommenden Jahren noch
weitere Bedarfe in dem Bereich geben und
deswegen ist auch eine weitere mögliche
eigenkapitalzuführung steht zur Debatte
das ist eine gute Basis die
Planungssicherheit für die Branche gibt
gerade in den von mir eingangs
angesprochenen herausfordernden Zeiten
mit diesen Mitteln werden wir hoch
belastete Strecken sanieren
modernisieren wir steigern die
Zuverlässigkeit des Bahnsystems deutlich
und schaffen spürbare Verbesserungen für
den Personen und den
Schienengüterverkehr
sehr erfreulich in diesem Haushalt bei
den letzten Jahren etwas zu kurz
gekommen sieht es für die
Bundeswasserstraße aus für den Erhalt
der
Infrastruktur 540 Millionen Euro für
Ersatz aus und Neubaumaßnahmen sind das
sogar 724 Millionen Euro insgesamt ein
Plus von 300 Millionen Euro im Vergleich
der Bundeswasserstraße im Vergleich zu
diesem Jahr der Bereich der
Bundesstraßen bleibt der Haushaltsansatz
in der Gesamtsumme Herr Bremse ruhig
bleibt der Gesamteinsatz konstant in der
Höhe von 12,8 Millionen hier wurde aber
auch Erhalt und Sanierung von Autobahn
gesetzt was insbesondere mit dem Blick
auf den Sanierungsbedarf bei Brücken
tatsächlich sinnvoll ist
denn meine Damen und Herren wir brauchen
die Fernstraßen auch für den Ausbau
unserer Energieinfrastruktur wir müssen
dafür sorgen da kann es dazu früh
angesprochen dass die Autobahnen nicht
zum Nadelöhr der Energiewende werden
weil beispielsweise Schwerlasttransporte
von Windrädern nicht im ausreichenden
Maßen stattfinden können hier muss und
hier wird auch die Autobahn GmbH mit
Nachdruck daran arbeiten die Genehmigung
von Großraum und Schwerlasttransport und
deutlich zu beschleunigen
an dieser Stelle möchte ich zudem darauf
hinweisen dass es uns mit diesem
Haushalt in den vorgesehenen Änderungen
in der mautgesetzgebung nun endlich
gelungen ist ja werde jetzt angesprochen
die geschlossenen
finanzierungskreisläufer der einzelnen
Verkehrsträger endlich aufzubrechen
meine Damen und Herren es gilt eben
nicht mehr Straße finanziert Straße und
Schiene finanziert Schiene es gilt jetzt
Verkehr finanziert Verkehr
und vor dem Hintergrund dass wir gerade
im Verkehrsbereich noch massive
Hausaufgaben bei der CO2 Reduzierung vor
uns haben ist das nicht nur voll
gerechtig sondern eben auch überfällig
auch im Bereich Digitalisierung hat der
Bundeshaushalt einiges vorzuweisen mit
rund 3 Milliarden Euro oder gigabit- und
unterstützt
Richtlinie 2.0 wird es einen noch
zielgerichtetere zielgerichtete
Unterstützung geben
meine Damen und Herren insbesondere
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung müssen
wir aber mit aller Kraft Vorantreiben
der Bund muss und wird hier Vorreiter
sein wie zum Beispiel bei der
registermodernisierung wenn das gelingt
kann und wird dies auch Ländern und
Kommunen einen entsprechenden Schub
geben die für die Umsetzung der
Digitalisierung ebenfalls in der
Verantwortung stehen hier brauchen wir
die entsprechenden Mittel unabhängig
davon ob es am Ende ein Digital Budget
gibt oder Digitalisierung halt über
entsprechende Haushaltstitel in den
Ressorts selbst forciert wird klar ist
wir dürfen bei der Digitalisierung nicht
sparen deswegen ist es über alles
wichtig
das auch in anderen einzutreten
vorhandene Ausgabe Reste die es gibt
weiterhin für die Digitalisierung
eingesetzt werden
meine Damen und Herren die im Frühjahr
vereinbarte Finanzierungszusage des
Bundes für das deutschlandticket steht
Herrli das sind drei Milliarden Euro das
ist nicht nichts und wenn sich mal
einfach mal damit beschäftigen würden
was bis da tun eine Monatskarte
beispielsweise in Köln kostet nur in der
Stadt Köln 114 €. jetzt haben wir
deutschlandweit 49 Euro das ist ein
riesiger Erfolg was sie machen ist das
klein reden schlecht reden
und auch das gilt noch mal zu sagen
lassen Sie sich von aktuellen
Diskussionen unter Presse nicht
verunsichern das deutschlandticket ist
ein riesiger Erfolg über 11 Millionen
Abonnenten wir werden in Zukunft auch
das solidarische Semesterticket
integrieren wir werden auch noch mehr
Abonnenten finden und natürlich wird das
deutschlandticket fortgeführt auch in
den nächsten Jahren 2024 auch 20 25 und
darüber hinaus
bei allen Verständnis für die damit
einhergehen Herausforderungen hier
helfen gegenseitige Vorhaltung und
Finger zeigen zwischen Bund und Land
überhaupt nicht weiter bunte Länder
müssen sich gemeinsam für das kommende
Jahr klar zum deutschlandticket von 49
Euro bitte kennen und Lösungen
erarbeiten wir als erstes für die
Bundestagsfraktion stehen dafür bereit
meine Damen und Herren ich komme zum
Schluss normalerweise würde ich an
dieser Stelle nun die diversen Förderung
formulieren was in diesem Haushalt noch
verändert werden sollte es noch
zusätzliche Mittelbedarf gibt und so
weiter
und das wäre auch ein Stück weit
einfacher gewesen wenn wir eben nicht 37
Millionen Euro Schadenersatz für an die
Steuererklärung ausgeben mussten dieses
Geld also nicht vom Mobilität
Digitalisierung ausgeben können sondern
quasi zum Fenster rauswerfen meine Damen
und Herren ich möchte heute abschließend
nur einen Appell noch an Sie richten
lassen Sie uns diesen Haushalt mit
Zuversicht arbeiten und die richtigen
Stellschrauben für die Zukunft drehen
die Voraussetzungen sind mit diesem
Haushalt bereits gegeben vielen Dank
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort dr
Dirk Spaniel
Süd daniel ist der verkehrspolitische
Sprecher der afd-bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrter
Herr Bundesminister ja
wir haben Halbzeit ihre Mannschaft hat
jetzt zwei Jahre gespielt
aber ein Großteil der Wähler in diesem
Land freut sich nicht auf die zweite
Halbzeit sondern wünscht sich nicht
sehnlicher als den Abpfiff dieser
Regierung
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
jetzt schauen wir uns doch mal an mit
welchen Versprechen sind sie in den
Wahlkampf gezogen
er wissen sie wollten die
technologieoffenheit und das
Verbrennungsmotor Verbot verhindern sie
sind reingezogen in den Wahlkampf für
den Aussagen dass sie die
planungsbeschleunigung von
Infrastrukturprojekten vorantreiben
wollen und damit hier in diesem Land
endlich schnelle Infrastruktur
ermöglichen und sie wollten als drittes
den Betrieb von Netz und Infrastruktur
trennen bei der Bahn
und im Endeffekt hier eine Bahnreform
herbeiführen jetzt schauen wir uns an
was sie gemacht haben das
verbrennungsmotorverbot das ist das
augenscheinlichste da haben sie auf
europäischer Ebene ein sicheres Veto
verhindert wir hätten das
Verbrennungsmotor Verbot auf
europäischer Ebene haben können sie
haben es verhindert sie haben sich
täuschen lassen sie haben sich täuschen
lassen mit einem Wagen versprechen dass
da lautet irgendwann werden irgendwie
synthetische Kraftstoffe berücksichtigt
und vielleicht kann man dann Ausnahmen
für diese Fahrzeuge machen und weil sie
so verunsichert waren und das gemerkt
haben haben sie ja EU-Kommission
geschrieben und sie haben bis heute
keine Antwort darauf das ist doch kein
Erfolg den sie feiern können das ist ein
großer Misserfolg den Sie eingeleitet
haben das zweite planungsbeschleunigung
da schauen wir uns mal an ist heute
schon gefallen Brücke die Rahmede
Talbrücke steht sinnbildlich für das
Versagen auch ihre
planungsbeschleunigung sie haben die
Brücke ist 2021 gesperrt worden und wir
haben jetzt sechs klare Bauzeit
kennengelernt diese sechs Jahre mit
ihren Gesetzänderungen diese sechs Jahre
können sie haben sie uns allen erklärt
können sie nur machen weil es
tatsächlich auf europäischer Ebene
Restriktion gibt jetzt schauen wir nach
Italien in Italien bauen wir diese
Brücke oder bauen die Italiener oder
haben Sie schon gebaut diese Brücke in
Genua in zwei Jahren die haben auch
keinen Verkehrsminister bis hin der
natürlich behindert durch die Grünen
hier natürlich
behindert wird in der schnellen
Ausführung und dann kommen wir zum
Lieblingsprojekt von uns allen das ist
die Bahn die Bahn die hier immer steht
als das tolle verkehrsträgerprojekt das
sollten Sie reformieren wir haben
hunderttausende Menschen in diesem Land
die jedes Jahr stranden in irgendwelchen
Bahnhöfen die der die zu späte Züge
erleben und die ein diskomfort erleben
und dieses Unternehmen waren das wäre
ohne ihre Kapitalerhöhung längst
insolvent das alles ist schon schön
genug was ist noch schlimmer die
Aufsicht die Aufsichtsgremien der Bahn
den sie ja denen sie ja hier wo sie ein
gewissen Einfluss drauf haben diese
Aufsichtsgremien genehmigen den Vorstand
der Bahn ein Gehalt über 2 Millionen im
Vorstand vorsitzen von über 2 Millionen
Euro in 2022 das ist Verschwendung von
Mitteln und ein ganz falsches Signal
und kommen wir noch mal zum 49
euro-ticket das 49 euro-ticket ist ein
nichts anderes als eine gigantische
Umverteilung von Steuermitteln von
Steuern die hier eingenommen werden im
Wesentlichen von der Landbevölkerung die
mit dem Auto fahren muss weil wie mein
Kollege das schon ausgeführt hat ja gar
keine Infrastruktur da ist und das wird
genommen um es ihrer Wählerschaft in den
Metropolen der städtischen bohemen in
den Rachen zu werfen dieses Geld wird
dafür genommen damit er kaufen sie sich
Wählerstimmen und sie nehmen dafür nicht
wie sich eben der CSU vorgeworfen haben
350 Milliarden Millionen für ihren
Wahlkampf sie nehmen jedes Jahr viele
Milliarden und ich schaue mir die Zahlen
von 2022 an unterstelle fest tatsächlich
sind die Regionalisierungsmittel über 14
Milliarden gewesen das sind vier bis
fünf Milliarden mehr als in den Jahren
davor das ist auch ihr deutschlandticket
es ist viel mehr als die von ihnen
angekündigten 1,5 Milliarden er witzig
und dann freuen sie sich über den Erfolg
weil Deutschland Ticket da sage ich
ihnen eins
nur weil die Leute frei wir nehmen heißt
das nicht dass wir gut waren
ich komme zum Ende faktisch faktisch
erleben wir ja ein
Bundesverkehrsminister der Geld
Steuergeld zum Fenster rauswirft ohne
sichtbare Erfolge vielen Dank
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das Wort
Matthias Gastel
vor Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen gerade im Warenbereich hat sich
diese Ampelkoalition sehr viel
ehrgeizige Ziele gesetzt
wir wollen mit dem deutschland-tag die
verkehrsanteile im Personen wie auch im
Güterverkehr deutlich erhöhen wir wollen
ein Programm für die schnelle
Kapazitätserweiterung entschiedenen Netz
auflegen außer Neubau vorantreiben wir
wollen die Digitalisierung ins
Schienennetz bringen und wir wollen
Bahnhöfe attraktiver und barrierefrei
ausbauen dieser Haushaltsplan Entwurf
setzt konsequent auf das auf was wir uns
vorgenommen haben als Koalition und
schafft damit die Grundlage dass all
diese Ziele auch tatsächlich erreicht
werden können wir erhöhen die Mittel für
die Verbesserung der Substanz Leistungs-
und Finanzierungsvereinbarung als
Stichwort und 1,8 Milliarden Euro die
Digitalisierung ist uns 700 € Millionen
Mehrwert als im Vorjahr das ist eine
Verdoppelung für den außer Neubau das
sind die bedarfsplanmittel geben wir 300
Millionen Euro mehr für die Engpass
Beseitigung 50 Millionen Euro mehr das
ist fast eine Verdoppelung gegenüber dem
noch im laufenden Jahr und wir stärken
und erhalten auch den Einzelwagenverkehr
damit wir den Güterverkehr weiterhin
erhalten und ausbauen können
beispielsweise dadurch dass wir den
kombinierten Verkehr stärker fördern und
die Gleisanschlüsse bei den Firmen
entsprechend ausbauen das sind alles
gute und wichtige Maßnahmen auf dem Weg
zum zu Erreichen unserer Ziele im
Koalitionsvertrag
möglich
möglich werden diese massiven Erhöhungen
der Investitionsmittel vor allem auch
durch die Ausweitung und die Erhöhung
der Lkw-Maut damit setzen wir wichtige
Impulse dort wo es möglich ist Güter
verstärkt auf die Schiene zu bringen und
wir schaffen Impulse dafür dass wir
alternative Antriebe um wegkommen zu
können von Diesel entsprechend dann auch
auf die Straße bringen wir haben aber
auch noch viele Hausaufgaben zu machen
viele davon setzen wir gerade
entsprechend um wir brauchen eine neue
finanzierungsarchitektur für die Schiene
damit man schneller vorankommt wir
müssen wegkommen davon dass 180
haushaltsköpfe alle so kompliziert
machen weniger Finanzierungsquellen und
dafür eine bessere und verlässlichere
Finanzierung beim Ausbau Neubau und beim
Erhalt erschiene wir ändern die
Strukturen bei der Deutschen Bahn damit
auch hier die Dinge effiziente gehen und
der mittelabrufe und des verbauen auch
tatsächlich der Haushaltsmittel möglich
werden wir beschleunigen Planung
Genehmigung und Bau und ich weiß auch
darauf hin dass er angekündigt wurde die
gvfg
Gemeindeverkehrsfinanzierungsgesetz
Mittel die die Länder brauchen um zum
Beispiel stillgelegte Bahnstrecken
reaktivieren zu können von allen auf
zwei Milliarden zu verdoppeln das müssen
wir in Angriff nehmen wenn die Mittel
fließenden zwischen ganz gut ab
das Versprechen der Ampelkoalition aus
dem Koalitionsvertrag erheblich mehr in
die Schiene als in die Straße zu
investieren sind wir gerade dabei
umzusetzen dass zeigt sich in diesem
Haushaltsplan Entwurf wir gehen
schneller voran bei den Investitionen
beim Ausbau und der Wunsch der jetzt
noch da ist ist dass wir auch
entschlossener entscheiden über die
Projekte im Bereich außer Neubau dann
gelingt es uns die Attraktivität der
Schiene entsprechend zu erhöhen um mehr
Güter in Personen im Güterverkehr als
auch mehr Personen in Personenverkehr
mit einer attraktiven und
verlässlicheren Bahn zu transportieren
und zu befördern das ist unser Ziel mit
diesem Haushalt sind Wurf kommen wir dem
große Schritte entgegen
Matthias Gastel für die bundesgründen
hatte nicht mehr so viel Redezeit jetzt
angedunkelt sie ist die Sprecherin für
digitalpolitik der Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Präsidentin Liebe Koliken
auch mit der sogenannten
fortschrittskoalition bleibt Deutschland
eine digitale Wüste laut Bitkom ist
bisher nur jedes zehnte digitalvorhaben
der Koalition umgesetzt und viele
Versprechen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
bleiben weiter Makulatur das
digitalbudget fehlt nun schon im dritten
ampelhaushalt und obwohl das
Mobilfunknetz immer noch löchriger ist
als bei den rentierenden Lappland und
nur jeder zehnte Haushalt in Deutschland
ein Glasfaseranschluss nutzt im
OECD-Durchschnitt sind viermal so viele
kürzt das bmdv den Titel für die
Unterstützung des Breitbandausbaus um
über 30% und die Zuschüsse zu
Verbesserung der Internetversorgung
sogar um über
60%. so gefährdet die Ampel die
Zukunftsfähigkeit der Gesellschaft so
holen wir den digitalen Rückstand
niemals auf
der Koalitionsvertrag versprach aber
auch ich zitiere
Entwicklungsaufträge werden in der Regel
als Open Source beauftragt die
Prioritäten einer Regierung erkennt man
aber nicht am Koalitionsvertrag sondern
am Geld und im kommenden Haushalt soll
das Budget für offene Software um die
Hälfte schrumpfen gleichzeitig schließt
der Bund aber eine Vertrag mit der
US-Firma Oracle ab über 3,88 Milliarden
Euro das sind 155 Mal so viel wie der
Bund 2024 für offene Software in die
Hand nehmen will digitale Souveränität
erreicht man so nicht meine Damen und
Herren
der Koalitionsvertrag versprache aber
auch ich zitiere eine ausreichende Folge
Finanzierung für das Online
zugangsgesetz also für das wichtigste
Programme Digitalisierung der Verwaltung
und außerdem das Verfahren künftig
antragslos und automatisiert erledigt
werden mit einer Priorisierung für die
Kinder Grundsicherung aber im Haushalt
24 werden 99% der Mittel für das Online
zugangsgesetz gestrichen und der
Teilhabe Beitrag für bedürftige Kinder
ist nicht in die Kindergrundsicherung
integriert keinesfalls antragslos und
digital soll er im Jahre ich verspreche
mich nicht
2029 kommen zum Ende der Nachfolge
Regierung dieses digitalpolitische
Totalversagen war und ist eine
Katastrophe für unser Land sorgen sie
endlich dafür dass sich daran etwas
ändert vielen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Christian schreider
ist mit die den Verkehrsausschuss für
die SPD-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebes Publikum fakt ist die
Verkehrswende kommt wir machen ernst mit
einer besseren Bahn nichts beweist das
mehr als dieser Haushaltsentwurf das
sehe nicht nur ich so das sehen nicht
nur wir so das sieht vor allem die
fachbranche so ich darf zitieren nun
stehen wir vor einer historischen Wende
mit Blick auf den Haushalt 24 lässt sich
sagen dass die Ampel die Investitionen
in die Schiene spürbar aufstocken will
und damit das Versprechen einlösen
erheblich mehr Geld für die Schiene als
für die Straße bereitzustellen
das ist für deutsche Verhältnisse
revolutionär und eine echte Trendwende
Zitat Ende
für deutsche Verhältnisse revolutionär
und eine historische Trendwende all das
sagt die Allianz pro Schiene der
Spitzenverband all derer die es gut
meint mit der Eisenbahn und der
Verkehrswende in Deutschland und endlich
meint es auch eine Regierung so richtig
gut mit der Schiene und wir setzen dabei
auch die richtigen Schwerpunkte wir
entlasten die Wirtschaft durch die jetzt
dauerhaft dauerhafte trassenpreissenkung
für Güterzüge wer sichern auf den
unprofitablen Güterverkehr durch die
drastisch erhöhte einzelwagenförderung
wir schaffen mehr Kapazität mehr
Zuverlässigkeit und auch eine
Einheitlichkeit im europäischen
Schienennetz weil wir die Mittel für die
netzdigitalisierung verdoppeln
unnötig teure Tunnel die Strecken
voneinander abschneiden und so
umleitungsmöglichkeiten verhindern sowas
darf wie schon bei Stuttgart 21 nicht
mehr passieren wir müssen die wertvollen
Mittel gezielt platzieren und nicht in
gigantischen Einzelbauten unsinnig
versenken
aproposer senken war es auch es hätten
243 oder 357 Millionen Euro mehr sein
können im Verkehrshaushalt Millionen die
anti-scheuer und seine CSU mit Ansage in
den Sand gesetzt haben gegen alle
Warnungen für den
csu-populismus-schlager Pkw-Maut aber
wir wissen nicht nur seit letzter Woche
für den Wahlkampf in Bayern da geht dann
plötzlich alles aber weil Rechtsbruch in
einem Rechtsstaat eben doch nicht geht
deshalb ist es nur mehr als recht das
Volker Wissing Herrn scheuer für diese
CSU gesteuerte Geldvernichtung in
Regress nehmen will auch dafür Glück auf
vielen Dank
der nächste Redner kommt von der cdu/cs
ist der verkehrspolitische Sprecher und
er hat ein bisschen längere Redezeit als
seine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen für alle haben
jetzt ein paar Monate schmerzvoll
erfahren müssen wie wichtig eine
funktionierende Infrastruktur ist wenn
man zurückschaut letzten Jahrzehnte
haben viel zu oft immer etwas skeptisch
was Straßenbahn geht Maschinenbau geht
viel zu oft hat meinen Straßenbau auf
verhindert viele haben auch hier immer
die Möglichkeit in Frage gestellt
deshalb ist es gut dass wir wissen dass
wir Infrastruktur brauchen und dass wir
Ausbau Schritt für Schritt auch
voranbringen müssen
[Musik]
Investitionen sind notwendig und das
wichtigste für Mission sind Sicherheit
und Verlässlichkeit und das ist das
größte dieser Regierung fällt meine
damente wenn sie Minister das morgen
verkünden wird ein zweites später die
Grünen gleich auf die Agenda gehen und
leichter dagegen sprechen das ist diese
Regierung wie immer
unheimlich ist und das keine Glasbild
bietet das ist das größte Problem für
die Infrastruktur und für die
notwendigen Investitionen
auch das Geld ist ganz ganz wichtig sie
haben gesagt vorhin
38,7 Milliarden Euro für den
verkehrsetag und vorgesehen immerhin 3,1
Milliarden Euro das heißt 8,8% mehr als
noch in diesem Jahr das ist schon mal
ein Wort aber im genauen Hinschauen
sieht man dann doch dass es ein anderes
Bild noch hinter gibt nämlich im
kommenden Jahr werden die Bürger mit
über sieben Milliarden Euro mit der LKW
noch mal mehr belastet als es bisher
gefallen ist diese lkw-mod übrigens die
Kollegen Vorredner immer so kritisieren
die Maus wird kurze Hand oder Nacht
verdoppelt jede LKW wird 2024 mit über
20.000 € mehr belastet also das heißt
unsere Wirtschaft für die
mittelständischen Logistikbranche als
das heißt für die meisten Entwicklung
auch für die für die sozial Schwächen
unserer Gesellschaft die denn mehr
ausgeben müssen Joghurt für den Butter
und alles mögliche das werden die
Experten doch entsprechend ausgeht aber
nicht sicher es wird eine Mehrbelastung
sein also die wegschwächende Wirtschaft
die wir heute haben noch mehr belasten
auch mehr Schaden auch das geht in die
ganz ganz falsche Richtung mein Lagern
man schaut das Geld aber das ist mir
eingenommen wird die sieben Milliarden
Euro jetzt auszugeben für die Straßenbau
von Schienenbau und es geht auch
sinnvoll zu wenden gehen nur drei
Milliarden Euro in den verkehrsetaren
und der Rest 4 Milliarden Euro
verdienen die keiner kennt man Alter
gegen Klarheit gegen Wahrheit gegen
Transparenz zu stößt die vielleicht
immer dafür die FDP hat immer gesagt da
müssen wir Transparenz sein wir haben
immer gesagt dass wir das Geld was wir
LKW dass die Bürger auch sehen wo ihr
Geld auch hingeht auch diesmal ganz ganz
strenglisch vernachlässigt und ist was
was auch da in die komplett falsche
Richtung geht meine Damen
liebe Kollegen liebe Kolleginnen es
wurden viele Versprechungen gemacht von
Ankündigung gemacht leider ist im
Haushalt davon wenig zu sehen ein
Beispiel der Ausbau des Radverkehrs ein
Thema das ja den Grünen anderen auch
sehr wichtig ist zu uns auch wichtig ist
allein dieses Jahr ist ein ganz ganz
großes Minus dabei der Haushalt 2022
hatte noch
750 Millionen Euro für den Radwege 15
Millionen 2023 warte nur noch 560
Millionen Euro und nächstes Jahr soll es
laut haben wir singen nur noch 400
Millionen Euro sein das sieht ja ganz
klar hier das ist auch da Rückschritt
statt Fortschritt die Zahlen sprechen
Sie sich deshalb auch da geht's komplett
in die falsche Richtung
Privatverkehr zum bundesstraßenbau
bundesautobahnbau
2020 das letzte Jahr noch der CO2
Regierung 11 Milliarden Euro wurden
bereitgestellt für die Ausbau der
Bundesautobahn und der Bundesstraße 11
Milliarden Euro
nach Inflation und baukostenbereinigung
werden es heute
14,5 Milliarden Euro um das gleiche
Niveau zu halten wie damals tatsächlich
stellt Herr Wissing jetzt 2024 nur noch
11,5 Milliarden Euro ein das heißt
konkret nach preisbereinigung um nach
den inflationswagen ein Minus von 25%
für die Autobahn und für die
Bundesstraßen ein ganz klares Signal
dass hier diese Priorität nicht mehr
gilt vor drei Jahren habe ich gesagt 50%
noch mehr ausgeben das sind ganz ganz
dramatische Rückschritt bei dem
Straßenbau
zum Schluss möchte ich nochmal das Thema
49 € Ticket auch noch mal erwähnen wir
auch das Lieblings Thema ja auch das ist
und der möchte noch mal ganz klar sagen
das bleibt die Flatrate zum Sparpreis
wird von vielen natürlich genutztes
gehört aber gleichzeitig wird deutlich
dass die Kosten für dieses Projekt
komplett aus dem Ruder laufen allein
dieses Jahr das Bundesland ein Verlust
den Verlust von 3 Milliarden Euro tragen
müssen nächstes Mal über 10 Milliarden
von Bund und Land gemeinsam ertragen
noch keiner gefunden das tragen will
also die Finanzierung komplett offen
Nachhaltigkeit sieht komplett anders aus
Leute
dieses Ticket unbezahlbar
die Freunde meine Damen und Herren da
ist der vorliegende Haushaltsentwurf ein
grenzflüster nach Rückschritt
josefsberatung stehen ins an ich hoffe
dass wir noch ein bisschen es besser
machen können in diesem Sinne freue ich
auf die einstehen Diskussionen danke
schön
der Bundestag diskutiert immer noch über
den Einzelplatz 12 Verkehr und digitales
insgesamt Verkehrsminister Wissing
38,7 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
gegenüber 35,8 Milliarden im laufenden
Jahr 2033 und die nächste Rednerin kommt
von den Bündnis grünen 20
Michael
2230 heißt es Nationalrat Verkehrsplan
und in der Tat sind wir auf dem Weg
dahin in Stadt und Land werden bereits
mehrere tausend Kilometer Radwege
geplant es wird gebaggert oder markiert
durch das Förderprogramm Stadt und Land
ist in den letzten Jahren etwas gekommen
in vielen Bundesländern sind die Mittel
von Stadt und Land bereits komplett
ausgeschöpft wie zum Beispiel in
Baden-Württemberg Sachsen-Anhalt in
Niedersachsen und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
denn die Menschen in Deutschland wollen
Radfahren mehr als 40% würden gerne mehr
Wege mit dem Rad zurücklegen
und dort wo es geht fahren Sie Rad im
ersten Halbjahr 2023 wurden in Hannover
an den Messstationen gerade an
Wochentagen spürbare Zuwächse gemessen
in Hamburg ist der Anteil des
Radverkehrs seit 2019 sogar um 33
Prozent gestiegen gleichzeitig steigen
seit Jahren die Absatzzahlen für E-Bikes
und Lastenräder und auch 2022 war ein
Rekordjahr für die Fahrradbranche
Fahrradfahren boomt da gibt es keinen
Zweifel
aber es ist noch sehr viel zu tun die
autofokussierte Verkehrspolitik der
letzten Jahrzehnte hat dazu geführt dass
das Fahrrad ein Verkehrsmittel ohne
durchgehende eigene Infrastruktur ist
alle Ortens gibt es massive Lücken im
Rad Verkehrsnetz unsichere oder fehlende
Radwege verhindern dass Menschen mit dem
Rad zur Arbeit oder zum Sport fahren sie
verhindern dass Eltern ihre Kinder mit
dem Rad zur Schule schicken doch immer
mehr Kommunen wollen dafür sorgen dass
alle Menschen sich unabhängig vom Alter
auf den Radwegen sicher fühlen
wir wollen diesen Trend bestätigen das
ist auch unser Anliegen für die
anstehenden Haushaltsberatung denn der
Bund muss auch finanziell seinen Beitrag
leisten damit das Fahrrad dann
Deutschland damit das Fahrradland
überall in Deutschland Realität wird
vielen Dank
für die AFD hat jetzt als nächster Eugen
Schmidt das Wort er ist Mitglied im
digitalausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Landsleute in Zeiten des rasanten
Niedergangs unseres einst so stolzen
Landes beschließt diese Regierung nicht
die eigenen Gehälter sondern die
entscheidenden Investitionen in
Digitalisierung und Netzausbau zu kürzen
ein ausgebautes Breitbandnetz ermöglicht
es im deutschen sich jenseits staatliche
Propaganda Medien besser und frei zu
informieren was freilich nicht im Sinne
dieser Regierung ist
hinsichtlich der
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen handelt
diese Bundesregierung ähnlich
bürgerfeindlich viele bürokratische
Abläufe müssen dringend digitalisiert
werden ein unfähiger Stadt nötigt
Millionen Deutsche in zunehmendem Maße
ihre wohlverdiente Freizeit in
amtsstufen abzusitzen und sich durch
endlose Formulare zu quälen
Digitalisierung kann Effizienz und
transparente hören wenn sie
bürgerfreundlich gemacht wird schauen
wir den aktuellen Haushaltsplan an der
3300 Seiten umfasst ist digital und
maschinenlesbar vorhanden aber statt
mehr Transparenz zu bieten sind in den
maschinenlesbaren Versionen
Informationen gekürzt
Absicht oder Unfähigkeit vermutlich
beides
und wenn man sparen muss dann bitte an
der richtigen Stelle wir haben immer
wieder Maßnahmen vorgeschlagen die
Milliarden deutsche Steuergelder an
sinnvollen Stellen einsparen würden das
fängt bei sozialen Migranten an und hört
bei der Finanzierung des Krieges in der
Ukraine noch lange nicht auf
aber selbst wenn die Bundesregierung die
Digitalisierung wollte sehe ihre Bilanz
nicht besser aus selbst wenn sie auf die
Idee käme Mittelmeerroute für sozialen
Migranten mit lade und wählernstationen
auszustatten würde diese inkompetente
Regierung kläglich scheitern
ihre Unfähigkeit in der digitalen
Transformation zeigt sich exemplarisch
an den 214 Millionen Euro die für ihre
sogenannte Corona waren eben
rausgeworfen wurden ihr Nutzen ist nicht
nur fragwürdig der Überwachung der
deutschen durch diese Regierung wurden
damit zu und dort geöffnet
als die afd-fraktion kürzlich nach
politisch motivierte Kriminalität fragte
kam vom weserministerium eine 300 Seiten
Antwort sie zu Hälfte keinen Text
enthielt
entweder fehlte das Geld für kompetentes
Personal oder sollte die Lesbarkeit der
Schwert werden vermutlich beides falls
es nur am Geld liegen sollte lassen Sie
uns als Parlamentarier Geld sammeln und
Frau Feser einen Excel-Kurs zu
finanzieren
die nächste Rednerin kommt von der SPD
Anja toffaczyk und sie ist mitten im
Verkehrsausschuss und Aufsichtsrat der
Deutschen Bahn für die Bereiche Station
und Service da ist ja genau die richtige
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Verkehrshaushalt 2024 behält die
Herstellung gleichwertiger
Lebensverhältnisse in der Stadt und auf
dem Land im Blick darum schaffen wir
gleichberechtigte Mobilität für alle
unabhängig vom Wohnort
Stichwort Radfahren für alle wir führen
eine Reihe von Förderprogramm fort und
von Bundesebene den Ausbau der
Radinfrastruktur zu unterstützen und 200
Millionen Euro investieren wir nicht nur
in Radwege sondern auch in den Aufbau
von mobilitätszentren an Bahnhöfen hier
ermöglichen wir die Anfahrt mit dem Rad
oder dem Auto zum Zug wo
öpnv-alternativen noch fehlen das
konkrete Angebot im Nahverkehr wird von
den Ländern und Kommunen gestaltet wir
vom Bund sorgen hier für eine gute
Vernetzung der verschiedenen
Verkehrsträger ein breites Angebot und
individuelle Lösung für jeden und jede
darauf kommt es an wenn es um Mobilität
geht
Bahnfahren für alle dafür reaktivieren
wir strecken und Haltepunkte und
investieren kräftig in das Schienennetz
über den Erfolg des deutschland-
wir wollen niemandem vorschreiben wie er
von A nach B kommt sondern Angebote
fördern damit sich alle ihren Weg mit
unterschiedlichen Verkehrsmitteln frei
und flexibel gestalten können auch der
Straßenverkehr wird deshalb in Zukunft
selbstverständlich weiter eine wichtige
Rolle spielen
gleichwertige Lebensverhältnisse in
Stadt und Land natürlich sind
gleichwertig und gleich nicht dasselbe
die Problemlagen in Stadt und Land sind
ganz unterschiedlich die Lösung können
also auch nicht dieselben sein es gibt
große Leidensdruck in den Städten zu
viele Autos zu viel Versiegelung
Wettbewerb um Straßenräume im ländlichen
Raum ist der Leidensdruck nicht geringer
aber was hier gebraucht wird mehr lade
Infrastruktur weniger Kosten für Fahrten
mit dem eigenen PKW ein dichtes
dichteres ÖPNV-Angebot oder eben
überhaupt ein ÖPNV-Angebot
wir reden in Deutschland mehr über
Mobilität als je zuvor diese Chance
müssen wir gemeinsam nutzen um in den
Zusammenarbeit von Bund Ländern und
Kommunen gestärkt vorangehen der Kanzler
hat es heute morgen zu Recht
eingefordert wir brauchen einen
deutschland-pakt um die Infrastruktur zu
erneuern die Verteilung der
Zuständigkeiten ist komplex die
Finanzierung ebenfalls im Zentrum muss
aber eine gemeinsame Verantwortung für
bessere Mobilität stehen und das erwarte
ich von allen Beteiligten
wir nehmen als Bund viel Geld für die
Mobilität in die Hand wir beschleunigen
Verfahren setzen auf das Potenzial der
Digitalisierung und bauen Bürokratie ab
wir geben mehr Geld im Verkehrshaushalt
2024 aus allen sportswängen zum Trotz
und damit setzen wir ein klares
Ausrufungszeichen
natürlich brauchen wir Zeit um die
entstandenen Löcher im Verkehrsnetz zu
flicken gerade auch in den ländlichen
Gebieten deswegen auch hier noch einmal
der Appell an alle Ebenen wir werden das
nur gemeinsam schaffen danke
hätte sogar noch Redezeit gehabt das ist
auch selten dass einer darauf verzichtet
aber sie hatte offensichtlich alles
gesagt was sie sagen wollte Felix
Schreiner jetzt für die cdu/csu sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
eigentlich schade in dieser Debatte weil
sie haben eine Chance verpasst sie haben
die Chance in der Debatte verpasst zu
erklären was die haushaltspolitischen
Schwerpunkt in der Verkehrspolitik der
nächsten Jahre sind und sie haben eine
Chance verpasst mit dem was sie uns
vorgelegt hatten wir hätten uns
gewünscht dass sie sich vielleicht zu
einig sind wie bei der Cannabis
Legalisierung oder bei anderen Dingen
aber auch nach diesem rhetorisch
emotionalen Feuerwerk des Ministers
heute hier stellen wir einfach fest es
ist ganz kleines Karo sie haben nicht
einmal den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
gefunden meine Damen und
sie regieren seit zwei Jahren aber sie
liefern nicht und ich möchte an ein paar
Beispielen konkret machen sie erreichen
Ihre Ziele nicht sie sagen dass bis 2030
mindestens 15 Millionen Elektroautos auf
den Deutschen straßenrollen sollen die
Realität ist aber eine andere seit
Monaten gehen die Bestellungen zurück
und die Verbraucher fordern vor allem
eines nämlich planungssicherheiten und
Rahmenbedingungen dazu gehört der Ausbau
der ladesäulen-infrastruktur es gehört
der die Anreize über die Kfz-Steuer und
es gehört auch dazu dass wir passgenaue
Förderprogramme über die KfW und vieles
mehr machen mir fehlt der Glaube dass
diese Koalition noch irgendetwas was
wirklich klimapolitische Anreize im
Verkehrssektor umsetzt auf die Reihe
kriegt das muss ich ihn so offen sagen
sie halten ihre Zusagen nicht ein ich
meine die Novelle der Lkw-Maut in Zeiten
einer Rezession es bedeutet doch in
aller Linie in aller erster Linie eine
Mehrbelastung für die Unternehmen und
die Bürger ohne einen nennenswerten
klimapolitischen Effekt die Unternehmen
haben gar keine andere Wahl und sie
werden die Kosten an die Endverbraucher
weiter durchreichen die letztendlich die
Zeche zahlen und Herr Wissing ich frage
mich schon haben Sie eigentlich gemerkt
dass ihnen ihr Kollege im Kabinett
Christian Lindner schlicht und
ergreifend vier Milliarden Euro mehr
Einnahmen von der Maut geklaut hat sie
haben es nicht mal verteidigt und die
Wahrheit ist dass diese vier Milliarden
jetzt wirklich fehlen für den Ausbau von
Infrastruktur in diesem Land
wir haben es jetzt schwarz auf weiß und
wir wissen dass wir dieses Geld eben
nicht haben für die Ertüchtigung von
Verkehrsinfrastruktur für die Sanierung
und den Ausbau von Brücken für
tunnelsanierungen für die Lückenschlüsse
die wir dringend brauchen nein bereinigt
und die Maut Mehreinnahmen sind der
Verkehrshaushalt um fast vier Milliarden
Euro wir können feststellen wir haben
kein Einnahme Problem wir haben eine
vollkommen falsche Prioritätensetzung
ihrerseits in den koalitionsfraktion
und das dritte Beispiel sie bilden in
keinster Weise die
Kostensteigerung bei Bau und Rohstoffen
auch beim Personal ab jeder
Privathaushalt in diesem Land weiß dass
die Kosten gestiegen sind nur sie
verschließen die Augen davor und sie
malen sich die Welt wie sie Ihnen
gefällt sie müssen sich doch eigentlich
mal ehrlich machen die
Verkehrsinvestitionen sinken real aber
Investitionen sind kein selbstweg sie
sind die Grundlage dafür dass wir unsere
wirtschaftliche Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in
diesem Land behalten und da
investieren sie leider viel zu wenig und
der vierte Punkt
wenn sie dann sagen ja wir erhöhen jetzt
die Mittel bei den Wasserstraßen die
Wahrheit ist sie haben im letzten
Haushalt die Mittel bei den
Wasserstraßen streflich reduziert sie
machen jetzt gerade mal den Fehler
wieder gut den sie damals angerichtet
haben aber Sie können doch hier nicht zu
einem Bekenntnis von einem Bekenntnis
für die Wasserstraßen in Deutschland
reden sie haben es gekürzt und jetzt
machen sie es gerade mal wieder gut aber
in Wahrheit kommt nicht mehr Geld hinten
an
und
lassen Sie mich deshalb einen
grundsätzlichen Gedanken sagen wenn wir
doch alle uns einig sind dass wir mehr
Investitionen in den verkehrspolitischen
Bereichen brauchen da müssen wir auch
darüber reden wie wir privates Kapital
im Verkehrsbereich bekommen darüber
müssen wir beraten wie wir
ÖPP-Projekte
akquirieren können wie wir ja auch Geld
aus privaten Sektoren in den
Verkehrsbereich mobilisieren können weil
wenn wir sinnvoll investieren wenn wir
kostengünstig Haushalten und dabei für
die Mobilität von morgen jetzt auch die
richtigen Maßnahmen treffen dann werden
wir es schaffen dass wir eine gute
Verkehrsinfrastruktur für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger hier im Land
haben und nicht nur in der Berliner
Blase so wie Sie es gerade heute von den
Grünen wieder mal so wunderbar
dargestellt haben
der Bundeskanzler hat gestern bei der
IAA noch mal versprochen 15 Millionen
Pkws mit E-Antrieb auf die Straße zu
bringen bis zum Jahr 2030 die Frage ist
nur die Lade Infrastruktur ist in
Deutschland nach wie vor sehr schlecht
er hat ja auch gesagt es wird demnächst
ein Gesetz geben dass jede Tankstelle so
eine Ladestation mindestens haben muss
Mike außendorf für die Grünen jetzt
weiter zu entwickeln um auch in Zukunft
Wohlstand schaffen und sichern zu können
und das unter erschwerten neopolitischen
Bedingungen und innerhalb der planetaren
Grenzen also nachhaltig und
klimaverträglich und auf diesem Weg
spielt die nachhaltige Digitalisierung
in mehrfacher Hinsicht eine
Schlüsselrolle sie ist zum einen
Wegbereiterin für neue Geschäftsmodelle
besonders für Startups kleine
mittelständische Unternehmen in den über
90% der Beschäftigten Beschäftigten das
Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft ausmachen
zugleich Dieter Branchenverband Bitcoin
ein Reduktionspotenzial von mehr als 30%
aller deutschen CO2 Emissionen
allein durch innovative digitale
Methoden und dieses Potenzial müssen wir
freilegen
und die digitale Infrastruktur ist
grundlegende Voraussetzung für alle
Entwicklungen in diesem Bereich
digitalpolitik reicht natürlich weit
darüber hinaus aber an dieser Stelle
möchte ich hier auf die Infrastruktur
näher eingeben denn sie ist ja auch das
Kernthema des bmdvs und des Haushaltes
und mit der überarbeitet der
Förderrichtlinie graue Flecken haben wir
zu einer weiteren Beschleunigung des
Ausbaus geführt die Zubaurate im
Jahresvergleich ist um 50% gestiegen es
bleibt aber weiter viel zu tun deswegen
ist so gut und richtig dass wir die
nötigen Mittel für den Breitbandausbau
bereitstellen
deutlich problematischer und da wohl
Licht ist auch Schatten ist es im
Bereich Mobilfunk hier haben wir ein
schweres Erbe wieder mal von scheuer
wenn wir uns erinnern zur Zeiten der
unionsgeführten Regierung bei der
letzten Frequenzvergabe wurden der oder
der Fokus eben nicht auf die
Erreichbarkeit der Menschen auf dem Land
gesetzt sondern auf die Optimierung der
Einnahmen für den Staatshaushalt und die
Vorgaben für die Netzbetreiber waren
völlig unzureichend und um dann diesen
Problemen der Funklöcher zu begegnen hat
ja Steuer sein eigenes Amt gegründet das
Feuer das Feuer schon funklochamt heute
bekannt unter dem Namen Mobilfunk
Infrastrukturgesellschaft kurz mit und
die Aufgabe der mich ist es Funklöcher
vor allem im ländlichen Raum zu stopfen
und das geht sie auch gut an das muss
man sagen zwar deutlich zu langsam wir
haben aktuell etwa 600 Standorte in
Entwicklung die ersten Türme werden bald
fertiggestellt aber es ist so eine
exponentielle Kurve wir sind ganz am
Anfang und sicher dass das vorangeht und
für diese wichtige Kernaufgabe wollen
wir auch weiterhin die Finanzierung
sichern
Funklöcher Funklöcher entlang der
Bahnstrecken die sind ein besonderes
Ärgernis und arbeitshemmendes und es ist
gut dass ich Minister Wissing hier
persönlich für Abhilfe einsetzt und wir
warten alle gespannt auf eine zügige
Verbesserung in diesem Bereich
auch im Bereich der Infrastruktur können
und müssen wir mehr auf Nachhaltigkeit
setzen bisher verbauen etwa die
Netzbetreiber alle eine eigene Antenne
also eigene aktive Infrastruktur
geteilte Nutzung mit anderen Betreibern
das wären National Roaming dass es eben
nicht vorgegeben und in der Praxis eher
die Ausnahme und es wäre viel besser
wenn sich hier zwei Netze einer Antenne
teilen würden dann könnten viel mehr
Menschen über diese Antenne telefonieren
und mit weniger Ressourceneinsatz
könnten wir besser umsetzen und das wäre
der Weg in die richtige Richtung
und durch die Vorgabe von National
Roaming wäre die Förderung auch
gleichzeitig weniger klimaschädlich das
heißt hier geht's darum klimaschädliche
Subventionen abzubauen und das ist ja
etwas das für ein Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben und insgesamt müssen
wir uns bei den weiteren
parlamentarischen Bereichen überall im
Haushalt Spielräume Arbeiten durch den
konsequenten Abbau klimaschädlicher
Subventionen
und die Koalition hat die
Weiterentwicklung der Gesellschaft durch
Digitalisierung und Nachhaltigkeit auch
in anderen Häusern im Blick gerade im
bmwk gibt es viele Programme um Startups
und KMU bei der sozialökologisch
digitalen Transformation zu unterstützen
und so auch zukünftig
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und Wohlstand zu
sichern
ich komme zum Schluss wir brauchen ein
effizienten Mitteleinsatz nicht nur in
der digitalpolitik um Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft eine Weiterentwicklung zu
ermöglichen damit wir auch zukünftigen
nachhaltigen Wohlstand sichern können
als nächste Rednerin kommt Joanna
cottasie war bis vor kurzem noch
Mitglied in der afd-fraktion ist eine
der sechs fraktionslosen ich habe für
einen Fehler gemacht nur fünf stammen
von der EM waren jemals in der AFD den
Stefan Seidler der auch noch redet der
ist Mitglied aber dazu später mehr
auf die schleppende Umsetzung des
online-zugangsgesetzes eines der
wichtigsten digitalpolitischen Vorhaben
der Ampel endet gerade im Fiasko von den
geplanten 575
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen sind nicht
einmal 40 umgesetzt nun kürzen Sie das
Budget massiv klemmen die Länder von der
Finanzierung ab und um Peinlichkeiten in
der Zukunft zu verhindern setzen Sie
sich einfach keine verbindlichen Fristen
mehr was ist das denn für eine Art
Politik zu machen das im
Koalitionsvertrag versprochene
digitalbudget fehlt ebenso wieder
digital Parkschule 2.0 ja sogar die
Anschlussfinanzierung des ersten
digitalpaktes fehlt inzwischen hinten
unsere Schulen Ländern wie Dänemark 20
Jahre hinterher der Ampel ist egal zur
Hälfte der Legislaturperiode hat sie nur
11% ihrer insgesamt 334 digital Vorhaben
umgesetzt jedes vierte Projekt wurde
noch nicht einmal begonnen für die
quantentechnologie stehen und 21
Millionen Euro weniger zur Verfügung das
Budget für das luft-
ebenfalls um 200 Millionen gekürzt
werden auch dahinter verbirgt sich eine
Kürzung für quantencomputing dabei hat
sie Ampel noch am Anfang dieses Jahres
versprochen Deutschland und uns in
diesem Bereich Weltspitze zu machen so
wird das nichts liebe Kollegen sie
sparen an der Zukunftsfähigkeit
Deutschlands sie kürzen bei der
künstlichen Intelligenz bei der
digitalen Bildung bei der gänsförderung
und bei der digitalen Souveränität
Volker Wissing ist als digitalminister
fast unsichtbar anstatt klimakleber
einzuladen sollten Sie sich darauf
konzentrieren Deutschlands digital
anschlussfähig zu machen Herr Minister
die selbstlernte fortschrittskoalition
spart ausgerechnet am Fortschritt keine
Leidenschaft keine ordentliche
Koordination kaum Einbindung der
Zivilgesellschaft keine digitalkompetenz
bei den Ministern und jetzt auch noch
weniger Geld die Ampel setzt das
traurige digitale Erbe Merkels fordert
und damit Deutschlands Zukunft in den
Satz noch haben sie zwei Jahre Zeit
ändern Sie den Kurs nicht um 360° , aber
um 180 investieren statt sparen ist
angesagt sonst sitzen wir im Neuland
fest während die Welt da draußen die
Zukunft gestaltet herzlichen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Johannes Schätzel
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen der vorliegende Entwurf zum
Einzelplan 12 setzt weiterhin auf einen
stark geförderten Glasfaserausbau und
jetzt liegen doch einige
Tagesordnungspunkte dazwischen meine
Damen und Herren an dieser Stelle wollen
wir uns aus dem Geschehen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag verabschieden es
sind auch nur noch drei Redner hier zu
diesem Einzelplan 12 digitales und
Verkehr wir schalten rüber nach Brüssel
wo die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute tagt